THE COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. TODAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. DID YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
FOUR NINE. SEVEN NINE EIGHT
SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THOSE CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL COVER THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. AND DIVIDE BE
DIVIDED INTO TWO PARTS PART A
WILL COVER PUBLIC SAFETY AND
JUDICIARY ISSUES. AND PART B.
WILL COVER LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES BOTH
PARTS ARE DISCUSSION ONLY. SO
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH PART A
ISSUE ONE R. O. E. S. STAFFING
AUGMENTATIONS WILL- YES PLEASE
PRESENT. I'LL BE GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK RG DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES GOOD TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY THANK YOU ARE CALIFORNIA
ARE MERGING SEASON DISASTERS
ARE MORE FREQUENT COMPLICATED
AND OFTEN INVOLVING MULTIPLE
COUNTIES AND REGIONS OF THE
STATE. AND MANY AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE EXPERIENCED THAT
ALL WILDFIRE EARTHQUAKE
FLOODING FLASH FLOODING MUDFLOW
TSUNAMIS DROUGHTS HAS MATCHED
POWER OUTAGES AND SECURITY
THREATS. AND WE LIKE YOU.
WITNESSED TOO MANY TIMES THE
DEVASTATION OF A COMMUNITY HIT
BY ONE OR MORE OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC DISASTERS. THE
STRUCTURAL AND FINANCIAL
RECOVERIES FOR COMMUNITIES ARE
LONG. AND CHALLENGING
PARTICULARLY FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES OF OUR STATE. GIVEN
THAT HE'S EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS ARE FAR MORE
FREQUENT. AND COMPLICATED THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES SIXTY
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND. FOR A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN POSITIONS THE
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY CAPABILITIES TO
BETTER SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS
INITIATIVE DOES THE FOLLOWING.
IT ESTABLISHES A PERMANENT
INCIDENT SUPPORT TEAM WITHIN
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER AND
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM MORE
QUICKLY RESPOND. AND SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
INSURE CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT
AND LESSEN OUR CURRENT RELIANCE
ON RE DIRECTED STAFF TO DO SO-
AN OPERATIONAL MODEL IS JUST
NOT SUSTAINABLE. IT ESTABLISHES
A NEW OFFICE OF EQUITY. TO BUY
ALCOHOL CALORIE HAS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR CONNECTIONS WITH
THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
AFTER DISASTER RESPONSE LEVEL
AND FURTHER ELEVATE EQUITY AS A
CORE PRINCIPLE OF THE
ORGANIZATION. IT ALSO PROVIDES
PERMANENT RESOURCES FOR THE
LEAST THOSE PROGRAM AND EXPANDS
ITS FOCUS TO INCLUDE RESPONSIVE
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. THE BILL
BETTER SERVICE TO DISASTER
SURVIVORS AND TO COMMUNITIES.
EVERYPLACE IS ANTIQUATED
SYSTEMS AND LEVERAGES
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES TO
MODERNIZE THE STATE'S
CAPABILITIES THROUGH TECHNOLOGY
AND STRENGTH IN DATA ANALYTICS.
AS DISASTERS AND THEIR IMPACTS
ON PEOPLE ARE PROPERLY- AND
PROPERTY HAVE INCREASED TIMELY
DATA AND ADVANCED ANALYTICS ARE
EVEN MORE CRITICAL TO SUPPORT
DATA INFORMED DECISION MAKING.
AND IT ESTABLISHES A NEW CALL
COST RECOVERY UNIT AT
CALLIOSTOMATIDAE MICE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY AND DISASTER DOLLAR
RECOVERY PROVIDED TO
CALIFORNIA. AS THE STATE'S LEAD
AGENCY FOR FRIEDMAN DAHLE A
FEDERAL DOLLARS. THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS HAVE
RESULTED IN BILLIONS OF FEDERAL
FUNDS RECOVERED AND PROVIDED TO
THE STATE AND I AND OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES THIRTY
SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION. A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION THE GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL LONG TERM COST
RECOVERY POSITIONS. THESE WOULD
BETTER SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY EFFORTS. TO ACCELERATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND GET OUR
COMMUNITIES BACK UP ON THEIR
FEET AND THE RECRUITMENT OF
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL DISASTER
FUNDS FOR STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND MAXIMIZE
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND HAZARD
MITIGATION PROGRAMS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
HAPPENING ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
NEWS SURE YES WE HAVE THE ALEJO
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. MANAGER
SENATORS YOU'RE SORT OF WORK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GIVE IT GIVE
OUR COMMENTS ON EACH OF THE
PROPOSALS PRESENTED. TO BEGIN
WITH ALL SPEAK TO THE PERMANENT
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER TEAM.
RISIBLE WE FIND THE PROPOSAL TO
KEEP TO CREATE A DEDICATED
SOCCER TEAM REASONABLE HOWEVER
WE WOULD NOTE THAT- WE ASKED
WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE DATA ON
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THEIR STAFF
THAT ARE CURRENTLY GETTING
REDIRECTED TO THE SOCCER TEAMS.
ARE UNABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR
EXISTING WORKLOAD AS SUCH IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
LEVEL OF RESOURCES PROPOSED IS
APPROPRIATE. WE DON'T RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL TO
CREATE AN OFFICE OF EQUITY AND
WITH RESPECT TO THE LIST DOES
GRANT PROGRAM WE FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL IS PROMISING HOWEVER
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT
REMAIN UNANSWERED TO BEGIN
WITH- THE FOLLOWING QUESTIONS
WE THINK. WE ARE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO RESPOND TO. SPECIFICALLY
WHAT SERVICES WOULD BE
SUPPORED HOW FUNDING WOULD BE
PRIORITISED BETWEEN SUPPORTED
SERVICES HOW- YES WOULD
IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICES. AND
HOW- YES WOULD PRIORITIZE
FUNDING BETWEEN THESE
COMMUNITIES. AND FINALLY
WHETHER OUTCOME DATA WOULD BE
COLLECTED AND USED TO INFORM
FUTURE GRANT AWARDS. WITH
RESPECT TO THE- DISASTER COST
TRACKING AND RECOVERY UNIT IN
THE MODERNIZATION- YES
TECHNOLOGY AND DATA ANALYTICS
WE FIND THE PROPOSAL REASONABLE
HOWEVER WE ARE INFORMED THAT-
YES HAS NOT SUBMITTED REQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION. RELATED TO THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
COMPONENTS OF THESE PROPOSALS
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THESE DOCUMENTS
SHOULD BE PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE IT APPROVES
ANY INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
FUNDING. HOWEVER IF THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE THESE
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD IT
COULD APPROVE THE FUNDING ALONG
WITH PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THAT THESE DOCUMENTS
BE PROVIDED TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
BEFORE FUNDS. FOR THESE
PROJECTS CAN BE EXPANDED. IN
ADDITION WE THAT IT LARGEST.
CHIU TO APPROVE THESE PROPOSALS
IT WOULD ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
MONTHLY REPORTS ON STATE
EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES
SOMETHING OUR OFFICE HAS
RECOMMENDED. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THE LONG TERM
RECOVERY- YOU KNOW THAT- YES.
YEAH THANK YOU- I JUST STUCK
MISTER CARTOON TO COULD YOU
PLEASE RESPOND TO THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THE L. A. L. I SHOULD
BE HAPPY TO MANAGER- MAYBE I'LL
START OFF WITH THE- THE ISSUE
OF BROCK ARE REDIRECTING STAFF-
AND THE EFFORT THAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR IN AND AMPLIFYING
OUR ABILITY TO HAVE A PERMANENT
CAPABILITY- AS I MENTIONED- YOU
KNOW TODAY IN THE EVENT OF A
DISASTER. THE MODEL THAT WE USE
THAT THAT HAS BEEN THERE FOR
ALL ALL UP SOME TIME IS A
CALORIE ASKED. REDIRECTS STAFF
FROM CORE FUNCTIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO RESPOND TO AND
SUPPORT THE RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS OF A DISASTER.
THIS IS JUST NOT A SUSTAINABLE
MODEL FOR MURDER SHOULD BE
SPONSORED RECOVERY TODAY GIVEN
THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE OF
DISASTERS. THE REDIRECTION OF
STAFF RESULTS IN DELAYS IN
PROCESSING OF KEY
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS ACROSS
THE ORGANIZATION. BURKE JUST
ONE EXAMPLE WE HAVE A ROUGHLY A
THREE MONTH BACKLOG IN
CONTRACTS AND INVOICES. THE
DELAYS IN PROCESSING OF
CONTRACTS AND WE'RE JUST COULD
RISK CALAVERAS IS ABILITY TO
SECURE VITAL SERVICES NEEDED.
FORMER JUST USER STEADY STATE
WORK SUPPORTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER-
OPERATIONAL CONSTRUCTS. DELAYS
ALSO IN THE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE HIRING PROCESS
OCCUR AND RESULT IN- YES LOSING
OUT ON QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
THIS IMPACTS OUR RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION. IT A GREAT DEAL
ALL CANDIDATES ARE TYPICALLY
NOTIFIED THAT THEY WILL BE RE
DIRECTED TO OTHER DUTIES IN THE
EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY AND WORK
INCREASED OVERTIME OVERTIME IS
A HUGE ISSUE BECAUSE OF THIS AS
WELL AS THINGS START TO STACK
UP. IT CANDIDATES OFTEN CITED
AS A REASON FOR NOT ACCEPTING A
POSITION OTHER CITED AS A
REASON FOR LEAVING THE
DEPARTMENT. AS WELL TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND CERTIFICATIONS
GET THE LATEST OFFER ALL OF OUR
PERSONNEL AS WELL AS OUR
ABILITY TO OFFER TRAINING
THROUGH OUR CALIFORNIA
SPECIALIZED TRAINING INSTITUTE.
I'LL TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
STATE AGENCIES R. AS A PART OF
THE REQUIRED- ONGOING STATE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
THAT REQUIRES TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND ULTIMATELY THE
BIG IT HUGE IMPACT ON MENTAL
HEALTH AND STRESS OF OUR
EMPLOYEES THAT- HOW THEIR
STEADY STATE WORK AND THEN GET
THE PLOY EIGHT TO BACK TO BACK
DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES. ARE
US AT YOU KNOW AT TIMES BEING
OF THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
FOR WEEKS- ADDED- AND- ONLY TO
GET RECYCLED BACK. TO THEIR
HEAVY STEADY STATE AND THEN
RECYCLED BACK INTO THE STATE
OPERATIONS. CENTER- TAKES A
HUGE TOLL ON THEM IN THE- AND
EXTENDS TO THEIR FAN. THIS THIS
THIS ESTABLISHING IS. THAT
WORKS TOGETHER AND GENERATES
EFFICIENCIES AND STRATEGIES
THAT COULD NOT BE MAINTAINED
USING THE EXISTING STRUCTURE
THIS THE SANITIZATION OF A TEAM
HAS A FOCUS ON BEING ABLE TO
RAPIDLY RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS ARE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAY AND
THIS WILL PROVIDE CONSISTENT
PROCEDURES AND COMMUNICATIONS
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY IN
PLACE. AS ACTIVATION STAFF ARE
PULLED TOGETHER ON THESE TWO
WEEKS- ROTATIONS PER MINUTE
STAFF WAS SURE- THAT WE GET OF
COURSE RESPOND RAPIDLY AND
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE BETWEEN
OUR RESPONSE STAFF ARE LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS- AND
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND CONTINUE.
TO BE ON THE WORK IT
RELATIONSHIPS AS WELL AS OUR
THROUGH THE RECOVERY OPERATION
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT ON THE-
ON THE- THE NEED TO START TO
MOVE. QUITE FRANKLY I I'M.
SENSITIVE TO THE ALEJO'S. EIGHT
ON AND GIVING HIM STICKS BEACH
AT THIS ON ON THOSE BUT-BACKGROUND OF THE MATTER IS
THAT. WE HAVE BEEN TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN- RESPONDING TO- YOU KNOW
BOTH THE RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
OF. COVERT WILDFIRE SIMPLE REST
OTHER THINGS AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
POLITICIAN ALL DATA TOGETHER
FOR HIM- BURKE B. L. A- ON THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU- IF I IF
I'M THE SECOND- TO- THE L. A.
YOU KNOW ON THE OFFICE OF
EQUITY AND LEAST DOES GRANT
PROGRAM- YOU KNOW OVERARCHING
THE ISSUE OF EQUITY- REALLY IS
OUT. B. THE PRINCIPLES THAT
NEED TO GET IN BED AND ALL THE
WAY DOWN. STARTING IN OUR
PLANNING AND PREPAREDNESS-
CYCLE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO- YOU KNOW CITIES
AND ALSO. PARTNERS AT THE YARD
OR NON GOVERNMENTAL CBO LEVEL-
AND- AND THEN ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE RESPONSE AND THEN
THROUGH THE RECOVERY. THAT DOES
HAVE TO BE BAKED IN PRINCIPLES
AND ALL OF OUR CONSTRUCT A PART
OF THAT IS OF COURSE THE LEAST
THOSE PROGRAM. I JUST AS THE
FIRST YEAR OF THE LEAST THOSE
CALIFORNIA GRANT FUNDING THE
FOCUS OF THE PROGRAM- IT MOVING
FORWARD ROLE WILL BE TO
CONTINUALLY EDUCATE. AND
AMPLIFY OUR I DIVERSE
ENFORCEABLE JENNIFER
COMMUNITIES ABOUT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS. HI THIS IS BEEN
AN ONGOING PROGRAM THAT HAS
EXPANDED THOSE EFFORTS. TO
INCLUDE INFORMATION AND
SERVICES RELATED TO RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY- SERVICES THAT ARE
BAKED INTO THE OUR OUR OUR
ENTIRE RESPONSE AND RECOVERY-
CONSTRUCT. THE SERVICES WOULD
INCLUDE TRAINING. CREATING
ACCESSIBLE. DEVELOPING CAN.
ASSETS LIKE SOURCE MEDIA OWN
MEDIA THAT HELP INSPIRE PEOPLE
TO GET PREPARE. KNOW WHERE TO
GO AND WHAT TO DO WHEN
RESPONDING TO AN EMERGENCY AND
HOW TO ACCESS RESOURCES TO
RECOVER FROM DISASTERS HARSH
PHYSICAL ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL IMPACT. THE FOCUS
HERE IS A POWER MEANT. IS AND
WE KNOW THAT THE MORE PEOPLE
ARE TRAINED AND EMPOWERED TO
MANAGE AND RESPOND TO DISASTER
THE BETTER THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THAT THROUGH
THE ENTIRE RECOVERY PROCESS.
HELLO YES WILL PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT
CALORIES ON A THREE YEAR CYCLE.
CONTINUALLY CAN'T SEEN THEM
BASED ON THE LATEST RESEARCH
AND COMMUNITY FEEDBACK. THE
CONTINUATION OF THE LEAST OF
CALIFORNIA GRANT PROGRAM WILL
COMPLEMENT THE OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY CAL WE ASK
INCLUDING OUTREACH TO OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES. AND
WORK WITH IMMIGRANTS.
UNDOCUMENTED AND CONSULATES AS
WELL AS- ALL OF THE GREAT WORK
THAT IS TAKING PLACE THERE ARE
ALOT CALACATTA WE AS OFFICE OF
ACCESS. AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS.
AND HOW DO WE HOW HOW IS
FUNDING TO BE PRIORITIZED
BETWEEN SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
KERN IS EDUCATION AND TRAINING
WILL REMAIN THE PRIORITY. ALSO
IN THE FIRST THREE YEAR CYCLE
WE WILL BE BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE BY EXPANDING THE
RESPONSE RECOVERY CAPACITY OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THOSE TRUSTED PLACES THAT
VULNERABLE. UP PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES TURN TO FIRST IT IS
ASTER- HOWARD CAL WE ASK-
IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICES ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WALL-
WILL- JANET WILL BENEFIT. HELLO
YES WE USE THE LEAST OF
CALIFORNIA DEVELOPED TOOL
OVERLY SOCIAL VULNERABILITIES
WITH THE STATE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN HAZARD MAPPING
OF EARTHQUAKE WILDFIRE AND
FLOODS THUS PROVIDING AN EVEN
TIGHTER TARGETING OF COMMUNITY
AT COMMUNITIES AT RISK WITHIN
THOSE COUNTIES. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON REACHING
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS OLDER
CALIFORNIANS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
LGBTQ FARMWORKERS AND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THIS
WILL BE DONE IN CONCERT AND
COORDINATION IN OUR OVER
ARCHING EFFORT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO BUILD A MUCH MORE
UP FOUNDATIONAL RESILIENCY UP
FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA. HOW- YEAH PRIORITY
FUNDING COMMUNITIES. LEAVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
GRANT T. L. A. COUNTY WILL
PROVIDE A PLAN FOR PRIORITIZING
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES IN
THEIR GRANT APPLICATION THOSE
APPLICATIONS WILL BE SCORED
BASED UPON A MATRIX THAT
INCLUDES SOCIAL VULNERABILITIES
AND HAZARD MAPPING I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY ALONG WITH
DEMONSTRATED KNOWLEDGE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES AND
EXPERIENCING EXPERIENCE IN
TRAINING COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TOGETHER WE WILL BUILD A
DISASTER RESILIENT RIGHT STATE
TO EMPOWER INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES
COMMUNITIES. AND TOWNS. WHETHER
OUTCOME DATA WOULD BE COLLECTED
AND USED TO INFORM. FUTURE
GRANT AWARDS THE BUT THE BASIC
ANSWER IS YES OUTCOME DATA SUCH
AS- HAS BEEN COLLECTED FOR OUR
CURRENTLY STARS CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM WILL BE USED TO MEASURE
OUR PROGRESS TOWARDS DISASTER
RESILIENCY AND WILL ALSO INFORM
FUTURE GRANT WARD'S- BIT ARE
ARE REQUESTED- AND- THERE WAS
SOME QUESTION ABOUT
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE CURRENT
RESULTS CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
WHAT IS CALIFORNIA GOTTEN FORCE
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
RESPONSE CALIFORNIA ALREADY
TWENTY OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF LEAST OF CALIFORNIA
REPAIRS CAMPAIGN FLOW THROUGH
HELLO YES. IN A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS WE SELECTED LEAD
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
IN TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES WHO IN
TURN SUB GRANTED THE FUNNY TO
OVER THREE HUNDRED SMALLER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THIS
WAS POWERFUL BECAUSE THESE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WORK ON
THE GROUND THEY WERE EMBEDDED
IN THE COMMUNITY THEY WERE THE
FABRIC OF THE COMMUNITY. THE
OTHER THIRTY MILLION OF THE VET
CAME THROUGH CAL VOLUNTEERS
SUPPORT VOLUNTEER AND SERVICE
TEAMS LIKE SEARCH THE COMMUNITY
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAMS FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND AMERICORPS
AND COMMUNICATIONS MATERIALS
CREATED RESEARCH AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. APRIL TWENTY OF
TWENTY ONE LEAGUE PLEASE THOSE
CALIFORNIA REACH MORE THAN
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH THIS AFTER
READING THIS EDUCATION. OUR
OLDER. WE SERVE FORTY NINE
COUNTIES ARE AND OVER SIXTY
MILLION PEOPLE WERE REACH WITH
COVERT NINETEEN SAFETY MESSAGES
MORE THAN EIGHTY NEW RESOURCES
WERE DEVELOPED IN OVER TWENTY
LANGUAGES. AND FIFTY COUNTY
DISASTER DIRECTORS DIRECTORIES
WERE DEVELOPED AND WILL BE
POSTED ON THE LEAST THOSE
CALIFORNIA DOT ORG WEBSITE IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH. WE CREATED
A VERY EASY TO UNDERSTAND AND
DURING DISASTER READY GUIDE
FOCUSING ON FIVE EASY STEPS TO
PREPAREDNESS. AND WE HANDED
THAT OUT TO OVER ONE MILLION OF
THESE GUIDES IN TEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES. HEATED SPECIAL
PROJECTS TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE IN THEIR HOMES IN
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS- IMPERFECT
IMPERFECT M. FOR MY GOD BIG A
CONVERSATION SERIES FEATURING
LATIN ACTS CELEBRATE HE'S
SPEAKING WITH STATE LEADERS
ABOUT TOPICS THAT IMPACT THEIR
COMMUNITIES. TALKS WITH MOMS A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN API
MOTHERS AND THEIR DAUGHTERS
DISCUSSINGISSUES RANGING FROM
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS YOU'RE
GETTING A VACCINATION. AS
SOCIAL BRIDGING PROJECT PHONE
CALLS TO ISOLATED CALIFORNIANS
SHARE PORN INFORMATION LIKE
WHERE TO FIND FOOD RESOURCES
AND HOW TO SIGN UP FOR THE
LOCAL EMERGENCY ALERTS. THIS
TWENTY TWO MONTH EFFORT WAS
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THIS
AND MORE BECAUSE IT WAS DONE TO
TRUSTED PARTNERS ALL THE WHILE
WHILE THE STATE WAS
EXPERIENCING A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC. AND SEVERE WILDFIRE
SEASON AND AGAIN THIS IS THE
BASELINE THE FOUNDATIONAL
ASPECTS OF BUILDING DISASTER
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA AND SO
MOVING FORWARD THE INITIATIVES
ARE TO AMPLIFY THAT EFFORT. AND
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ALL OF YOUR
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU OUR- ARE
AS PREPARED FOR DISASTER. AND
ABLE TO NAVIGATE. THE.
DISASTERS REPORT TO SEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- I
APPRECIATE THOSE ANSWERS- IT'S
VERY VERY THOROUGH- I WANT TO
ASK YOU- BECAUSE THERE'S
ALREADY AS I UNDERSTAND IT
TWENTY SEVEN STATE AGENCIES OR
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE ENGAGED IN
EQUITY WORK- HAVE YOU UP
THOUGHT ABOUT THE KIND OF
EITHER COORDINATION OR ABILITY
TO BE CONSISTENT WITH OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES THAT
ARE DOING SIMILAR EQUITY WORK.
ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW TO DO THAT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THERE IS
THERE IS A CURRENT BILL RIGHT
NOW OUGHT TO CREATE THE OFFICE
OF RACIAL EQUITY WHICH PROPOSES
TO CENTRALIZE AND STANDARDIZED
ON EQUITY FRAMEWORK BUT- ANY
THOUGHTS OR EXPERIENCE ON THAT.
AT THE EXPENSE OF A QUESTION
AND A YES- WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AND WORKING WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES ARE AND- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE DOING OUR
RESEARCH AS WELL ABOUT WHAT IS
BEING- DEVELOP ACROSS THE B. R.
AND WE HAVE STATE AGENCIES. I
WILL I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
EQUITY. PIECE I MEAN THERE
OBVIOUSLY IS A LOT OF SYNERGY
THAT WE NEED TO- LEVERAGE AND
BILL BECAUSE WHEN WE RESPOND TO
DISASTER IT'S NOT JUST- YES
RESPONDING TO DISASTER. BUT
IT'S ALL THE STATE FAMILY
RESPONDING TO A DISASTER THE
PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY IN BEING
ABLE TO DELIVER DISASTER
RESPONSE. WELL START BACK WITH
THE BILL THE- PRINCIPLES OF
LIVING EQUITY START PLANNING
CASE WHERE WERE WERE WORK
ENTERING IT THAT'S WHY THE
LEAST THOSE PROGRAM IS SO
IMPORTANT. ON THE FRONT AND- IN
BEGIN BUILDING THAT BASS LINE
THAT FOUNDATION. OF BROADBAND
THAT THAT TRANSLATES INTO THE
RESPONSE. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO COMMUNITY NO
INDIVIDUAL IS LEFT BEHIND. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY EQUALLY RECEIVED
DISASTER AID. AND I AM IN THE
MOST EQUITABLE FASHION- AND
THAT THAT NO ONE NO ONE IS
AFRAID TO BE ABLE TO GET
ASSISTANCE. AND THAT THAT GOES
THROUGH ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
RECOVERY PROCESS AND SO THERE
ARE SOME UNIQUE THIS IS TO THE
EQUITY IN BEING ABLE TO
ACTUALLY DELIVER DISASTER. AND
HUMANITARIAN AID- BUT THERE'S
ALSO THE NEED TO EXTRAPOLATE
THAT TO THE OTHER STATE FAMILY.
THAT WE TASK TO SUPPORT US IN
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
DISASTERS SO THE SHORT ANSWER
IS YES WE WILL COORDINATE WITH
THOSE OTHER STATE AGENCIES- BUT
WE ALSO HAVE SOME VERY UNIQUE.
EQUITY RELATED ISSUES WITH THIS
ASTOR. DISASTER DELIVERY OF
OBJECT PROGRAMS GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU KNOW- I'M
CARRYING THEM A BILL FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ON
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND- THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN THE
HOUSEHOLDS WHERE THEY WORK. AND
WHAT BROUGHT UP WHAT BROUGHT ME
TO THAT WAS MANY MANY STORIES
OF DAY LABORERS. AND DOMESTIC
WORKERS WHO WERE NOT PROVIDED
WITH ANY INFORMATION ABOUT.
THEIR RIGHT TO EITHER LEAVE. OR
THEIR RIGHTS ON- HOW TO CLEAN.
UP TOXIC- THAT WERE LESS AS WE
OF THE FIRES- THERE ARE A
NUMBER VERY DISTURBING STORIES
SO. I'M I'M SURE HOPING THAT
INCLUDED IN OUR THE PLANNING
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING HERE'S
HOW TO PROVIDE SERVICES AND
PROTECTION FOR- THOSE WHO DON'T
LIVE IN THE AREA BUT WORK IN
THE AREA- AND- MAY HAVE
LANGUAGE ISSUES MAY HAVE
IMMIGRATION STATUS ISSUES. BUT
THEY'RE WORKING IN THEIR- AND
AGAIN MANY TIMES DIDN'T GET THE
KIND OF. PROTECTION AND
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY NEEDED AND
DESERVED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I THINK IT'S A GOOD. VERY
IMPORTANT POINT. THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S AGAIN SOME OF THAT AS WE
AS WE START MOVING SO FAST TO
RESPOND TO THESE DISASTERS AND
DISASTERS ARE SO FREQUENT. AND
THEY AND THEY BECOME EVER MORE
COMPLICATED JUST BECAUSE OF THE
OF THE SCOTT SIZE SCOPE AND
SCALE THAT WE'RE SEEING- THIS
IS THESE ARE THE AREAS WE DO
NOT WANT TO FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND IT REALLY DOES WHAT
YOU JUST SAID REALLY SPEAKS- AS
AS THE- ONE OF THE KEY AREAS OF
US BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS- THAT.
EFFORT NOT JUST WITH LEAST
THOSE ARE RIGHT BUT BAKING IN
THE EQUITY RELATED- PRINCIPLES
THROUGH ALL OF OUR UP TO OUR
REGIONAL OPERATIONS DOWN TO OUR
FIRST RESPONDER LEVELS. MAKING
SURE THAT ALL OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ARENA IS ADDRESSING THAT
IN THAT FASHION WE WANTED TO BE
ON THE FRONT END OF THE FOURTH
FOUGHT NOT AS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT AFTER THE
FACT SO. I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU AS WELL ON THAT AND- IN GET
YOUR YOUR ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK
QUITE I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COLLEAGUES CENTER NEWMAN ANY.
QUESTIONS ARE. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL OF OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS- PROVIDE TO
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
MEDICARE UP NEXT IT THAT THE
HOLD OPEN ITEM NEXT IS ISSUED
TO AND THIS IS VICTIMS OF CRIME
ACT SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING- ALSO
BE PRESENTED BY- HELLO YES
HELLO YES. GREAT THANKS BROWN
SHARE SO ON THE ON THE VICTIMS
OF A CRIME- SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING- THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
FOR VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR VICTIMS OF
CRIMES SUCH AS RAPE CRISIS
CENTERS AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTERS THE STATE SHARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL VOCA
FUNDING HAS DECREASED IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS THE FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION. A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS THROUGH THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY. TWENTY THREE-
THROUGH THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE THIS
WILL ENSURE SERVICE PROVIDERS
MANY OF WHICH ARE NONPROFIT AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ABLE TO PLAN AND CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE IS VERY CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND SERVICES. THE
VICTIMS OF. A CRIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- THERE ARE SOME- I
MEAN THE L. A. WOULD PLEASE.
SORT OF BORED THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE ARE
CURRENTLY EFFORTS TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THROUGH THE FOCUS THANKS ACT
THAT COULD RESULT IN INCREASED
FEDERAL FUNDING IN THE FUTURE.
ACCORDINGLY IF IT'S THE
LEGISLATURE GOAL TO MAINTAIN
THESE SERVICES IT COULD
CONSIDER ADOPTING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING ANY FUNDS
NOT NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN THE
EXISTING SERVICE LEVEL TO RIVER
AT THE END OF THE YEAR. THANK
YOU AND DON'T FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
INTERNATIONAL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER TAT.
OKAY WOUND THAT COLLEAGUES-
MISTER CENTER NEWMAN NO CRISIS
MANAGER OKAY ALL RIGHT- THAT'S
ALL HOLD OPEN ITEM AS WELL
AGAIN THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH-
NEXT IS- ISSUE THREE COMMUNITY
HARDENING TO BUILD DISASTER
RESILIENCE OF COMMUNITIES.
AGAIN NO THANKS MADAM CHAIR-
DOES SPEAKING OF THE SAME SORT
OF- YOU KNOW FRAMEWORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT- YOU
KNOW WE- WE JUST RECENTLY
TALKED ABOUT LEAST DOES AND-
AND BUILDING OUR CAPACITY TO
RESPOND. THIS IS AN INITIATIVE-
THAT IS FOCUSED ON- ON ON
BUILDING DISASTER RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE KNOW THAT- WITH THE
KIND OF DISASTERS WERE SEEING
THE FREQUENCY SCOPE AND SCALE
BIG BIG OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES-
ARE GETTING YOU KNOW JUST HOW
DID ONE AFTER THE OTHER WITH
REGARD SOMETIMES. THEY'RE
THEY'RE RESPONDING TO A NEW
DISASTER WHILE THEY'RE HAVING
TO STILL BE RECOVERING FROM THE
PREVIOUS DISASTER AND YOU KNOW
THIS FOCUS IS THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
DISASTER REBUILD DISASTER
REFILL. SO TO STRENGTHEN AND
BETTER PREPARE OUR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE'RE
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A NEW
INITIATIVE CALLED REPAIR
CALIFORNIA. BUILDING DISASTER
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES THIS IS
FOUNDATIONAL- IN THAT IT REALLY
DOES FOCUS ON BUILDING UP A
FRAMEWORK AND. AN OUT AND OUT-
OF. I NEVER THROUGHOUT OUR LOW
CAN I IMAC THE POWER OF
GOVERNMENT NOT NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS ARE THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO
RECOGNIZE AND SYNERGIZE RISK
PRIORITIZATION AND UP RELATED
ACTION AND HELPS TO ADDRESS
CURRENT BARRIERS FOR LOCAL AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS THIS FUNDING
WHICH SUPPORT LOCAL COMMUNITY
PROJECTS AND INITIATIVES
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS ALL
HAZARDS. VULNERABILITIES ARE
AND BUILD- RESILIENCY AND
PROTECT ENTIRE COMMUNITIES
BEFORE DISASTERS WITH THE
SUPPORT OF STATE GOVERNMENT AND
AGAIN I EMPHASIZE BUILDING THAT
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND ACTIVE
ABILITY BEFORE DISASTERS ARE
ALLOWED TO HAVE THAT CAPABILITY.
WHEN A DISASTER OCCURS. THE
PROGRAM WOULD TARGET
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
PROMOTING THE PRINCIPLES OF
EQUITY AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
AND BUILDING A FOUNDATION FOR
STATEWIDE RESILIENCY EDUCATION
TO ALL HOUSES TO PARTNERSHIPS
ENGAGEMENTS AND COMMUNITY
HARDING PROGRAMS. WILL ALSO
INCLUDE FUNDING TO HELP RELIEVE
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF UP 21100% OF.
THEIR SHARE OF COST REQUIRED
BURKE MITIGATION PROJECTS UNDER
THE FEDERAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PROGRAM. WHICH HAS BEEN A
BARRIER FOR MANY MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE AS AS A FIRST
RESPONDER I WILL TELL YOU I
HAVE SEEN AND WALK THROUGH TOO
MANY COMMUNITIES. AFTER THEY'VE
BEEN LEVEL BY DISASTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. THOSE LIVES ARE
FOREVER CHANGED BY THESE
EVENTS- WE KNOW THAT DISASTERS
WILL HAPPEN BUT WE CAN'T DO A
BETTER JOB IS SUPPORTING A
PREPARING OUR COMMUNITIES SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY THE L. A- PLEASE. WELL MY
COMMUNITY HARDENING ACTIVITIES
CAN ACHIEVE NOTABLE BENEFITS-
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY HOW FUNDS
WOULD BE PRIORITIZE BETWEEN
DIFFERENT TYPES OF HAZARDS SUCH
AS WILD FIRES EARTHQUAKES AND
FLOODS HOW FUNDS WOULD BE
DIVIDED BETWEEN OFFSETTING
FEDERAL MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THE
EXTENT TO WHICH FEDERAL
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE
OFFSET HOW DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE IDENTIFIED
AND HOW FUNDS WOULD BE
PRIORITISED BETWEEN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
KNOW THAT IF THE LEGISLATURE
CHOOSES TO APPROVE THIS FUNDING
IT COULD STRUCTURE THE PROGRAM
TO BE CONSISTENT WITH ITS
PRIORITIES. FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE ON COULD CHOOSE TO
DIRECT A CERTAIN PORTION OR ALL
OF THESE FUNDS TOWARDS A
SPECIFIC TYPE OF HAZARDS SUCH
AS WILDFIRES AND IFIT CHOSE TO
TAKE THIS ROUTE IT COULD DO SO
BY ADOPTING PROVISIONAL OR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I'M HAPPY
TO SEE QUE QUE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU AGAIN MR GARDNER G. COULD
YOU PLEASE RESPOND TO THE L. A.
L. HAPPY DEMAND. THANK YOU- AND
THANKS OPEN QUESTION- SO THE
FIRST ONE IS HEALTH PLAN TO RE
PRIORITIZE BETWEEN DIFFERENT
TYPES OF HAZARDS. SUCH AS
WILDFIRES EARTHQUAKES AND
FLOODS. THE PROJECTS THAT ALIGN
WITH THE MITIGATION STRATEGIES
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF THE
STATE HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN
AND A LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN. AND RISK ASSESSMENTS OF
LOCAL COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDER
RESILIENCY ROUNDTABLES WILL BE
THE VEHICLE THAT HELPS US TO
PRIORITIZE THIS FUNDING. EACH
LOCAL COMMUNITY HAS A SIGNATURE
ARE THEY HAVE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF RISKS AND THREATS NOT YOU
CAN'T HATE THE STATE ABROAD
RUSSIAN AND EVERYBODY. NOT
EVERYBODY HAS A WALL PARKS RACK
NOT EVERYBODY HAS EARTHQUAKE
THREAT BUT WE DO NEED TO KNOW
WHAT WHAT THREATS EXIST AND-
AND THAT THAT ENGAGEMENT- WITH
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY PARTNERS IS
CRITICAL AS WELL AS ALL THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
STATE LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN. COMMUNITIES WILL UNDERGO
A COMPREHENSIVE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANNING PROCESS
WHERE THEY IDENTIFY THEIR
GREATEST HAZARDS. COMMUNITIES
CAN THEN SUBMIT PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR HOUSES BASED
UPON. THE GREATEST LOCAL MEAT
FUNDS WILL BE PRIORITIZED FOR
PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE MULTI
HAZARD BENEFITS. FOR EXAMPLE
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE
HARDENING FOR FLOOD FIRE OR
EARTHQUAKE. AND THAT ACCOUNT
FOR FUTURE CONDITIONS ALERT AND
WARNING FOR EXAMPLE OFFER ALL
HAZARDS OR PROJECTS TO ADAPT
ALL HAZARD BUILDING CODE
INCREASES OR POSSIBLY. LAND USE
PLANNING CHANGES. HOW WILL FIND
HOW FUNDS WERE BE GIVE BETWEEN
ALSO FED MATCHING. AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THERE IS
NO SET AMOUNT DEDICATED TO
FEDERAL MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. HELLO
YES IT TENDS TO DO EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH WITH LOCAL PARTNERS TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS THE GREATEST
NEED. AFTER LOCATION FOR SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL INCLUDE
SOME ASSISTANCE WITH A COST
SHARE BROWSER MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAMS AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
FOR OTHERS IT MAY BE FOR OTHER
EFFORTS SUCH AS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR PROVIDING SEED
MONEY FOR PROJECT SCOPING AND
DEVELOPMENT OR INVESTMENT IN
MITIGATION PROJECT AND IN FACT-
PART OF THIS FUNDING WOULD GO
UP- AND BEAT LAMPERT USED TO
BRING A- THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
RESILIENCY ROUND TABLES
TOGETHER- IT'S NOT JUST THE
GOVERNMENT SOLUTION IT'S A
PUBLIC PRIVATE NON GOVERNMENTAL
FAITH BASED WHOLE OF COMMUNITY
APPROACH- AND WE HAVE TO BREAK
THE CYCLE. AND THERE'S NOTHING
LINEAR ABOUT THIS DISASTER
PLANNING AND RESPONSE IT'S VERY
ASYMMETRICAL SO WE NEED TO
APPROACH IT IN THAT MANNER TO
BE OUT IN FRONT OF FUTURE
DISASTERS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE. THE EXTENT TO WHICH
FEDERAL MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
WOULD BE OFFSET DALY ABROAD
PROGRAM GOOD POINT. UNDER THE
ACT HI OTHER MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM THE ELIGIBLE FEDERAL
SHARE IS UP TO SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. WITH THE LOCAL COST
SHARE REQUIREMENT OF TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT DETERMINE
THEIR GREATEST NEED. TO INCLUDE
ASSISTANCE WITH THE LOCAL COST
YEAR WITH THE FEDERAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PROGRAM. FUNDING
WOULD BE A- AVAILABLE FOR UP TO
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. FOR THAT
25% MATCH ARE AT. THIS JUST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN GETTING
THOSE MITIGATION PROGRESS
STARTED. THE SPECIFIC CRITERIA
METRICS THAT WILL BE USED FOR
THE COST YEAR OFFSET THE
TERMINATION IS STILL BEING
DEVELOPED BUT WILL INCLUDE A
CONSIDERATION. FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL THE QUESTION WAS
DISADVANTAGED WOULD BE
IDENTIFIED. THE STATE HAZARD
MITIGATION OUR PLAN INCLUDES A
VERY DETAILED ANALYSIS OF
HAZARDS IN CALIFORNIA OVERLAID
WITH SOCIAL GOING TO RELOOK
PEAK WITHIN THE STATE. LOCAL
MITIGATION PLANS SIMILAR
INCLUDES THIS ANALYSIS. JUST
FIFTY THIS SERVES S A ROADMAP
TO IDENTIFY THE HIGHEST AREA OF
NEED A COMBINED WITH EXPERTISE
FROM THE CALLOW YES OFFICE OF
EQUITY AND OTHER STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS. AND USING EXISTING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
DEFINITIONS WILL RESULT IN
COMPREHENSIVE AND CONSISTENT
PROGRAM METRICS. AS WELL
ANALYSIS OF PREVIOUS DISASTER
IMPACT. IMPACTS COMMUNITY
HISTORY OF MITIGATING HIGH RISK
COMMUNITY INTEREST AND CAPACITY
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL BE
CONSIDERATION FACTORS. AS WELL
THE QUESTION WAS HOW FUNDS
WOULD BE PRIORITIZED TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THESE DETAILS ARE STILL IN
DEVELOPMENT GENERALLY HOWEVER
IT WILL BE LEVEL IT WILL WILL
WILL LEVERAGE BENEFIT COST
ANALYSIS COMPLY. WITH HOUSING
PROFILE ANALYSIS WILL INFORM
PROCESS THAT ENSURES PROJECTS
ARE IMPLEMENTED IN AREAS THAT
INCREASE AND BUILD A FOUNDATION
OF COMMUNITY RESILIENCE. WHERE
THE GREATEST NEED EXIST. THANK
THANK YOU HAVE ARE HAPPENING AT
FOR THE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
RESHAPE THAT- CENTER NEWMAN I'D
DO HAVE A GREGORY. AB SO YOU TO
THE- YES SORRY IT GOES WITH TO
GET THE DEPARTMENT OF FINE OVER
LET'S DO THAT HOLD ON ONE
SECOND. NOTHING FURTHER TO
FURTHER TO AND CHECK THANK YOU
YOU INTIMIDATE. NOT LIKELY. MY
QUESTION SO THANK YOU THE- YES
DO YOU PREFER TO SPEAK TODAY
THERE IS A NOTE IN MY ANALYSIS
THAT THAT INDICATES THE STATE
WOULD PRIORITIZE THE GRANT
FUNDS FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE WIDESPREAD
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION SAID-
CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
WHAT'S THE STANDARD FOR
WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION AND HOW WAS IT.
ASSESSED YEAH SO GOOD QUESTION-
I THINK THAT THAT BUT CONSERVE
BY WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY.
ENGAGEMENT IS THAT WHAT WHAT WE
WANT IS WE WANT OUR- IN THIS
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY. WE DON'T WANT TO
JUST HAVE ANOTHER ONE OFF RAMP
THAT GOES TO A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OR TO AN ENTITY- THAT- IT MAYES
ACCOMPLISH A SINGLE- MITIGATION
EFFORT FIVE IT DOESN'T BUILD
THIS THIS CONCEPT OF RESILIENCY
SO WHAT WE WOULD. WE WOULD DO
IS WE WOULD LOOK AT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN OUR IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS IN OUR PARTNERSHIP
AND- IT COURAGE THEM TO BRING
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY TOGETHER
AND WE WOULD ASK THEM HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO. BE ABLE TO
BRING THE WHOLE TREE TOGETHER
AND WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
EXAMPLES- AND TECHNICAL
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AS I MENTIONED EARLIER-
YOU KNOW ALL THE DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT MAKES UP
THE FABRIC OF THAT COMMUNITY
PEOPLE LIVE. GO TO CHURCH GO TO
SCHOOL SHOP FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IS THESE ARE ALL
ENTITIES WE HAVE SEEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN DISASTER AFTER
DISASTER THERE ARE NOT ONLY
IMPACTED BY THE DISASTERS BUT
ALSO A SOLUTION TO THE RECOVERY
AFTER THE DISASTER AND WHAT WE
WANT IS- TO THE LEVERAGE ALL OF
THOSE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY- AND
SO WHAT WE WOULD LOOK TO. IF
YOU WOULD SEE WOULD RECEIVE
WHAT COMMUNITIES. WHAT WHAT
TREATING GAVE IT CAN BE HAD-
HOW MUCH CAN BE INVESTED ON THE
PART OF THAT COMMUNITY IT'S THE
WILL IT'S NOT JUST THE
POLITICAL WELL OPERATIONAL
WELL- YOU KNOW WILL PROVIDE
FUNDING AND WILL PROVIDE ALL OF
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
WRAPAROUND IT IS A ONE TEAM ONE
FIGHT SORT OF EFFORT. YOU HAVE
DEPRECIATE THAT SHOULD SERVE IN
WITH RESPECT TO THE THIS IS A
ONE TIME GRANT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS I'M TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF HOW FAR THAT
GOES. WHAT'S A TYPICAL
INCREMENT OF ALLOCATION AND
WHAT IS. YOUR WITHIN THAT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
MILLION AND. WHAT WHAT A
COMMUNITY CAN ONLY DO WITH
THOSE FUNDS. SO OKAY GREAT
QUESTION A LOT OF DEPENDS THE
COMMUNITY AND- IT DEPENDS OF
THE- SIZE AND SCOPE OF-
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE-
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE RIGHT A
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS UP IS UP YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
SIZE AND CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THIS REALLY
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO OUR OUR OUR
CITIES AND DISTRICTS- YOU KNOW.
PARDON BIG PART OF THIS MONEY
WILL NOT ONLY- REALLY BE
FOCUSED ON BRINGING TOGETHER
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT ENTITIES I
THINK IT'S UP HELPING
COMMUNITIES TO- TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING TOGETHER
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AROUND
THE RESILIENCY ROUNDTABLE THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT COULD
GET US SEED MONEY TO GET
COMMUNITY STARTED BASED UPON
ASSISTANCE FROM- YES AND OUR
STATE FAMILY- AND THEN. WE
WORKING WITH THEM AND THE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE ROUNDTABLE
THAT WOULD HELP FIND LEVERAGE
MANY OTHER SOURCES OF GRANT
FUNDING THERE ARE STE FEDERAL
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANTS THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED MULTIPLE
OTHER KINDS OF RESILIENCY
GRANTS THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
PLUGIN THE A MERICAN REPORT
RESCUE ACT PROPOSES ANOTHER
KIND OF THE HOUSING MITIGATION
GRANT INFRASTRUCTURE WORK FEMA
HAS NOW PROPOSED BRICK WHICH IS
A BUILDING DISASTER. RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE. EITHER
ALL CREATED. IN AND SO- REALLY
IT'S NEW- EFFORT THAT CENTER
DRIVES ALL OF THAT AND
MAXIMIZES MONEY COMING INTO
LOCAL COMMUNITY. BUILDING
RESILIENCY BASED UPON A SET OF
METRICS THAT WE WILL WORK WITH
THAT COMMUNITY- TO IMPLEMENT SO
IT'S YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IT'S
ALL IT'S ONE YEAR- IT'S FOR-
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WE KNOW IT'S ONLY GOING
TO GO SO FAR SO WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IF YOU WANT TO REALLY.
AMPLIFY THAT BY BUILDING
CAPACITY. AND THEN LEVERAGING
THAT CAPACITY TO BRING AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE DOLLARS BASED
UPON METRICS SO YOU JUST LAST
FOLLOW UP ON THAT SHOW SO IF
THERE ARE. JUST OVER FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- NOT ALL OF THEM
ARE. YES YOU KNOW IDENTIFIED IS
THAT YOU KNOW OBVIOUS LOCATIONS
FOR CERTAIN KINDS OF TESTERS
HOW MANY CITIES JUST ROUGHLY.
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS MONEY
COULD BE SPREAD. OUT TO ASSIST
THEM WITH THIS SORT OF
PREPARATION. SO SIR I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME
FOR THAT BUT I SEE WHAT YOU'RE
GOING AND YOU KNOW THE ISSUE IS
THAT. MAYBE IT IN A ROOM IN A
REGION MAYBE IT'S A- YOU KNOW
AN AREA WHERE THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME CITIES THAT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA WANT TO FOCUS ON
CITIES THAT ARE A LITTLE BIT
UNDERSERVED AND UP AB LAST
RESOURCE. THERE MAY BE OTHER
CITIES THERE IS FAR AS HOW MUCH
MONEY YEAH YEAH YOU GET IT GETS
DOLED OUT WE ALSO WILL LOOK AT.
MAYBE YOU HAVE A SERIES OF
THREE OR FOUR CITIES THAT ARE
VERY SMALL RIGHT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER AS THEY CONSENTED TRIES
THAT WE KNOW THAT AS A AS AN
INDIVIDUAL CITY. THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT IF THE
IF THEY CAN MATCH THAT THEY CAN
COMBINE. THE THREE CITIES THAT
ARE NEXT TO EACH AYE I THINK
ABOUT THE PENINSULA SAN
FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE AND SAN
MATTEO COUNTY. WE'VE GOT YOU
KNOW MULTIPLE SMALL COMMUNITIES
ARE DOWN ALONG. THE PACIFIC
COAST HIGHWAY LOS ANGELES WE'VE
GOT THE SMALLER CITIES THAT
COULD COME TOGETHER AND COMBINE
RESOURCES AND WE CAN PROVIDE
GRANTS TO HELP AMPLIFY. THAT
AFTER A GET THEM STARTED SO I
THINK THE ANSWER IS WE'RE NOT.
THAT'S NOT FULLY VETTED OUT
YET- AND YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE
THE NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME BUT
I JUST KNOW THAT FROM.
DEVELOPING SIMILAR PROGRAMS IN
THE PAST OBVIOUSLY THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY TO GO AROUND TO
REALLY GET EVERYBODY WHAT WE
NEED TO BUT THERE'S A WAY TO-
LEVERAGE UP VARIOUS SOURCES OF
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO MEET A
BASELINE LEVEL OF METRIC. ENJOY
PROJECT THAT'S RIGHT SO I
ASSUMED IT YOU COULD PROBABLY
CREATE A MATRIX THAT
IDENTIFIES. CITIES BY TYPES OF
HAZARD AND ALSO BY LEVELS OF
NEED- AND I WOULD ASSUME THAT
WOULD BE SUCH A I THINK IT
WOULD IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE WORTH DOING- WITH
AN EYE TOWARD THIS ALLOCATION.
BOB. SO DO APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERS THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATOR. GREAT QUESTION
CENTERED ON NEWMAN I AM. WHAT
IS TO EXTENT. OF HAS BEEN
EXPERIENCE- IS ON DOING THE OUT
REACH AND UP TO THE VARIOUS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
WHETHER IT'S UNDER THE LEAST
DOES PROGRAMMER OR NEW AS
YOU'RE PROPOSING UNDER THIS OF-
REQUEST OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. WHAT DO YOU
HAVE TO BUILD ON. WHAT HAVE YOU
DONE OR WHAT'S BEEN THE
EXPERIENCE TO DATE. WELL ON THE
ON THE ON THE LEGAL SIDE OF
THINGS- YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE
BUILT A GREAT FOUNDATION- YOU
KNOW- I SAY MEASURE EARLIER-
WE'VE REACHED- AND ACTUALLY IF
IT SERVED OVER OVER FORTY NINE
COUNTIES OVER THE LAST. YEAR
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
EFFORT- FUNDING OVER THREE
HUNDRED SOME SMALLER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. WHO ARE OFFICE
OF INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS WE
ENGAGE WITH THAT CONSULATE'S
OFFICE SUPPORT MISSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ARE TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH- WITHOUT.
REPRESENTED DEMOGRAPHICS A BIT
BETTER IN CALIFORNIA THAT MAKE
UP THE FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA BOB
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE- DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS INFORMATION-
THROUGH CAL POLY TEARS. UP
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PUSH OUT
MONEY FOR BUILDING SEARCH AND
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS. AND
ENHANCING AMERICORPS. THAT'S
JUST SOME OF THE EXAMPLES OF
THE LEAST THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE AMPLIFIED THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT AS WELL- THROUGH
THE DISASTER RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE. M. IN IN
CAL CAL WE ASK FOR WORKING WITH
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- TO.
IMPLEMENT HAZARD MITIGATION
PROJECTS THESE PROJECTS ARE ALL
HAZARD- THEY RANGE FROM
EVERYWHERE FROM FLOOD
MITIGATION PROJECTS THE
WILDFIRE DECIDED RETROFITTING-
TO LAND. A SLIGHT DOUBT
PROTECTION- CHIU NOT. MAPPING
OUR LIST GOES ON AND THINK
ABOUT IT IS THAT- THESE ARE ALL
VERY POWERFUL AND IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS AND THEY DO BUILD A
BASELINE FOR US TO. START FROM
THEY ALSO PROVIDE. MY SURE THAT
THEY COME INTO THE TO THE- YES
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON. WHAT I WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU AS A C. AS THE-
YESTER ACTOR IN MULTIPLE
DISASTERS OVER THE COURSE OF.
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IS. IT'S
NOT. THERE'S NO CONSISTENCY TO
THE DEGREE ARE TO BUILD A
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE GOING AND
RESPONDING TO A DISASTER WHEN
DISASTER OCCURS. OR MULTIPLE
DISASTERS OCCUR OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE CAPACITY.
TO BE ABLE TO WITHSTAND THAT
BOTH. OPERATIONALLY BUT ALSO.
ECONOMICALLY AND THEN NO. WHERE
THE RESOURCES ARE THAT THEY
NEED. TO BE ABLE TO. RAPIDLY
RECOVER FROM THAT DISASTER SO-
YES I SPENT A LOT MORE TIME.
RESPONDING IN AND WORK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND- WE JUST
SEE THESE GAPS EXIST SO THE
IDEA HERE IS TO. BUILD ON ALL
OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
WE HAVE A STANDARDIZED
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
ARE THAT EVERY JURISDICTION IS
IT'S IN STATUTE AND- BY LAW BE
JURISDICTION OPERATES FROM SO
WE'VE GOT ORGANIZATIONAL
CONSTRUCT. WE'VE GOT MEDICATION
PROGRAMS WEAVERVILLE
REQUIREMENT FOR HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL EVERY COMMUNITY HAS TO
HAVE A- LOCAL HAS RECOGNITION
PLAN TO BE ABLE TO GET DISASTER
EIGHT THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT- AND-
AND WE'VE GOT THESE- WE'VE
WE'VE GOT THIS- ENGAGEMENT
THAT'S HAPPENING. DAY TODAY
BETWEEN OUR REGIONAL STAFF AND-
YES HEADQUARTERS AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMUNITIES AT THAT
FIRE AGENCIES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. NOW IT'S
LIKE. WE NEED TO PULL THIS ALL
TOGETHER AND BUILD THIS
FOUNDATION STATEWIDE- THE BILL
THE RESULTS. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION SIR. GOOD
CENTER I'M GOOD AT. GOOD IT
JUST AND IT'S NOT A- QUESTION.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A BIG
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH OT TO
COMMUNITIES THAT EITHER HAVE
ALREADY BEEN. TOUCHED BY THE
SERVICES OR WHO NEED TO BE. OUR
PROVIDED SERVICES AND WE NEED
TO OUT REACH- SO I THINK IT IN
THAT SENSE IT'S REALLY. GOOD I
THINK THE- IT WOULD BE GOOD TO
KNOW FOR US OF WHICH ARE THE
COUNTIES WERE THIS IS ACTUALLY
BEEN DONE WORD IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKED. THERE'S YOU SAID THREE
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
THEY I THINK THE LEGISLATORS
WOULD ALL WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT. AND ALSO TO HELP IN ANY
WAY THAT WE CAN AND WHETHER WE-
WHETHER WE ARE IN FOR EXAMPLE.
LEGISLATORS ARE FROM AND THE
VARIOUS DIVERSITY CAUCUSES OR
WE REPRESENT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SOME COMBINATION OF
THOSE. I THINK IT WOULD BE
REALLY GOOD TO REPORT BACK OR
HAVE A MECHANISM- TO LET US
KNOW WHERE AND HOW THE SERVICES
ARE BEING PROVIDED SO AGAIN WE
COULD- ASSIST WE COULD FILL
GAPS- WE KNOW THAT IN DURING
THE CALL WITH NINETEEN- FOR
TESTING FOR THE ACTUAL
VACCINATIONS WE WORKED HARD IN
THE VARIOUS CAUCUSES- TO
RECOMMEND WHERE- IN OUR VARIOUS
DISTRICTS THOSE SERVICES SHOULD
BE PROVIDED SO. AT SOME POINT I
THINK IT WOULD BE THAT SHOULD
BE BUILT IN ARE YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S EIGHTY D. WE FEEL
IT WHETHER IT'S A FIRE HAZARD
WE FEEL IT- AND ESPECIALLY A
FUND LIKE THIS THAT WHICH IS
SPECIFICALLY TO BE USED TO
ASSIST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SO THAT KIND OF.
WITH YOU KNOW OUTREACH- AND
FORMAL OUTREACH I THINK WOULD
BE A VERY GOOD THING TO DO
THANK YOU CAN I ADD SOMETHING
ON CHURCH I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE REALLY AWARE OF
THE HAZARDS- THAT ARE PRESENT
UNTIL IT IS ASTERS CHAU THERE'S
PROBABLY AN ITERATIVE PROCESS
HERE- WE ENSURING INFORMATION
FROM THE COX'S BROSSEAU FROM. I
THINK FROM- YES I DO I FIND
CONSERVE HAZARDS. THAT ARE MOST
LIKELY TO PRESENT THEMSELVES- I
THINK IT- FOR- YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AGAIN AND REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU BEING HERE
THANK YOU MR. COLOR DUTY THEY
SAY THAT YOU HAVE CARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THIS OKAY NOW
WE'VE MOVED ON FROM IT C. THIS
ISSUE WILL ALSO BE HELD OPEN WE
MOVE ON TO JUDICIAL BRANCH.
AND- THAT'S ISSUES FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU MISTER PHILLIPS. IN
HIS SHOES. FOR OKAY. WELCOME MR
DR FRANCIS OF WE'LL START WITH
ISSUE FOUR AND WILL THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH PLEASE PRESENT.
YES GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS LIKE COOKING GARBAGE
FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE- AN
OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE ISSUES
OF THE NINE ISSUES ARE
PRESENTED IN THE AGENDA AS-
DISCUSSED WITH DR FRANCIS. I'LL
GO THROUGH THE DESCRIPTION WE
DO HAVE- STAFF AND EXPERTS TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS
ON THE ISSUES AND I'M
SPECIFICALLY DESCRIBING AS WELL
AS ANY OTHER ITEMS AND YOUR
GENDER. SO FIRST WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS ITEMS. THE FIRST IS
A REVISION PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT EARLY
DISPOSITION READING THIS
CONFERENCE PROGRAM. THIS
PROPOSAL BILLS ON A PROGRAM
INITIATED BY THE CHIEF JUSTICE
IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN RELATED DELAYS. IN
CRIMINAL CASE PROCESSING.
MAKING TEMPORARY ASSIGNED
JUDGES AVAILABLE TO COMPETE
COMPLETE READINESS CONFERENCES
TO RESOLVE LOW LEVEL
MISDEMEANOR. OR FELONY CASES
BEFORE THEY GO TO TRIAL. NEXT
ITEM IS WITHIN THAT IS OF THE
MAYOR REVISION PROPOSES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
REQUEST ADDITIONAL FUNDING UP
TO SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS. TO
ADDRESS THE COURT'S CASE OF
BACK OFFICE THIS FUNDING WHICH
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO APPROVAL BY
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCED UPON
REVIEW OF THEIR DATA
DEMONSTRATING A PERSISTENT CASE
BACKLOG. COULD BE USED TO
PROCURE RESOURCES SUCH AS
ADDITIONALSTAFF OR SPACE TO
PROCESS CASES. ONE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THE FINES AND FEES ON A
SHIP. THE MAIN REVISION
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS
TO SUPPORT A DEBT FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM TO ELIMINATE DEBT. OWED
ON EXISTING FINES AND FEES FOR
TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTION TICKETS ISSUED
BETWEEN JANUARY. TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. UNDER THIS PROGRAM
I LO INCOME INDIVIDUAL COULD
APPLY TO HAVE A 100% OF THEIR
DEBT FORGIVENESS GIVEN UPON
SUBMISSION OF AN APPLICATION
VERIFYING THEIR LOW INCOME
STATUS. NUMBER THREE IS-
RELATED TO- PRE TRIAL DETENTION
FUNDING. YOU MAY RECALL THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED BUNCH BILL LANGUAGE
OUTLINING THE FREE TRIAL
DECISION MAKING PILOT IN THE
COMING THAT LANGUAGE WAS A
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME ALLOCATION TO THE
JOINT COUNCIL TO FIND.
IMPLEMENTATION OPERATION THE
VALUATION OF THE PROGRAM'S OUR
EFFORTS AT LEAST TEN COURTS
WITHIN A PRE TRIAL DECISION
MAKING. BUILDING UPON THAT THE
MERE REVISION INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TO SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING TO EXPAND A
PRE TRIAL POWER PROGRAMS FUNDED
FROM THE ONE TIME RESOURCES IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN. BUDGET
ACT. IN FINAL ITEM THAT WILL
TALK ABOUT IS NUMBER FIVE THE
LEGAL AGE FOR RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS TENANTS DISPUTES. BE
REVISION INCLUDES TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR THREE YEARS A TOTAL OF
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE LEGAL AID SERVICES FOR
RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS. AVOID
EVICTIONS FORECLOSURES. SAID
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE
WILL BE PRESENTING AT THE
MOMENT. WE DO HAVE STAFF
AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS AS YOU MAY HAVE THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. OKAY WE HAVE THE- KALLIO.
COMMENTS. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE
COMMENTS ON FOUR OF THE ITEMS
BEFORE YOU COINCIDENTALLY THEY
ARE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR AS
LISTED ON YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE
EIGHT- THIS IS STARTING WITH
THE FIRST ITEM WE DO OUR
COMMENTS ON THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR- AT LEAST SIXTY
MILLION EACH FOR CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL CASE BACKLOGS AND SO ON
THAT ONE WE'RE ACTUALLY
RECOMMENDING REJECTING THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE AND THERE IS
A PROCESS OUTLINED IN NINETEEN
FORTY OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR
STATE PROGRAMS TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
UNANTICIPATED AND NECESSARY
EXPENSES. WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
AS PART OF THAT PROCESS- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IF THE
AMOUNT NEEDED EXENE SORT OF
WHAT IS ALREADY SET ASIDE IN
NINETEEN FORTY- THERE IS A
PROCESS FOR OBTAINING MORE
MONEY SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN MAINTAINING THIS
LANGUAGE WE DO RECOMMEND OF
MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE TO
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROCESS IN TWO WAYS THE
FIRST IS WE RECOMMEND-
MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE TO
INCLUDE LEGISLATIVE
EXPECTATIONS FOR HOW THE
FUNDING MAY BE USED I'M FOR
EXAMPLE LIMITING IT TO CERTAIN
CASE TYPES ARE CERTAIN
PROCEEDING TYPES. OR IF IT'S
KIND OF A STATE WIDE TARGETED
EFFORT- SIMILAR TO THE EARLY
DISPOSITION READINESS
CONFERENCE PROGRAM WHICH IS FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH ARE PRESENT
ON THE SECOND- MODIFICATION IS
WE WOULD RECOMMEND MODIFYING IT
TO INCLUDE WHAT INFORMATION
MUST BE PROVIDED TO JUSTIFY THE
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING-SO FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER REQUIRE
INFORMATION ON A STATE WIDE
BACKLOG- WHAT PARTICULAR
ACTIONS- INDIVIDUAL TRIAL
COURTS HAVE TAKEN TO MITIGATE
THE BACKLOGS AND HOW AND HOW
THE PROVIDED FUNDING WOULD. BE
ALLOCATED AND USE. I'M TO ISSUE
TO THE FINANCE ITEM OR YOUR
REGION- WE WOULDN'T KNOW THAT
WE KERN DON'T HAVE THE TRUE
BILL. FOR THE PROGRAM AT THE
TIME AT THIS TIME WE DO FIND
THAT THE PROPOSAL MERRICK'S
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AS IT
WOULD PROVIDE RELIEF TO LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS. HOWEVER
THERE ARE SOME KEY QUESTIONS
THAT REMAIN AND THOSE INCLUDE
WHAT HAPPENS OF THE PARTITION
PARTICIPATION RATE IS HIGHER
THAN EXPECTED RESULTING IN A
LARGER REDUCTION IN FINANCE THE
REVENUE THAN IS CURRENTLY
ANTICIPATED. HOW MUCH FUNDING
WOULD BE PROVIDED FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION AND OUTRAGE
COSTS. HOW IN THE BACKFIELD TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BE
DISTRIBUTED AND HOW THE PROGRAM
OPERATES IN TANDEM WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND ONLINE EDUCATION OF
INFRACTIONS AS WELL AS ABILITY
TO PAY DETERMINATION STATEWIDE.
AND THE ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS ARE CRITICAL TO ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO WEIGH THE
PROGRAM AGAINST OTHER
PRIORITIES AS WELL AS TO ENSURE
THAT IT IS STRUCTURED AND
OPERATED IN A MANNER
CONSISTENT. WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES AND EXPECTATIONS.
AND SO FINALLY ON THIS ITEM WE
WILL NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT ALSO NEED TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT OF REVENUE REDUCTIONS ON
OTHER STATE FUNDS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED BY THIS TYPE OF
ROMANIA. BECAUSE BACK FEELS FOR
THEM ARE NOT PROPOSED AS PART
OF THIS PROPOSAL THAT BEING
SAID THE LEGISLATURE HAS
VARIOUS. OPTIONS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS IT. MOVING TO THREE-
AND THE PRIEST OF THE TRIAL THE-
PROPOSAL- WE DO FIND THE
PROPOSAL MERITS CONSIDERATION
AS IT PROVIDES RELIEF TO LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS. WHO MAY
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME PAYING
BAIL AND GIVEN A RECENT COURT
RULING THAT WOULD INCREASE THE
NEED- FOR PRE TRIAL SERVICES.
HOWEVER WE DO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER MODIFYING
THE PROPOSED BUDGET LANGUAGE IN
A FIVE WAY. THE FIRST IS- THE
CAR PROPOSAL ALLOCATE FUNDING
TO THE TRIAL COURTS BASED ON
EACH COMPANY'S SHARE OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION OF EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD AND SO
WE WOULD RECOMMEND MARC
CONSIDER MODIFYING THE
LANGUAGE. TO ALLOCATE FUNDING
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOURTHS IN THE NEXT
THREE FISCAL YEARS. USING
ALTERNATIVE OR ADDITIONAL
METRICS SUCH AS CRIMINAL
FILINGS TO ENSURE FUNDING ONE
MORE CLOSELY MATCHED POTENTIAL
WORKLOAD FOR EACH COUNTY. A
MODIFICATION IS- TO REQUIRED
DETAILS ANNUAL REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON EXPENDITURES AND
KEY OUTCOME DATA OVER THIS
AREA. TO INCREASE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AND ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS BEING USED
ACCOUNTABLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THE THIRD MODIFICATION IS TO
SPECIFY THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO MODIFY THE
ALLOCATION FORMULA IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
FISCAL YEAR BASED ON ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT HAS BEEN RECEIVED AS
WELL AS THE FIRST- REQUIRED A
JUDICIAL COUNCIL EVALUATION OF
PRE TRIAL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND THIS COLLEGE- REYES.
ADDITIONAL METRICS SUCH AS THE
PERCENT OF PEOPLE RELEASED
PRETRIAL RELATIVE TO FINDINGS
WHICH MAYBE- A BETTER METHOD
ARE BETTER METRIC FOR
ALLOCATING THE FUNDING. THE
FOURTH MODIFICATION- WE WOULD
RECOMMEND IS PROVIDING COURTS
FLEXIBILITY TO CONTRACT WITH
BEING ENTITY THAT IS BEST
SUITED TO PROVIDE PRE TRIAL
SERVICES RATHER THAN JUST
PROBATION. AS THAT WOULD ENSURE
THAT- THAT THERE ARE OTHERS
THAT COULD PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AND WE'RE CONTRACTING
WITH THE ENTITY THAT IS BEST
EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE IT. AND THE
FINAL MODIFICATION IS TO
REQUIRE THE EVALUATION OF THE
IMPACT OF RACE AND OTHER
FACTORS ON RELEASED DECISIONS
TO HELP INFORM WHETHER FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS NEEDED.
AND THE FINAL- SET OF COMMENTS
THAT WE HAVE IS AN ISSUE FOR ON
YOUR AGENDA WHICH IS RELATED
SHOE IN ONE TIME- IT ISN'T THE
NEIGHBOR VISION INCREASE
INCLUDES AN AUGMENTATION A ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION- FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AND SO ON THIS
ITEM WE DO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL PROVIDE A LIST OF
PROJECTS THAT WILL BE FUNDED BY
THIS PARTICULAR AMOUNT. BEFORE
ACTING ON THE PROPOSAL IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THE SELECTED PROJECTS
ALIGNED WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES AND WE WOULD NOTE
THAT FOR THE THIRTY MILLION
THAT WAS PROPOSED AS PART OF
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL- AS PART
OF JANUARY BUDGET AND USUAL
RANKING WAS ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THE THIRTY ONE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE FUNDED BY- THAT.
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING. SO THAT
WILL CONCLUDE OUR COMMENTS AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WESLEY- I GREW HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COMMENTS.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
STATUS JUSTIN EDELMAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN A
RESPONSE IF THANK YOU THE L. A.
AS ANNOUNCED ON ISSUE NUMBER
READ IT THE TRIAL RELEASES- I'M
THE ADMINISTRATION IS OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THELEGISLATURE ON
DETERMINING THE BEST FACTOR TO
CONSIDER THE COUNTY NEEDS FOR
THE- ALLOCATION OF THIS FUNDING
WE FELT THAT THE SPECIFIED AGE
RANGE APPROPRIATE DRESSED
POTENTIAL PRE TRIAL RELEASE
NEEDS. BUT ARE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO CONSIDER OTHER METRICS ARE
COMBINATIONS AS RECOMMENDED-
AND ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION
AGREES THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S REPORTING AND-
FINDINGS ON THIS PROGRAM SHOULD
BE ROBUST AND HAVE MEANINGFUL-
AFTER WE KNOW THINGS EARNS THE
SOME OF THE L. A. O. L. A-
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SPECIFIED
OUTCOME DATA IS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL I. DEPENDING ON THE
LANGUAGE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
EVENTUALLY AN ALTERNATELY-
INCLUDED WE KNOW THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT MORE. RESOURCES
WILL BE NECESSARY FOR THIS
PROPOSAL- SPECIFICALLY TO
FACILITATE SOME OF THE IN
DEPTH- RECORDING PROCESS IS
THAT SOUND MORE AKIN TO A
DETAILED GRANT MANAGEMENT OR
ACADEMIC STUDIES. AS THE
RECOMMENDATION OF EXPANDING THE
OPTION TO- CONTRACT TO NON
PROBATION ENTITIES THAT
APARTMENT CONSIDERED TO BE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERS THAT
PRE TRIAL RELEASES SUPPORT
ISSUE AND THAT PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ULTIMATELY ANSWER
TO THE COURTS I'M INFORMATION
INVOLVES OTHER COUNTY- ENTITIES
IN CERTAIN ASPECTS OF HIS
REHABILITATIVE OR COUNSELING
SERVICES THAT'S ULTIMATELY
OPTED THAT PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS CHOICE I THIS
PROPOSAL REGARDS PEOPLE'S
LIBERTY AND WE BELIEVE THAT IS
THE CORE FUNCTION AND NOT
NECESSARILY A COUNTY FUNCTION.
AS SUCH WE BELIEVE THAT COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE BEST
SITUATED TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THIS PROPOSAL- FOR
THE OTHER DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ISSUES I'LL TURN TO MY.
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT. OKAY GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING JESSE
REMIND APARTMENTS FINANCE IN
REGARDS STUDENTS CAN DRESS A
COUPLE ISSUES IDENTIFIED BY
MISLI I IN REGARDS TO
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE ALLOWING
THAT YOU SHOULD COUNCIL TO
REQUEST RESOURCES FOR THAT
WE'RE BACK LARGEST ONE READER
EIGHT OVER THE PAST YEAR THAT
JUDICIAL BRANCHES HAD TO
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE OPERATIONS
TO CHANGE THE ARTWORK IN THE
SPREAD OF CORONER AND TEEN
THESE CHANGES HAVE DELAYED
NORMAL CORE OPERATIONS THAT
RESULTED IN A LOT OF. CRIMINAL
AND CIVIL CASES I THIS THIS
PREVAILING WHICH PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG OF THESE CASES I'M
INTERESTED LEN RECOMMENDATION
TO REJECT THIS LANGUAGE JUST
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE DO
NOT CONSIDER TO REJECT I'M
SORRY SIR JACK THIS LANGUAGE IN
THE STATE OF THE FUNDING COULD
BE REQUESTED TO BE NINETY FORTY
UNANTICIPATED COST REQUEST
PROCESS WE JUST LIKE TO NOTE
THAT DO NOT CONSIDER THESE
COSTS TO BE ON ANTICIPATED SO
THEREFORE NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE NINETY FOUR YEAR
PROCESS TO HOUSTON WILL. THIS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE I'M IN
REGARDS TO AND WE HAVE ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS REQUEST
ON BY LIMITING THE USE OF THIS
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN CASE TYPE
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT ACROSS
FIFTY EIGHT SUPERIOR COURT
BACKLOGS COULD GARY BY KEY STEP
IN RESTRICTIONS IT'S FUNDING
CUTTING HIM IN PERSPECTIVE
WHAT'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS.
THEIR BACKLOGS. I'M IN REGARD
TO THE- EYE DOCTOR. FROM JUST
ONE HIGHLIGHTED IN THAT THIS
DEBT FORGIVEN PROGRAM PROVIDE.
FINANCIAL FOR LOW COMMITTEE.
LOW INCOME. THROUGH THE
ELIMINATION DEBT- DON'T EXIST
FIND FEES. TRAFFIC IN NON
TRAFFIC IN. TO GET ISSUED.
JANUARY FOR TWENTY FIFTH ENGINE
TWO TWENTY ONE. GIVEN THE
BURDEN FINE PIECES OR HAVING.
VISUALS THERE'S OF URGENCY
PROVIDE THE STREET IN. NEEDED
THEM. I'M IN. OF FIVE BY THE A-
THEY'RE STILL STERN COMPONENTS
OF THIS BUT- THAT WE WILL BE WE
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BUT WILL
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN JUDICIAL.
POTENTIAL THIS PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU AND WHAT KNOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OKAY YOU CAN US. GO
AHEAD FULLER NAY I SIR I DO
HAVE A AND A NUMBER OF FIVE THE
FIVE FEES- PROBABLY I GUESS
READ THE JUDICIAL CARE. WELL
HOW DO YOU ENJOY- MAKING THE
FOLKS WHO. ARE IN A AND FEES
MAKING THEM AWARE OF THE
PROGRAM WHAT WHAT'S THE WHAT
WHAT WHAT WOULD BE THE
MECHANICS- TO GET- SOME OF. THE
PUBLICIZES THE SITUATION THAT
YOU HAVE SOME ASSURANCE- THAT
THE YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOST IN NEED ARE AWARE OF THE
PROGRAM AND ARE. INCLINED TO
APPLY. GOOD MORNING- SENATORS-
I'M SHELLEY KERN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSOLE JUSTICE
SERVICES OFFICE- AT THE BRITISH
COUNCIL I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. HIGHER IN THE
STUDENT LEGISLATION- WE HAVE
HAVE DONE OUTRAGE YOU WEBSITES
AND- DMB THIS TIME- IN ORDER TO
ENHANCE OUR REGION TO REALLY
REACH PEOPLE WHO- WE HOPE WILL
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM. WE
ANTICIPATE WORKING WITH WITH
VARIOUS- NONPROFIT'S LEGAL
SERVICES AGENCIES TO TRY TO GET
THE WORD OUT THROUGH THEM IN
ORDER TO REALLY EXPAND THE NET
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO
BECOME AWARE OF THIS PROGRAM
AND THEREFORE BENEFIT FROM IT.
IT SHOULD IT'S SO WEIRD I THINK
A REALLY INTERESTING
CONVERSATION I GUESS IT WAS
LAST WEEK. ABOUT THIS VERY
SUBJECT AND- HE DID JUST DO YOU
ENVISION MAKING A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN. OF FINES AND FEES ROAD
AND LAST WEEK'S DISCUSSION WAS
ABOUT THE- SERVE BURDENS OF
THESIS AND SERVE A PRIVATE
DIFFERENT LAYERS OF GOVERNMENT
BUT- HOW IT WORKS RIGHT SO
YOU'LL FIND AT LEAST INFERIOR
TO SERVE A PURPOSE THE PURPOSE
WOULD BE DETERRENCE FROM. THAT
AND THE FEAST IT WOULD YOU MAKE
IT IS DANGEROUS TO SIMPLY THE
AGGREGATE AMOUNT- WE KIND OF AS
A BLANKET MATTER- AS TO HOW
MUCH SOMEBODY OWN. FOR THAT
DEBT RELIEF PROPOSAL THAT YOU
ALL ARE CONSIDERING TODAY IT'S
A 100% RELIEF FROM THE FINES
AND FEES FROM THE TOTAL AMOUNT
DUE INCLUDING SEVERAL
ASSESSMENTS. ABILITY TO PAY
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE PROSPECT
OF A PROGRAM THAT IS ALSO A
BOOKLET THAT IS LINKED TO THIS.
PROPOSAL AND IS THE PROST
BECTIVE. PROPOSAL THAT ONE ALSO
CONSIDERS THE ENTIRE AMOUNT
DUE- FROM. THE INDIVIDUAL AND
AGAIN IT REALLY IS A MATTER OF
MAKING SURE. THAT PEOPLE WHO
CAN LEAST AFFORD THESE FINES
AND FEES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ADDED ON FOR MANY MANY
YEARS TO OPPOSED TO SUPPORT
IMPORTANT GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
BUT REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE- RECEIVE RELIEF
THAT THEY NEED AND ARE NOT
BURDEN FOR A LONG TIME- FIVE
FIVE THIS THAT. I JUST MIGHT
OWNER SO WITH RESPECT TO.
VERIFY LOW INCOME STATUS WHAT
IS THERE A SLIDING SCALE SOME
SHORT WHAT'S WHAT'S THE-
THROUGH THE BASELINE AND HOW IT
WORK IS AS IT RELATES TO. THE
CALCULATIONS DOWN SMEBODY
MIGHT KNOW. YEAH THE DEFINITION
THAT'S THAT THAT'S BEEN USED-
IN THE ABILITY TO PAY PROGRAM
WE'RE STILL AS AS WAS MENTIONED
BY MISS THE AND IN THE PROCESS
OF FINALIZING- POTENTIAL
TRAILER BILL- FOR YOU TO WHILE
TO CONSIDER- THE LANGUAGE IS
USED IN A TV IS A HUNDRED AND
25% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE. FOR A RECIPIENT OF
CERTAIN SPECIFIED PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE BENEFITS IN THE WAY
THAT IT WORKS- IN IN ABILITY TO
PAY PROGRAM IS- INDIVIDUALS-
CAN UPLOAD INFORMATION AND SAY-
THAT THEY OR AND WE'RE WORKING
ON LINKING TO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- IN PRIOR
INDUSTRY PROGRAMS THE WAY THAT.
WORK IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
TESTIFIED- UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THEY ARE LOW
INCOME THEY DO MEET THE
STANDARDS. APPRECIATE THAT THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MEASURE. THANK YOU- YES I HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS. ON UP. FULLY
TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL- IN
GOING BACK TO YOUR ALLOCATING.
FUNDS TO THE COURT BASED ON
EACH COUNTY'S. PROPORTION OF
STATE POPULATION EIGHT EIGHTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE. I THINK
THERE WAS SOME REFERENCE OUR
RESPONSE TO THIS BUT WHY IS
THAT AT THE- TARGETED AGE GROUP.
AND WHY IS THAT AGE GROUP ARE
USED OVER ARRESTS AND FILING.
THIS IS SHELLY CURRENT WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL JUST
REITERATE- WHAT WHAT-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTION
AND THAT IS WE DEVELOP THAT WE
SUGGESTED ORIGINALLY THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE-
POPULATION BECAUSE THAT'S
USUALLY READILY AVAILABLE- AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO. WORK WITH WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE AND OF COURSE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO CHANGE
THAT FORMULA THAT'S THE DESIRE.
OKAY WITH REGARDS TO THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THE
COURTS TO ADDRESS CRIMINAL AND
THE CIVIL BACKLOG. HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO- HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
USE OUR RESOURCES IN A WAY
THAT'S EQUITABLE TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG OF. AND WHAT'S THE
SPLIT BETWEEN CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL CASES ON THE SIXTY
MILLION- AND IZZARD
PRIVATIZATION OF THE CASES.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE- THIS IS
LIKE COMPUTER MACHINERY HAVE
NANCY EVERHART ON WHO IS THE
CHAIR OF THE COURT EXECUTIVES
VISOR COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT TO YOUR QUESTIONS
CONTRARILY NANCY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS NANCY
EVERHART CEO FROM SAN
BERNARDINO SUPERIOR COURT ASK
YOUR QUESTIONS- AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE RESOURCES
WE HAVE DATA FROM THE LAST YEAR
THAT DOES DEMONSTRATE TO US THE
BACKLOG EACH COURT HAS SEEN. IN
MANY CASE TYPES NOT JUST-
CRIMINAL OR NOT JUST A IN CIVIL
BUT ACTUALLY ACROSS MANY CUT
CASE TYPES ANDWE ARE ACTUALLY
IN THE PROCESS OF COLLECTING
UPDATED DATA THAT COMPARES OUR
PROGRESS OVER THE LAST YEAR
SINCE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REDUCE
SOME RESTRICTIONS- AND SHOWING
US WHAT THE OUTSTANDING BACKLOG
IS. THAT THE COURT WILL BE ABLE
TO MAKE REQUESTS FOR THE
FUNDING IF IT'S A IF IT'S
APPROVED BASED UPON THEIR NEED
AND THEIR STATED ACTUAL PLAN
FOR REDUCING THOSE BACKLOGS SO
THAT'LL GIVE US A MEASURE MEANT.
AS TO THE SPLIT BETWEEN
pARE SEEING ABOUT A 20% MORE
BACKLOG IN CRIMINAL CASES
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE. THE THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT IS
STATED WITHIN YOUR MAY REVISED-
AND SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING OUT TO. TO HELP US WITH
EARLY DISPOSITION ON THAT
CALENDAR WE'RE NOT PLANNING ON
SETTING ASIDE A SPECIFIC
PORTION OF FUNDING FOR. FOR
JUST A VERY S. I'M SORRY FOR
SPECIFIC CASE TYPE. BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT WE ARE SEEING
BACKLOGS AGAINST ALL CASE TYPES.
AND THERE'S THE PRIORITIZATION
AGAIN- WE'RE LOOKING AT-
SUSTAINED FUNDING- TO HELP US
WITH THOSE REDUCTIONS IN THE
VARIOUS CASE TYPES IF YOU HAVE
FURTHER QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER THEM. SO JUST AS A
FOLLOW UP IS THAT MEAN IT'S UP
TO EACH COURT- WHO DECIDES THE
PRIORITIZATION AND ON THE SPLIT
HOW THE MONEY WILL BE USED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR EACH
COURT IS EXPERIENCING- BACKLOGS
IN DIFFERENT AREAS BASED ON A
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS- THE
ABILITY OF FACILITIES TO HAVE
PEOPLE COME INTO THEM- JURY
TRIALS. MAYBE STAFF AND LACK OF
STAFFING IN AREAS EVEN PROCESS
FILINGS SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT PER COUNTY THE IDEA
IS THAT THE TRIAL COURTS WOULD
APPLY TO THE- JUDICIAL COUNCIL
INDICATING THEIR NEED AND WITH
MEASURE MONTHS ON HOW THE
BACKLOG WOULD BE REDUCED. SO
OFTEN IN THE FINAL DECISION IS
MADE BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
NOT INDIVIDUAL COUNTY'S COURTS.
THERE WOULD BE AN ABILITY TO
APPLY BY THE TRIAL COURTS BUT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WOULD BE
THE ONE WHO WOULD BE ALLOCATING
THE FUNDS. MATANCERA STILL ARE
THIS IS LIKE WITH YOUR WHICH IS
STILL ARE GATHERING OF
INFORMATION OR JUSTIFICATION-
TO THE- DEPARTMENT FIND IT'S
ALSO GOING TO LEGISLATURE WILL
BE ASSESSING WHAT ARE THE
BACKLOGS THE SCOPE OF THE
BACKLOGS. WHERE THE BACKLOGS
AND ARE IN A CROSS THE STATE OF
THE CITY TYPE OF CASES.
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE ARE IN
FUSION A SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
DUE TO ADDRESS THOSE- DOES
BACKLOG SO IT IS PART OF OUR
DATA GATHERING TO DETERMINE.
THE NEED AND WE DO HAVE BROUGH
YOUNG I'M ON THE LINE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING IN TERMS OF
ANY DATA. DATA POINTS SO YOU'D
LIKE TO DISCUSS. YES I JUST
WANNA. YOU KNOW GET BACK FROM
YOU. WHERE YOU GOING WITH THAT-
IN A WHERE DO WE THINK WE'RE
GONNA END UP AND HOW DO WE GET.
HOW DO WE THAT LEGISLATORS GET-
YOU KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
GIVE FEEDBACK ON THAT. BECAUSE
THAT- I COULD SEE IF IT'S JUST
COR BY COURT ORDER IT THE
COURTS MUST HAVE SOME SORT OF
GUIDELINES ON THAT'S I'M TRYING
TO GET AND WHERE DO WE GET THE-
REWARD WE GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CHIME IN. ABSOLUTELY AND AS
PART OF THE PROPOSAL THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT ARE I REQUEST
YOU TO FINANCE IS A UPON THEIR
APPROVAL- SUBMISSIONS ARE
LEGISLATURE PER REVIEW PRIOR TO
DISTRIBUTION OF THEM FUNDS BACK
TO THE BRANCH SO YOU HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY LONG OKAY SUBMIT
THE REPORT TO ALTHOUGH THE
PROPERTIES COMMITTEES GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITH
REGARDS TO THE- FINES AND FEES.
RELEASE- WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR
PLANS TO DO COMMUNITY OUTREACH.
WITH REGARDS TO THE YOU KNOW
THE COMING OUT WHICH TO THE
AREAS THAT WILL BE IMPACTED BY
THE PROPOSAL. I THINK CENTER
NEWMAN. TOUCHED ON THAT BUT IF
YOU COULD EXPAND THAT. SURE-
MADAM CHAIR SHELLEY CURRENT
WITH WITH- THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
OUR HOPE THIS TIME IS TO- DO A
MORE EXPANSIVE OUTREACH TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT WE ARE
REACHING COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
MOST IMPACTED BY- THESE FINES
AND FEES AND SO TO THAT END- WE
HOPE TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH-
LEGAL SERVICES AGENCIES AND
OTHER NONPROFITS PEOPLE WHO
HAVE REGULAR CONTACT WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE BURDENED BY
THESE FINES AND FEES IN ORDER
TO- BRING THEM INTO THE SYSTEM
AND- AND- MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT LEAVE.
OKAY THE BUT YOU DON'T HAVE A
YOU DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC PLAN
OR- LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS- HOW
DO YOU. HOW DO YOU DO THAT.
WHAT WE HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED THAT YET MANAGER
OKAY- AND WITH REGARDS TO THE
RELIEF SPAN IT'S FIVE YEARS-
WHAT HAPPENS TO SOMEONE- HOW
YOU FIGURE. THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THE DEBT PRIOR TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN LIKE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM RETHINKING ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM OR THEY
JUST. LOST LET YOU KNOW MISS
THE CUT OFF. YES YOUR MIND FROM
THE CLINICS ON THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. AND IN REGARDS TO
THE HERE HERE FOR YOU TWENTY
FOUR. THE DEBT FORGIVENESS. FOR
GRAHAM WAS MEANT TO BUILD OFF
PRIOR PROGRAMS THAT WERE
INTENDED TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
WANT TO EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THIS DEBT FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE. THE YEAR
YOU'VE REFERENCED TO ALLOW THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO BE ELIGIBLE AS
WELL- IT WOULD INCREASE THE
FISCAL IMPACT FOR THIS PROPOSAL
ADAM WE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THOSE KIND. STATION ARE IN C.
R. IS HE OF TO SQUARE FISCAL
IMPACT OF EXPANDING INTO
BRITAIN'S PROGRAM- QUALIFYING
TIME PERIOD OKAY. IT IT IS A
MUCH HIGHER AMOUNTS OF THAT
THAT'S OUT THERE AS YOU
MENTIONED CENTER SO I MEAN I%
GUESS I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
FUNDING TO AND WHAT POINT. DO
YOU TREAT THAT DATA IS
UNCOLLECTIBLE- IF AT ALL. IF
YOU KNOW IF THIS WERE CONSUMER
BUSINESSES EMPLOY YOU YOU CAN
CALL THAT I COLLECTED THAT- SO
HOW DO WE LOOK AT THAT. EARLIER
THAN SAY TWENTY FIFTEEN. IS IT
STILL PRESUME THAT IT'S
COLLECTIBLE AND TO PEOPLE STILL
MAKE BUDGET PLANS AGAINST IT.
OR DOES IT GET USED AGAINST
THEM. YEAH I MEAN IT'S A GIVEN.
DEFER TO MY COLLEGE EDUCATION
COUNCIL FOR ON THE SPECIFICS
AS- AS FAR AS WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED COLLECTIBLE ON PRIOR
TO THAT DATE. IT IS LIKE A
DIRECTION THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AGAIN- IT IS UP TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY AND PROGRAM
TO DETERMINE COLLECTABILITY NON
COLLECTIBILITY- WE DO PROVIDE
GUIDELINES BUT THERE'S NOTHING-
SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF DURATION
AN AGENT THAT. YOU'RE YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT THE BUSINESSES TO
USE CERTAIN METRICS BETTER.
THIS AGAIN THIS IS A LOCAL
DECISION. WE DO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO ASSESS THE H. COLLECTABILITY
THE DEBT. BUT IT IS A LOCAL
DETERMINATION. AND SO WE DEFER
TO THEIR DECISION AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THE DEBTORS IS A
COLLECTIBLE ARE NOT THAT CLOSE
IT WOULD BE SOME PORTION THAT
IS EFFECTIVELY NOT CLICKABLE
AND NOAH. THAT'S A QUESTION
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING AS WELL
AS ADDITIONAL COUNSEL TO THE
PROGRAMS. BUT AGAIN IT'S THEIR
DECISION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
MAKE THAT PROCESS SO ISSUE I
THINK IT IT MIGHT BE
INTERESTING AND- AND POSSIBLY
HELPFUL IS THERE ANY. IS THERE
A BASIS FOR GIVING US SOME
SENSE OF- BOTH THE AGGREGATE
LEVEL OF UNCOLLECTED FINES AND
FEES ACROSS STATEMENT. AT
LOOKING AT THAT ON A MORE LOCAL
BASIS- BECAUSE I DON'T I DON'T
REALLY OF REALLY HAD. A BASS
LINE AT THIS POINT- FRAME
REFERENCE WENT. OUR MOST RECENT
SERVICES AGAINST GUARDS OUR
MOST RECENT. COLLECTIONS
BORDERS IDENTIFY OVER. EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS OF. OUTSTANDING
DEBT ONE NOTE THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME YOU HAD A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION. OF THE
ALMOST TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
UNCOLLECTIBLE DEBT BECAUSE
PROGRAMS DID DISCHARGED. THE
COLLECTABILITY SHARON'S ON
THEIR OWN FROM THEIR BOOKS SO
HAS BEEN PROGRESS MADE BUT
THERE STILL IS ALREADY KNOWN
AGAIN I SIGNED BY EACH
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM IN COUNTY
ROUTES WITH THE OUTSTANDING
DEBT THAT THEY HAVE WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY BASIS I THINK COULD BE
HELPFUL LIKE I THINK I. SPEAK
FOR EVERYBODY WHEN I SAY ONE.
THAT'S A LOT OF MIND. THANK YOU
YEAH I MEAN WE ADDRESS THAT
RIGHT WITH THE- THE FEES IN
PRISONS JAILS AND PRISON FEES
AND FOR SERVICES THAT WERE
BEING RENDERED AND WE
EVENTUALLY GOT RID OF ALL OF
THAT- AND THEN JUST- COUPLE.
QUESTIONS IS THERE AN IN PERSON
WAY TO RECEIVE THE RELIEF
BECAUSE I NOTICED THAT IT SAID.
THE QUALIFICATION WAS YOU DID
IT ONLINE. ESPECIALLY CURRENT
WITH THOSE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- SIMILAR TO THE EIGHTY
P. PROGRAM- WE ANTICIPATE THAT
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO BOTH USE
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER TO
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THIS
BENEFIT AND THEN ALSO FROM IN
PERSON IF THAT'S IF THAT'S
NECESSARY. IS THAT UP TO THE
COURT TO DECIDE OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
DONE STATEWIDE. I IMAGINE AGAIN
THE LANGUAGE HASN'T BEEN
FINALIZED YET BUT IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGED WITH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
ANTICIPATE THAT IT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT WE ALLOW FOR
STATEWIDE. AND FINALLY DO YOU
HAVE ANY ESTIMATE AS TO HOW
MANY PEOPLE WOULD WILL BE
IMPACTED BY THIS. ALL RELIEF
PROGRAM. BUT WE IMAGINE THAT-
IF YOU GO BACK AND YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF CITATIONS THAT
HAVE BANNED- ISSUED IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE PERIOD-
UNDER WHICH IS AVAILABLE AND
THEN YOU THINK ABOUT THAT AND
AGAIN IT'S BASED ON A LOT A LOT
ON ESTIMATIONS. THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT WE ANTICIPATE
PROBABLY HAVE ALREADY PAID
THEIR ENTIRE FIND IN FEET-
THOSE WHO WILL BE RESPONSIVE TO
IT AND THEN AND THEN ULTIMATELY
THOSE WHO WILL QUALIFY BECAUSE
THEY DO- THEY DO WITH THAT
MEANS THAT THAT THE POVERTY
THRESHOLD THAT'S GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE LEGISLATION WE
IMAGINE THAT WILL BE ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. INDIVIDUALS AGAIN AND
THAT'S ALSO ANOTHER FACTOR THAT
WE CONSIDER WHEN WHERE AND
WHERE I'M DOING THAT ANALYSIS
IS THAT BASED UPON SOME OF THE
DATA THAT WE'VE COLLECTED
CURRENTLY THROUGH OUR ABILITY
TO PAY PROGRAM- INDIVIDUALS
HAVE ON AVERAGE ABOUT ONE POINT
FOUR TICKETS FOR INDIVIDUAL.
OKAY ALL RIGHT I THINK THAT'S
ALL- ANYMORE QUESTIONS AND YOU.
KNOW WHAT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO. ISSUE FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. OF ISSUE FIVE IS ON
THE CDC OURS OF THE REGION
PROPOSALS AND ADJUSTMENTS AND
SEE WHO'S GOING TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF CBC ART TODAY. I'M
GONNA START US OFF MANAGER THIS
IS ERIC SWANSON- I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF FISCAL SERVICES. THE FIRST
ISSUES THAT YOUR CONSULTANT
HIGHLIGHTED WERE ISSUES ONE AND
TWO ORDERS WHICH ARE THE ADULT
INSTITUTION AND DJJ POPULATION
UPDATES AND JUST WANTS. RCBC
ARE UPDATES ITS POPULATION
ESTIMATES TWICE PER YEAR FOR
THE JANUARY BUDGET MMA
REVISION. WITH ME TODAY IS
CHRIS CHAMBERS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF OUR OFFICE OF RESEARCH TO
TALK ABOUT OUR SPRING
PROJECTIONS. FOR INCARCERATED
ADULT IN OUR JUVENILE WARD
POPULATIONS SALTERTON OVER TO
HIM. THANK YOU ERIC. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS CHRIS CHAMBERS ON
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CCRC
OFFICE OF RESEARCH I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO BRIEF THE COMMITTEE ON
CBC OUR SPRING TWENTY TWENTY
ONE POPULATION PROJECTIONS.
DESERVE MENTION TWICE EACH YEAR
IN THE SPRING AND THE FALL OF
OFFICE OF RESEARCH PREPARES
POPULATION PROJECTIONS ON ADULT
BJJ AND PAROLE SUPERVISION
POPULATIONS. WHEN WE LOOK AT
ADULT POPULATION IN ALL
INSTITUTIONS POPULATION CD
SEARCH POPULATION WAS NINE
DOLLARS NINE. THE FIVE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY INMATES AND
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WHICH
IS ABOUT TWO POINT 9% MORE
INMATES DAM. ARE PROJECTED IN
FALL TWENTY TWENTY POPULATION
PROJECTIONS FOR THE SAME MONTH.
THIS IS PRIMARILY BECAUSE CDCR
HIS RESUME INTAKE OF INDIVIDUAL
SENTENCED TO PRISON. HOME
REMAIN INTENDED JAILS AWAITING
TRANSFER TO STATE PRISON.
OFFICE OF RESEARCH ANTICIPATES
THAT THIS YOUNG TECH WORKERS
ROUGHLY THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
OFFENDERS PER MONTH OR ROUGHLY
EIGHT HUNDRED PER WEEK THROUGH
THE END OF THIS YEAR. EXPEDITED
YET THINK WILL DRAW DOWN THE
BACKLOG OF THE FENDERS FOR CDCR
SENTENCES CURRENTLY AWAITING
TRANSFER IN COUNTY JAILS. ONCE
THE BACKLOG WHICH AS OF TWO
DAYS AGO WAS APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY SIX HUNDRED HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED INTAKE WILL RETURN TO
CREATE PANDEMIC LEVELS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO.
THIS IS TYPICALLY SEVEN HUNDRED
A WEEK FOR ABOUT TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED A MONTH ON AVERAGE.
WHEN LOOKING FROM A PERSPECTIVE
OF AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION OR
EIGHTY P. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTION AND OVERALL EDP UP
950-003-0020 FOUR AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. IN PROJECTIONS
NOW ESTIMATED EIGHTY P. A
HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE AN INCREASE
OF NEARLY A THOUSAND. CDCR
ANTICIPATES THAT DON'T
INSTITUTION POPULATION WILL
PEAK AT 1-001-300-0400 SEVENTY
TO EIGHTY PM CRISCO YEARS
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
DECREASED 210-012-0008 HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX EIGHTY P. IN FISCAL
YEARS TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
SOME OF THE FACTORS THAT WERE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT FOR
PROJECTIONS. RANCOR POPULATION
PROJECTIONS INCLUDE DEFECTIVE
EXPEDITED EXPEDITED RELEASES
THAT WERE INITIATED LAST YEAR
IN RESPONSE TO THE COMMENT AND
IMMATURE- DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OR THE END OF THIS
YEAR. SPRINT POPULATION
PROJECTIONS ACCOUNTED FOR
AFFECTS- INCREASED TO GOOD
CONDUCT CREDITS ARE G. C. C.
EARNING. FROM THIRTY THREE AND
A THIRD PERCENT 250% FOR ALL
NON VIOLENT SECOND STRIKERS AND
AN INCREASE UP FROM TWENTY
PERCENT. TO THIRTY THREE AND A
THIRD PERCENT FOR VIOLENT
OFFENDERS OF THE PLAN EFFECTIVE
DATE OF APRIL FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OF NOTE- THESE GCC
CREDIT EARNING CHANGERS
ACTUALLY TOOK EFFECT MAY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH COULD
HAVE. SOME SMALL IMPACT ON THE
RATE OF RELEASE. THE SPRING
POPULATION PROJECTIONS ALSO
ACCOUNT FOR ONE TIME POSITIVE
PROGRAMMING CREDIT FOR PPC A
TWELVE WITH TWELVE WEEKS
GRANTED TO OFFENDERS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE AS OF JULY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY. TPC CREDITS WERE
APPLIED TO ELIGIBLE INMATES
WITHOUT ANY SERIOUS RULE
VIOLATIONS BETWEEN MARCH FIRST
AND JULY FIFTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY. WHEN WE LOOK AT PRO
POPULATION SIMILAR TO THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTION CDC EXPECTS THAT THE
ACTIVE ADULT POPULATION. ACTOR
PAROLE POPULATION WILL DECREASE
AS IMPACTS OF UPDATED EARNED
JUST CHARGE POLICY IN A PRO CAP
APPLICATION THAT BECAME
OPERATIONAL IN TWENTY TWENTY
ARE REALIZED. KERN DISCHARGE
POLICY ALLOWED ELIGIBLE
PAROLEES WHO BEGAN THEIR PAROLE
PERIOD PRIOR TO JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR POSSIBLE DISCHARGE NO LATER
THAN TWELVE MONTHS AFTER
RELEASE FROM PRISON. THE PAROLE
CAL ALLOWS OFFENDERS RELEASED
TO PAROLE ON OR AFTER JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TO SERVE A
MAXIMUM TWO YEAR PAROLE PERIOD
AS LONG AS THEY ARE NON SEX
REGISTRANT OR TO NINETY
DETERMINEDLY SENTENCE PAROLEES.
WERE THREE YEARS FOR THOSE WITH
AN INNER INDETERMINATE SENTENCE.
LOOKING AT CURRENT NUMBERS AS
OF MAY NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THERE ARE 500-008-0030
SEVEN ACTIVE OFFENDERS SERVING
COROLLA CALIFORNIA. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTED AN
OVERALL ROLE WE AVERAGE DAILY.
POPULATION OF 450-009-0020
FOUR. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND AP M. EIGHTY P. S. NOW
PROJECTED TO BE FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
OR AN INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
FIVE PERCENT. OF THE POPULATION
IS HIGHER THAN PREVIOUSLY
PROJECTED DUE TO THE ACTUAL
START DATE OF THE EARNED
DISCHARGED POLICY REFLECTED IN
THE PROJECTION. WAS JULY AND
NOW HAS BEEN UPDATED TO OCTOBER.
FOR THE REMAINING YEARS OF THE
PRODUCTION CYCLE CDCR EXPECT
ANNUAL DECREASES. WHAT
POPULATION REACHING THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND. TWENTY THREE
PAROLEES BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE INET FIVE
YEAR REDUCTION OF APPROXIMATELY
28% WHEN LOOKING AT JUVENILE
POPULATION R. S. DJJ IS RELYING
TO A LOCAL SYSTEMS PERCENT
PERCENT NOW EIGHT TWENTY THREE
C. STARK SPECS A TOTAL JUVENILE
AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION WILL
DECREASE. BY APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT POINT 6% IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO REACH SEVEN HUNDRED YOUTH BY
JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR.
THE POPULATION IS EXPECTED TO
DECREASE AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE POINT 3% YOU REACH FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE YEARS BY
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AS WE LOOK AT CURRENT
POINT IN TIME NUMBERS AS OF MAY
EIGHTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
EJ'S TOTAL INTEREST SO THE
POPULATION IS SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX. COMMITMENTS WILL IN
TO DJJ JULY THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN YOUTH RECEIVED A
DJJ WITHOUT POINT WILL REMAIN
THERE TO FINISH IN TERMS. OF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MANAGER WE CAN
PAUSE HERE FOR- THE L. A. O. OR
WE CAN KEEP RUNNING THROUGH OUR
ISSUES IT'S UP TO YOU- OR UP TO
THE COMMITTEE. OF C. ONE AND
TWO. YEAH WHY DID YOU KEEP
GOING AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO
THE L. A. L. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU ARE. THE NEXT ISSUE- THAT
WAS THE WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ON
IS- ISSUE THREE WHICH IS COATED
NINETEEN RESPONSE AND FOR THIS
ONE WE'RE GONNA START OFF
ACTUALLY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING. MICHAEL FRAZIER
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK YES. WONDERFUL
SO THE MAY REVISION COOLEY
NINETEEN B. C. P. REQUESTS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR CDC ARE SCORED
NINETEEN RESPONSE. WHICH IN
ADDITION TO THE ONE TIME TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS OR
QUESTIONS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
COOLEY NINETEEN PCT. CDC ARE
STILL REQUIRE IN BUDGET YEAR
TO. FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT.
MILLION DOLLARS. THE LARGEST
COMPONENTS OF THE MAY REVISION
OR PLASTER FOR PHOENIX STAFF
TESTING- PAYMENTS TO COUNTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF PRESENT INJURY
AND QUICK RENTAL OTHER LESSER
COMPONENTS KROGER CUSTODY OVER
TIME- CLEANING AND
MISCELLANEOUS EXPENDITURES.
DESPITE IMPROVEMENT IN ACTUAL
CASES IN VACCINATIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT POSITION SHE
STARTED CONTINUE TO RESPOND TO
THE PANDEMIC AND CONTINUANCE OF
FURTHER HELP OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
CONTINUING PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE TO PROTECT. STAFF AND
INMATES- FOR ADDITIONAL BEACH I
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO MAKE
FROM B. TO OF CORRECTIONS THAT
WITH. YEAH REALLY QUICKLY THE-
OF MAY WERE PROVISIONING CLUES-
PROJECTIONS OF EXPENDITURES
THROUGH TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
IT WAS BASED PARTLY ON ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES THAT WE'VE-
INCURRED THROUGH MARCH THIRTY
FIRST. AS YOU KNOW CO THAT HAS
BEEN A VERY DYNAMIC ISSUE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO REFINE OUR
APPROACH TO CO THEY BASED ON
REAL TIGHT DATA AND
INFORMATION. HOWEVER ARE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO TAKE A
VARIETY OF PRECAUTIONS TO
PROTECT PREVENT ANY FURTHER
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS WITHIN
INSTITUTIONS. INCLUDING REGULAR
TESTING INCREASED CLEANING AND
PROVIDING PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT- CITY SIR WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE COST OF
THE NEAR TERM TO PROTECT STAFF.
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
PROMOTE SAFE OPERATIONS EVEN
THOUGH THE NUMBER OF ACTIVE
CASES HAS DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND VACCINATION
RATES. HAVE INCREASED. OUR AND-
WITH ME TODAY'S DUANE RIEDER
WHO REPRESENTS OUR HEALTH CARE
FISCAL SECTION WE CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS- WHEN WE
CONCLUDE. OUR PRESENTATIONS. SO
THAT'S FOR THAT ISSUE. THE NEXT
ISSUE WE WOULD LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT IS- ISSUE SIX WHICH IS
OUR DOORWAY BOTTLE ASSOCIATED
PROPOSALS. THESE ARE TWO
PROPOSALS GROUPED INTO WHAT WE
ARE CALLING THE NORWAY MODEL
NORWAY IS GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED
FOR ITS MODEL CORRECTION SYSTEM
DEMONSTRATED THROUGH ITS LOW
RATE OF RECIDIVISM AND
SUCCESSFUL POST RELEASE
OUTCOMES NORWAY'S MODEL IS
DISTINGUISHED BY THE LEVEL OF
ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL AND LIFE
AND JOB SKILLS TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES. THE USE OF
INNOVATIVE AND TRAUMA INFORMED
WITH REHABILITATIVE PRACTICES
AND THE CMMUNITY AND CAMPUS
LIKE LOOK AND FEEL OF THE
PRISON ENVIRONMENT. MAY
REVISION INCLUDES THIRTEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THREE MILLION ON GOING TO
EXPAND PROGRAMMING AND
UNDERTAKE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENTS. AT VALLEY STATE
PRISON AND THIS PRISON WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS STRIVE TO
BE SORT OF A CALIFORNIA
EXAMPLE. OF THE STORE WAY
MODEL. ROSS IS SEEKING THIRTY
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION AND
ONE TIME GENERAL FUNDS TO
REPLACE EXISTING METAL DAY ROOM
FURNITURE. WITH MORE
COMFORTABLE FURNITURE FOR
POSITIVE PROGRAMMING AND NON
DESIGNATED PROGRAM FACILITIES
AND OUR FEMALE INSTITUTIONS. I
WITH ME TODAY IS MARION
SPEARMAN WHO'S GOING TO START
OFF AND SERVE OUR SUPPORTERS
STARTUP WITH MERION SPIRIT IN
THE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT-
VALLEY STATE PRISON. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAMEIS MERRY
INSTRUMENT I'M THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION MALE INSTITUTIONS AT
CDC ARE. I WANT TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF SEVERAL
COMPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING
TO CREATE A THERAPEUTIC SETTING
AT VALLEY STATE PRISON DOWN
AMID DATE BUT THAT MADERA
CALIFORNIA. WERE INCARCERATED
PERSONS CAN SERVE THEIR
SENTENCES AND PRACTICE
PROSOCIAL SKILLS IN A
REHABILITATIVE ENVIRONMENT.
SIMILAR TO THE OUTSIDE
COMMUNITY. SO THREE OF MY TALK
ABOUT- WE HAVE A REQUEST TO
INSTALL BARBECUE GRILLS AND
PATIO FURNITURE. AND TABLES ON
IT AND IF THE VISITING PATIO
AREA FOR INCARCERATED PERSONS
NURSE FAMILIES TO SPEND QUALITY
TIME TOGETHER TO FOSTER BONDS
TO STRENGTHEN WELL THE
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH.
ANOTHER ACTUAL BCP THAT HOBBY
TALK ABOUT LATER IS THE
FREQUENCY OF VISITING- IT'S
PROVEN WE HAVE PEOPLE VISIT
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS IT PROVED
TO REDUCE PRISON VIOLENCE
STRENGTHEN FAMILY BONDS. BREAK
INTERGENERATIONAL CYCLES OF
INCARCERATION AND IT HELPS WITH
SMOOTH REENTRY INTO WRITTEN
UPON RELEASE. THEREBY REDUCING
RECIDIVISM RATES. AND LASTLY
WE'RE REQUESTING ABILITY TO
PROCURE INSTALL TWO MODULAR
BUILDINGS TO ACCOMMODATE
GROWING NUMBERS OF INCARCERATED
PERSON ACTIVITY GROUPS.
CURRENTLY VALLEY STATE PRISON
HAS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY GROUPS
AND WE WILL BE INCREASING THOSE
BUT AS WE CONTINUE OUR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. AND
ALSO THESE OF MODULAR AS WELL
ALLOW US AT THE INCLUDE CREASE
PROGRAMS TO MINIMIZE WEIGHT
LESS. AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER SWANSON SAID WE'RE ALSO
ASKING FOR MODULAR FURNITUREIN
HOUSING UNITS OF SELECTED
PRISONS WHERE THE POPULATIONS
HAVE MADE CONSCIOUS DECISIONS
TO LEAVE PRISON GANGS AND
PRISON POLITICS BEHIND. AND BUT
THEY ARE LEAVING IS SELF
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR SUCH AS
DRUG USE VIOLENCE REFUSAL TO
POSITIVELY PROGRAM TO BE
INVOLVED IN PROCURING ILLEGAL
CELLPHONES AND ALL THOSE
NEGATIVE THINGS THAT PEOPLE DO
WHO. HAVE NOT MADE THE STEP IN
THEIR LIFE THE SELF
REHABILITATE. SOME MEMBERS OF
OUR DEPARTMENT TO INCLUDE
DIRECTOR RIPS AND GIPSON A
COUPLE YEARS AGO VISITED AND
MET WITH THE NORWEGIAN PRISON
OFFICIALS WERE THOSE OFFICIALS
EMPHASIZED TO MISS GIBSON AND-
THE OTHER PEOPLE WENT THERE THE
PRINCIPLE OF NORMALITY.
PROGRESSION THROUGH A SENTENCE
SHOULD BE AIMED AT RETURNING TO
THE COMMUNITY. SO THE MODULAR
FURNITURE WE'RE REQUESTING
MAYOR IS THE NO WAY PRISON
SYSTEM WHERE THEY'RE HOUSING
UNITS REPRESENT COMFORT HEALING
AND THERAPEUTIC ENVIRONMENTS.
SO NOT LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUES SERRA LARSON AND
SHOULD DISCUSS ADDITIONAL
ELEMENTS OF THE BALLOT STATE
PRISON A HANDSOME AND REQUEST.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU MR SPEARMAN
I'M STERILE OR SOMETIME AYE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR IN THE DIVISION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS HERE
AT CDC ARE. AND AS MR SPEARMAN
MENTIONED ALL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING COMPONENT. THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING TO
SEPARATIST PENS UP FOR
PROFESSIONAL SUCCESS WAS
RELEASED AND THAT INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR A NEW MICRO LONG
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM- WHICH
WILL ALLOW OUR STUDENTSAND
PARTICIPANTS YOUR- BILL HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS- AND
AN ASSOCIATED H. FACT MEANING
PROGRAM THAT LEADS INTO THAT
MICROPHONE PROGRAM. A NEW MEDIA
SCHOOL WHICH WILL TEACH
STUDENTS HOW TO CREATE A
PODCAST AND DEVELOP VIDEO AND
AUDIO PRODUCTION SKILLS. AND A
COLLABORATION WITH OF THE LOCAL
AMERICAN JOB CENTER COULD YOU
CONNECT TO BE RELEASED
OFFENDERS WITH EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THE PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES AN EXPANSION OF
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS BY CREATING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE PATHWAY IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR LOCAL
STATE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BY LEVERAGING OUR EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH RUSSIAN I
COLLAGEN CSU FRESNO IN THE SOON
TO BE AVAILABLE HELLO GRANT
FUNDING. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE'RE PLANNING TO
SERVE UP TO EIGHTY STUDENTS PER
YEAR UPON FULL IMPLEMENTATION.
I'D BE HAPPY TO DISCUSS ANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND MORE DETAIL-
ANSWER THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ALL POLL HALF. OUT
OTHERWISE WE'LL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO MR SWANSON. ARE THE
NEXT ISSUE WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT- WAS ISSUE NINE WHICH
HAS TO DO WITH STAFF MISCONDUCT
AND THEIR DISCRIMINATE.
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINT
PROCESSES. IN AN EFFORT TO
ENHANCE CITIES YOURS
PROGRAMMING PROCESSES DEDICATED
TO PROACTIVELY ADDRESSING STAFF
MISCONDUCT AND DISCRIMINATION
WHEN IT OCCURS. ADMISSION
INCLUDES TWO PROPOSALS THAT
WILL ENABLE CDCR TO MAKE
INSTITUTIONS SPECIFIC AND
SYSTEM WIDE REFORMS AND
IMPROVEMENTS WITH THE GOAL OF
CONTINUING TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
HOUSING FUNDING OF THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
POINT THREE IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THIRTY SIX POINT
EIGHT MILLION ON GOING TO
SUPPORT. THIS INITIATIVE.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
AMY MILLER AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONAL POLICY RESEARCH AN
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND AS ERIC
MENTIONED I AM HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS OUR REQUEST FOR FUNDING
TO EXPAND CDC OURS OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS OPERATIONS.
THE FIRST ARE PART OF THIS WILL
INVOLVE- RESPONSE TO AN ORDER
BY THE UNITED STATES DISTRICT
COURT TO REFORM OUR STAFF
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION AND
DISCIPLINE PROCESSES. TO ENSURE
CDC ARE COMPLETE UNBIASED
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION
INTO ALL ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT VIOLATING THE RIGHTS
OF ANY CLASS MEMBER UNDER THE
ARMSTRONG REMEDIAL PLAN OR THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
IN RESPONSE TO THE SARS
REQUESTING FUNDING TO ESTABLISH
A CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
INSIDE THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS THAT WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SCREENING ALL
INMATE GRIEVANCES AND OTHER
CLAIMS SUBMITTED TO CDC ARE
OUTSIDE THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS.
WHICH DETERMINE IF THE CLAIM
INVOLVES AN ALLEGATION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. IN ADDITION TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A CENTRALIZED
SCREENING PROCESS WE ARE ALSO
REQUESTING FUNDING TO EXPAND
THE TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS
REQUIRED TO BE SENT TO THE
ALLEGATION INCREMENTED CEMENT
SECTION OF THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. TO INCLUDE
ALL ALLEGATIONS OF UNNECESSARY
OR EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF SEPT STAFF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OR STAFF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OF INMATE'S.
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
PROTECTED CLASS MEMBERS. AND
ALLEGATIONS OF RETALIATION BY.
DUE TO THE USE OF THE STAFF
COMPLAINT. THE FUNDING REQUEST
WILL BE TO EMPLOY THE CHAIN
NOTED ABOVE AT THE SIX INSTEAD.
IDENTIFY IN THE COURT. IN
ADDITION TO THE REQUIRE ESOS
WITH THE COURT FOR WE ARE ALSO
SEEKING FUNDING A STOP
STATEWIDE IN. PROCESS FOR ALL
USE OF FORCE AND PRISON RAPE
ELIMINATION ACT ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST OUR- CURRENTLY
INQUIRIES INTO ALLEGATIONS OF
UNNECESSARY OR EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE AND ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND STAFF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OF INMATES
ARE CONDUCTED BY SPECIALLY
TRAINED INSTITUTION STAFF.
UNLESS THERE IS ALREADY
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE
ALLEGATION OR IN THE CASE OF
USE OF FORCE THERE ARE SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY DOCUMENTED. WHEN
ASSIGNED THESE IN CORY'S THE
INSTITUTION STAFF ARE EXPECTED
TO COMPLETE THEM IN ADDITION TO
ALL OF THEIR REGULARLY ASSIGNED
DUTIES. WHEN THE ALLEGATION
ENQUIRY MANAGEMENT SECTION WAS
DEVELOPED USE OF FORCE AND
STAFF SEXUALMISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS WERE EXCLUDED FROM
AMES BECAUSE THE EXISTING
PROCESSES FOR REVIEWING THESE
TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS ALREADY
PROVIDED FOR SEVERAL LAYERS OF
REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT. BOTH
INTERNALLY AS WELL AS
EXTERNALLY BY WAY OF THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. WITH
THAT SAID CDCR DOES HOLY
RECOGNIZE THE SERIOUSNESS AND
THE SENSITIVITY THAT SURROUND
THESE TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS AND
HOW TROUBLING IT WOULD BE IF
EVEN ONE OF THESE ALLEGATIONS
IS NOT THOROUGHLY EXAMINED IN A
FAIR AND ETHICAL MANNER. YOU
SEE ARE ALSO KNOWS THE
DEPARTMENT'S CREDIBILITY
DEPENDS ON THE ABILITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT IN EVERY CASE.
APPROPRIATE STEPS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN TO IDENTIFY CORRECT AND
HOLD STAFF ACCOUNTABLE WHEN
MISCONDUCT IS SUSTAINED. THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS IS
DISTINCTLY SEPARATE FROM CDCR
INSTITUTIONS TO MAINTAIN
OBJECTIVELY IN THE
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS. THIS
INTENTIONAL SEPARATION MAKES
INVESTIGATORS LESS SUSCEPTIBLE
TO BIAS AND INFLUENCE FROM
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
STAFF THEIR CHARGE TO
INVESTIGATE. LIVING THE PROCESS
FOR INVESTIGATING ALL
ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING USE OF
FORCE STAFF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ANSPACH SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AGAINST INMATES TO THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS WILL
ENHANCE THE INVESTIGATOR
DASCHLE PROCESS BY ENSURING
THESE ALLEGATIONS ARE
INVESTIGATED BY STAFF. WHO ARE
EXPERTS IN THE INVESTIGATORY
PROCESS AND WHOSE SOLE JOB IS
TO INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT. SHARE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
AND I WILL AND STAY ON IN CASE
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MISS
MILLER. IT. BUT IN TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE DUANE OUR
READER WHO'S GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED TO BE
FOCUSED ON. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I AM DOING
READER I AM THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CCS OR THEIR FISCAL OFFICE-
BEFORE YOU TODAY ISSUE ELEVEN.
WE HAVE TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS- THE FIRST ONE IS A
PEP. STAFFING PROPOSAL TO
STANDARDIZE AND INTEGRATE FULLY
INTEGRATE- THE PICTURE SO THESE
ARE WERE TRANSFERRED TO CDCR IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO THE PARTNER
STATE HOSPITALS- AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE. THE TELL US I-
SUPERVISOR PROPOSAL- IS WELL TO
PROVIDE SOME- SUPERVISOR
POSITIONS TO OUR- TELL US LIKE
OFFICE- IN REGARDS TO THE TIP
PROPOSAL- WE'RE LOOKING TO- FOR
INTEGRATED THE PETS AND INTO
OUR PROGRAM AREAS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH- MEDICAL NURSING- AND
CUSTODY- RIGHT NOW THE THREE
TRIPS TO TRANSFER DURING THE
WRONG. FONG ON BUDGET AREA. AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO INTEGRATE THEM
AND REALIGN THEIR STAFFING- TO
OUR CURRENT STAFFING- OUR OUR
CURRENT STAFFING MODELS FOR
EACH OF THE AREAS- THESE THESE
FACILITIES TRANSFERRED OVER IN
JULY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO
IT'S BEEN ALMOST FOUR YEARS-
SINCE IT TRANSFER. AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY AND
WORK GROUPS TO IDENTIFY THE
APPROPRIATE STAFFING FOR THESE
FACILITIES. AND THIS PROPOSAL
IS THE PRODUCT OF THAT EFFORT-
WE DID WORK WITH THE PROGRAM
AREAS AT THE INSTITUTIONS WE
WORK WITH THE INSTITUTION
LEADERSHIP- HEADQUARTERED
PROGRAMS- AND VARIOUS OTHER
ENTITIES TO GET FEEDBACK AND-
THROUGH TOOK PROPOSE WHAT WE
FEEL IS NEEDED FOR THESE AREAS-
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH PORTION-
WE LOOKED TO THE TWO THOUSAND
NINE THE WHOLE STAFFING MODEL.
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED AND USED
AS A BASIS WE ALSO- LOOKED TO
THE D. S. H. HAS RECENTLY
PROPOSED TO UPDATE IT STAFFING
RATIOS ON AN EXTENSIVE
WORKLOAD. ANALYSIS AND SO WE-
INCLUDED THAT UPDATED RATIO
FROM A ONE TO THIRTY FIVE FOR
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY
PATIENTS TO ONE TO THIRTY AND
ALONG WITH THAT- IN IN THE-
NURSING AREA WE LOOK TO TITLE
TWENTY TWO WHICH IS ESTABLISH
STANDARD- MODEL OF CARE FOR.
ACUTE SENSES BEDS AS WELL AS
OUR MED CLASS MODEL THAT WAS
APPROVED IN- ADDITIONALLY IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN AND
A B. C. PMM UPDATED AGAIN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THE
CPA AND WE USE THOSE RATIOS AND
APPLIED THEM- TWO DIFFERENT-
PROGRAM AREAS- TO DEVELOP. A
MODEL AND TWO INCH OTHER A
STAFFING CAN WITH WHAT WE HAVE-
CURRENTLY- AND IN OUR OTHER SEC
ARE HEALTHCARE AREAS- THERE IS
ALSO A NEED FOR CUSTODY
POSITIONS- THERE WAS A REVIEW
DONE- BY THE DIVISION OF ALL
ADULT INSTITUTIONS- AND- THEY
ARE LOOKED AT THE FUNCTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE. REPLACED WE
HAD EMPLOYEES IN THESE UNITS
WHICH ARE MEDICAL TECH
ASSISTANCE THEY HAVE PROVIDED
SOME NURSING AND SOME CUSTODY
FUNCTIONS- WE NEEDED TO REPLACE
THOSE BECAUSE THE FUNCTIONS AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE ARE.
THE MOST APPROPRIATE-
CLASSIFICATION FOR THESE HIGH
SECURITY AREAS SO- WE BUILT IN
CUSTODY WE ALSO BUILT IN SOME
PRIMARY CARE AND SOME ANCILLARY
POSITIONS DUE TO THE- EXTENSIVE
WORKLOAD THAT THAT DOES COME
OUT OF THESE AREAS- IN THE IN
THE PROPOSAL YOU'LL SEE- WE
INCLUDED ALL THE CALCULATIONS-
IN OUR WORKBOOKS- AND- WE KNEW
THAT THIS WAS A LATE PROPOSAL
WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT. WE
PROVIDE AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE AND SO WE DID
INCLUDING- THE CALCULATION AND
WORKBOOKS- TO HELP- WITH
EXPEDITED ANALYSIS AND DID OUR
BEST TO ILLUMINATE- THE MODELS
THEMSELVES- TO HELP IN THAT
ANALYSIS- SHOW WITH ME TODAY
IS. DR META W. DIRECTOR OF THE
STATEWIDE HEALTH PROGRAM WILL
BE HERE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS- IF NEEDED. ON ON THE
STATEWIDE SHOWS LIKE- PROPOSAL.
WE ARE IN NEED OF ABOUT NINE
POSITIONS AND THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS- TO PROVIDE
SUPERVISORY OVERSIGHT- FOR OUR
REGIONAL OFFICES WHERE WE
PROVIDE TELL US I- SERVICES
BACK TO THE INSTITUTIONS. WE
ORIGINALLY- HAD TRIED TO COVER
THIS NEED WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES AND VACANCIES AND
REDIRECTED. THEM- BUT THERE
ISIC PROGRAMMER FROM. TO THE
THAT THEY PROVIDE ALONG WITH
SUPERVISOR COMPONE. AND WE WILL
THAT. IT WAS NOT SUSTAINABLE WE
NEEDED THAT THAT SUPERVISION
BACK. IN THE INSTITUTIONS- SO
THIS THIS IS A- I REQUEST TO
REPLACE THOSE POSITIONS- TELL
US LIKE HAS HELPED US GET TO-
THE 90% STORY THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO ACHIEVE FOR MANY
YEARS SO TELL US IDEAS OF VERY.
KEY COMPONENT- IN OUR STAFFING
MODEL TO ENSURE THAT THAT WE
MEET THE CHAIR OF THE PATIENTS
UNDER OUR PURVIEW- IN ADDITION-
WE WERE ABLE TO HIGHER TOLLS
LIKE POSITIONS WE CAN HIRE THEM
WITH CIVIL SERVICE RATE WHICH
IS- MUCH CHEAPER THAN THE
REGISTRY RATES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN USING TO FILL MANY
VACANCIES. SO WE ARE ARE- DOES
LIKE IT'S ALLOWING US TO PAY
FOR POSITIONS- AS WE ARE BUDGET
AND OF COURSE SOME OF THAT
COSTLY REGISTRY. SO IT HAS.
BEEN A GREAT BENEFIT TO THE
DEPARTMENT. SO AS A MAN DR
MEADOW W. TO STAY. HEALTH PRO
IS HERE- TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MR READER MMHM. OKAY ARE.
MOVING DOWN TO OUR FINAL
ISSUES- WE HAVE A ONE ISSUE WE%
WERE ASKED TO HIGHLIGHT AS WELL
WAS- ARE PROPOSAL RELATED TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES THREE
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ONGOING GENERAL
FUND INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
BORDER PATROL HEARING
COMMISSIONERS FROM. SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY ONE TO ADDRESS A
BACKLOG IN HEARINGS. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO PERMIT BPH
TO CONDUCT VIDEO CONFERENCE
HEARINGS AND WITH ME TODAY IS
JENNIFER SCHAEFFER EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS TO TALK ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
JENNIFER ANISTON JENNIFER
SHAPER THANK YOU DROPS OR THE
BORDERS WILL HEARINGS I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY DRASTIC COMMITTEE
TODAY. THE BORDER PRO HEARINGS
HAS EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
PROJECTED PAROLE HEARINGS
MAINLY AS A RESULT OF AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER. DID YOU
EVER THINK YOUR CAMERAS ON NOT
ON RIGHT NOW- INTERESTING
CHANCY. LET ME. TRY RAISING MY
HAND I'M I'M DOING AUDIO BY
PHONE AND VIDEO. BY COMPUTER
DOES THAT CHANGE THINGS. NO I
APOLOGIZE STE STE LET ME SWITCH
OVER TO DIFFERENT AUDIO.
WELL
WHAT CAN WE DO. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE SKIP OVER THIS ONE
AND COME BACK TO IT IF THAT'S
OKAY. OKAY. I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO- CHRIS LEAF IS GONNA
TALK ABOUT OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
ISSUES. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CHRIS LEAF AND I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
DIVISION- WE HAVE A FEW CAPITAL
OUTLAY OF PROPOSALS THAT ALL OF
RUN THROUGH- THE FIRST IS THE
REAPPROPRIATION FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING FOR THAT
SEE I AM FIFTY BAD MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS DISABILITY- THIS
REAPPROPRIATION IS NECESSARY
AS- WE ARE. REQUIRED TO READ
TO- SOME PORTIONS OF THE
REQUEST FOR THE PROJECT. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT- CONSTRUCTION
WILL BE ABLE TO START LATER
THIS CALENDAR YEAR ONCE THAT'S
BECAUSE- PROCESSES- COMPLETE.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL IS FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR LUNAR
PLANS- AND WORKING DRAWINGS FOR
THE DESIGN OF INDIVIDUAL
EXERCISE YARDS AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FACILITY
OF FACILITY B. THIS PROJECT IS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE- EXERCISE
YARDS THAT ARE WITHIN THE
PHILIPPINES ALLOW MAXIMUM.
CUSTODY INMATES TO RECEIVE
ADEQUATE OUT OF CELL TIME. THE
THIRD OF PROPOSAL IS A- SWITCH
OF FUNDING FOR THAT HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
FROM LEASE REVENUE BONDS TO
GENERAL FUND. AND- FINANCE
COULD EXPLAIN THAT FURTHER AND
THE LAST- CAL POLY PROPOSAL IS
A REAPPROPRIATION. OF BOSTON
WITH THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIRTEEN MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION
IMPROVEMENTS AT THIRTEEN-
SEPARATE FACILITIES. ADAM HAPPY
IT'S TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE TIME.
OKAY LET ME- TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR AUDIO OR AUDIO VIDEO-
PROPOSAL AND THEN WE'LL GET
BACK TO JENNIFER SHE FOR- OUR
SWEET YEAH THE PROPOSAL THAT
YOU WE HAVE BEFORE YOU THAT YOU
REGARD THAT IT'S REGARDING
FIXED VIDEO CAMERAS ONE OF OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT AUDIO VISUAL
SURVEILLANCE IS INTEGRAL TO SEE
THIS YEAR'S ABILITY TO MODERATE
HER ACTIVITIES WITH ITS IT
WITHIN ITS INSTITUTIONS AND
MAINTAIN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION
STAFF. EFFECTIVE SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEMS HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
FACILITATE CONTRABAND
INTERDICTION AND SUPPORT
ENQUIRIES AND INVESTIGATIONS OF
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF AND
INCARCERATION CURSED RATED
INDIVIDUAL MISCONDUCT THESE
SYSTEMS GENERALLY SERVE AS A
DETERRENT FOR IMPROPER OR
ILLICIT ACTIVITIES THEREBY
IMPROVING SAFETY AND ENHANCING
OPERATIONS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS. AND THIS IS NOT
AN TECH FOR US IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN CDCR INSTALLED AB SS
WITH TWO HUNDRED SEVEN HIGH
DEFINITION CAMERAS IN
DESIGNATED HIGH TRAFFIC A LARGE
CONGREGATION AREAS AT. HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON THIS SERVED
AS A TECHNICAL PILOT ENABLING
CDCR TO TEST THE VIABILITY AND
OPERATING THIS TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT ON CDC OURS NETWORK.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CDCR
RECEIVE FUNDING TO COMPLETE A
BSS AT HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON
AND INSTALL A BSS ALSO AT THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITIES. THESE LOCATIONS
WERE DETERMINED TO HAVE AN
IMMEDIATE NEED FOR A THE- BASED
ON CRITERIA SUCH AS THE NUMBER
OF VIOLENT INCIDENTS. SO THE
MAYOR REVISION INCLUDES A TOTAL
OF TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT
THREE MILLION GNERAL FUND OVER
THREE YEARS AND ELEVEN MILLION
I'M GOING TO INSTALL MODERN FIX
SECURITY CAMERAS. AT TWENTY
FOUR ADDITIONAL INSTITUTIONS
THIS PROPOSAL ALONG WITH
EXISTING EFFORTS UNDER WAY WILL
FLUCTUATE A ROLLOUT OF NEW
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS AT
ALL OUR INSTITUTIONS STATEWIDE.
THESE RESOURCES AND
COMPLEMENTARY FUNDING INCLUDED
IN THE ARMSTRONG COURT
COMPLAINTS PROPOSAL ONE ABLE
CDCR TO INSTALL FIX SECURITY
CAMERAS AT NINE TO TEN
INSTITUTIONS. PER YEAR OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. WOMEN OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER SURVEY
ACROSS THE PRISON SYSTEM AND
GREATLY INCREASE CDC OUR
CAPACITY TO OPERATE SAFE. AND
EFFECTIVE PRISONS. SO NOW I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO JENNIFER
SHAFFER AND THEN I THINK OUR
MARATHON OF ISSUES IS OVER.
THANK THANK YOU CAN YOU AND SEE
ME NOW YES WE CAN. EXPLAIN I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT I'M JENNIFER
SCHAEFFER EXECUTIVE OFFICER
ABOARD PRO HEARINGS. THE BORDER
HEARINGS EXTRA A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
PROJECTED PRO HEARINGS MAINLY
AS RESULT OF AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF HEARINGS. DUE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN. THE RESULT OF
THE SUPREME COURT'S DECISION IN
IN RE GATLIN WHICH EXPANDED THE
NUMBER OF PERSONS ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE CONSIDERATION UNDER
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN AND THE
EXPANSION OF ELDERLY PEOPLE
UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO
FOUR. THE BOARD PRINT IT WILL
NEED TO SCHEDULE NEARLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND PAROLE HEARING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO PUT THAT INTO
CONTEXT IN CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THE BOARD SCHEDULED
SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED CALL
HEARINGS. TO ADDRESS THIS
INCREASED WORKLOAD THIS
PROPOSAL EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
COMMISSIONERS FROM SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE TO ALLOW THE BOARD
TO EXPAND ITS PRO HEARING
CAPACITY TO MEET THE PROJECTED
WORKLOAD. IT WOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH AN ADDITIONAL SIX
POSITIONS OF THE BOARD AND-
LEVIN POINT THREE POSITIONS AT
THE DEPARTMENT TO HANDLE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS CRITICAL
TO SCHEDULING AND CONDUCTING
PAROLE HEARINGS. THIS BROWN'S
PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO CONTINUE
CONDUCTING HEARINGS BY VIDEO
CONFERENCE. SINCE APRIL FIRST
OF LAST YEAR THE BOARD IS
CONDUCTED ALL PAROLE HEARINGS
BY VIDEO CONFERENCE UNDER THE
AUTHORITY OF AN EMERGENCY
ORDER. CONDUCTING HEARINGS BY
VIDEO CONFERENCE HAS NOT
IMPACTED THE OUTCOME LET'S
HEARINGS HELD. AND CONDUCTING
HEARINGS BY VIDEO CONFERENCE
ALLOWS THE BOARD TO CONDUCT
MORE HEARINGS BY ELIMINATING.
TRAVEL TIME FOR COMMISSIONERS
AND DEPUTY COMMISSIONERS. THE
BOARD IS ALSO PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE THE STATUTORY MANDATE
TO PROVIDE NOTICE OF PAROLE
HEARINGS TO THE JUDGE WHO
CONDUCTED AT THE INCARCERATED
PERSON SENTENCING HEARING.
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN THE BOARD
HAS SENT MORE THAN FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND NOTICES THE SENTENCING
JUDGES VIA THE US MAIL AS
REQUIRED UNDER THE PENAL CODE.
THE BOARD RECEIVED LESS THAN
TWO HUNDRED RESPONSES TO THOSE
NOTICES THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDED
INPUT CONCERNING THE PAROLE
HEARING. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THESE PROPOSALS
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE HOUSE. OKAY
THANK YOU MACHE FOR. MISTER
SWANSON ANY OTHER. I THINK
THAT'S ENOUGH ISN'T IT I THINK
WE SHOULD THE POINT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU- OKAY- YES
WE GO TO THE L. A. L. PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CAITLYN
ON YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TOGETHER AND
MY COLLEAGUE LUKE AND I HAVE
COMMENTS ON EACH OF THE
SEVENTEEN ITEMS WITHIN THIS
ISSUE UNLESS YOU'D LIKE US TO
PROCEED DIFFERENTLY OUR PLAN IS
TO GO IN ORDER OF THE AGENDA
WHICH PEOPLE PASSING IT BACK
AND FORTH. BETWEEN EACH OTHER
AND THEN OF COURSE PLEASE. YOUR
FREE DUI INTERRUPTED AT ANY
TIME IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. AND
I WILL START WITH ISSUE ONE
WHICH IS. A BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH JUDGE
PROJECTIONS FOR THE INDIAN
PROBABLY POPULATIONS. AND AS
YOU RECALL AND THERE IT COUNTY
JAILS CURRENTLY HAVE A BACKLOG
OF AROUND SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE WHO. HAVE BEEN SENTENCED
TO STATE PRISON BUT HAVEN'T
BEEN TRANSFERRED THERE YET DUE
TO THE STOPPAGE OF INTAKE THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLACE OVER MUCH OF
THE PAST YEAR DUE TO CODE
NINETEEN. AND YOU MINISTRATION
EXPECTS TO CONTINUE RAMPING UP
INTAKE AT. THROUGHOUT THIS
BUDGET YEAR AND CLEARING THAT
BACKLOG DURING THE BUDGET YEAR-
SO ACCORDINGLY THEY'RE
PROJECTING ANY INCREASE IN THE
INMATE POPULATION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR HOWEVER IN THAT PROJECTION
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR TIME THAT
THESE INMATES HAVE BEEN SERVING
WHILE IN COUNTY JAIL AWAITING
TRANSFER TO STATE PRISON- GIVEN
THAT. NOTHING ABOUT THE RENDON
TAKE SHOULD AFFECTED THE LENGTH
OF IN ONE SENTENCE REALLY JUST
A LOCATION WE THINK THAT NOT
ACCOUNTING FOR THAT TIME
THEY'VE SERVED ON THEIR PRISON
SENTENCE LIKELY RESULT IN AN
OVER ESTIMATE OF THE POPULATION
AT CDC ARE WEALTHY HOUSING IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. HOWEVER
ESTIMATING THE EXACT AMOUNT OF
THE REST OF THE OVERESTIMATION
WOULD BE DIFFICULT SO WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE FUNDING
BUT I DOCKING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SHALL REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND ANY FUNDING IT
RECEIVED ASSOCIATED WITH
INMATES HE DID NOT END UP
SERVING AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND OF
COURSE IT ABOUT THEN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THAT IT- THE
DEPARTMENT CDC ARE CONSTANTLY
MONITORING THEIR BUDGET AND
COULD VERY WELL RIVER THAT
POPULATE THAT AND POPULATION
RELATED FUNDING AT THE END OF
THE BUDGET YEAR BUT THERE'S NOT
NOTHING THAT WOULD- REQUIRING
THEM TO DO THAT IN FACT THEY
COULD ALLOCATED TOWARD OTHER
PURPOSES SO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
INTENDED TO GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE SOME OVERSIGHT OVER
HOW THIS- POTENTIALLY EXCESS
AMOUNT OF FUNDING IS ULTIMATELY
USED- AND THEN WITH THAT WE
DON'T RAISE CONCERNS I'M ITEMS
TWO THROUGH FIVE BUT I WILL
HAND IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES.
TO DISCUSS ITEMS SIX. YOU
MORROW LEGISLATURE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- I. THE TWENTY SIX IS
ABOUT WAY MOM AND RELATED
PROPOSALS. ON THE STARTING OFF
TALKING ABOUT THAT. AND
EXPANDED REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS A PROPOSAL FOR VALLEY
STATE PRISON. WE THINK THIS
RESULT COULD HAPPEN ERIC BUT
OVERALL OVERALL EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE PROGRAM IS UNCLEAR. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE PROPOSAL
DOES INCLUDE RESOURCES FOR
EVALUATION TO TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THE BUT BUT YOU'RE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
YOUR MAKE THE FUNDING LIMITED
IT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND A CAR
IN THE PARKING TRICK OR RESULTS
OF THAT. NO LATER THAN A TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THIS WILL THE
LEGISLATURE TO USE MODERATION
DETERMINE WHETHER THE ONGOING
RESOURCES SHOULD BE PROVIDED
FOR THE PROGRAM BEING IN TWENTY
TWENTY OR TWENTY FIVE. FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE VALUATION WERE
TO SHOW THAT THE PROGRAM IS
COST EFFECTIVE THAT WOULD MAKE
SENSE. TO THEN PROVIDE ONGOING
FUNDING. THE NEXT. ROSA WITH
THIS ITEM WAS ABOUT MY-
GRATEFUL EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF NEW FURNITURE- FOR
VARIOUS YARDS. THROUGHOUT THE
PRISON SYSTEM. WE THINK IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THIS WOULD BE
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE METHOD
FOR CDCR TO IMPROVE
REHABILITATION WITHIN THE
PRISONS. THANK YOU FOR PROVING
THIS PROPOSAL WE RECOMMENDED
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRES VCR TO
RECORD WHETHER IT HAS
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES. RIGHT
HOLD A MEET WITH ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE BASED REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS. WHICH ONE POTENTIAL
WAY THAT CAN MORE EFFECTIVELY
IMPROVE REHABILITATION. WITHIN
PERSONS. IF CAN THE THIS IS THE
CASE OR- THE BILL COULD AMERICA.
OTHERWISE THERE MAY BE MORE
COST EFFECTIVE APPROACHES TO
MEETING THE REHABILITATION
NEEDS OF IN. I WILL NOT HANDED
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE CAITLIN
MCNEILL WHO WILL BE DISCUSSING
NINE EIGHT WHICH IS THE NEXT.
ITEM ON THE AGENDA FOR WHICH WE
HAVE ISSUES- I THOUGHT CONCEPTS
ARE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
THE L. A. I'M FINE ITEM AIDS IT
WHITE INCRIMINATION OF EXPEDIA
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS HE NEVER
ONLY IN THAT VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
SEEMS NORMAL THE STAR CRUISERS
GIVEN THAT IT COULD HELP
PROVIDE- INJECTIVE EVIDENCE
WITH WHICH TO EVALUATE CONCERNS
ABOUT STAFF MISCONDUCT WHICH IS
OF PARTICULAR. CONCERN RECENTLY
AT VARIOUS PRISONS HOWEVER
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
PROPOSAL GIVEN THAT IT WOULD
FIND A WIDE IMPLEMENTATION OF
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE ULTIMATELY
AT ALL PRISONS OVER THREE
YEARS- BECAUSE WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT INSTALLING VIDEO OUT OF
PRISON THAT IS SUBSEQUENTLY
CLOSED AND THIS IS. BECAUSE WE
ESTIMATE THAT- THE POPULATE
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE. POPULATION
PROJECTIONS SHOW THAT. OVER THE
NEXT YEARS THE STATE COULD BE
IN A THE CAUSES TO CLOSE.
AROUND THREE THREE PRISONS IN
ADDITION TO THAT YOU THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
ANNOUNCED FOR CLOSER. SO WE
RECOMMEND ONLY APPROVING
FUNDING AT THIS TIME WHEN THE
FOR PRISONS BACK ARE SCHEDULED
TO RECEIVE. UNDER PROPOSAL
DURING THE BUDGET YEAR BECAUSE
THOSE FOR PRISONS ARE NOT
PRESENT THAT. HERE TO BE STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE AND
THERE'S NO NEED TO FIND AT THIS
TIME INSTALLATION WORK FUTURE
YEARS. SO IN A YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN COME BACK IN
THE FUTURE TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR- TO
ROLLOUT VIDEO SURVEILLANCE AT
OTHER PRISONS. YEARS AT WHICH
POINT AT THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
HAVE GREATER CLARITY ON WHICH
PRISONS. RIGHT BECAUSE EACH
YEAR. I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT. YES OUR
RECOMMENDATION WON'T AFFECT-
THE INSTALLATION OF VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE AT. PRISONS BETTER
I'VE TO LOCATE OR ORDER RELATED
TO. MISCONDUCT BECAUSE YOUR
SURVEILLANCE FOR THOSE- REASONS
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A SEPARATE.
AND THEN MOVING ARMS. RELATED
TO THAT ISSUE IN FACT THAT
PROPOSAL- SEARED SET OF
PROPOSALS ITEM NINE STAFF
MISCONDUCT AND FOR ME BETWEEN
CLASSES- I HAVE COMMENTS ON THE
STAFF MISCONDUCT- PROC PROCESS
SEASON PACKAGES PROPOSALS
RELATED TO THAT TOPIC. AND I
HAVE TWO COMMENTS. ON ELEMENTS
OF THAT PACKAGE. THE FIRST IS
ON THE FOR HIM IN NEED PROBABLY
ALLOCATE OF STAFF MISCONDUCT IN
THIS TASK THANK YOU TO FIND-
PROPOSAL TO FIND BODY WORN
CAMERAS ON OFFICERS AT.
REPORTER THE FIRST ON THE BACK
END PROCESS FOR INVESTING YOU
PROBABLY ALREADY. OF
MISCONDUCT. FIND THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES. WORKING AND PROCESS
IS HIGHLY UNCERTAIN AT THIS
TIME. BOTH THE NUMBER OF CASES
THAT THAT THOSE- STAFF WILL BE
REQUIRED TO INVESTIGATE PER
YEAR AND THE TIME IT TAKES EACH
STAFF PERSON TO COMPLETE THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS IS VERY
UNCERTAIN AND THIS IS BECAUSE I
DETAILS OF THE PROCESS ARE
STILL UNDER NEGOTIATION AN
ONGOING LAWSUIT. THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT- ARE SOON WILL
REQUIRE INVESTIGATION AT PER
YEAR IN THESE CLOTHES ALSO
COMES FROM HISTORICAL DATA AT A
TIME WHEN. POPULATION WAS MUCH
HIGHER AND- THAN IT IS TODAY
AND IS EXPECTED TO BE IN THE
FUTURE EASIER IT'S ALSO HAD
SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTY
ESTIMATING THE TIME KERN
MASTICATION IN FACT. IT REPORTS
THAT IT. THE MEDICALLY UNDER.
THAT TIME IN THAT EARLIER. ARE
RELATED TO THIS APPROACH. YOUR
IS ALSO LOOKING FOR EFFICIENT
TO REDUCE THAT AMOUNT OF STAFF
TIME BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR BUT
THOSE WHAT EFFICIENCY YOU WILL
ULTIMATELY FIND AND WHAT ACT
WILL HAVE- FOR EXAMPLE
INSTALLATION VIDEO SURVEILLANCE.
ASSEMBLY WELL USED AFTER TIME-
PROTESTING. BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR
HOW BY HOW MUCH ALSO CONNECTING
YOU. SEE YOUR- YES YOUR
CONFERENCE IS SOMETHING THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING FAST TIME
BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT IMPACT
THAT WOULD HAVE- SO WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
REQUESTED NINETEEN MILLION
AUGMENTATION FOR THIS PROCESS
AND A NINE POINT NINE BASED
FUNDING THAT ARE HAS FOR THE
BEST YOU CAN TWENTY. YEAR
LIMITED TERM BASIS TO DISMISS.
FOR PARTY MINISTRY. I REQUEST
RESOURCES- AFTER HOW DATA WITH
WHICH MORE ACCURATE ASSESSES HE-
AND AGAIN THIS WAIT WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD CERTAINLY
COME FORWARD IN THE FUTURE WITH
ME THE EXTENDED ENDS UP BEING
OVER THIS. HAVING ACCESS
RESOURCES- DO THOSE. BECAUSE
COME FORWARD WITH A PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE FUNDING BUT- DOESN'T
HAVE AN- SOUTH AND SO WE
RECOMMEND AND- REQUIRING THEM
TO COME FORWARD WITH A PROPOSAL
NONETHELESS- INCREASED.
OVERSIGHT OVER THIS PROCESS AND
THE RESOURCES REQUIRED FOR IT.
I'M MOVING ON TO THE SECOND
ELEMENT MACINNES I HAVE
COMMENTS ON. HERE IS
RECOMMENDED THEM AT BECAUSE
THEY'RE REQUIRED PURSUANT TO
THE WORK ORDER AT SIX BUSINESS.
THE GIVEN YOUR LONG WEEKS
LIMITED IMPLEMENTING BODY WORK
NUMBERS AND LIMITED. AMOUNT OF
RESEARCH ON THE EFFECTIVENESS
CORRECTIONAL SETTINGS MORE
BROADLY RECOMMENDED. THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE AN
EVALUATION. AFTER FINDING
RIDICULOUS FIND- THEN WE DID
NOT RAISE CAN ON ITEM AND I
WILL. WE'LL DISCUSS ITEM. FROM
HERE ON MORGAN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE ON
I AM IN ELEVEN WHAT DOES MENTAL
HEALTH CARE ARGUMENTS ARE ON
THE U. N. SIXTY FOUR POSITIONS
AND THIRTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION ON GOING FOR A SECOND
YEAH TRICK INPATIENT PROGRAMS
WELL THE MINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL AS OF
YESTERDAY EVENING WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO REVIEW ALONG WITH
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
PROVIDE WE FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION
DEMONSTRATING A NUMBER OF
REQUESTS OF PETITIONS OR THE
INCREASING SERVICE LEVELS ARE
NECESSARY. FOR EXAMPLE CDCR HAS
NOT DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
CURRENT SERVICES PROVIDED BY
EXISTING STAFF OF THE LAST FOUR
YEARS PARTY ADEQUATE IN
ADDITION WHAT CITIES ARE
INDICATED THAT HAS OR ALREADY
HAS SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO MEET
THE PROJECTED. NEEDS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION. THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES. TO PROVIDE.
TREATMENT CAPACITY AT THAT MOST
IN LOW OF CARE- IN ADDITION TO
EXISTING SERVICES. I SAID WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NOT APPROVE THE PROPOSAL UNLESS
IT IS YOUR COMBINED SUFFICIENT
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE PROPOSED
STAFFING AND SERVICE LEVELS
INCLUDED IN THIS REQUEST. AND
THE NEXT TIME FOR TRIPP COMMONS
IS ITEM THIRTEEN WHICH I WILL
HAND OVER TO ILLINOIS DEAL
THANK YOU. I AM THIRTEEN IS A
FIFTY MILLION AUGMENTATION TO
THE ONE TIME AT FIFTY MILLION
AUGMENTATION BECAUSE IN JANUARY
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT
WOULD BRING THE- TOTAL PROPOSED
ONE HANG UP TIME AUGMENTATION.
AT FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE YOU
HUNDRED MILLION ON TOP OF THE
DEPARTMENTS TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL BASED BUDGET. FOR
THAT PURPOSE- AS I NOTED IN MY
COMMENTS EARLIER IN THE STATE
COULD BE IN A POSITION TO CLOSE
THREE PRISONS- IN ADDITION TO
THE TWO ALREADY ANNOUNCED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. WE THINK
THAT- THE CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION CENTER IN NORCO
CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON AND CORRECTIONAL
TRAINING FACILITY IN SOLEDAD.
APPEAR TO BE STRONG CANDIDATES
FOR CLOSURE PRIMARILY BECAUSE
THEY ALL HAVE HI ESTIMATED
REPAIR COSTS RELATIVE TO THEIR
INMATE CAPACITY. AND I WOULD
NOT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
PROVIDED. A LIST OF PRISONS
THAT IT BELIEVED TO BE STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE TO THE
EXTENT THE STATE THE POPULATION
DECLINE ENABLES THE STATE TO.
CLOSE ADDITIONAL PRISONS- WE DO
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR THIRD THAT THE
TOTAL HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
IMITATION- GIVEN THAT
SIGNIFICANT STATEWIDE PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. BUT WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT- WOULD PROHIBIT
CITIES HERE FROM SPENDING THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME LIMITATION AND IT'S TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLAR BASED
BUDGET. ON PRISONS THAT ARE
STRONG CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE
AND LESS THE DEPARTMENT PUTS
FORWARD. AND SHOWING THAT THOSE
FACILITIES WILL NOT BE CLOSED
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
REALLY A TINY FRACTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S TOTAL NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED WHICH IT
ESTIMATES AT AT LEAST A BILLION
DOLLARS AND POTENTIALLY AS HIGH
AS THIRTEEN BILLION JUST IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALONE- SO
THERE'S ALREADY GOING TO HAVE
TO BE SOME VERY TOUGH DECISIONS
ABOUT WHERE TO SPEND THIS- THIS
HUNDRED MILLION- SO OUR
RECOMMENDATION WON'T. RESULT IN
LESS. WHAT HERE IS NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIR BEING MET
WE'RE JUST SAYING LONG ISN'T A
VAST MAJORITY OF THE NEED IS
NOT GOING TO BE MATH LET'S TRY
LET'S. NOT ALLOCATED FOR
PRISONS THAT HAVE A HIGHER
CHANCE OF CLOSURE YEAH- AND WE
DO NOT RAISE CONCERNS AN ISSUE
THE FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN AND I
WILL PASS IT OFF TO LOOK COOL
DIFFERENT COMMENTS ON ITEM
SIXTEEN SEVENTY. BRITISH MORE
OVER THE L. A. L. I AM SIXTEEN
ALSO DEALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SIMILAR TO A PREVIOUS PROPOSAL-
UNDER THIS ONE- ACR AND JUST
THE NUMBER OF CIVIL SERVICE
MENTAL. HEALTH DECISIONS BASED
ON THE SIZE OF THE INMATE
POPULATION ANNUALLY. AND PASS
YOUR SEATS ARE UNABLE TO FILL
OF CIVIL SERVICE MEDAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND IF YOU DON'T IF THE
SURPLUS FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
THE THINKING POSITIONS FOR
VARIOUS PURPOSES. FOR EXAMPLE
BECAUSE OF DIFFICULTY GOING
LIKE HI TRANSPOSITIONS. EIGHT
USED FOR ABORTION THE FUNDING
TO OR CONTRACTED PSYCHIATRY
REGISTRY SERVICES WHICH ALLOWS
THEM TO MAINTAIN. A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES
OR IN ANY- DESPITE HAVING A
SHORTAGE OF STAFF WRITTEN. IN
THEIR EVER FUND THIS BY USING
SOME OF THIS. FUNDING
ASSOCIATED. WITH THOSE BIG
POSITIONS. DUE TO A LARGE CROWD
IT MAY OF THE BAY. SUPPORTS ARE
IN THE WHOLE POSITIONS ARE
BEING. AND MULTI PLANTS
ELIMINATE THE POSITION IF
YOU'RE DO WE A LOT PORTION OF
THE ON THE FOR THESE MISSION.
DIRECTLY NINE THREE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FORTY
POINT THREE MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY YOU AN
ONGOING IN FUNDING THAT
OTHERWISE- WOULD HAVE BEEN
MOVED WITH APARTMENTS BUDGET.
THE MINISTRY SHOULD BE THAT A
WILL OF THE FUN FOR BE USED FOR
PSYCHIATRIC REGISTRY SERVICES
WHETHER YOU MAY NOT BE USED
TOBACCO FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
ELIMINATED POSITIONS.
ADMINISTRATION INDICATES HAS
BEEN REDIRECTED FROM THESE
POSITIONS TO OTHER PURPOSES
WITHIN THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM- THANK A TIME BUT JUST
RECENTLY THIS WEEK BENEFIT HAD
INDICATED THAT- A PORTION OF
THIS FUNDING NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION. HI BEN- WE DIRECTED TO
AN INCREASE IN POSITIONS THAT
WERE AUTHORIZED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND TEN ELEVEN BUDGET
TACTICAL BROOKS FUNDING HAS NOT
BEEN PROVIDED HOWEVER THE
NATIONAL INFORMATION ON WHAT
THESE OTHER OR PURPOSES FOR
WHICH THE FUNDING WAS
REDIRECTED HAS NOT BEEN
PROVIDED. ASSETS WERE
RECOMMENDED APPROVING ELEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY YOU BECOME OF
THE FUNDING SHORTFALL FOR THE
COUNTRY REGISTRY SERVICES I DO
NOT APPROVE THE REMAINING
FUNDING UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN DEMONSTRATE
THAT THE REDIRECTED FUNDS IS
BEING USED FOR PURPOSES.
CONSISTENT. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES. THAT
INCLUDES ITEMS SIX MEETING FOR
I KNOW SEVEN. THE MOTIVE IT
ANNUAL POINTS- FOR MAINTENANCE
I. THAT MIGHT CLOSE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSALS. TO ENSURE
THAT FUNDING IS NOT SPENT
UNNECESSARILY ON INFRASTRUCTURE
PRISONS. ARE CLOSED SHORTLY
THEREAFTER. THE FIRST OF THE
CATHOLIC WORLD RULES THAT WE-
RECOMMENDED MODIFICATION TO GO
TO A PRESS THIS IS FOR THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY PROJECTS
SICK. WELL WE DO NOT CONSUME
THE CHANGE THE STRUCTURE
BENEFIT PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED YOU KNOW TO THE
PROPOSAL. WE INCREASE FUNDING
FOR PROJECTS AXIOM FEED THAT
WHICH HADN'T BEEN BY PLANS A
STRONG CANDIDATE FOR CLOSURE.
WE THE LEGISLATURE MODIFIED
PROPOSED BUDGET BUILDING BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION RESTRICTING
MINISTRATION FOR MAKING ANY
EXPENDITURE OR THAT THE
PROPOSED FUNDING PRISONS AT THE
LEGISLATURE IDENTIFIES AS FROM
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE. THIS IS
FOR EXAMPLE STUDENTS. THAT AND
ONCE THE DEPARTMENT PUTS FOR
CHRISTY CLOSURE PLAN WHEN THE
NEEDS BASILIDES. WILL NOT BE
CLOSE. THE NEXT. WITHIN THE
MEDICATION ROOMS WHICH TRAVIS-
RECOMMENDATION WE KNOW THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD RESULT IN
PROVIDED FUNDING TO A PROJECT
AT THE CALIFORNIA TRAINING
FACILITY CT. WHEN THE PERSONS
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A STRONG
CANDIDATE FOR CLOSURE.
I SAID
WE RECOMMENDED. YEAH YEAH JUST
FOR ME PLEASE. OKAY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE FRIENDS
AWARE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WILL COMMENT ON- A
FEW OF THE PROPOSAL HERE FOR
CDC ARE IN RESPONSE TO THE L.
A. O. THAT INCLUDES THE NORTH
PROPOSALS WHICH I BELIEVE RIGHT
AND SIX OF YOUR AGENDA SO
THAT'S THE BALLOT STATE PRISON
HANCE MINTS. AND IF THE
FURNITURE REPLACEMENT-ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT ON YOUR AGENDA
WHICH IS THE STATE WIDE X.
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE AND THEN
ITEM UMBER NINE ON YOUR AGENDA
WHICH IS THE STAFF COMPLAINT
PROCESS. SO TO START OFF WITH
VALLEY STATE PRISON FIRST THE
MINISTRY MISSION DOES NOT
BELIEVE IT IN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE REPORT DATE IS
ENOUGH TIME TO COLLECT
MEANINGFUL DATA. ON THE IMPACT
OF THESE PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO RECIDIVISM AND
POST RELEASE OUTCOMES. EVEN
THOSE YOUR AS PROPOSING TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM OUT A
COMMONS THE MAJORITY OF THE
PUZZLES MEASURES REPRESENT BEST
PRACTICES RECOGNIZED IN THE
CORRECTIONAL SETTING. AND I
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN.
SUCCESSFULLY DEMONSTRATED IN
THE NORWAY MODEL IN OTHER
CONTEXTS SO MUCH IS INCREASE
ACCESS EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
REBUILDING REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES. AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION. THE
PURPOSE OF COLLECTING
ADDITIONAL DATA WILL BE HELPFUL
IN. GAUGING PROBLEM AFFECTED IS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF POTENTIALLY
UNDERTAKING TARGETED EXPANSIONS
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAM ELEMENTS
THROUGHOUT SEIZE YOUR SYSTEM
BUT IT IS NOT INTENDED TO IMPLY
THAT THE ECONOMICS OF THIS
PROPOSAL ARE NOT THEMSELVES
EVIDENCE BASED FOR EFFECTIVE.
THE PROPOSAL CORE COMPONENTS
HAVE ONE TIME FUNDING NECESSARY
TO STAND THEM UP AND THESE
PROGRAMS DO NOT LEND THEMSELVES
WELL TO LIMITED TERM FUNDING.
ADMINISTRATION IS MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE CITY SEARCH
CURRENT REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM
OFFERINGS. BUT SUGGESTING THAT
DATE- DATA SHOULD BE PROVIDED
IN A LITTLE PROPOSAL IS NOT A
REASONABLE APPROACH. AND MOVING
ON TO THE FURNITURE PROPOSAL IN
THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT INTEND
TO REPLACE OTHER REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS BUT SERVES AS A
COMPLEMENT TO THOSE EFFORTS BY
CREATING A MORE WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT. IN WHICH INMATES
CAN PURSUE REBUILD IT
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
AGAIN EXCUSE ME- CURRENTLY
THESE FACILITIES HAVE- STERILE
METAL FURNITURE DATING IS
TYPICAL TO AN INSTITUTIONAL
SETTING BUT VERY MUCH CONTRARY
SURE OF REHABILITATIVE SETTING-
THIS IS A ONE TIME COST TO
COMPLEMENT EXISTING EFFORTS. IN
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
TAKING A NUMBER OF OTHER
MEASURES TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING- AND
FINALLY ON THIS ONE I WOULD NO
DATE ONE OF THE SUCCESSES OF
THE NORWAY MODEL IS. AND
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
OCCURS AND THAT IS PRECISELY
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL INTENDS TO
ACHIEVE IS ENHANCING
PROGRAMMING. I CREATED A MORE
CONDUCIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
REHABILITATION IS NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH AS THE
ELLIE- RECOMMENDATIONS SUGGESTS.
AND THEN WE TO YOU I NUMBER
EIGHT- WHICH IS STATEWIDE
SURVEILLANCE. THESE FUNDS TO
INSTALL VIDEO CAMERAS- PROPOSED
OVER THREE FISCAL YEARS TWO
PROVIDED FEASIBLE ROLLOUT
SCHEDULE FOR IMPLEMENTATION IN
THIS GIVEN THE COMPLEXITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROJECTS
AND VARIANCE FROM INSTITUTIONS
TO TEACH AND AS WELL AS
FLEXIBILITY FOR SEA SHEPHERD
ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES AS THEY
OCCUR OVER TIME. SO THE
FLEXIBILITY THE L. A. DESCRIBES
IS BAKED INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL THIS
INVESTMENT WILL PROVIDE
CERTAINTY AROUND THE INTENT TO
YOU OF ACTUATE THIS STATEWIDE
ROLLOUT WITHIN THE STATE'S
CURRENT FISCAL OUTLOOK- WE'RE
ONE TIME RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS PURPOSE. AND
THIS CERTAINLY IS ESPECIALLY
HELPFUL FOR EQUIPMENT
PROCUREMENT AND PROJECT
PLANNING. AND THE LAST ONE I
WOULD NOTE HERE IS THAT AT AS
MY COLLEAGUE- CRISTINA BRIDGE
NOTED EARLIER- REGARDING THAT
THE POPULATION. GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND CURRENT AND
FUTURE POPULATION PROJECTIONS
THE ADMINISTRATION RECOMMENDS
APPROVAL OF THESE RESOURCES
INCLUDED HERE- BECAUSE HOLDING
OUT DEPLOYMENTS- AND LYFT OF
UNCERTAINTY AROUND POPULATION
PROJECTIONS. WOULD ULTIMATELY
UNDERMINE THE INTENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND DELAYED
REALIZATION OF THE BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DEPLOYMENT
OF FIXED CAMERAS ACROSS CDCR
SYSTEM INCLUDED INCREASED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
AND THEN FINALLY MOVING ON TO
THE- STAFF COMPLAINT PACKAGE
AGAIN UP WITH THIS ITEM NUMBER
NINE I WILL START OFF WITH- THE
USE OF FORCE AND CREE OF PARTS.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
APPROVAL OF A LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM RECRUITING FOR LIMITED
TERM POSITION CAN BE
CHALLENGING AND DOCUMENTS VCRS
ABILITY TO HIRE TRAIN AND
RETAIN THESE POSITIONS.
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSCORES THAT
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL BOTH
TO MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ARMSTRONG COURT WERE AND TO
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IN CONVERSATIONS
EARLIER THIS YEAR. APPROVAL OF
ONGOING RESOURCES DOES NOT
LIMIT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REVISIT PROGRAM STAFFING LEVELS
OR AFFECT MR THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS CCR HAS ALREADY MADE
DECISIVE COMMITMENTS TO KEEP
THE LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE
INFORMED OF ITS PROGRESS. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AND
THAT'S REGARDLESS OF THE TIME
SPAN THE REQUESTED RESOURCES.
AND THEN MOVING ON TO YOU-
FINALLY THE ARMSTRONG PEAS- I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO NOTE ON BODY
WORN CAMERAS THE CITIES ARE IS
MONITORING THE USE OF BODY WORN
CAMERAS AND IS IN THE PROCESS
OF. COLLECTING DATA REGARDING
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS. AND THEY
ARE BEING PURSUED ON A PILOT
BASIS- PURSUANT TO THE
ARMSTRONG COURT ORDER. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABLE TO
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND IS OPEN TO DISCUSSING HOW
BEST TO DO THAT. AND WITHIN
THAT TIME TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE MICHAEL FLEISCHMAN-
FOR COMMENTS ON MORE OF THE
PROPOSAL'S. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHAEL SESSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF THE
FIRST- ISSUE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO RESPOND TO THE AREA ON
SUNDAYS NUMBER ELEVEN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE SPECIFICALLY THE
PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT. OF
PROGRAM INTEGRATION AND
STANDARDIZATION PROPOSAL. UP
WITH REGARDS TO A JUSTIFICATION
OF THE INDIVIDUAL POSITIONS THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES DETAILED
BACKUPS OF THE CALCULATIONS AND
METHODOLOGIES THAT NGUYEN IN
DETERMINING THE POSITION.
KURDISTAN'S BRINGING WITH HER
HIPS A PSYCHIATRIC PATIENT-
PROGRAM INTO CONFORMING WITH
THE SAME STAFFING LEVELS THAT
pJUST PROCESS. AS WELL AS
MEETING STATE AND FEDERAL
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS. THE
ADMINISTRATION AS DALY NOTED IT
IS WORKING WITH THE L. A. L.
ACT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THE SEC. AND
THEN JUST ON THE ON THE
CONCERNED ABOUT REQUESTING THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT. THAT EACH
OF FOR IN THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUESTING THAT VERY VERY
NARROW ASPECT THE PROPOSAL NOT
OF THE FLAG STANDS. WHICH ARE
BANDS THAT CAN SHIFT BETWEEN
LEVELS OF CARE- LOWER HIGHER
ASK NEEDED IN IN ORDER TO
RESPOND TO CHANGES IN THE
COMPOSITION OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH POPULATION. BUT THEN
MOVING ON TO THE LARGER
PROPOSAL- JUSTIFICATION WHEN
THESE THREE TIPS WE'RE ONE
THREE CATCHER TRANSFERRED. FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TO CDC ARE IT WAS
UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS TRANSFER
WAS SIMPLY SHIFTING. DASH
RESOURCES TO CDCR DISHES
OPERATIONS AT THE TIME BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT. IN
MANY WAYS FROM THOSE OF CDCR
FOR EXAMPLE GASH. HAD A
DECENTRALIZED ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURE THAT IS NOT RIGHT SIX
YEARS MORE CENTRALIZED
PROGRAMMATIC STRUCTURE. IN THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE FULLY
INTEGRATE THE THREE LIFT AND
SHIFT. IN THE CDCR CELEBRATIONS
AND THEN BRING STAFFING INTO A
LINE ACROSS THE THREE TIPS THAT
WERE DIFFERENT H. AND D. TO-
THAT SHE CAN SEE ARE STARTED ON
ITS OWN. USING CONSISTENT
METHODOLOGIES THAT REFLECTS USE
YOUR STERN OPERATIONAL NEEDS IN
A WAY THAT WILL BEST SERVE. THE
PATIENTS OF THESE JUST SURVEYS.
THE MINUTE IS NOW BROUGHT FOR
THESE CHAIN UNTIL THIS TIME
ORDER TO BE L. A. TO. MORE THE
MOST THOUGHTFUL OF HER ABOUT
HOW TO. THE TIPS MODELS. THE
NEXT THING THAT I WANT SPEAK TO
OUR IS AND- ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN- THE REDIRECTION OF
FUNDING FROM. LISTED IN THE
AGENDA AS REDIRECTION OF
FUNDING FROM A LIMITED CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS. TO SHANGHAI
AND PSYCHIATRY REGISTRY STUFF.
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT THE BEARS IT'S NOT JUST
FOR REGISTRY TO US AND THAT
THERE IS A SHORTFALL. OF WHICH
HAS HAPPENED OVER THE COURSE OF
MANY YEARS AND WE ARE STILL
WORKING. ARE STILL WORKING IN
ORDER TO. DETERMINE EXACTLY HOW
THE SHORTFALL HAD COME UP I
DON'T WANT TO CHEW UP THE
THOUGHT THAT IT WAS ONLY
REDIRECTING FUNDING FROM ONE
PURPOSE YOU ANOTHER EXTRACTED
THE- NINE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
STEP ASIDE EIGHT. I WAS NOT IN
FACT A REDIRECTION- BUT IT WAS
JUST NOT FUNDING- IN THE FIRST
PLACE. BUT OUR COMMITMENT IS TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM AT THE LEVEL
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE FUNDED FOR
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT IT
DEBTS- SO WE'RE OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT A LONG TERM
SOLUTION- OUR BIGGEST INTEREST
IS GETTING THE PROGRAM THROUGH
THE BUDGET YEAR- BUT WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO BE OUR NEED
EXPRESSED HERE- AND ARE
EXCITED- I GUESS BUT-
INTERESTED HAPPY TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
JUSTIFICATION. AND MAYBE MEET.
LAST NAME IN THE PARKING OF
FINANCE BUT AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN- JUST
CIRCLING BACK TO ISSUES
THIRTEEN AND SEVENTEEN WHICH
REGARD BE INFRASTRUCTURE-
EXPENDITURES ON CD STARK STATE
PRISONS. I THE MINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THE ANXIETY OF
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE GIVEN THE
CONCERN OF FUTURE PRISON
CLOSURES POSSIBILITIES- HOWEVER
THE ADMINISTRATION REMAINS
COMMITTED TO RIGHT SIZING THAT.
THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM BUT
IDENTIFICATION OF WHICH PRISON
TO CLOSE RANGE A COMPLEX ISSUE
THAT REQUIRES TAKING MORE INTO
ACCOUNT BEEN JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITIONS AND
NEEDS- OTHER IMPORTANT FACTORS
INCLUDE SPECIALIZED PROGRAMMING
EMISSIONS FOR POPULATIONS THAT
THOSE PRISONS. ARE THE STAFFING
LEVELS AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
THERE AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING AVAILABLE FOR THE
INMATES. WERE ALSO CONSIDERED
WITH OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES
THAT ARISE WHEN YOU CAN JUST
IDENTIFYING PRISON FOR
POTENTIAL CLOSER ONCE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT IS MADE- EVEN IF
ONLY FOR A RANKING OF
INSTITUTIONS THAT THREATENS CDC
OURS ABILITY TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN STAFF AT THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. DESPITE BENITEZ
FOR THEM TO REMAIN OPERATIONAL
UNTIL CLOSURE THIS CAN BE
PARTICULARLY DETRIMENTAL OF
PHYSICIANS ARE NOT FILLED AND
THE AREAS AND SOME PROGRAMS
LIKE HEALTH CARE UNFILLED.
UNFILLED POSITIONS MAINLY TO
LEGAL ACTIVITY AGAINST THE
STATE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY UNDER A
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO QUARTER
ORDER TO ACHIEVING 90% FILL
RATE FOR PSYCHIATRIST
POSITIONS. AND CDCR ALREADY HAS
TROUBLE FILLING THOSE POSITIONS
AND PREMATURELY IDENTIFYING
PRISONS FOR CLOSURE EXACERBATE
THOSE DIFFICULTIES- AGAIN
CLOSING OR EVEN JUST
IDENTIFYING PRISONS FOR CLOSURE
IS A MAJOR DECISION HAS NORMA'S
IMPLICATIONS. BUT THE STAFF WHO
WORK THERE INMATES HOUSED IN
LIVING THERE AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. I'M AS
SUCH IDENTIFYING PRISONS
CLOSURE IS A PATH WE DO NOT
WANT TO START DOWN THE WE'RE
RELATIVELY CERTAIN THAT IT CAN
BE COMPLETED- AS SUCH. WE THINK
THE NOTION HAVE PROHIBITING ARE
HOLDING HOSTAGE INSTEAD. FROM
RECEIVING NEEDED. REPAIR UNTIL
CDC PROVIDE STATUS OF PRISON.
IS- SOMETHING THAT WOULD MAKE
IN. IMPACT APARTMENTS ABILITY
TO ME ITS ME AND- FOR THE
POPULATIONS INVOLVED-
AMBASSADOR WRAP UP- FOR OUR
COMMENTS ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
I'M JUST TO KIND OF CIRCLE BACK
WITH THE POPULATION PROJECTIONS
I'M WE ACTUALLY DON'T THINK
THAT BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IS
NECESSARY AS MISTER NEAL
MENTION. ON THIS IS THAT A
PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THAT WEEK COMPLETE
TWICE A YEAR AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THEN AGAIN AT THE ME
RADIATION HOME RECEPTION
POPULATION. IN TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY
IN THE POPULATION REGARDING.
THEIR- TERM THEY'VE ALREADY
SERVED IN STATE JAILS THAT'S
LIKELY TO BE AN OUT YEAR IMPACT
SO WHAT NECESSARILY IMPACT THAT
THE REQUEST FOR HER FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR FUNDING IN THE
SUBSEQUENT YEAR. IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD-
ADJUSTING REFLECTED THAT THE
FOLLOWING GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS BY HALF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. I
OKAY VETTEL ALL DEPARTMENTS
OKAY- NOW WE GET COULD JUMP IN-
MAYBE WE COULD DO THIS UP SIR
NEWMAN ALDS START AND IF YOU
HAVE SOMETHING BEFORE THAT OR
AFTER THAT WE CAN THAT'S RIGHT
I DON'T HAVE IT BECAUSE- OF
FIGHTING. OKAY ALL RIGHT ON ON
ON ITEM THREE THE COVERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE- CAN CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THE CHANGES IN THE
RESEARCH REQUESTED RESOURCES
GIVEN THE REDUCTION IN CASES AT
CDC ARE- THE IN PERSON
VISITATION AND ALSO THE VACCINE
OF ROLLOUT- MAYBE YOU COULD
UPDATE US ON THE VACCINATION
NUMBERS FOR STAFF AND THE
INCARCERATED- YOU KNOW. WHAT
WHAT ARE THOSE. STEPS BUT
CONSIDERING ALL OF THIS- WHAT
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES. YEAH THIS IS ERIC'S
ONCE AGAIN DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
GODWIN READER TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT VACCINATIONS THAT ARE
PART OF THAT YOU KNOW IT IS
DIFFICULT WE ACKNOWLEDGE IT IS
DIFFICULT BUDGETING FOR KOBE-
HOW WE WENT ABOUT- ESTIMATING A
RESOURCES FOR BUDGET YEAR. IS
LOOKING AT- OUR ACTUAL SPENDING
THROUGH MARCH AND THEN TRIED TO
ADJUST IT DOWN BASED ON-
FACTORS WE KNOW ABOUT SO WE ARE
THERE IS A ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR THINGS
THAT WE KNOW MAKE CONTINUING
BUDGET YEAR SUCH AS CLEANING
AND THE WE HAVE BEEN USING A
RENTING TENTS IN SOME CASES AND
THAT MAY CONTINUE. IN BUDGET
YEAR AS WELL IN ADDITION- BY
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO CONTINUE
PURCHASING- PP EQUIPMENT AND
ALL THAT. SO THOSE ARE THE
COULD TIE AND WE MAY HAVE TO-
CONTINUE WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TESTING AS WELL WHICH ALL
TURNED OVER TO DUANE RIEDER WHO
COULD TALK ABOUT TESTING AND
ALSO. WHERE WE ARE AS FAR AS
VACCINES. GOOD AFTERNOON
MANAGER DOING READER- DEBBIE
DIRECTOR CCHS- CURRENTLY. WE
HAVE ABOUT 45% OF OUR- STAFF
VACCINATED IN ABOUT. 68% OFOUR
INMATE POPULATION VACCINATED-
WE ARE CONTINUING TO ENCOURAGE
STAFF- VIA EDUCATION TO GET
VACCINATED WE ARE OFFERING-
APPOINTMENT FREE- VACCINATIONS
OF MATERNA. AND THE JOHNSON
JOHNSON ONE SHOT. AND WE-
DEVELOPED A LEARNING- MODULE
THAT STAFF CAN TAKE TO HELP
EDUCATE THEM ON THE ON THE
PARAMETERS OF THE VACCINATIONS
AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO GET
VACCINATED- THROUGH EDUCATION
MODULE- IS FOR STAFF TESTING-
WITH THE VACCINATION NUMBERS.
WHERE THEY'RE AT AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO DO STUFF TESTING-
THINGS ARE CHANGING- THROUGH
CDC AND ANSWER THE STATE
GUIDELINES AND SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- TO. REVISE OUR
GUIDELINES AS NECESSARY- BUT
THE INSTITUTIONS ARE A VERY.
TIGHT POPULATION VERY CLOSE
PROXIMITY. AND SO- AT THIS
POINT- WE'RE STILL- TESTING-
BOTH STAFF AND INMATES- TO
INSURE IT BUT WE. DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL OUTBREAKS. DO
YOU HAVE A- A GOAL THAT YOU SET
TO REACH I MEAN I KNOW WE ALL
WANT WELL MOST OF US ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. BUT IS THERE A
GOAL THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
NO OUR GHOST OF ACTUALLY IS
MANY STAFF AND PATIENTS AS
POSSIBLE- AND WE'RE WE'RE
ENCOURAGING THAT THROUGH
EDUCATION WEREN'T PURGING THAT
THROUGH. OFFERING CLINICS- AND
DO IT EVERY CHIU EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO GET STAFF ACTION AT IT
BUT- OUR GOAL IS TO VACCINATE
AS MANY AS POSSIBLE. OKAY ARE
WITH IT LOOKS LIKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE STAFF.
OF LEVEL OF VACCINATION AND THE
INMATE- EIGHT YOU SAID YOU'RE
OBVIOUSLY LOOKING FOR-
VOLUNTARY- USING PERSUASION OR-
I DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER-
TACTICS- BUT- WHAT HAPPENS IF
IT STAYS AT THAT LEVEL. YOU
KNOW WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH WILL CONTINUE
WORK WITH THE CDC GUIDELINES
AND FOLLOW BEST PRACTICES- WE
ARE JUST HOPING TO EDUCATE WE
EVER LEADERSHIP GOING OUT THERE
AND- WORKING WITH THEIR STAFF
AND HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND
ENCOURAGING. THEM TO GET
VACCINATED AND TRYING TO DISPEL
ANY RUMORS- ARE ANY CONCERNS
THEY MAY HAVE- BUT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET GET
FOLKS FASCINATED- AND IF IT. IF
THEY ARE- OR IF THEY SAY
THEY'RE VACCINATED DO YOU
REQUIRE THEM TO SHOW PROOF A
VACCINATION- AT THIS POINT
WE'RE NOT REQUIRING- STAFF TO
SHOW PROOF OF VACCINATION- IF
THEY SAY THEY ARE. NOT NOT AS A
REQUIREMENT FOR WORK. IF THEY
SAY THAT THEY ARE VACCINATED DO
YOU REQUIRE PROOF OF THAT- WE
ALL HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK ON
THAT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU OKAY
I AS FAR AS I KNOW WE HAVEN'T
BEEN- ASKING TH- STAFF TO PROVE
THEIR VACCINATIONS AT THIS
POINT BUT LET ME LET ME- DOUBLE
CHECK ON THAT FOR YOU OKAY.
GREAT- CENTER YOU MEAN YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM
NOT IN STOCK. OKAY ALL RIGHT
LET'S. JUMP AHEAD TO- MY
FAVORITE THE NORWAY NUMBER SIX
THE NORWAY MODEL. I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THAT I HAD THE- I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF GOING TO
NORWAY A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO SO
I CAN REALLY PICTURE- AND IT
WAS ALL VERY- PRETTY
INCREDIBLE. TO SEE SUCH A
DIFFERENT ICARCERATION PRISON
SYSTEM- I KNOW OUR CONDITIONS
ARE DIFFERENT AND HISTORIES AND
ALL OF THAT BUT- PEOPLE ARE
PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE.
ESTABLISHED SOMETHING THAT'S
QUITE EXTRAORDINARY OF ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE AND WE CAN
YOU KNOW WE CAN GO BACK AND
FORTH AS- YOU KNOW TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT REPLACING
THE- I ROOM FURNITURE IS GONNA
MAKE A DIFFERENCE OR NOT WILL
HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS I KNOW
THE PURPOSE OF THAT IS TO-
CREATE A MORE THERAPEUTIC.
ENVIRONMENT IN IRAQ I GIVE YOU
ALL JUST A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
THINKING ABOUT ALL THESE PIECES
AND THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT IN
WHAT I SAW. OVER THERE. THE
WEATHER'S MAXIMUM OF SECURITY
OR YOU KNOW ON THEIR WAY OUT OF
NO DOUBT THE ENVIRONMENT- WAS
SOMETHING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
INCLUDING FURNITURE AND OTHERS.
BUT THE ONE THING THAT STOOD
OUT EVEN MORE THAN THE PHYSICAL
ENVIRONMENT. WAS AND THEY MADE
A POINT OF- WE WENT TO THE-
THEIR EDUCATION FACILITY THEIR
TRAINING FACILITY AND UP THAT
STOOD OUT MORE THAN ANYTHING IS
THERE PROGRAM. VERY LONG TRIP-
TRAINING EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
BEFORE THEY'RE HIRED- AND THEIR
CONSTANT OF FOCUS ON TRAINING
OF THE OFFICERS. AND THEY WE
EVEN HAD IN OUR GROUP A FEW
OFFICERS FROM ANOTHER- STATE.
AND THOSE PRISON OFFICIALS WENT
AND THEY SHARED A OF VIDEO OF
HOW THEY HAD APPLIED OF CERTAIN
CONCEPTS ON DE ESCALATING
SITUATIONS AND THEY SHOWED HOW
THEY HAD APPLIED IT HERE IN THE
US IN THEIR STATE. AND IT WAS
QUITE EXTRAORDINARY AS WELL SO
WHAT STOOD OUT MORE THAN
ANYTHING WAS THE CHANGE YOU
KNOW THE CULTURE THE CHANGING
TALKING THROUGH SAFETY FOR THE
OFFICERS WITH AS MUCH OF A
CONCERN IF NOT MORE OF A
CONCERN. THEN THE INMATES OF
AND SO IN ALL OF THIS
CONVERSATION AROUND THE NORWAY
MODEL- HAS THERE BEEN ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT THE
TRAINING ALL OR- CHANGING OF
THE CULTURE OF WILL BE. I CAN I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S MISTER
SWANSON- SOME OTHERS YEAH WHEN
WE STARTED OFF- MADAM CHAIR-
ONE OF THE PROPOSALS THAT'S NOT
IN THE MAY REVISION BUT THAT
WAS PART OF THE JANUARY BUDGET
WAS TRYING TO LOOK AT- GETTING
TO. CHANGING OUR- TRAINING SO
IT BETTER REFLECTS. THIS GOAL
OF AREA. YOU KNOW BETTER SORT
OF NORWAY MODEL SORT OF.
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
MISSION- SO ONE THING WE WILL
LOOK AT IT WAS- THERE'S-
RESOURCES FOR DE ESCALATION AND
THAT KIND OF TRAINING I DON'T
HAVE THOSE FOLKS WITH ME TODAY
BUT- LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
MERION SPEARMAN WHO COULD KIND
OF TALK ABOUT- HOW WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT VALLEY STATE PRISON.
HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT ASPECT OF
THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRPERSON MISTRESS
BERMAN- SOCIAL DIRECTOR IN
TOURING THE PRISON- SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THIS POSITION FOR ABOUT
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF IN
GETTING OUT TALKING TO STAFF
DOWN THERE I IS SO UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENT THERE WERE STAFF
TRULY CARE ABOUT PRISONERS AND
I AND I KNOW THIS COMES FROM
THE LEADERSHIP OF WHARTON
FISHER AND HIS MANAGEMENT TEAM.
AND HOW THEY INTERACT WITH-
INMATES THERE- I WASN'T SEVERAL
HOUSING AS WE HAVE INMATES WHO
ARE PART OF OUR ENHANCE
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM THERE YOU
KNOW PARBAT HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS. AND- THESE OFFICERS
WAS DOING HI NICOLE THAT DATA.
THESE OFFICERS DID REAL WELL IN
IN IN GETTING PEOPLE TO WEAR
THEIR MASKS- YOU KNOW KIND OF
DON'T WANT TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
SO I KNOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS THAT HAS MADE VALLEY
STATE PRISON SO SUCCESSFUL WITH.
CONTINUING THE NORWAY MODEL. IS
THE EMPLOYEES THERE ARE WE HAVE
A WHILE P. PROGRAM A YOUTHFUL
OFFENDER PROGRAM THERE AND NOW
ONE OF THE OFFICERS I THINK YOU
TESTIFIED HEARING LAST YEAR
OFFICER ROBERT HERNANDEZ- HE'S
GOT LIKE ABOUT TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE YEARS IN THE APARTMENT
AND HE AND I TALKED FOR AT THAT
HEARING AND HE SAID YOU KNOW I
WAS I ASKED MY SON YOU'VE BEEN
DEPARTMENT LONG IN POWER IF YOU
KEPT THIS. FIRE AND ENTHUSIASM
TO WANT TO BE PART OF HELPING
YOUNG YOU FOR MEN BE BETTER
PEOPLE SO THAT WHEN THEY GO
BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITY. THAT
THEY ARE TAX PAYING CITIZENS.
AND HIS BASIC DISCRIMINATE
COACHING BY PEOPLE WHO BACK IN
THAT PART OF WHAT A VERY
CYNICAL NOW. THEY WERE TRYING
TO RETIRE AND HE SAYS I I'VE
SEEN PEOPLE CHANGE. BY US
PROVIDING THEM REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND HE SAID I'VE SEEN
PEOPLE WHO CAME IN WHO TOLD ME
IT GETS WANTING TO POSSIBLY
PROGRAM VALLEY STATE PRISON. ME
TODAY MAKE THE CHANGES AND HE
SAID THAT WAS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS THAT SOLD HIM
THAT PEOPLE CAN CHANGE WHEN YOU
GIVE. PEOPLE HOPE. AND
EXPRESSED TO THEM THE NEED FOR
THEM TO BE BETTER PEOPLE. SO HE
HAS BEEN ABLE IN ALL TO
CONDUCT. ON THE FACILITY HE
WORKS ON TO TALK TO HIS PEERS
OTHER CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
AND TO GET THEM TO UNDERSTAND
YOU KNOW OUR VISION AT IN OUR
DEPARTMENT. AND VALLEY STATE
PRISON AND HE TOLD ME HE SAID
THERE WAS A COUPLE OFFICERS
HAVE KIND OF REALLY WE'RE KIND
OF YOU KNOW STICK. SPOT ON
KNOWN WHERE THEY WERE AND HE
SAID NOW THESE THESE IT THOSE
TWO OFFICES IN THIS ONE
BUILDING HE SAID. THEY ARE LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT DOING THEIR PART
IN ENCOURAGING YOUNG YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS AGO THEIR CLASSES. IS
THEY MADE A TOTAL SHIFT IN
THEIR MIND SET. SO AGAIN IT'S-
WITH THE MODEL IS IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S LIKE A- YOU HAVE LINES TO
TAKE SO ONE THING IS A STAFF
THE STAFF ENVIRONMENT AND THE
AND THE STAFF ATTITUDE AT
VALLEY STATE PRISON- IS VERY
VERY GOOD AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
FORWARD THINKING AND WHAT WE
WERE OUR DEPARTMENT'S GOING.
THEN WE HAVE THE ACTUAL INMATE
POPULATION WHO HAS LEFT A
GENERAL POPULATION YARD THE
PRISON POLITICS HAS ELECTED TO
NOT BE PART OF ALL THAT SELF
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR. AND THEN
WE ADD THAT THE ACTUAL
PROGRAMMING DAY INACTIVITY
GROUPS WE HAD ALL THE EDUCATION
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
WE AT COLLEGE THERE WE HAD THE
TRAUMA INFORMED TREATMENT THERE
IN IN THE FOURTH LEG OF THE
TABLE. WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
WITHOUT THIS ADDS SOME PHYSICAL
THINGS THERE SO WE HAD THE
PHYSICAL WHICH MEANS THIS
MODULAR FURNITURE WHICH- IT'S
COMP IS COMFORTABLE. M. AS IN
NORWAY MODEL THEY'RE LOOKING AT
PEOPLE NOT JUST BEING IN PRISON
LONG TERM LOOKING AT PEOPLE
GOING OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND SO IN THE COMMUNITY ALSO
TIME WE'RE NOT SITTING AT METAL
TABLES AND STEEL. STEEL CHAIRS
IN A COMMUNITY WE HAVE YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE AT A POOL REPORTER
HOUSE YOU HAVE COMFORTABLE
LOUNGE THINGS WITH YOUR
BARBECUE YOU HAVE ALL THOSE
THINGS THERE AND DAVE AS YOU
SAY JACK EVER BEEN AND ALWAYS
YOU BETTER THERE. THAT KINDA
HELPS. WHERE THEY'RE MIMICKING
IN THE NORWAY MODEL THEIR
PRESENTS KIND OF WHAT PEOPLE
CAN HAVE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
SO BASED UPON THAT I THINK IT'S
A VERY VERY POSITIVE THING
WE'RE DOING. WITH THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX AND I THINK WITH VALLEY
STATE PRISON AS WELL AS THE
OTHER FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE
SELECTED. WHERE PEOPLE ARE
TRULY TRULY TRYING TO THE BEST
THAT THEY CAN THAT THINGS WILL
WORK WELL. AND I NOTICED GIPSON
IS WORKING- WITH A GROUP OF
PEOPLE TO LOOK AT SOME THINGS
FOR STAFFING AND SO WE CAN KIND
OF YOU KNOW. CONTINUE TO FOSTER
I GUESS THE NORWAY MODEL OF HOW
THEY ALL. WORK WITH THEIR STAFF
AND HOW THEY TRAIN YOUR STAFF.
YEAH A I WOULD JUST- URGE. THAT
HI OF REPORT BACK IF WE'RE
GONNA. OF BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT
BECAUSE- I DON'T THINK. LEAVING
IT UP TO INDIVIDUAL GOOD
OFFICERS. NECESSARILY YOU KNOW
IT HAS AN IMPACT ON THEIR THEIR
PEERS. BUT I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE- WE CAN'T WAIT FOR
THAT UP IT'S GONNA BE MORE
INTENTIONAL AND MORE DELIBERATE
AS FAR AS WHAT'S EXPECTED OF
OFFICERS- SO JUST YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR RESPONSE-
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN TERMS
OF THE PROGRAM- WHICH
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE AND TO BE
ABLE TO ENTER THE PROGRAM- DOES
THAT INCLUDE. OF THOSE WITH
TIME LEFTTO SERVE DOES THAT
INCLUDE THOSE LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE WHAT WHAT IS IT THAT WHO
IS IT AND HOW YOU DETERMINE WHO
GETS ACCESS TO- THE AS OR WHAT
EVER NEEDED TO GET THE BA. OKAY
THE FIRST SERRA LARSEN MY
COLLEAGUES. AND AFTER YOU MADAM
CHAIR STERILIZED AND AGAIN FROM
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AT CDC ARE STILL THERE
ARE NO RESTRICTIONS ON- ACCESS
TO OUR VA PROGRAM IF FOLKS MEET
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA SO
THEY FUTURE MOST PREREQUISITE
COURSES AT THE A LEVEL AND
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR PLACEMENT
OF VALLEY STATE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM NOW VALLEY STATE
ONLY SERVES A CERTAIN SECURITY
LEVEL BUT WE DO HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE PROGRAMS
ACROSS ALL SECURITY LEVELS. AN
ACT- INSTITUTIONS THAT HOW'S
LIFERS AND I'LL AND- STUDENTS
WITH A LOT STATUS SO THERE IS
ACCESS FOR OUR STUDENTS KIND OF
ACROSS ALL SECURITY LEVELS I'M
AND ACROSS THOSE OTHER STATUS
THERE'S TWO THAT BACHELOR'S
LEVEL EDUCATION EVEN IF EVEN IF
IT'S NOT THE SPECIFIC VALLEY
STATE PROGRAM. BUT WE DO WORK
WITH OUR PARTNERS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT MR SPEARMAN OVER IN OUR
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
ON GETTING FOLKS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR PLACEMENT OF
VALLEY STATE AND ELIGIBLE FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROGRAM
TRANSFERRED. TO RALLY SO THAT
THEY CAN PROTECT EIGHT.
PRIORITY FOR US TO MAKE SURE
FOLKS WERE PUTTING EFFORT AND
OF HAVE THAT LAW BEING TO WORK
ON THEIR BACHELOR'S BUT THEY'RE
ABLE TO TRANSFER TO AN
INSTRUCTOR. I HAVE DOCTOR. OKAY
IS THERE A LIMIT AS TO THE
NUMBER- WHO CAN PART OF THE
NUMBER THAT CAN PARTICIPATE.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT A
CLASS SIZE OF ABOUT EIGHTY
STUDENTS ONCE WERE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED- IN THAT AND THAT'S
JUST BASED ON KIND OF LOOKING
AT THE- NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT
WE HAVE THAT ARE KIND OF
REACHING THE ELIGIBILITY LEVEL.
THAT WE THINK WILL BE ABLE TO
SERVER AND SO YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY BASED ON WHO WHO
IS REACHING OUT LEVEL OF BEING
ABLE TO WORK ON MY BACHELOR'S.
AND THAT'S EIGHTY OUT OF. WITH
THE TOTAL POPULATION THERE. THE
POPULATION I THINK THE MADAM
CHAIRS BOUGHT A. TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED. AND TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE BACHELOR'S LEVEL EDUCATION
IS ONE PROGRAM THAT WE OFFER IN
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS WE ALSO HAVE MANY
STUDENTS AT VALLEY STATE WHO
ARE WORKING ON THEIR G. EACH
YEAR OF THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA WHO ARE WORKING ON
ASSOCIATES LEVEL EDUCATION FOR
PARTICIPATING IN OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE THEM WITH
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING- FOR UPON
RELEASE. SO DOES ALL THOSE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT
BE PARTICIPATING IN THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREE PROGRAM
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T YOU KNOW
TAKEN THOSE PREREQUISITE
CLASSES OR ACHIEVE THERE IS
THOSE YET DEGREE THAT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT THEY'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN ACADEMIC OR OR
OTHER TYPES OF. EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. OKAY AND ALL THE
OTHER PHYSICAL THINGS THAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT- THE M.
BESIDES THE FURNITURE OF THE
MODULES FOR ACTIVITY GROUPS-
THE PROGRAMS THE- CONSTRUCTION
MICROPHONE CONSTRUCTION ALL OF
THOSE WOULD BE. FOR THOSE
EIGHTY PEOPLE IT WOULD BE FOR
ANYBODY ELSE. SORRY I KNOW THAT
BACHELOR'S DEGREE PROGRAM IS
WHAT WE'VE WE'VE PEGS- FOR THAT
NUMBER OF PURCHASE SPENDS THOSE
EIGHTY PARTICIPANTS THERE BUT
ALL OF THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
HAVE I'M KIND OF A PARTICIPANT
SIZE BASED ON WHAT WE THINK WE
CAN GET IN TERMS OF PETER'S
INTO THOSE PROGRAMS THOUGH FOR
THE MICRO HOME PROGRAM. WE
REQUIRE SOME PREREQUISITE
TRAINING AND OTHER TYPES OF
CONTRACTING SKILLS BE THAT AGE
TRACK FOR PLUMBING- OR
CONSTRUCTION TRADES THAT ARE
ALL OF THOSE THINGS KIND OF
WORK TOGETHER TO BUILD THE
MICRO HOMES AND SO BASED ON
THAT THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT VALLEY STATE ROUTE
COMPLETED THOSE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS REBUILD THE MICRO HOME
PROGRAM. I'M KIND OF BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS IN
THAT PROGRAM AND WE CAN PROVIDE
I'M BACK UP TO SHOW CAN OF WHAT
THOSE PARTICIPATION NUMBERS
LOOK LIKE FOR THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS THE MEDIA'S ROLE
THAT WE'VE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CREATING THAT MICRO HOMES
PROGRAM THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAM. AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
THE KIND OF EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
THAT WILL BE PROVIDING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE LOCAL
AGENT HE AND WE CAN KIND. OF
SHOW YOU WHAT THOSE NUMBERS
LOOK LIKE. OKAY THANK YOU- JUST
A QUESTION ON THE STAFF
COMPLAINT RELATED- ISSUES OF.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE CDC ARE RECEIVED
ALMOST TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND AND FORTY SEVEN
POSITIONS OF AND ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW REGIONAL MODEL
FOR REVIEWING AND INVESTIGATING
THE INMATE COMPLAINTS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT- AND TO REVISE THE
GRIEVANCE REVIEW PROCESS THE O.
I. G. REPORT FOUND THESE
RESOURCES WERE NOT DEPLOYED
EFFICIENTLY AND PART OF THAT
HAD TO DO WITH THE TIME TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS. SO ARE
THE RESOURCES REQUESTED IN THE
MAY REVISION IN ADDITION TO
WHAT WAS GIVEN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AMY MILLER- FUND DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONS POLICY RESEARCH
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT- THE ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES THAT THESE
REQUESTED RESOURCES ARE IN
ADDITION TO THOSE RESOURCES
THAT WE WERE GIVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE ALLEGATION
INCREMENTED INSPECTION- AND AS
NOTED IN THE REPORT THAT THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
PUT OUT. OUR INVESTIGATIONS AND
INQUIRIES INTO ALLEGATIONS
BEING RECEIVED BY THAT UNIT-
WAS MUCH. WAS WAS MUCH LONGER
IT WAS TAKING AS MUCH LONGER TO
COMPLETE THOSE INVESTIGATIONS
THAN WE HAD ORIGINALLY. ASSUMED
IT WOULD AND SO IN OUR NINETEEN
TWENTY B. C. P. WE HAD ASSUMED
IT WOULD TAKE APPROXIMATELY
TWELVE HOURS PER IN CORRIE WHAT
WE FOUND WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE UNITS M. IN IN THAT
FIRST SIX MONTHS OR SO WAS IT
WAS ATUALLY TAKING US ALMOST
THREE TIMES AS LONG TO CONDUCT
AN INQUIRY WE DID IT BRING A
PERSON INTO EVALUATE OUR
PROCESSES AND BY EVALUATING THE
PROCESSES OF THAT PARTICULAR
UNIT WE HAVE SINCE THEN REDUCED
THE TIME IT IS TAKING TO
COMPLETE THOSE ENQUIRIES. AND
WE'RE NOW DOWN TO ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR HOURS HER INQUIRY MORE OR
LESS- WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE SOME OTHER
EFFICIENCIES TO BE FOUND BUT
JUST BASED ON THE NUMBERS OF
ALLEGATIONS SPECIFICALLY
REGARDING PRISON RAPE
ELIMINATION ACT- ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST STAFF USE OF FORCE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST STAFF AND
THEN OF COURSE THE- THE
ARMSTRONG LITIGATION AND THE
NEEDS FOR THOSE AREAS AS WELL
WE STILL BELIEVE THAT THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED. WE DID HOWEVER TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE RESOURCES WE
ALREADY HAD IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT WE WERE NOT
ASKING FOR DUPLICATIVE
RESOURCES OR DOUBLE COUNTING
ANY OF THOSE NUMBERS. OKAY
THANK YOU THE ONLY QUESTION ON
THAT ON THE- NUMBER IN FRONT
THE PAROLE. HERE WE GO UP THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS OF-
YOU INCLUDE OF THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES- GENERAL FUND TO
DELIVER SERVICES FOR VICTIMS
DURING THE PAROLE HEARING
PROCESS OF. AND THE- YOU'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO- EXPAND THINGS
LIKE THE VICTIM OFFENDER
DIALOGUE PROGRAM I MEAN IT IT
SEEMS TO ME AND I'VE MET WITH-
CRIME SURVIVORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES- THEY PLAY A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART IN THE TRIAL AND
THE ROLL PROCESSES
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES THEIR
INVOLVEMENT- LEADS TO- DAY
MOTIONAL DISTRESS AND TRAUMA
THAT AND TO REPEAT THAT. OF BUT
WE HAVE OF WE SPEND MORE ON
PRISONS THAT ACTUALLY ON THE
VICTIMS AND SO IT SEEMS TO ME
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE
SERVICES FOR THE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. OF BUT THAT
INCLUDES- ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
BASED VICTIM SERVICES AND
SERVICES THAT PROVIDE- LONG
TERM RESOURCES FOR THE VICTIMS
SO THAT THEY COULD ACTUALLY.
HAVE MORE STABILITY AND ALSO-
RECOVER- SO IT SEEMS TO ME IS-
IT THE PURPOSE OF THIS FUNDING
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF STAFF.
WHAT WILL THEY FUNCTION THE
SAME AS THE EXISTING STAFF OF
LIKE TO SEE IF THERE ARE-
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE- WHAT IT
IS EFFECTIVE RIGHT NOW WHAT'S
BEING PROVIDED WHAT'S
EFFECTIVE- IS A NEW FUNDING
GOING TO SUPPORT FUNCTIONS THAT
ARE EVIDENCE BASED- AND HOW A
DESCRIPTION OF HOW THE STAFF
INTERFACE WITH. DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS WHO INTERACT WITH-
SURVIVORS. I DON'T KNOW WHO
COULD ANSWER THAT. SO JENNIFER
SHAFER THE BORDER PATROL
HEARINGS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS THIS GROUP OF-
ARMS THESE FIRST OF ALL OF THE
OFFICE OF VICTIMS AND- SURVIVOR
RIGHTS AND SERVICES DOES
PROVIDE SERVICES TO VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS- FOR ALL
AREAS OF CORRECTION SO THEY
PROVIDE VITAL AND CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CORRECTIONAL PROCESS. AS WELL
AS BE DISCRETIONARY CALL
HEARING PROCESS NIELSEN
SESSIONS THE REQUESTED- BUDGET
ARM FOR THE OFFICE OF VICTIM
AND SURVIVOR RIGHTS AND
SERVICES WILL HELP ENHANCE SO
SERVICES THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE DIRECT
SERVICES THAT THE OFFICE CAN
PROVIDE SPECIFICALLY TO VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE BOARD'S
PAROLE HEARING PROCESS
CURRENTLY THERE'S KIND OF A
PATCHWORK OF- DIFFERENT PEOPLE
INTERACT AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION- IT VARIES BY
COUNTY- SO THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
ALLOW THE OFFICE TO PROACTIVELY
REACH OUT. TO VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS WHO HAVE REGISTERED
WITH THE OFFICE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PAROLE HEARING PROCESS
WE THINK IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION. ABOUT WHAT TO
EXPECT- PRIOR TO THE PAROLE
HEARING TO LET THEM KNOW WHY
THE PERSON IS ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE CONSIDERATION. AND THEN
WITH RESPECT RESOURCES YOU'RE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. HOPE GUARD
TO PROVIDE RESEARCH ARE
REFERENCES REFERRALS- TO BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL VICTIM SERVICES
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
SPECIALIST PEOPLE ARE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
WHICH CAN BE EXTREMELY
TRAUMATIC. SO THESE PARTICULAR
LAYS SONGS THAT WOULD BE FUNDED
BY THIS PROPOSAL ARE
SPECIFICALLY INTENDED TO
PROVIDE THOSE DIRECT SERVICES
TO PERSONS GOING THROUGH THE
PRO HEARING PROCESS AND IT WILL
ALLOW- SOME OF THE EXISTING
PERSONNEL THAT TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES- UPON REQUEST
CURRENTLY. TO ALSO BE ABLE TO-
DEDICATE ADDITIONAL TIME TO THE
VICTIM OFFENDER MEDIATED ARE
OUR PROGRAM. DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION YEAH I JUST- YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE'S. THE
REASON I MENTION THE-
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S IS. IT ARE THESE
SERVICES TO HELP MORE OF THE
HEALING PROCESS OR IS THAT OKAY
GET READYWE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THIS PAROLE HEARING AND
YOU KNOW OF- NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING OUT FOR THE HEALING
PROCESS OF THE VICTIMS. SO I AM
IT IS I CAN SAY THAT IT'S
DEFINITELY FOUNDED IN THE
HEALING PORTION- AND- THAT
SAID- EVERY VICTIM OR SURVIVOR
THAT COMES TO A PAROLE HEARING
ON MAY BE IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE AND SO THE FIRST FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE PRIORITY IS TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT. AND WHAT
THE PROCESS IS ABOUT EXPLAINED
FOR EXAMPLE- THE SCIENCE BEHIND
ADOLESCENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND WHY WE HAVE USED THEIR
HEARINGS EXPLAIN HOW- THE
IMPACT OF LONG TERM
INCARCERATION AND AGING AND
PRESENT HAS ON SOMEBODY'S-
RECIDIVISM AND ME CURRENT
RECIDIVISM RATES MANY VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS WHO COME BEFORE
THE PAROLE BOARD ARE- VERY-
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR THEIR
PERSONAL SAFETY IF THIS PERSON
IS RELEASED AND SO PART OF IT
IS EXPLAINING. ARE THE OUTCOMES
OF THE CURRENT PROCESS AND
TRYING TO SORT OF PROVIDE THE
CONTEXT IN WHICH A RELEASE
OCCURS TODAY- FROM A PAROLE
SUITABILITY HEARING IT'S ALSO I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THE
STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS UNDERSTAND THE
LEGAL STANDARDS AND WHAT THE
BOARD IS LOOKING OUT PRIOR TO
MAKING A FULL DETERMINATION AND
THESE RAISONS. WOULD CERTAINLY
HELP- BY ADDITIONAL EDGE THAT
RESPECT. FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN ACCEPT-
MORE OF THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESS SEES AND THEY HAVE AN
INTEREST IN THOSE RESOURCES
THESE LAYS ON CAN ALSO
DEFINITELY PROVIDE THOSE
REFERRALS AND ASSISTANCE. I
WANT TO BE REALLY CAREFUL TO
SAY THAT YES THEY WILL SUPPORT
THAT HEALING PROCESS BUT I
THINK IT'S REALISTIC TO
UNDERSTAND THAT FOR MANY
PEOPLE- THEY'RE NOT READY FOR
THAT BUT PROVIDING MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION. IS THE BEST WAY
FORWARD TO HELPING PEOPLE GET
TO A PLACE WHERE THEY ARE. IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN ACCEPT- A
DIFFERENT RESOURCES FOR HEALING
AND MOVING FORWARD. OKAY THANK
YOU- MOST. WOMB. THE
REDIRECTING OF THE FUNDING
FROM- THE LEMONADE TO CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS- DO YOU HAVE
A BREAKDOWN OF HOW THE RE
DIRECTED SAVINGS WOULD GO TO
ONE OF THE BEST PSYCHIATRY
REGISTRY COST AND TO OTHER NON
PSYCHIATRY REGISTRY COST YOU
HAVE THAT. BREAK DOWN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELCHER- WE'LL BE
LOOKING TO RETAIN ELEVEN POINT
THREE FOR REGISTRY- COSTS AND
TWENTY NINE POINT SIX MILLION
FOR TO COVER STARTING WAGES OF
OUR EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH
STAFF. TIED TO OUR SEVEN DAY.
OKAY. IT IS NEWMAN NORMAL THE
PARK- ALL I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT I DIDN'T EVEN CALL
ON PM. WELCOME SENATOR HOW ARE
YOU. I'M SORRY OKAY I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE ON WILL
WELCOME YES GO AHEAD SAID IT
CONTAINS LISTENING I'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING I GUESS OUR- IN
THAT SENSE OKAY WELCOME TO THE
GREAT GREAT JOB- ALL THE WAS
QUESTION AND ANSWER I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION- IT IS REALLY JUST
A PROCESS QUESTION UNITS I HOPE
IT DOESN'T SEEMS SLIGHTLY OFF
TOPIC BUT IN TERMS OF THE
HEARINGS THIS IS PERFORMANCE
SHAVER IN TERMS OF THE HEARINGS
THEMSELVES- WHAT IS THE LEVEL
OF- CONFIDENTIALITY OF THOSE
HEARINGS ARE RECENTLY- EARNED.
WAS WATCHING A DOCUMENTARY
WHERE THERE WAS ACTUALLY A- YOU
KNOW CAMERA FOOTAGE OF THE
INSIDE OF THE HEARING IT IN A
MAYBE. THE CARD KIND OF
PROMPTED ME TO THINK COULD A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
EXAMPLE SIT IN ON A- OR PRO
HEARING OR OR IS THAT A CASE BY
CASE WORKER MR. AN ARRANGEMENT.
SO WE VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ARE WE VERY MUCH
LIKE TO HAVE PEOPLE COME AND
OBSERVE THE PRO HEARING PROCESS
ARE WE ROUTINELY APPROVED FOR-
OBSERVERS SO LONG AS THEY HAVE
NO CONNECTION TO THE CASE. SO
OUR PEOPLE NOW OBSERVE- BY
VIDEO- PREVIOUSLY THEY USED TO
OBSERVE IN HEARING BUT NOW IT
OUR HEARINGS ARE BEING
CONDUCTED BY VIDEO PEOPLE
CANNOT SURVIVE VIDEO STE. SO IN
OTHER WORDS OTHERS IN THE
PROJECT ON ITS OWN LIKE VICTIMS
OR- PEOPLE WITH CONNECTIONS TO
THE CASE UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES- ABOUT THAT- I
I'M JUST UNDERSTAND YOUR
ANSWERS TO. A MEMBER OF THE
STATE SENATE LIKE MYSELF THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD BE CONSIDERED
EIGHTY WHEN INTERESTED PARTY
BUT- JUST A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
OBSERVING. A PARTICULAR
HEARINGS RIGHT. ABSOLUTELY I'M
FOR AS THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PROCESS REALLY REQUIRES A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
SO WE DO WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
OBSERVE HEARING SO LONG AS THEY
HAVE NO INTEREST IN THE OUTCOME
AND THEY DO NOT KNOW- ANY OTHER
PERSONS THERE. AND YOU'RE
CORRECT- APART FROM NEUTRAL
OBSERVERS WE DO HAVE OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE. HAVE A STATUTORY RIGHT
TO BE THERE AS WELL. IT THANK
YOU FOR MUCH DEMAND COME. THANK
YOU ADVENTURE THANK YOU AS WELL
AND- I'M SORRY IT WAS A LITTLE
LATE TODAY THERE WAS A- ANOTHER
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENTAL DUTY THAT
I HAD THIS HAPPEN SOMETIMES
WITH THE WITH COMMITTEE TIMING
SO I'M GLAD TO BE HERE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
GLAD YOU JOINED- I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION- RIGHT NOW WE DON'T.
WE'RE NOT GETTING THE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE STATE
COULD IMPROVE ITS GRANT RATES
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT- WHETHER
IT'S THE ENTRANCE INTENT IS TO
ADDRESS THE BACKLOG INCREASED
GRANT RATES OR BOTH OR NONE. SO
CURRENTLY THE PROPOSAL IS-
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO SCHEDULE AND
CONDUCT ALL REQUIRED HEARINGS.
AS FAR AS PURPOSE WE-
ATTEMPTING TO INCREASE THE
GRANT GRANTS. I'M CURRENTLY OUR
STANDARD IS WHETHER OR NOT THE
PERSON OPPOSES A CURRENT AND
RESOURCE TO PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
WE USE EVIDENCE BASED-
PROCESSES FOR THAT AND WE- WE
USE A STRUCTURED DECISION
MAKING FRAMEWORK TO ARRIVE AT
THAT CONCLUSION. AND THERE IS
THERE ARE A LOT OF VARIABLES
THAT GO INTO. PSYCHOLOGISTS
THINK TRY. MY VIDEO STOPPED.
STE STE. CAN YOU STILL HEAR ME
YES. OKAY I APOLOGIZE MY I
THINK MY VIDEO WILL GO BACK ON
IN JUST A MOMENT SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT. THERE WE GO. I'M D.
CONCERN IS REALLY HOW THEY'RE
TWO DIFFERENT WAYS I SUPPOSE OF
INCREASING GRANTS- ONE IS TO
CHANGE THE STANDARD- BY WHICH
WE DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEBODY
IS A CURRENT AND RESOURCE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY HOWEVER I WOULD
CAUTION THAT- BUT DIRECT
RESPONSE TO THAT WOULD LIKELY
BE AN INCREASING RECIDIVISM
RATES. THE OTHER WAY OF. I HAVE
TRYING TO INCREASE GRANT RATES
WOULD BE TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS TO EXPAND- THE
COGNITIVE BASED INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
PROGRAMS FOR REHABILITATION- TO
AS MANY PARTICIPANTS ARE AS
MANY PERSONS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AS POSSIBLE. I
HOPE THAT HELPS ANSWER THE
QUESTION. IT YES IT CLARIFIES
IT- IT WAS MENTIONED I GUESS IT
WAS EARLIER TODAY THAT THE
RESPONSE FROM JUDGES. OF. THE
NOTICES THAT WERE SENT OUT THE
JUDGES AND THE RESPONSE WAS
LIKE TWO HUNDRED IS THAT. TWO
HUNDRED OUT OF THE ORDINARY
BELIEVE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE THOUSAND. DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA WHY THAT IS OR- WHAT CAN
BE DONE THAT. SO A COUPLE OF
THINGS ON THAT YES ONE IS. YOU
KNOW WHEN THESE LAWS WERE
WRITTEN- I'M JUST GUESSING
THAT- TERMS OF INCARCERATION
WERE MUCH SHORTER. SO
CURRENTLY- THE MINIMUM AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT SOMEBODY HAS TO
SERVE PRIOR ON AVERAGE- PRIOR
TO BEING ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE
SUITABILITY HEARING IS FIFTEEN
YEARS. SO THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
JUDGE WHO WAS SITTING AT
SENTENCING TO STILL BE ON THE
BENCH I AM FIFTEEN YEARS LATER
OR UPWARDS OF SOMETIMES TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THIRTY YEARS
IS VERY UNLIKELY. SO I THINK
THAT THAT HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
SHIFTED SINCE THE LAW WAS PUT
INTO A INTO A FACT THE OTHER
THING IS THAT- OUT YOU KNOW
THAT A LOT OF CASES THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF CASES
ARE RESOLVED BY JURY ARE- BY
PLEA AGREEMENT. SO INFORMATION
THAT IS GAINED AT SENTENCING-
MAY NOT BE REALLY ANYTHING
MORE- MORE EXTENSIVE THAN WHAT
WE GET FROM A PROBATION
OFFICER'S REPORT OR THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPORTS OR- THE
FRANKLIN HEARING I DOCUMENTS IT
RECEIVES FOR USE OF FIVE OR SO
A LOT OF THE INFORMATION IS
DUPLICATIVE. OF WHAT WE RECEIVE
ANYWAY AND THEN LAST- ONE THING
THAT HAS CHANGED IS OUR LEGAL
STANDARD- PREVIOUSLY IT WAS
PERMISSIBLE TO THE BOARD NOT
TALKING A COUPLE DECADES AGO IT
WAS PERMISSIBLE FOR THE BOARD
TO DENY SOMEBODY POLL BASED ON
THE SEVERITY OF THEIR OFFENSE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE UNDER THAT PARA
DYING THAT THE SEVERITY FACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SEVERITY OF
THE OFFENSE WOULD BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT FOR THE BOARD TO
CONSIDER. NOW IN THE WAKE OF
SIGNIFICANT- LET LET JUST
MEDICATION AND SOME
LEGISLATION- OUR STANDARD IS
WHETHER THE PERSON POSES A
CURRENT AND REGIONAL RISK TODAY
AND SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT IS WHO IS THE PERSON
TODAY YES WHO WERE THEY WERE.
BACK THEN BUT WHO ARE THEY
TODAY AND HOW THEY CHANGED. AND
SO THE- OF OUR HERE HAS ALL
CHIU SIGNIFICANTLY SO I'M NOT-
AT I DON'T MEAN TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE JUDICIARY
OR ANYBODY WHO MIGHT HAVE
GOVERNED THE SENTENCING
HEARING- TWO DECADES AGO. BUT
CHANCES ARE THE FOCUS OF OUR
HEARING IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
INFORMATION THAT A JUDGE WOULD
HAVE FROM TWENTY YEARS PRIOR I
HOPE THAT MAKES SENSE YES.
CERTAINLY OKAY- SENATOR NEWMAN
YOU HAD. I THANK YES MA'AM SURE
I ITEM QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY
AROUND TIME I THINK IT'S ITEM
ELEVEN- MAYBE IT OVERLAPS WITH
I'M SIXTEEN WHICH IS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE- THE
HEAD COUNT FOR THE P. I. P.
SECTION OF THE B. C. P. AND SO
I GUESS MY QUESTIONS PROBABLY
STARTING WITH MISTER SWANSON I
THINK- AND SPECIFICALLY. AS YOU
LOOK THROUGH THE B. C. P.
EITHER THERE THERE ARE SOME
SLIGHT CHANGES IN HEAD COUNT-
YOU KNOW MOSTLY MINOR BUT WHEN
YOU GET TO THE PSYCH TECH
SECTION- THERE'S A VERY LARGE
DECREASE IN HEADCOUNT FOR FOUR
OH FIVE TWO TWO HUNDRED TEN. SO
IF YOU COULD GIVE US LIFTED
LITTLE INSIGHT AS TO WHY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. OKAY WHEN. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS DOING READER
AGAIN DEBBIE DIRECTOR- YOU KNOW
THE SHIFTING AND RESOURCES
FROM- PSYCH TECHS. AFTER
MARKERS- TO THE BASELINE
OPERATIONS OUT THERE. ONE OF
THE THINGS- THAT WAS ADDED INTO
C. H. YOU HAVE WAS- SOME
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS TO
TAKE ON SOME OF THAT WORK LOAD-
THEY ALSO HAD- SOME PEACH SHE'S
DOING SOME ESCORT WORK- WHICH
WE'VE REPLACED WITH CUSTODY
OFFICERS- WHICH IS MORE
APPROPRIATE. AND WE'VE ALSO
ENHANCED OUR IN STAFFING SO
WE'VE INCREASED- THE R. ENDS
OUT THERE AS WELL- BUT
BASICALLY IT COMES DOWN. TO THE
MODELING AND THEN WORKING WITH
THE INSTITUTION- TO DETERMINE.
WHAT WOULD BEST SUIT THEIR
NEEDS- AND MEET THEIR PATIENT
NEEDS- FOR THAT POPULATION- WE
REALIZE THAT IT IS. A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION- BUT
WE'VE COUNTERED THAT WITH-
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS IN OTHER
CLASSIFICATIONS- THAT ARE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR SOME OF THAT
WORKLOAD. SHOWS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THESE ARE
SUBJECTS THAT ARE ALL THE
REPRESENTED THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. I AND. THAT DURING
THE- YEAH THEY THEY KNOW WORK
WITH WORKING OVERTIME EVEN AS
THEY TOOK PERCENT PAY CUTS. SO
THIS SEEMS LIKE A EXT. SHE FROM
THE POINT OF VIEW OF THAT- TO
ALMOST WRITTEN REDUCE IT BY
HALF- INITIAL EIGHT EMPLOYED BY
THE LOT WHERE THE WHERE THOSE
POSITIONS LOCATED. BOTH THE
BALL OF THOSE POSITIONS LOCATED
EACH YEAR INSP. AT THE HEALTH
FACILITY. AND SO. MANY IF
PRINCE THERE. BUT WE CAN THE
WORK WAS NEW DURING THE PANTO-
AGAIN SEEMS REALLY DRASTIC TO
REDO THAT WORK BY. AND SO- I
MEAN I GUESS YOU'VE COME. ON IT
ALREADY BUT I HAVE SHOULD HERE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE. SERVE
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
CREATE A I'D I'D BE GRATEFUL
BUT- THIS STAND OUT TO ME IS SO.
THAT A- READ SEVERE VILLE AS- A
SHARE OF YOUR- THAT WAS.
PROBABLY NOT EXPECTING AND
ISN'T IN I GUESS WOULD ASK YOU.
ARE THERE TO RE. ANY OF THOSE
TECH TO OTHER FISH. ARE YOU
SIMPLY PUT ON LIMITING THOSE.
OF COURSE NOT- WILL THROUGH A-
TO VOLUNTARY TRANSFER IS YOU
KNOW I'M FINE HOMES FOR STAFF.
AS AS MUCH AS- AND- WE WILL
WILL BE MORE- WITH INSTITUTE TO
WORK THROUGH THAT CHANGE. IT
WON'T BE- THERE'S PROCESS THAT
WE GO WITH THE YOU. AND- KELLY-
TO ADDRESS THOSE THOSE SHOULD
AND REESE. AND APPRECIATE SO.
SURE I'D I'D LIKE LITTLE MORE
INTO INTO THAT IF YOU. OF THIS
BUT BE SHE- THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU. NO I THANK YOU FOR
REYES THE ISSUE- CENTER-
BECAUSE- IT'S NOT ALL FIRST AND
FOREMOST IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO
HOLD. NOW BUT IT'S ALL. THE
ELEMENT OF BILLS POSITIONS- YOU
KNOW AND THE PEOPLE TAKE THEM
THEN. DON'T HAVE THIS TO. THAT
THE PRIOR- EMPLOYEES DID. THANK
YOU FOR RAISING THAT- I JUST
WANNA- JUST MAKE A I INTO OF
GOING BACK TO THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND OF THE THAT. WERE
IMPACTED. BY OF THE NUMBER OF
CLOSURES- WE'RE GOING BACK AND
FORTH ON THIS- ISSUE WHETHER OR
NOT WE SHOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION WATER THAN NOT WE
COULD GET THE INFORMATION. BUT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOTTA BE SOME
PLANNING PROCESS SOMEWHERE
THAT'S TAKING PLACE WITH
REGARDS TO OUR FUTURE CLOSURES
OF PRISONS- AND NOW PUTTING US
IN A POSITION OF HAVING TO
AGREE. TO CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS AND- OFF AND OTHER
THINGS LIKE THE CAMERAS WHERE
DO YOU PUT THOSE- WE'VE GOTTA
COME TO SOMETHING HERE THAT
MAKES SENSE THAT. ALLOWS FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY BUT- WE ALSO
NEED TO KNOW AS LEGISLATORS SO
THAT WECAN MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS POSSIBLE AND NOT I
REMEMBER HEARING THIS AND ARE
VERY FOR. IT WAS OUR VERY FIRST
HEARING A WITH THIS CAME UP AND
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS A PLAN WHERE DO WE
SEE OURSELVES GOING SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS- A
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS.
AS TO HOW TO SPEND OUR- OUR
DOLLARS ARE PUBLIC DOLLARS- I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A- NEED
FOR A FINAL COMMENT BUT I
REALLY FEEL IT KEEPS COMING UP
IT KEEPS COMING UP. AND WE KEEP
GETTING PUSHED BACK THAT- IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE TO DO THAT- MOSTLY
COMING FROM I THINK DEPARTMENT.
OF FINANCE. ANYBODY FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ONE
INSTEAD DRESS THAT. SENATOR LET
ME START OFF FOR A C. D. C.
ARE. JUST THAT ARE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF AND
ASSEMBLY STAFF ON- ARE COMING
UP WITH A- A LANGUAGE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN LIVE WITH IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS OF HOW WE-
IDENTIFY PRISONS FOR CLOSURE
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT THAT BUT
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE TAKING
PLACE- WE DO- LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES ALL THE TIME AND WE MAKE
SURE. PART OF I COULDN'T TURN
IT OVER TO CHRIS LEAVEA LITTLE
BIT TO TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS BUT
CERTAINLY WE ARE PUTTING FORTH
PROJECTS THAT ARE. MOST
IMPORTANT FOR- FOR PRISONS IN
YOU KNOW JUST TO MEET THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
INMATES ABOUT THE STAFF IN
GENERAL RIGHT. AND I AM ARE YOU
APPRECIATE THAT I UNDERSTAND
MAYBE THINGS GET SO BAD BEFORE
WE FINALLY DO THE WHARTON'S
MORE IN FEES CAPITAL OUTLAYS-
PROJECTS BY COURT ORDER. THE
CARD BY COURT ORDER. OR IS THAT
IS THAT CORRECT IMPROVE.
FRIEDMAN ROBIN FIRST OF F. OF
THE FOUR MAJOR REVISION
PROPOSAL THAT THEY THINK AND
THAT MADE. ARE COURT RELATED TO
COURT. AND ALSO THE- SEE H. C.
A. ONE RELATED SUPPORT OR- IT'S
REALLY TO A THAT CAME OUT IN
JANUARY. YEAH I MEAN I WANT TO
GET TO THE POINT WHERE IT.
COURT ORDERS UNDER. BUT THE-
THAT'S THE- OF SIT. WEEK
GETTING. A PUSHED IN. OUR JUST
WANNA. GO BACK- MISS SHAVE-
YOU'RE- SOMETHING IN ABOUT- THE
HEARING. AND THAT OF. IN THE
GRANT RAY WOULD LEAD TO
INCREASED OF. COULD YOU EXPLAIN
THAT SOME WHITE WHY DO BELIEVE
THAT. WELL CURRENTLY- YOU KNOW
WE- THERE'S NO OF TESTING-
REALLY TO RATE WOULD BE OF
PEOPLE WHO WORK ON COURSE WHO
WERE PREVIOUSLY CANNOT RIGHT
YOU HAVE TAX REALLY FOLKS TO
SEE WHAT THEY WERE RATES- WOULD
BE. AND SO IN I THE MARQUEE YOU
REALLY THE MORE OPPORTUNITY YOU
HAVE FOR INCREASE AND
RECIDIVISM RATES ARE CURRENT
RECIDIVISM RATE USING THE
STANDARD THAT WE USE NOW IS AS
I SAID GENERAL RECIDIVISM IT'S-
TWO TO FIVE. OR PERSONS RE-
HAVE A NEW CAN WITHIN THREE
YEARS AND WHICH LESS THAN 1%
HAVE A NEW CONVICTION FOR A-
WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
VIOLIN THE FLUTE AS AN
OFFENSIVE- ANOTHER PERSON. SO
THE RECIDIVISM RATES ARE VERY
LOW- YOU CAN EXPECT THAT IF WE-
IF WE INCREASED OR I SHOULD SAY
LOWERED- THE STANDARD FOR WHO
GETS RELEASED AND- IT WOULD
POTENTIALLY AND LIKELY. RESULT
IN AN INCREASE IN RECIDIVISM
RATES. IN STORE CLEAN WHAT WE
FIND FROM OTHER JURISDICTIONS
IS THAT- AND IT'S A IT'S A
POLICY. WHEN YOU HAVE SOME WHO
CAN OF VERY SERIOUS CRIME SUCH
AS MURDER AND RAPE MAN'S. THERE
TENDS TO BE VERY LOW TO. FOR RE.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE SERVING A
TERM THAT CANNING. OR DID THE
SENTENCE INCLUDED. NOTE TWENTY
FIVE YEARS TO LIFE AND SO IF
SOMEBODY'S RELEASED- PRIOR TO
THE END OF THEIR LIFE AND THEY
GO OUT AND DO SOMETHING- A
VIOLENT- TOWARD SOMEBODY AGAIN.
HISTORICALLY THERE'S BEEN
LITTLE TOO FOR THAT AND SO I
GUESS THE QUESTION FOR
POLICYMAKERS IS REALLY- WHAT
LEVEL OF RECIDIVISM- IS
APPROPRIATE- FOR PERSONS WHO
ARE SENTENCED TO LIFE TERMS.
OKAY WILK. I'M NOT SURE WHEN
YOU SAY THIS- IT HELLO IN THE
STAND IS FAR STANDARD CHANGE US
MEAN THAT WE'RE IN STANDARD-
BUT I THINK IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONSIDER IT A REAL
IMPORTANT PART OF. THE PAROLE-
HEARING. WITH WHAT WE EXPECT
OUT OF- WE LOOK AT WORK FLOW
WHAT WE OUT OF THEM AND- WE
GOING THE MOST AND EXPECTS THAT
ARE- IT WILL NOT BE A BIT ODD
TO DO. AS YOU SAID- LET'S HAS
LAWS OF CONSIDERING OF FROM
SEVERAL AGO AND PART OF THAT IS
BIG OF WE BELIEVE MANY OF US
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEBODY TO BE
RELEASED AND HAVE CHANGED THEIR
LIVES SO- I GUESS. YOU KNOW USE
TERMS LIKE LOW THE STE THE STAN.
AND RECIDIVISM WILL INCREASE IF
YOU HAVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING WITH US.
I WELL WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
SUBSET OF PERSONS WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEASED AS A RESULT OF A
DETERMINEDLY SENTENCED THEY
WERE DETERMINEDLY SENTENCE BUT
THEY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PAROLE CONSIDERATION HEARING.
AND WE'RE JUST NOW GATHERING
THE DATA ON THEIR RECIDIVISM
THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED PAROLE
AND SUBSEQUENTLY RELEASED AS A
RESULT OF THE DETERMINANT TERM
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME- WE MAY
ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY-
TO COMPARE- THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FOLKS WHO ARE APPROVED
FOR RELEASE. AND THEIR
RECIDIVISM RATES AND THE FOLKS
THAT WERE DENIED A RELEASE BUT
IT'S VERY PRELIMINARY. ARE AS
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENTS
RECIDIVISM IS BASED ON THREE
YEARS OF FOLLOW UP AFTER
RELEASE AND THE LAWS GOVERNING
PROEHL DISK RUSSIAN AREA
DECISION. ARE PRO FOR DETERMINE
SENT PURSE DO NOT GOING TO US
INTEL- REALLY TWENTY. IS WHEN
THEY FOR STARTED REALLY SO THEY
A VERY VERY NUMBER. BUT I THINK
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE WILL HAVE
THAT SORT OF COMPARISON
AVAILABLE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME. THIRTY CENTER
COURT. THE QUESTION- OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SWANSON
THANK YOU- FOR SPIN A LONG TIME
BUT I THINK IT WELL WORTH ALL
OF OUR THE PRESENT THAT YOU
MADE AS AS A AND OUR QUESTION
THANK YOU- WE GO NOW TO ISSUE
SAID. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
YOUR A PRESENT. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR- IN MEMBER OF THE- NAME
IS ASHER HART- BUT OFFICE AT ME
TO OF JUST- THE MAY REVISED BY
INCLUDES TWO PROMOTE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE. WE ARE
NECESSARY TO COMMENCE THE AND-
I AS- WITH. LEGISLATIVE CELLS
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX PERTAINING TO
POLICE USE OF. AND AB TUESDAY
NINE NINE PERTAINING TO STATE.
SPECIFIC DOJ HAVE A THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN
POSITION AND POINTS THAT
MILLION INTO ONE TO TWO. AND
TWO POINT ONE MILLION ON GOING.
TO AB. FIFTEEN OH SIX TO EIGHT
A BOARD INVESTED TEAM AND TO
SUPPORT NOT. AND LEGAL SUPPORT
WERE TO A AND SHOOTING.
INVOLVING THE DEATH OF THE
UNARMED. CURRENTLY THERE BASED
RESEARCH OF THE- THIRTEEN
MILLION IN IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
WHICH REFLECT THE INITIAL
RESOURCES NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THREE AND GUESTS INVESTIGATIVE
TEAMS. THE RESOURCES REQUEST IN
THIS ME REVISED PROPOSAL ARE
REQUIRED IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RESOURCES AND
WILL BRING DOJ CLOSER TO ITS
GOAL OF SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTING THIS NEW PROGRAM.
THESE RESOURCES WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO BETTER ADDRESS
THE CRITICAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION WHICH
HISTORICALLY SEES SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
INCIDENTS THAN OTHER REGIONS
STATEWIDE. AND WILL ALSO ALLOW
DOJ TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
VICTIM SUPPORT AS MANDATED BY
MARSY'S LAW. SECONDLY DOJ HAS
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR SEVEN
POSITIONS AND NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
INCREASING TO TWO POINT NINE
MILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND DECREASING TO NINE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND I'M
GOING TO COMMENCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS
ASSOCIATED WITH EIGHTY TWO SIX
NINE NINE. PERTAINING TO THE
TRANSFER OF UNSAFE HANDGUNS.
THE REQUESTED RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL TO INFORMING THIS BILL
AND WILL SUPPORT THE NECESSARY
I. T. CONSULTANT SERVICES AND
STOPPING TO BEGIN THE REQUIRED
FIREARM OWNER NOTIFICATIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS RELATED TO
THE NEWLY ADDED TRANSFER
PROHIBITION EXEMPTIONS AND
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS.
BECAUSE DOJ I. T. SYSTEMS DO
NOT CURRENTLY CAPTURE THE DATA
NECESSARY TO VALIDATE THE
COMPLETENESS OF UNSAFE HANDGUN
TRANSACTION INFORMATION THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL ALLOW
DOJ TO AUDIT APPROXIMATELY 10%
OF FIRE ARMS DEALERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ANNUALLY.
AND TO WORK TOWARD THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN AUTOMATED
SYSTEM TO NOTIFY OWNERS OF
UNSAFE HANDGUNS OF THE
APPLICABLES TRANSFER
RESTRICTIONS. DOJ'S COMMITTED
TO THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SAFETY BILLS
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT IN
ESTABLISHING THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THESE NEW
WORKLOADS. I WITH THAT WE ALSO
HAVE EXPERTS FROM OUR BUREAU
FIREARMS CRIMINAL LAW DIVISION
IN CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
INFORMATION SERVICES DIVISION
HERE TO ASSIST WITH ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
ON THESE EFFORTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BONTA DOES L. AWAY
HAVE ANY. L. A. O. SORRY. HELLO
LEO HOW ANY- COME. THE UP.
SORRY THE. I AM I NEED ONLY THE
LARGEST GALA OFFICE- WE HAVE A
CALL COME FROM BOTH OF THESE I-
THERE BOTH BRIEF- ON ISSUE OF
RELATED TO THE USE OF FOR- WE
WOULDN'T AND REVISION ALSO
BUDGET PHONE LANGUAGE AUTHOR
THE IF I TO MORE FUN IF YEARS
J. W. NEED FOR JUST RESOURCE.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING BRIDGE THE
LANGUAGE AS IT ON CURRENTLY OUT
IN ITEM NINETY FORTY THE ANNUAL
ALREADY FOR STATE TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FOR ON INTO. BUT NOT
EXPENSES SO THIS OF WOULD ALLOW
THE LETTER TO MONITOR THE OF
THE NEW PROGRAM AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER STATUTORY
CHANGES ARE POTENTIALLY NEEDED
SUCH AS TO ADJUST THE PROGRAM
SIZE OR SCOPE ON THE SECOND
ITEM WE RECOMMEND MODIFYING.
THE PROPOSAL'S. AND OF THE COST.
TO THE DEALERS WERE OF C.
SPECIAL ALSO KNOWN AS- AT THE
ALLEGED. SPECIFICALLY AMENDED
STATE LAW TO ALLOW FIRST KERR
AND- TO BE BY. A FEW REVENUE.
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU AND OF
FINE. HI KEVIN CLARK WITH THE
BERMAN FINANCE- RESPONSE TO THE
L. A. ALWAYS COMMENTS RELATED
YOU AB YOU KNOW SIX BRIDGES
LANGUAGE IS NOT A FEW CONCERN
THAT AFTER- WITH THE APPROACH.
OF THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY
MONTHS PROCESS- REALLY REQUIRE
IS COME FIRST SERVE BASIS ON A
PERSONAL SIR BATES THAT MEANS
THAT. THE OJ IS NOT GUARANTEED
TO THEIR COVERED BY THIS WILL
FUNDING. AND IT'S JUST NOT A
SURE FIRE MACINNES FOR OUR-
FUNDING. SO THERE'S- GIVE THE-
IN SENSITIVITY OF AB NICE THIS.
THE NINETY FOUR PROCESS IS
REALLY COST THAT ARE GOING TO.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT IT
APPEARS UP THE GLOBAL IN THIS
CASE. IN WE DO A KNOWLEDGE THE
BOSTON OF CERTAIN TIMES FUTURE.
AND ULTIMATELY WE DO BELIEVE
WE'RE- THE NEW YORK AMOUNT OF
FOR DEALERS TO IMPLEMENT. YOU
KNOW SAY- THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
CAN BE ON A- AND IT'S LEFT TO
BE SHERMAN DID NOT OF WORK
THAT'S TRACKS. DOJ AGAINST.
WIRED'S YOU SUBMIT YOUR
JUDGMENTS AND THE JOINTS
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WOULD BE. HAVE OPPORTUNITY
REVIEW MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
REALLY THERE'S COLLABORATION
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS
AKINS THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
BROOCH. ON THE RESPONSE FROM
COMMENTS FROM LA- ON USING A
MODIFIED PROPOSAL TO SHIFT A
PORTION OF COSTS ARE FACTORED
ROAST SPECIAL ACCOUNTS WERE IN
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE
IMPLEMENTATION. YOU CAN BE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
WITH L. A. R. THE DEPARTMENT-
ASSASSIN MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT RECOMMENDATIONS. OKAY.
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT I JUST HAVE ONE
YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED IF I JUST
WANT MAKE SURE- THE ASK IS FOR-
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUT THE-
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS SITES
COST IN THE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS- AND IT ALSO THE
ANALYSIS ALSO CITED SPECIAL
FUND. AS A POTENTIAL SOURCE OF
COULD YU RESPOND TO THAT
THAT'S WITH REGARDS. TO TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE. MADAM CHAIR
THAT SAYS ACTUALLY HARPER DOJ
AGAIN- IN TERMS OF YOUR
QUESTION REGARDING TWO SIX NINE
NINE AND THE- INITIAL
APPROPRIATIONS ANNOUNCES THAT
SITES COSTS AND THE THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS- WE WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT- THE FLOOR ANALYSIS
WAS BASED ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS- THAT
WAS- DONE ON. AT A POINT IN
TIME OF THE BILLS- LANGUAGE-
THE LANGUAGE CONTEMPLATING A
NEW DATABASE WAS NOT AMENDED
INTO THE BILL UNTIL AUGUST
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY AND THE
RELEVANT APPROPRIATIONS
ANALYSIS BUT- I BELIEVE YOU MAY
BE REFERRING TO HERE IS DATED
PRIOR TO THOSE AMENDMENTS
APPEARING IN PRINT- THE BILL
WAS NOT MADE EXPLICITLY
RETROACTIVE UNTIL AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY- WHICH WAS
AFTER THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING WAS HELD. ON AUGUST
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY- BASED
ON THIS TIMELINE DOJ- HAD ONLY
TEN DAYS WITH SUBSTANTIAL
UNRESOLVED QUESTIONS- AND DID
NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
REPORT FISCAL PRIOR TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT ANALYSIS
DEADLINE A FOR THE BILL'S
HEARING ON AUGUST TWENTIETH- AS
A RESULT WE COMPLETEDTHE
ANALYSIS TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION BOTH THAT AUGUST
TWENTIETH AND AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH AMENDMENTS- THE LATTER OF
WHICH CONTEMPLATED
RETROACTIVITY. I DO J.
SUBSEQUENTLY REPORTED DURING
THE ENROLLED BILL REPORT
PROCESS AND THOSE COSTS- IN
ADDITION TO A LETTER WAS SENT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE-
HIGHLIGHTING. THE CURRENT
COSTS- YEP THAT IS OUR RESPONSE
GET. OKAY AND- COULD YOU
EXPLAIN A FEW- AGAIN THE CHEN
WHY THE GENERAL FUND WAS
PROPOSED- TO IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL INSTEAD OF SPECIAL FUND.
YES WE ARE CURRENTLY DOJ'S
CURRENTLY I'M HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE L.
A. O. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M TO DISCUSS THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF DROZ- FOR
THE WORK LET'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL AND THOSE DISCUSSIONS
ARE ONGOING. AND WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ELLIE- TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT DRESS WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE UNSOURCED. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
COLLEAGUES SENATORS. CORTESE'S
CENTER COURTESY YES I THINK
MAKING SURE- I GUESS FOR MISS
HARPER IN THIS MAY BE I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE-
THAT YOU HAVESOME KIND OF A
CORD AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- THIS THIS IS NOT.
WELL JUST ISSUES QUESTION BUT-
YOU KNOW I KNOW THE- AB TWO SO
TWENTY SIX NINE NINE. MR HATTA
CATCHY HAD NINE OF. UNSAFE
FIREARMS- RELATING TO BILL
OPENS UP A GOOD BY THE WAY WAS
ADOPTED BEFORE I GOT HERE- YOU
KNOW WITH- WITH THAT REFERENCE
THAT TERM ON SAFE ARMS WHICH OF
COURSE CARRIED OVER. INTO THIS
BUDGET ANALYSIS TODAY THE BILL
JUST SAYS ON STATE FARM SAYS
DEFINED- IN A BEEN WORRIED FOR
TACTICAL PURPOSES HOW IT'S
DEFINED IN IN THERE FOR. IN
THIS EFFORT TO. CREATE OR OR
MERGE DATABASES WHAT DATABASES
WILL BE INVOLVED OR IMPLICATED
IN THAT PROCESS. LET ME JUST
SAY AYE AYE AYE AGAIN THE
GENERIC TITLE IN SIMPLER TERMS
CAN BE TAKEN FROM ONE EXTREME
TO ANOTHER AS- NO SOMEBODY WHO
GREW UP N. A RURAL
ENVIRONMENT- WE WERE ALWAYS
TARGET ALL FIREARMS ARE UNSAFE-
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO BE HANDLED
SAFELY BUT THERE IS NO SUCH
THING AS A SAFE FIREARMS AND
REALLY ASKING THIS AS A
SPECIFIC QUESTION I KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE DEFINITION BUT WHAT IS
THE DEFINITION FOR PURPOSES OF
STATUTE- FIREARMS IN THE HANDS
OF SHAMANS FOR EXAMPLE FARMS-
YOU KNOW I KINDA KNOW SOME OF
THE CATEGORIES AND- I COULD BE
IN THE DEFINITION. BUT I DON'T
ACTUALLY DEFINITION. YES
SENATOR- WE DO HAVE ALISON
MENDOZA ON THE LINE FROM OUR
BUREAU OF FIREARMS AND WHO MAY
BE ABLE TO ASSIST YOU WITH THAT
QUESTION. MENDOZA WITH THE
BUREAU OF FIREARMS. AND NEXT SO
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A ROSTER OF
NOT AND STATE HAND THEN SEND
THESE FIREARMS GO THROUGH THESE
HANDGUNS GO THROUGH A SERIES OF
TESTING BY CERTIFIED LABS. AND
THEY HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- THERE'S
CERTAIN TESTING WAS FAR AS DROP
TESTING. AND BROADCASTING FIVE
TEST AND IS- AND ARE LISTED ON
OUR ROSTER IF NOT AND YOU CAN'T
GAINES. B. AND UNSAFE HANDGUNS
AT THIS BILL REFERRING TO ARE
HAND GUNS THAT HAVE NOT GONE
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM. DOES THAT
MAKE TESTING BY THE CERTIFIED
LAB. IN HOW IS IT. THAT THE-
YOU KNOW I MEAN I'M LISTENING.
IRWIN READING THIS IN THE
PARAGRAPH HERE- IN OUR PACKETS
HOW IS IT THAT A FEDERALLY
LICENSED FIREARM DEALER. I
WOULD END UP HAVING ONE OF
THOSE FOR SALE IN THEIR STORE
IS SET. IS THAT SOME KIND OF.
IMPLICIT PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE
NOT HONORING THE STATUTE IN THE
FIRST PLACE- IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE SELLING. I'M
SURE I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE- NO WORDS WERE ACROSS THIS
IS BREAKING DOWN THE SPEED OF A
STATUTE THAT SAYS STATE. ARKET
THE HANDGUN ISN'T PROPERLY
TESTED ITS ON STATE IT SHOULD
BE SOLD- DON'T WE HAVE WHILE
ASIAN OF ALL RIGHT AT THE
MOMENT THE SOMEBODY DECIDES TO
GO AND SELL IT AND PRESUMABLY.
TO VOTE AGAIN WE'RE GOING FOR
DATABASE PURPOSES WOULD BE
THROWING LICENSE. TO YOURS IS
DISCOVERED A PROBLEM IS. THE AT
THE REQUIREMENTS CAN DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FIRE IT'S ALL
DEPENDENT ON PURCHASING THEM SO
THE ROSTER THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
NOT- OUR- OUR CLIENTS THAT CAN
BE SOLD TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
I LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS CERTAIN
EXTENSIONS THAT THEY CAN JUST
BANDS THAT ARE AT THE END
CAMPAIGNS THAT WE'RE JUST
ASKING ONE SIX NINETY NINE.
THIS IS SO YOU'RE SAYING IS
THEY COULD BE SOLD BUT ONLY TO
CERTAIN FIRES. YEAH THEY'RE
BEING SOLD TO NON PERMITTED
BUYERS UNDER THE STATUTE- THERE
NEEDS TO BE THIS ALREADY
PROCESS IN THE SORT OF DATABASE
DEVELOPMENT- TO TRACK WITH
THAT'S OCCURRING INTO INTO TO
ENFORCEMENT IT IS AT THAT LEVEL.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO RIGHT I'M
SORRY NEED TO CUT YOU OFF AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS AN AGENCY
CAN BUY DIRECTLY FROM THE
MANUFACTURER IN THOSE
TRANSACTIONS ARE NOT RECORDED
WITHIN OUR- TRUST OUR DEAL
RECORD OF SALES SYSTEM. AND
AGENCIES WOULD ENSURE THAT
INFORMATION INTO THE AUTOMATED
FIRE SYSTEM WITHIN TEN DAYS OR
STATUTES. WE HAVE NO DRONES
RECORD AT THIS TRANSACTIONS- SO
THAT THAT'S ONE AREA OF THE
AUDIT THAT WE WOULD NEED TO GO
INTO THOSE AGENCIES TO BE ABLE
TO TRY TO ACQUIRE THAT
INFORMATION. AND THERE'S ALSO-
THAT TRANSFERS THAT OCCUR
PRIVATE PARTY. TRANSFERS IN
BETWEEN THIS ALLOWS FOR CERTAIN
I OF AGENTS TO TRAIN CERTAIN
THAT'S TWO DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
AND IN THAT IN THAT DRESS ENTRY
SYSTEM WHEN THEY ARE CONNECTING
TO TRANSACTIONS WE DO CHECK FOR
CERTAIN OR THE DEALER CHECKS
FOR CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS- AND
THAT INFORMATION. IS USED TO
ALLOW CERTAIN AND THEN
TRANSACTIONS TO OCCUR THE
SYSTEM HOWEVER THAT IS NOT
ROUTINE IN THE AUTOMATED SYSTEM
SO WE DON'T HAVE THIS ABILITY
OUT. THIS TIME IT'S ONLY AT THE
TIME THAT THE TRANSACTION- AND
HOW DOES FALL OFF AND THE
ROSTER ALL THE TIMES THAT
ROSTER CHANGES IT COULD CHANGE
STATE. SO THIS LITERALLY IS
THIS. DEFINITION IF YOU WILL-
WARM THIS. IS LITERALLY A LIST
OF HARDWARE IT'S NOT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH. PERSONS
WITH CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE
CERTAIN RECORDS LIKE FELONIES
LIKE THREW THAT OUT THERE AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THIS IS
LITERALLY A LIST OF. HARDWARE
PRODUCTS BUT A WAY TO PUT IT-
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL FIREARMS
THEMSELVES WHAT WHAT'S OKAY
WHAT'S SAFE WHAT'S NOT OKAY
OKAY IN IN THE EYES OF. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INSTEAD GET
I'M JUST TRYING TO ACT OF
LISTENING SAYS ONE LONGTIME
HEARING THIS CORRECTLY. ROSTER
THAT THE DEPARTMENT MAINTAINS
IS THAT A HANDGUN THAT HAVE
GONE THROUGH THAT SAFETY
TESTING BY THE CERTIFIED LABS.
I'M BETTER FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AND MOST OF THOSE
HANDGUNS HAVE BEEN ON THE
ROSTER FOR MANY YEARS WE HAVE
ADDED. AND HE NEW AND GUNS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO MEET
CERTAIN SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED. I'M
SUCH AS THE BACKGROUND THESE
AND THE CHAMBER LOAD INDICATOR
MY BREASTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
ON THE ROSTER THAT WE MAINTAIN
IT'S REALLY. FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC NOT OR- LAMPARD'S. RIGHT
IN INTO WE DO WE AT THIS POINT
HAVE ENOUGH DATA TO HAVE ANY
IDEA- YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
INCIDENTS OF HARM. IS COMING
FROM. THE SALE OR TRANSACTION
OF THE OF THE ROSTER OF
FIREARMS FROM THIS ROSTER TO
THE GENERAL PUBLIC OR IS THAT
PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEVELOP WITH THIS DATABASE-
SOME SOME TRACKING OF. WHATEVER
WHO DROPS A GUN ON THE GROUND
AND THEN SOMEBODY GETS SHOT IT.
IS DO WE KNOW WHAT THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT PROBLEM
ACTUALLY IS IN TERMS OF
INCIDENTS. I I'M SORRY I DO NOT.
AND SHALL NOT IN THE SYSTEM
WOULD NOT TRACK. THAT ACCIDENT
THAT HAPPENED. IT WOULD BE
EIGHTY TRACKING OF- BOUGHT A
FIREARM OUT AND WE'RE JUST
WHETHER IT WAS ON THE ROSTER
NOT ON THE ROSTER SEARCH.
ENGINES ON THE TRANSFERRING
BETWEEN AGENCIES CRACKS OR WHO
HAS POSSESSION AND OWNERSHIP.
RIGHT RIGHT WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
GETTING IS YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
ONE. ACCIDENTAL DEATH FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE ONE TO
MANY OF COURSE BUT- LIKE IT OR
NOT WE'RE IN THE BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS SO WERE ONE GOING
HERE IS TO REALLY KNOW. HOW
MUCH BENEFIT WE'RE GETTING FOR
THE COST IN TERMS OF. OF
INADVERTENT OR ACCIDENTAL HARM.
ASSEMBLY THAT'S WHAT MOST OF
THE HARM IF SOMEONE WANTED TO
INTENTIONALLY HURT SOMEONE IT
WILL MATTER MUCH IT WAS A
FIREARM ON THIS LIST IN MY
OPINION OR FARM THAT'S NOT ON
THE LIST. BUT THEY HEARD
SOMEBODY WITH A HEARD SOMEBODY
WITH IT BUT- IT SOUNDS LIKE-
ACCIDENTAL DISCHARGE. YOU KNOW
OTHER UNSAFE CHARACTERISTICS IN
THE FARM THAT WE SHOULD BECAUSE
AN ACCIDENTAL DEATH IS WHAT.
FOLKS WERE AFTER WITH THE
INTENT OF THIS IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND I'M JUST TRYING TO S.
WERE LITTLE BIT DOWNSTREAM YOUR-
OUT. MISSION WE ALSO ALREADY-
OR SUGGESTING TO SOME DEGREE
THE SO THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
OF ME ASKING. NO OVERTIME. AND
SO I'M I'M JUST EXPLAINING WHY
I'M ASKING THIS QUESTION SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THE ANSWERS
RIGHT NOW BUT MAYBE SOMETHING.
FOR ME THAT I WANT TO BRING
BACK CAN. IN ASKED WE TAKE A
LOOK AT LATER ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER COURTESY- NOR
SENATOR NEWMAN WE'RE GOOD OKAY-
SO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD OPEN WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVEN- THIS IS
THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY BY THE WAY THANK YOU
EVERYONE WHO WAS JUST UP WITH
THIS- THIS IS THE- BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. ISSUES SEVEN THIS
WILL BE THE FINAL DISCUSSION
ITEM ON THE BSE SEES. MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS AND
ADJUSTMENTS I ALSO LIKE TO ASK-
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF- BE. SEE AN AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS KATIE
HOWARD I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PSEC HOPE YOU
CAN HEAR ME ALL RIGHT- I'M ALSO
HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUE RECORDED
THE BRIDGE IF THERE ARE ANY
DETAILED QUESTIONS ON THE
CALVET PROPOSAL- AND SO I
WANTED TO START I'LL JUST GIVE
A VERY BRIEF SUMMARY OF ALL
FOUR ITEMS AND THEN THERE. MAY
BE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AFTER THAT- WITH THE
CHURCH PERMISSION SO STARTING
ON THE CAL THIS ITEM- CAL THAT
THIS THE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS IN THE PSEC HAS
ADMINISTERED THIS GRANT. FOR
ABOUT THE LAST TEN YEARS THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL WOULD ADD
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM. AND THAT ONE
TIME INCREASE WILL BE SPREAD
OUT OVER THE NEXT THREE FISCAL
YEARS IN ADDITION THERE ARE TWO
OTHER PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES TO
HELP THEM IN THIS PROPOSAL
FIRST. IT INCREASES THE CAP ON
INDIVIDUAL GRANTS SO A PROJECT
COULD RECEIVE UP TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A THREE YEAR GRANT
AND THAT COMPARES TO A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE CURRENT PROGRAM AND NUMBER
TWO IT DIRECTED THE SEC TO GIVE
PREFERENCE TO PROPOSALS THAT
ADDRESS REDUCING VIOLENCE
INVOLVING YOUTHS AGED. FOURTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE- AGAIN
WHILST WILL STOP THE END FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR FURTHER DETAIL
YOU MAY WANT HERE ON THIS- THE
NEXT NIGHT THE NEXT TWO ITEMS
ON THE LIST ARE MORE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE. SO THE MAY REVISED-
INCLUDES ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
PROP FORTY SEVEN FUNDING- THEN
THAT'S ONE OF THE GRANT THAT
THE SEC ADMINISTERS AND THERE'S
A CALCULATION THAT GOES INTO
THAT AMOUNT AND- THERE IS AN
INCREASE OF. ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN ME REVISED-
D. O. F. IS BETTER EQUIPPED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THAT ONE.
ITEM THREE IS P. R. C. S. OR
POST CAN POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION AND- THERE IS A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INCREASE OF
TWENTY THREE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS THERE. AND THEN FINALLY
I JUST WANTED TO SUMMARIZE
BRIEFLY THE- ITEM FOR WHICH IS
A PROPOSAL TO DECREASE LEASE
REVENUE FINANCING AUTHORITY FOR
COUNTY JAIL CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAMS- IN THE AMOUNT OF JUST
OVER TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. AND THOSE
AMOUNTS COME FROM SEVERAL
COUNTIES AWARD RELINQUISHMENT-
AND AWARDED FUNDS FOR JAIL
CONSTRUCTION- AS YOUR AGENDA
NOTES THERE IS A SEPARATE AND
RELATED ACTION TO ALLOCATE
RESOURCES INSTEAD. TWO GRANTS
THAT WOULD EXPAND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT RESOURCES FOR
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS YOU ARE SYSTEM
INVOLVED- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE ARE FOUR SEPARATE COUNTY
JAIL FINANCING PROGRAMS SO THIS
RELINQUISHMENT PROPOSAL.
AFFECTS BOTH THE BSE C. BUDGET.
AND OF THE CDC ARE BUDGET.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY THAT YOU HAVE
AND AS I MY COLLEAGUE RECORDED
REACH IS HERE. FOR CALVET. OKAY
LET'S SEE CAN WE HAVE THE L. A-
PLEASE COMMENTS. LMAO WE DIDN'T
RAISE ANY CONCERNS ON THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU OKAY OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. JUST NAY
NEWMAN PARTMINER FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES ANYBODY
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
NONE SEE NO HANDS- WITH HOWARD
YOU DID SUCH AN EXCELLENT JOB
THANK YOU. MAYBE IT'S BEING
LAST. WELL NOT QUITE LAST YEAR
IN THE MIDDLE OF YOUR LAST IN
THE MIDDLE BUT OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE GOOD
SEEING YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY- COMMENTS- THIS IS TO HOLD
OPEN OF COURSE AND- WE'RE
MOVING ON- TO- PART B. PART.
THREE THERE WERE FOUR WEEKS AGO
YEAH OKAY- THE SMARTER WAY TO
DO IT WITH. OKAY WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO TAKE A QUICK BREAK-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I HAVE NO
PROBLEM- WILL TAKE MAX FIVE
MINUTES MAX.
OKAY. WE ARE NOW MOVING TO PART
B. WHICH WILL COVER LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES LET'S
BEGIN WITH YOUR ISSUE ONE WHICH
IS THE E. D. D. DEFERRED IN
PERSPECTIVE WORKLOADS- OF COOL
WILL PRESENT ON BEHALF OF. EDT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS JULIE STILL UP. THE LABOR
AGENCY I THINK YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES YES WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR GOOD TO SEE YOU SEE YOU
TOO CLEARLY THESE HEARINGS ARE
NOT FOR LIGHTWEIGHTS ONLY THOSE
WHO CAN. GO THE DISTANCE
ALLOWED- MADAM CHAIR I'M SO
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND YOUR LIFELONG COMMITMENT TO
WORKING PEOPLE I'VE BEEN SHAPED
BY YOUR WORK FOR DECADES AS OF
AS HAVE SO MANY OTHERS I'M
ACTUALLY GONNA GIVE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE ITEMS RELATED TO THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AGENCY LISTED IN THE AGENDA HAS
SO. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
WITH ISSUES WERE THROUGH SIX.
THESE AND ITEM LIVE UNDER CHEST
OFFICE THE GOVERNOR'S OFF OF
THIS AND I CAN DEVELOPMENT AND
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
WHICH ARE ALL PART OF A
COHESIVE VISION FOR HOW WE
RECOVER FROM THIS PANDEMIC
BETTER THAN WE ENTER. AND BUILD
AN ECONOMY THAT IS NOT ONLY
CHARACTERIZED BY GROWTH AND
PROSPERITY BUT ALSO BY EQUITY
RESILIENCE AND CARBON
NEUTRALITY WHAT WE CALL A HIGH
ROAD ECONOMY. AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE AS WELL TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ABOUT THESE ITEMS. BUT YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLE PARTNERS TO US
DURING THIS DIFFICULT YEAR A
YEAR WERE CALIFORNIA CAME
TOGETHER BUT THE STEPS THAT WE
HAD TO TAKE TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF CODED. THAT TO SAVE LIVES
HAVE REALLY- REQUIRED
COLLECTIVE SACRIFICE AND THE
SACRIFICES LIKE THE EFFECTS OF
THE PANDEMIC ITSELF WERE NOT
BORN EQUALLY. WORKERS OF COLOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS WOMEN
HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY HARD
HIT. BUSINESSES AND IN SOME
CASES ENTIRE INDUSTRIES WERE
SHUT DOWN AND WORKERS HAVE PAID
THE PRICE BOTH ON THE FRONT
LINES AND IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
LINE. WE NEED BUDGET
INVESTMENTS THAT ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES HEAD ON- TO START
WITH THE ITEM THAT YOU
MENTIONED MADAM CHAIRWOMAN I
KNOW YOU ARE WELL AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS HAVE FACED ALL OF US
NOT JUST MY TEAM AT THE LABOR
AGENCY BUT ALSO YUR STAFF.
HAVE WORKED COLLECTIVELY WITH
EDT TO ADDRESS THEM AND THIS
WORK OF COURSE IS ONGOING AND
THE PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES AND SHORTCOMINGS
THAT PRE DATED THE PANDEMIC.
WHAT WERE MADE IMPOSSIBLE TO
IGNORE BY IT. AND THIS INCLUDES
A BENEFITS SYSTEMS OF
MODERNIZATION WHAT WHAT LET LET
ME LET ME FIRST MENTION ITEM
YOU YOU YOU SAID MONTREAL MOST
IT INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR DEFERRED WORKLOAD
THIS IS WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PANDEMIC SEARCH AND
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT
WORKLOAD IN AS TIMELY A FASHION
AS IS POSSIBLE. IT ALSO
INCLUDES BILL BENEFIT SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT THAT'S GOING TO
ALLOW ET DE TO ENGAGE IN THE
PLANNING NEEDED TO BUILD A
SYSTEM THAT IS RELIABLE. AND
FLEXIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR MOMENTS
OF EXTREME CRISIS AS THIS LAST
YEAR HAS BEEN BUT ALSO FOR
WHENEVER SOMEONE NEEDS IT RIGHT
UNEMPLOYMENT IS A CRISIS FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT FACES IT
WHENEVER IT HAPPENS. AND WE
NEED A SYSTEM THAT'S BUILT ON
MODERN TECHNOLOGY AND HUMAN
CENTERED AND THIS WORK WAS PUT
ON HOLD WHILE EDIE WAS FOCUSED
ON MEETING THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND SO WE HAD
TO RELY ON THE EXISTING SYSTEM
AND WE DO NOT NOW HAVE THE
STRONG LEADERSHIP AT EDT. TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND DIRECTOR
BE ASSIGNED AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR
NASTY FARIAS ARE BOTH HERE TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. ONE OF
THE EDT ITEMS ALSO IS DIRECT
DEPOSIT I KNOW YOU ALL HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THIS TO- AND HAVE
URGED AND SUPPORTED- WE WANT TO
MOVE AWAY FROM JUST RELY ON
DEBIT CARDS. WHICH WILL ADDRESS
BOTH THE NEED TO EXPEDITE
PAYMENTS AND TO FIGHT FRAUD.
THERE'S ALSO A LINE ITEM FOR
YOU AYE NAVIGATORS AT THE
AMERICAN JOB CENTERS THIS IS
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN PEOPLE
ARE UNEMPLOYED AND LOOKING FOR
HELP THAT THERE ARE ALSO PEOPLE
ON SITE WHO CAN ASSIST IN ALL
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE
STATE- WITH NAVIGATING THE U.
I. SYSTEM. OF COURSE THESE
PROPOSALS ARE ARE. THERE'S
THINGS WE NEED RIGHT NOW
THERE'S ALSO FOUNDATIONS THAT
WE'RE BUILDING SO THAT
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THESE NEEDS
WILL LESSEN AS WE SPENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR SYSTEMS
AND REALLY- ROOT. OF REFINED
AND TRUE- THE PROCESS THAT ARE
YOU. TO DELIVER I'VE BEEN.
THERE IS ALSO TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT IT EDT
LANGUAGE ACCESS INITIATIVE.
AGAIN SOMETHING THAT YOU ALL
HAVE REYES SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART
SOMETHING WE KNOW THAT IS
NEEDED. WHICH IS ENSURING THAT-
OUR GOVERNMENT SERVICES
ESPECIALLY AGAIN SOMETHING
LIKE- LIKE EDIE AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WHICH IS
REALLY. HE IS MOST NEEDED IN
THE IN THE WORST OF TIMES- THAT
THAT IT'S ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND HAVING A MULTI
LINGUAL- MULTIPLE ACCESS AND
SERVICES ESSENTIAL TO THAT AND
THIS ALSO INCLUDES GRANTS. TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE OUR REGION EDUCATION
TO THOSE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT COMMUNITIES. THIS
BUILT ON THE VISION OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH CBO. WHO HAVE
THE TRUST OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE NEED TO SERVE IS A
REALLY KEY STRATEGY. WHAT WE
ALSO KNOW IS THAT BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. EVEN PEOPLE WHO WERE
EMPLOYED. WE'RE NOT. ENJOYING
THE QUALITY OF JOBS. THE WAGE.
HEALTH JOBS. UNION UPWARD
MOBILITY AND OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE JOB THAT WE WANT FOR OUR
CELL. FOR A LONG ONE AND FOR
ALL WERE. HELLO ECONOMY LIKE
THAT OF THE NATION HAS SEEN
GROWTH IN BOTH HIGH WAGE AND
LOW WAGE JOBS BUT A HOLLOWING
OUT OF THOSE MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
AND A DECLINING SHARE OF
WORKERS WHO RECEIVE HEALTH
BENEFITS RETIREMENT BENEFITS
THOSE IMPORTANT SOURCES OF
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND SHE
MEASURES OF JOB QUALITY. AND IN
ADDITION NOT ALL REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE FULLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC SUCCESS AND THE
VIBRANT ECONOMY. SO THE MAY
REVISION WHICH WE ALSO CALL THE
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN
PROPOSES A NEARLY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE AND JOBS
PACKAGE TO TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES BROUGHT ABOUT BY THE
PANDEMIC. BUT ALSO THAT EXISTED
BEFORE. IT RECOGNIZES THAT BAD
JOBS LOW WAGE JOBS EXPLOITATIVE
JOBS ARE AS MUCH A CHOICE AS
GOOD JOBS ARE CHOICE AND WE
HAVE A CHANCE NOW TO SHOW WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA COME DOWN ON
THAT DECISION MAKING. WE NEED
TO REBUILD OUR ECONOMY AND WE
ALSO NEED TO REVERSE A DECADES
LONG TRENDS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
OF BOTH IN LOW WAGE WORK AND
THE GROWING GAP BETWEEN THE
RICH AND THE POOR. THIS BUDGET
DOES MORE THAN TALK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES IT MAKES REAL
INVESTMENTS AND HOW WE DELIVER
AND YES THE REQUEST ARE BIG BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE THE CHALLENGES
ARE HUGE. SO THE PLAN INCLUDES
A SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FUND. WHICH WILL
ALLOW FOR BOTTOM UP PLANNING
FOR EACH REGION OF THE STATE
RECOGNIZING THAT ONE SIZE DOES
NOT FIT ALL IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE HAVE TO BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
WHAT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
GROWTH WILL LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
TO BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT JOB
CREATION. BUT WE HAVE TO ENGAGE
EMPLOYERS AND INDUSTRIES AND IN
THE LANGUAGE OF ECONOMIST WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE DEMAND
SIDE FOR LABOR. THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN ALSO INCLUDES
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET WORKERS
INTO THOSE GOOD JOBS IT
INCLUDES BUILDING BRIDGES
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
OUR WORKFORCE AGENCIES. IT'S
ABOUT TRANSFORMING OUR WORDS
OUR SYSTEM SO THAT WE'RE TRULY
PREPARING WORKERS FOR THE
QUALITY JOBS AND MEETING
EMPLOYER NEEDS AND COMBATING
THE SYSTEMIC EXCLUSION OF THOSE
WERE TOO OFTEN LEFT BEHIND EVEN
IN GOOD TIMES. AND THIS IS THE
SUPPLY SIDE FOR LABOR SO WE
CAN'T DO JUST ONE WE KNOW THAT
IF WE ARE NOT INTENTIONAL BUT
JOB CREATION ABOUT PLANNING
REGIONALLY FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND DEVELOPMENT THAT ALL THE
TRAINING IN THE WORLD WILL NOT
LIFT WORKERS OUT OF POVERTY.
AND WILL NOT MAKE REGIONAL
ECONOMY STRONG. AND WE KNOW
THAT IF WE ARE TRAINING WITH
THE NEEDS OF EMPLOYERS AND
WORKERS IN MIND AND COMMITTING
COMMITTING TO TRUE ACCESS FOR
THOSE WHO OTHERWISE WOULD BE
LEFT BEHIND WE WILL REINFORCE
ALL THE INEQUITIES. AND WE WILL
MISS OUT ON THE TALENTS AND
ABILITIES OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE PEOPLE. EACH OF THESE
TWO PIECES THE- RESIDENTS FUND
AND THE TRAINING. EACH OF THEM
HAS TWO CATEGORIES IN THE
PROPOSAL I'M JUST GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT THEM THEY'RE
DIFFERENT ISSUE ITEMS BUT I
WANNA. DEMONSTRATE HOW THEY FIT
TOGETHER BECAUSE ALL THESE FOUR
PIECES REALLY COMPLEMENT ONE
ANOTHER. SO FIRST OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FUNDING.
FOR THIS ECONOMIC IT IS CALLED
THE COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FUND. THERE WILL BE
ONE PLANNING GRANTS TO EACH OF
THE STATE'S REGION'S AGAIN AS I
SAID EARLIER RECOGNIZING THAT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BOTH
STRATEGIES WITH THE REQUIRED
BOTTOM UP PLANNING BY THOSE WHO
KNOW THE REGION'S BEST. AND CAN
ALIGN THE REGION'S STRENGTHS
AND THE NEED FOR ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
CLIMATE AND EQUITY AND ACCESS
TO GOOD JOBS ALL THOSE THINGS
NEED TO HAPPEN TOGETHER. AND TO
MAKE THIS MORE THAN JUST WORDS
AGAINST THE FUNDING BILL WILL
ALLOWTHE CREATION OF HIGH ROAD
TRANSITION COLLABORATIVE.
WORKER VOICES ARE HEARD WHAT
EMPLOYERS ARE HEARD ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE REGIONS
AND THEY WILL ANSWER THE
QUESTION HOW WE CREATE THE GOOD
JOBS OF OUR FUTURE. WHERE WILL
THE JOBS COME FROM THAT'S THE
FIRST COMPLETE THE PLANNING
COMPLEMENT OF THE RESILIENCE
FUND THE SECOND IS
IMPLEMENTATION. BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO PLANNING AFTER
PLANNING RIGHT WE NEED FUNDS
THAT WILL ALLOW IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
PLANS. SO THESE COLLABORATIVE
WILL BRING COMMITTEES TOGETHER
THROUGH INCLUSIVE PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES EMPLOYERS THAT
INCLUDES WORKERS THAT INCLUDES
INDUSTRIES IN BOTH AREAS TO PUT
AS A ROAD MAP FOR ECONOMIC
GROWTH. AND AND. AND THEN IT
WILL ALSO PUT IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THOSE PLANS THAT'S THE FIRST
BIG BUCKET THE SECOND AROUND
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ALSO HAS TWO
COMPONENTS. THE FIRST IS REALLY
JUST JOB READINESS RIGHT IT'S
THE WHO'S GONNA TAKE THESE JOBS
AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE GETS INCLUDED- AND ARE
HYDRO TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS AND
OUR HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS THOSE H. R. T. P.'S HRC
SEES. THERE WAS ORIGINALLY IN
THE BUDGET A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR- REQUEST THERE'S
NOW AN ADDITIONAL NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS ON TOP AT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION BRINGING IT
TO A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
INVESTMENTS IN THESE BOTH
INDUSTRIES AND WE KNOW WHAT
SOME OF THEM ARE RIGHT WE KNOW
THERE'S GONNA BE HOSPITALITY
TRANSPORTATION HEALTHCARE AND
MORE AND WE KNOW THAT H. O. T.
PCH OUR SPECIES WORK. THERE'S
ALSO FUNDING FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL PROVIDING
TRAINING FUNDS IN HIGH DEMAND
SECTORS THAT INCLUDE I. T.
INCLUDE ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
INCLUDE HEALTHCARE AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. AND THESE PLANS
WILL TRAIN ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WORKERS. I JUST ON ETP
SIDE- AND SO THESE ARE TRAINING
FOR GOOD JOB THEY'RE ALIGNED
WITH OTHER PARTS OF THE BUDGET
RIGHT INCLUDING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES INCLUDING HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION. INCLUDING WHAT
YOU HEARD ABOUT THIS MORNING
DISASTER RELIEF AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. AND FINALLY THE
FOURTH PIECE THE OTHER BUCKET
UNDER WORKFORCE IS INVESTMENTS
IN THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT WILL
STRENGTHEN THE LINKS BETWEEN
EDUCATION TRAINING AND
INDUSTRY. PUTTING THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ON A PATH TO
A NEW AND A BETTER FUTURE ONE
THAT IS FULLY ALIGNED WITH THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY AND TO EQUITY. AND
ON THAT ITEM THERE'S A HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
CREATE NEW AND DEEPER
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND OUR COLLEAGUES
ATTENDING COLLEGES ARE ALSO
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. BUT THESE
FUNDS COMPLEMENT THE FUNDS I
JUST MENTIONED TO THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOP
ORG AND ETP. AND IT WILL
ADDRESSES. LONGSTANDING
CRITIQUE THE AGE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM AND- DO NOT CORRELATE
TO CURRENT FUTURE. JOBS THE
LAST THING I JUST SAY IS THAT
WALL SO MUCH ABOUT THE LAST
YEAR WAS NOT FORESEEN SOME OF
THE THINGS ARE REFLECTED IN
THIS MAYBE VISION IN THIS
CALIFORNIA COMEBACK PLANS ARE
THE RESULT OF SEEDS THAT HAVE
BEEN PLANTED. BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST YEAR AS THE STATE'S
CHALLENGES EVD HAS DEMONSTRATED
WE CANNOT FIX THE LEAKY ROOF O
THE HOUSE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STORM. SO WE HAVE TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS SO THAT WE ARE. YOU
LIVING IN STRENGTH BEFORE IT
BECOMES A CRISIS AND WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUES TIM
RAINY UP. OF THE COMPANY WILL
POST ON THE BOARD AND READ HAVE
YEAR OF THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL. IN THEIR BOOK HERE TO
SO- ALL OF THIS IS ALSO BEING
DONE IN CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TAKE
WARDEN SARAH WHITE AND SARAH IS
ALSO HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT THE
FUNDS BUT THESE INVESTMENTS
BUILT ON THINGS WE KNOW WORKS
INCLUDING BRING EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES LABOR AND MANAGEMENT
TOGETHER WITH INTERMEDIARIES
WHO KNOW THE REGIONS OR THE
INDUSTRIES REALLY WELL. WE'VE
ALSO HAD WORKED THE GOVERNOR'S
FUTURE WORK COMMISSION OVER THE
LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR HENRY STERN
WHO SERVED ON THAT COMMISSION
WHO CREATED RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING LET'S END POVERTY
WORKING CALIFORNIA LET'S REJECT
THE IDEA THAT WORKERS SHOULD BE
GRATEFUL JUST TO HAVE ANY JOB
BECAUSE JOB QUALITY MATTERS AND
LETS THE FUTURE PROOF
CALIFORNIA BY A LINE OF WORK
FOR SYSTEM OUR EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS AND THE JOBS OF
THE FUTURE. AND THESE
PRINCIPLES ARE INFUSED
THROUGHOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IT IS TUE THAT SOME
OF THIS HAS NOT BEEN DONE
BEFORE BUT WE CANNOT JUST RELY
ON THE OLD WAYS OF DOING THINGS
AND CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS LED
BECAUSE WE ARE SMART ABOUT
BUILDING ON WHAT WORKS AND ALSO
UNAFRAID TO BE BOLD WHEN THE
MOMENT REQUIRES IT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT OUR CLIMATE GOALS
OPPORTUNITIES NOT JUST FOR
CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN WATER BUT A
CHANCE TO BREAK THE JOBS. THERE
HOUSING GOALS ARE NOT JUST A
WAY TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS AND
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES BUT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE GOOD JOBS
IN COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THEM
THE MOST THERE ARE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ARE NOT JUST ABOUT ALL
THE ISSUES YOU HEARD ABOUT BY
DOCTOR DEALER DO JESUS DIRECTOR
GO DID YOU THIS MORNING BUT
ALSO ABOUT CREATING GOOD JOBS
IN DISASTER RELIEF. AND ALL
THOSE OTHER. ICAL PRIORITIES
FOR THE- AND IT CARE. ARE OUR
NOT JUST A MEETING THE NEEDS
FOR CHILDCARE AND THE ELDERLY
BUT ALSO OF CARE WORKERS
THEMSELVES. WE HAVE SEEN THAT
THIS WON'T HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT
AND IT WON'T HAPPEN UNLESS WE
THINK BIG. ENGAGE INDUSTRIES
AND MAKE INVESTMENTS AND THEN
DO THE WORK TO DELIVER. SO I'M
GONNA STOP THERE AND SEE IF.
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANYTHING TO
ADD AND I KNOW YOU MAY HAVE
SPECIFIC- QUESTIONS. ON THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES. FROM WHAT I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU-
DIRECTORS WHO ARE APPRECIATE
YOU GIVING THE OVERALL- VISION
OF WHERE WE'RE GOING OR WHERE
WE WANT TO GO- AND I AGREE-
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THERE'S A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT- ARE I WANT TO
RAISE IT JUST IN GENERAL TERMS
BUT THEN WE CAN GET INTO IT
WITH THE SPECIFIC ISSUES BUT I
DO BELIEVE THERE'S ANOTHER
ELEMENT- THAT GETS LOST AND I
THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL TO OUR
SUCCESS. AND THAT IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
FOR THE USE OF ALL THESE- FUNDS
AW I'M NOT AFRAID TO THINK BIG
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE MAKE THESE VERY BIG-
INVESTMENTS THERE WERE REALLY
GOING TO GET OUT OF IT WHAT WE
ENVISION AND WHAT WE WANT TO
GET OUT OF IT- THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAPPEN UNLESS YOU HAVE
A- SPECIFIC ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES SO. WITH
US HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT- I
APPRECIATE AGAIN- YOUR
PROVIDING THAT VISION AND MAYBE
WE COULD DIG INTO- THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US
HERE TODAY- AND SO PLEASE STICK
AROUND. I'M SURE YOU'LL BE PART
OF A ANSWER IN ANY OF THE- ON
COMMITTEES QUESTIONS- SENATE
QUARTERS THE ANYTHING THAT YOU
WANT TO SAY BEFORE WE JUMP INTO
SPECIFICS. NO THANK YOU MEASURE
I'M GOOD FOR NOW OKAY. GREAT
SO- LET'S GET INTO. SENATOR
NEWMAN DID YOU WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING BROADLY BEFORE WE GET
INTO THE SPECIFIC ISSUES NO
MA'AM OKAY THANK YOU GOOD OKAY
I LET'S GET INTO THEN ISSUE ONE
OF WHICH IS THE DEFERRED IN
PERSPECTIVE WORKLOADS AND
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION OF
RESOURCES DOES ANYBODY WANT TO.
EXPLAIN THAT. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WHO ARE YOU I AM JAILED FOR
ALL THE FISCAL OFFICER FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OKAY. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING HERE TO TALK ABOUT OUR
BUDGET REQUESTS- SO AS
SECRETARY SU TOUCHED UPON THE
FIRST COMPONENT OF THIS ISSUE
IS A TO R. SEVENTY SIX POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND
REQUEST. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO TO ADDRESS WORKLOADS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INITIAL
PANDEMIC CLAIMS SURGEON
ADDITION TO SUSTAINING CURRENT
WORKLOAD DEMANDS. THE SECOND
COMPONENT OF THIS ISSUE RELATES
TO EDIE'S ABLE REVISED
SUBMISSION FOR THE U. I.
PROGRAM WHICH REDUCES FEDERAL
FUNDS IN THE U. I. PROGRAM BY
ABOUT SEVENTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. AND SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO POSITIONS TO
ALIGN WITH THE ESTIMATED
FEDERAL RESOURCES. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
REQUESTS AND I ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM HEAT ARE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. OKAY OBVIOUSLY THE EDT
AND GETTING OUR BENEFITS OUT IS
BEEN ON EVERYBODY'S MINDS-
SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC. GO WAY THAT MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOBS
OVERNIGHT- CAUSED. ENORMOUS
DISTRESS AND HARDSHIP- CAN YOU
JUST- UP- I DON'T KNOW WHO
WOULD BE FROM ADD JUST DESCRIBE
A LITTLE BIT MORE BY THESE
ABOUT THESE. A DEFERRED
WORKLOADS AND- WHAT WOULD YOU
MEAN BY BY THAT DATE DEFERRED
IN PERSPECTIVE WORKLOADS. THANK
YOU CAROL WILLIAMS- CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO THIS
REQUEST SO IT'S CALEB MENTIONED
AT THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
THE SIGNIFICANT WORKLOADS
PRIMARILY ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS WERE DEFERRED TO
MEET THE UNDERLYING MISSION OF
PAYING YOU NOT YOU KNOW PUT
THEM. ON A PLANE INSURANCE
BENEFITS- DURING THAT PASSED
THIS PAST YEAR- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR QUITE
HONESTLY AND LATE DECEMBER
EARLY JANUARY AND THEY MANDATED
THAT THESE WORKLOADS. RESULT WE
HAVE PROPOSED ENTERING A
CONTRACT TO FOR ASSISTANCE WITH
THESE WORKLOADS BECAUSE THEY
ARE DAUNTING AND I THINK YOU
HAVE SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
IN FRONT OF YOU BUT IF I COULD
JUST SPEAK TO HER BUT SHE'S
JUST ASK WHAT ARE THESE
WORKLOADS THE PROSPECTIVE WORK
THAT CALEB MENTIONED AS YOU ALL
KNOW WE DO HAVE A BACKLOG
TODAY. SO IT WOULD. IT WOULD
NOT BE APPROPRIATE IN OUR MINDS
TO NOT ASK FOR ASSISTANCE TO DO
THE WORK BEHIND US IF WE'RE NOT
CURRENT TODAY WHICH WERE NOT
SO. THIS REQUESTED DOES FACTOR
IN THE DELTA DIFFERENCE OF THE
BACKLOG THAT CONTINUES TO
OCCUR. TODAY THAT'S WHAT WE
MEAN BY PROSPECTIVE AND
RETROACTIVE BUT THE BULK OF THE
WORK HAS TO DO WITH
DETERMINATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
CONDUCT DETERMINE ONE'S
ELIGIBILITY. THERE ARE VENDORS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THAT
HAVE BEEN ASSISTING OTHER
STATES AND WE THINK THE
COMPLEMENT OF EDT CONTINUING
OUR ROBUST. MERIT STATE STAFF
HIRING THAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
WE ARE HIGH AND WE CONTINUE TO
HIRE EVERY SINGLE MONTH COUPLED
WITH OUTSIDE VENDORS SYSTEMS
WILL ALLOW US. TO RECTIFY THIS
WORKLOAD WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS
SO I'LL STOP THERE AND ALLOW
FOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OKAY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE BACK
LOG- IS IT OF- THE NUMBER THAT
OF CASES THEY JUST EXIST AND
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO GO AFTER
THEM AND THEY GO YOU KNOW THEY
DECREASE AND DECREASE OR IS IT
A LOOK AT CHANGING NUMBER OF
CASES- HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE
WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH WELL AS-
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL WEEKS TODAY'S
BACKLOG HAS TO DO WITH
PRIMARILY THE END OF- A CLAIM
IT'S BENEFIT YEAR WE'RE CLAIMS
AND AFTER TWELVE MONTHS AND
GENERALLY CLAIMANTS ARE ASKED
TO OR IF THEY NEED TO CONTINUE
THEY HAVE TO REAPPLY FOR NEW
CLIENTS WE ARE WORKING ON A
PROCESS RIGHT NOW WE HOPE TO
HAVE IT IMPLEMENTED- IN VERY
SHORT. WELL IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS SO THAT A SPECIFIC
SUBSET OF CLAIMANTS DO NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE TO REAPPLY WE CAN
LOOK AT THEIR INFORMATION WE
CAN LOOK TO SEE IF ANY WAGES-
HAVE INCURRED OR OCCURRED IN
THE PAST QUARTER AND IF NOT WE
WILL MOVE THEM FORWARD IF THEY
CONTINUE TO CERTIFY
AUTOMATICALLY IN IS TO CONTINUE
BENEFIT PAYMENTS SO BUT THIS IS
THE BULK OF THE WORK THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EXPRESS AS A
BACKLOG IN THE BACKLOG AGAIN
IT'S REFLECTED ON OUR DASHBOARD
IT'S OVER TWENTY ONE DAYS IT IS
THE WORK ET DE NEEDS. TO DO AND
IT IS IT IS GROWING. SO THAT'S
THE WORK AHEAD SO THE REQUEST
IS TO DEAL WITH. THE SLIPPAGE
IN THE CURRENT WORK AS WELL AS
ALL OF THE WORK BEHIND US THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. IT SENATOR
NEWMAN. I'VE MISSED WHIMS THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY. I
QUESTION FOR YOU WITH RESPECT
TO THE BACKLOG- IS. THE WORK
BEING DONE IS THAT TO SATISFY
THE. HI IF YOU CAN HEAR WE HAVE
LOST AUDIO FOR THE ROOM YEAH
WE'VE WAITED TO AND I'M SURE
THE SUSPENSE WAS JUST KILLING
YOU. AB SO THEY THE BAD LUCK AS
YOU WORK YOUR WAY THROUGH IT IS
ARE THERE ANY OTHER CLAIMS THAT
ARE NOT BEING PAID OR IS IT
SIMPLY MAKING SURE THAT YOU
MEET ALL THE STATURE
REQUIREMENTS. AROUND YOU KNOW
ALL THE REPORTING PAPERWORK
ASSOCIATED WITH CLAIMS THAT
THAT IS A GREAT THAT IS THE
QUESTION THE DETERMINATION
INTERVIEW THE DETERMINATION
WORKLOAD AS IT EXISTS TODAY
GOING FORWARD AS WELL AS THE
WORK THAT'S BEHIND US.
CURRENTLY DOES NOT ALLOW
CLAIMANTS TO BE PAID SO BEHIND
US THEY WERE ALL PAID SO IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE RETRO ACT.
RETROACTIVE WORKLOAD TO SEE IF
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN PAID.
PRESENTLY ONCE WE RESUMED THE
DETERMINATIONS WHICH WE RESUMED
IN JANUARY WE ARE COULDN'T-
CLAIMS ARE NOT BEING PAID. IF I
DETERMINATION INTERVIEW NEEDS
TO BE CONDUCTED. SO FORWARD.
CLAIMANTS ARE NOT BEING PAID WE
ARE LOOKING AT OPTIONS TO
ADDRESS THOSE BUT TODAY. IF
THEY'RE ABOUT. SOMETHING OCCURS
WITHIN THE CLAIM WHEN THEY'RE
CERTIFYING HOW THEY'RE
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS. AND
IT'S IT THAT. CAUSES EDT STAFF
PERSON TO HAVE TO REVIEW THAT-
QUICKLY CALL THE CLAIM OF
COURSE SCHEDULE OF FULL
DETERMINATION INTERVIEW WHILE
ALL OF THAT IS BEING CONDUCTED
OR THE CLAIMANT IS WAITING FOR
US TO CONTACT THEM. THEY'RE NOT
PRESENTLY BEING PAID- THAT'S
WITH THE SUIT THANK YOU SO WITH
RESPECT TO ENTER YOU TOUCH ON
WHICH IS WHICH IS THE- A RE
APPLICATION. A RECONFIRMATION
PLANS UP HOW BIG IS HOW BIG IS
THAT NUMBER RIGHT IT IS AS A
PERCENTAGE OF CLAIMS IT'S NOT A
HUNDRED BUT I'M SURE IT'S- NOT
A SMALL NUMBER EITHER OF CLAIMS
THAT NEED TO BE RENEWED FOR THE
FOR THE- AFTER A YEAR OF
BENEFITS. AND TO WHAT EXTENT
ARE YOU ACTUALLY WHAT'S THE
TIME FRAME RIGHT NOW BETWEEN A
BENEFITS ENDING AND THEN RE YOU
KNOW RE RE CONFIRMING
ELIGIBILITY TO BEGIN PAYING TO
GET IN THE SECOND YEAR. IT'S
HUGE. IT IS HUGE IT IS UPWARDS
OF SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
CLAIMANTS AND IT IS OUR NUMBER
ONE- WORK EFFORT TODAY. THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM AND ANY SUBJECT
MATTER STAFF OR HAVE BEEN HITS
DOWN ALL WEEK BECAUSE THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING TO SEE. ONE WE CAN MOVE
THEM FORWARD- WITHOUT HAVING TO
FILE A CLAIM- BUT IS ALSO THE
WORK EFFORT THAT WE DISCUSSED
LAST WEEK WHEN WE NOTIFIED ALL
CLAIMANTS BY TEXT OR EMAIL. TO
LET THEM KNOW THAT THEY NEED TO
FILE A CLAIM. BECAUSE MANY HAVE
BEEN SITTING IN QUEUE YOU'VE
HEARD THIS PENDING STATUS
YOU'VE HEARD IT FROM YOUR STAFF
YOU'VE HEARD IT FROM US. ON
KNOWING IF THEY'RE NOT GOING
THROUGH ALL OF THE INFORMATION
ON THERE YOU ARE ONLINE ACCOUNT
THEY WERE UNKNOWINGLY NOT-
FILING FOR NEW CLAIM WHEN IN
FACT THEY THEY NEED TO SOLICIT
TEXT MESSAGES OUT TO ALL OF
THEM NO BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY IF WE CAN MOVE
THEM FORWARD WITHOUT HAVING TO
FILE A CLAIM THEY DON'T NEED TO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THAT EFFORT ON
AND REDUCE THAT VOLUME OF-
INDIVIDUALS. WHOSE CLAIMS CLAIM
YOUR HAS COME AN EXPIRED AND
NOW THEY'RE IN THE PENDING
STATUS AND UNDER. UNDER THE
CURRENT CONDITIONS. I ASSUME
MOST CLAIMANTS ARE STILL
ELIGIBLE AFTER THEY THEY THEY
ACTUALLY MAKE THAT RE
APPLICATIONS THAT. IS THAT
GENERALLY TRUE I WOULD SAY
THAT'S GENERALLY TRUE SO IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF IT'S JUST A
BEARD YOU KNOW IT'S JUST THE
BROCCOLI THIS NURSERY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MANAGER. GREAT
THANK YOU- I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT THE- APPROXIMATELY HOW
MANY WORKERS ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED OR- TO DO THIS WORK-
CABLE IF YOU CAN CONVERT FROM
ME I'M AWARE THAT WE CONVERTED
AND THE REQUEST IS IN HOURS
WORTH OF WORK. BECAUSE WE WERE
LOOK THINKING TO LEAVE IT TO
THE VENDOR TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MANY PEOPLE THAT THEY NEED TO
BRING ON AND SUPPORT AND- BUT I
COULD JUST TAKE THE LIBERTY TO
SAY IN OUR THOUGHT PROCESS
REGARDING- CLEARLY STATE STAFF
AUGMENTATION AND OR OR VENDOR
WORK- YOU SEE THAT OUR PROPOSAL
IS FOR A VENDOR ASSISTANCE
WHILE WE DO CONTINUE TO HIRE
AND BEHIND THE VALUE STATE
STAFF. BECAUSE IT IN OUR OUR
DETERMINATION WILL BE FASTER.
FASTER IN TERMS OF TRAINING AND
FASTER IN TERMS OF- SOON AS
THEY'RE TRAINED THEY'RE ON THE
FLOOR WORKING. AND THERE'S WITH
STATES OUT THERE HAS TO BE A
RAMP UP IN CONSIDERATION FOR
THE- THE LEADS AND THE MANAGERS
THAT HAVE TO BE HIRED-
ALONGSIDE THAT THE STATE STAFF
SO I'M SORRY IF I DEVIATED FROM
THE QUESTION- MY APOLOGIES IF
YOU COULD ASK IT AGAIN. WELL
ACTUALLY THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
CORE OF WHAT I WAS LEADING UP
TO OKAY YES I THINK THERE'S OR
R. THERE IS A REAL ISSUE FOR
ME- THAT IF WE'RE GONNA AUG. A
CONTRACT OUT WELL I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S WHY I ASKED YOU IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBERS YEAH ARE WE
GOING TO CONTRACT OUT WHAT IS.
OF THE POTENTIAL OF HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE. TO DO THIS WORK AND WHY
DOES WHY DO WE HAVE TO CONTRACT
WITH THE VENDOR. TO DO- TO HIRE
PEOPLE OUT VERSES YOU CAN GET A
VENDOR TO. DO THE TRAINING YOU
CAN GET A VENDOR TO DO THE
RECRUITMENT I MEAN I I'M NOT
SURE BUT- CLEARLY THIS IS AN
ISSUE OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THE REPRESENTATION.
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE SO
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT. A
VENDOR THAT WILL BRING AND
CONTRACTED OUT WORKERS INSTEAD
OF HIRING- STATE STAFF. FULLY
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE IN YOU'RE
pI JUST REALLY WANTED TO IMPRESS
THE PARALLEL TRACK THAT WE-
ABSOLUTELY REQUIREMENTS
ABSOLUTELY INTEND TO CONTINUE
WITH OUR STATE STAFF HIRING WE
HAVE FALLEN SHORT OF OUR MOST
RECENT GOALS. IN HIRING- CASE
IN POINT IN APRIL SIX WE HAD
PLANNED TO HIRE TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX STAFF THEY WERE AT
THE- OFFICE TECHNICIAN LEVEL.
WE FOUND TWENTY EIGHT. NOT A
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT APRIL FIFTEENTH WE WERE
TARGETED TO HIRE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE OF OUR MOST
ADVANCED CLASSIFICATION THAT'S
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
REPRESENTATIVE OUR TARGET WAS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE WE HAVE
ROBUST RECRUITMENT GOING ON WE
HIRED NINETY SEVEN. TO DATE
THERE'S ONLY EIGHTY SIX THAT
REMAIN IN THAT CLASS SO YES ALL
EFFORTS WILL CONTINUE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LET UP BUT THE FACT
REMAINS THAT WE ARE FALLING
SHORT OF ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO
HIRE THE SO THIS WILL CONTINUE
IN PARALLEL WITH THE VENDORS
AND YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE
INVOLVED WITH- NATIONAL WELL
THE STATE'S COME TOGETHER WITH
THE SIMILAR ISSUES. THERE ARE
VENDORS THAT. ARE KNOWN OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT ARE
SPECIALIZED IN YOUR LINE. IN
THE OTHER STATES HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY BEEN ABLE TO BRING
THEM FORWARD PARALLEL WITH
THEIR STATE SAFF TO KNOCK DOWN
DID THIS BACKLOG WORK BUT I
HEAR YOUR CONCERNS AND THEY'RE
WELL TAKEN. OKAY WELL I'M JUST
NO I'M- HIGHLY RESPECT THE FACT
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU ALL ARE
DOING- I REALLY DO I THINK THIS
HAS BEEN AN ENORMOUS ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE ONLY USE OF TERM
UNPRECEDENTED IT'S BEYOND
UNPRECEDENTED- BUT I'M- I WOULD
NOT SUPPORT GETTING A
CONTRACTOR I'M NOT TAKE
CONTRACTED TO DO OUGHT TO BE
THE ACTUAL EMPLOYER OF THESE I
THINK YOU CAN GET AN OUTSIDE
CONTRACTOR TO HELP RECRUIT. IF
THEY HAVE THAT SPECIALTY THEY
SHOULD HELP RECRUIT THEY COULD
HELP TRAIN BUT I THINK IN TERMS
OF BEING EMPLOYEES THEY SHOULD
BE STATE EMPLOYEES- OKAY.
SENATORS ANY OTHER- QUESTIONS
ON ISSUE ONE. RUN ISSUE ONE NO.
THANK YOU MISS WILLIAMS- WITH
IS THAT. THAT IT HERE OKAY
THANK YOU MS WILLIAMS ON THIS
ONE ISSUES HERE FOR MOVING ON
NOW TO ISSUE TO WHICH IS THE U.
I. LOAN INTEREST PAYMENT. WHO
WILL TAKE THAT ON. YES MADAM
CHAIR- THIS IS CAPABLE AGAIN
WITH EDT CAME. COMPONENTS TO
THIS ISSUE- THE FIRST OF WHICH
I'LL TOUCH UPON- THE GOVERNOR'S
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES AN UPDATE
TO THE LOAN INTEREST PAYMENTS
ON THE FEDERAL LOAN THAT WAS
SECURED BACK IN TWENTY TWENTY
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE PAYING
YOUR BENEFITS- THE AMOUNT WAS
DECREASED FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ESTIMATE OF FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND. DOWN TO NOW ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION- THAT PAYMENT DOES COME
DUE IN SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR-
THE REASON FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IS PRIMARILY DUE TO
FURTHER INTEREST RELIEF
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THAT THE STATE NOW
REALLY ONLY DOES INTEREST FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR DAYS- AS
OPPOSED TO THE PRIOR ESTIMATE
WHICH IS REALLY BASED ON ABOUT
NINE MONTHS. ACCRUED INTEREST
IN ADDITION TO THAT MUCH-
BETTER- ECONOMIC CONDITION THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES IN I'M
COMPARED TO WHERE WE ARE AT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- SO
THAT'S THE FIRST COMPONENT IS
THE REDUCED INTEREST PAYMENT ON
THE SECOND COMPONENT- I'LL
ACTUALLY DEFERRED MY COLLEAGUES
AT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW ON THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDED. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE- WHICH
WAS LEVERAGING A PORTION OF OUR
BUT FUNDING TO PAY DOWN SOME OF
THE OUTSTANDING- FEDERAL YOU
AYE FINANCE. THANK YOU
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND US
SENATORS DANIELLE BRANDON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- FOR
THIS THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING ABOUT ONE BILLION AND
FEDERAL RECOVERY FUNDS TO
IMPROVE THE BALANCE OF THE
STATE'S YOU I FIND THE MAY
REVISION REFLECTS THE BALANCE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION SPENDING
THEY ARE PLAN BASED ON
MINISTRATION PRIORITIES FOR
COVERT RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
AND THAT THE AMOUNT RECEIVED
THIS COMMITMENT BALANCES THE
HISTORICAL INVESTMENT THIS MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AS WELL AS
THE NEED TO MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT
ON THE U. I. LOAN. I'M AND I.
pKNOW YOUR QUESTIONS ANSWERED
THANK YOU WITH WITH RESPECT TO
THE BALLOT SHOULD THE SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS A COMING OF
THE GREAT RECESSION WE CARRY A
BALANCE ABOUT I GUESS LESS THAN
HALF OF WHAT WE EXPECT TO HAVE
COMING OUT NOW- AND THEN THERE
WAS FINALLY FULLY REPAID- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HOW LONG WILL
IT TAKE CALIFORNIA. ASSUMING
THAT THE YOU KNOW THE LOAN
BALANCE IS PROJECTED A TWENTY
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION HOW
LONG AND HOW WILL WE BE ABLE TO
GET BACK DOWN TO ZERO AGAIN.
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE AND- WHAT
WILL IT TAKE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- SENATOR- THIS IS
CALEB MORAL WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED ALL THE DEPARTMENT
I'M SO AS AS YOU MENTIONED- YES
THE OUTSTANDING ADVANCE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WAS ABOUT
HALF OF WHAT IT CURRENTLY IS
NOW CURRENTLY ARE OUTSTANDING
ADVANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ABOUT TWENTY POINT
FIVE BILLION- THAT IS
ANTICIPATED GROW BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR TO ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
AND ACTUALLY PROJECTED TO
FURTHER GROW TO ABOUT TWENTY
SIX OR TWENTY SEVEN. BY THE
NEXT YEAR- ABSENT ANY
ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO THE
FINANCING STRUCTURE IN YOU WHY
IT WILL MORE THAN LIKELY TAKE
THE BETTER PART OF A DECADE IF
NOT LONGER TO PAY THAT OFF
REALLY THE ONLY EXISTING
MECHANISM TO PAY DOWN- THE
OUTSTANDING FEDERAL LOAN IS AS
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL AWARE AND
WHAT OCCURRED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. IS THROUGH- FOOD
CREDIT REDUCTIONS SO THE
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT TAX-
STATES THAT HAVE OUTSTANDING
ADVANCES FOR- A TO WITH THAT AT
YEAR TWO AND BEYOND- EMPLOYERS
HAVE TO START PAYING IN IN A
HIGHER INCREASE FEDERAL TAX AND
THAT GOES TO PAY DOWN THE
OUTSTANDING ADVANCE THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AS WE CURRENTLY
PROJECT THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA
OBVIOUSLY START HAPPENING. AND
THAT WILL START TO PAY DOWN
THAT LOAN ADVANCE BUT IT TAKES
A WHILE BEFORE IT STARTS TO
REALLY PICK UP AND PAY DOWN THE
LOAN ADVANCE BECAUSE IT'S ONLY
A POINT 3% INCREASE EVERY YEAR
THAT EMPLOYERS. PAY AN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL TAXES. AND
CHAU AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD IT
IN THIS COMMITTED BEFORE-
THERE'S REAL APPREHENSION ON
THE PART OF EMPLOYERS IS TO-
YOU KNOW WHAT THE BURDEN MAY BE
WHEN THAT TIME COMES SO WHAT'S
THE THINKING. OR THE PROCESS
FOR- LETTING THEM KNOW IS BORN
VANCE'S POSSIBLE OR- I GUESS
PROSPECTIVELY SOFTENING THE
BLOW IN SOMEWHERE AND IT IS
SUPPOSED TO LIKE ONE ASSESSMENT
TO BEGIN THE YEAR WHICH IS. AS
I UNDERSTAND HOW IT TYPICALLY
HAPPENS. YEAH WELL AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CENTER- SO
THAT THE FOOD TAX WHICH AGAIN
THAT'S ADMINISTERED BY THE IRS
THAT'S NOT ADMINISTERED BY-
THAT BECOMES DOING PAYABLE
JANUARY JANUARY FEBRUARY REACH
YEAR I BELIEVE- THERE ARE
NOTIFICATIONS TO EMPLOYERS THAT
GET PUT OUT BY THE IRS. AND I
ALSO BELIEVE HE PUTS ON OUR
WEBSITE- LINKS TO THE IRS- WEB
PAGES AND NOTIFICATIONS AROUND.
FOOD- SO EMPLOYERS ARE AWARE-
THEY THEY NORMALLY HAVE TO
REPORT THEIR FOOD A LIABILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. AND THEN
WHEN IT COMES TIME WHEN A STATE
IS WHAT'S CONSIDERED A CREDIT
REDUCTION STATE WHERE THEY HAVE
TO START PAYING THAT POINT 3%
ANNUALLY- THERE'S A SEPARATE
FORM THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE TO
FILE WITH THE IRS. SO THEY'RE
NOTIFIED THAT THE STATE THEY'RE
IN HAS A HIGHER FEDERAL TAX
RATE AND THEY THEN HAVE TO PAY
THAT LIKE YOU SAID IN JANUARY
FEBRUARY EACH YEAR- THE FIRST
YEAR. THEN EMPLOYERS IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE HIGHER FOOD TAX WOULD BE
FOR TAX YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WHICH BECOMES DOING PAYABLE IN
JANUARY. OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AB PREACHER THAT SO WITH
THE EXTRA. BE AND BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL- THAT
THE BUSINESSES WILL HAVE
RECOVERED SAYS THAT THIS ISN'T.
A REALLY ONEROUS- DOESN'T
REALLY OWNERS IMPACT ON
BUSINESSES THAT ARE PROBABLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW AS THEY
WORK THEIR WAY OUT OF THIS
RECESSION. THANK YOU SIR FOR
THE QUESTION I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION- I DON'T KNOW IF
I HAVE THE ANSWER TO THAT
OBVIOUSLY AS YOU STATED- I'M
NOT SURE OF MY COLLEAGUES AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO- ALL I
KNOW IS THAT'S THE CURRENT
MECHANISM. THAT EXISTS AND IS
IN IN FEDERAL LAW THAT THAT
WOULD TRIGGER- CONSIDERING
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OUTSTANDING
ADVANCE. YEAH IT JUST IT IT
STARTS TO FEEL YOU KNOW KIND OF
LIKE INSULT INJURY AT SOME
POINT WITH. THE SAME BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW SO
DEVASTATED IN A RECESSION- IT
WILL BE THEN HAS TO PAY ANOTHER
BILL- AS AS WE ARE. JUST
GETTING OUT OF IT. SO YOU KNOW
IT'S SOMETHING WE PROBABLY
SHOULD THINK ABOUT IS THE
LEGISLATURE- FOR THE FOR THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GREAT WELL WE'RE GONNA.
UP A COMMENT FROM MR ALAMO AND
THEN GO TO SENATOR CORTEZ HE-
SAID OKAY SENATOR. YES YES
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
REALLY SENATOR HER JUMPING AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHAZ ALAMO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'M GOING TO SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT- DVDS
PROPOSAL HERE RELATED TO THE U.
Y. INTEREST PAYMENT AS WELL AS
THE LARGER A. R. P. FUNDS- ONE
BILLION DOLLAR DEPOSIT- BUT
JUST A COUPLE SORT OF POINTS
FOR CONTEXT OUT REGARDING THE
DEPOSIT ITSELF.I'M REITERATE
THE PROPOSED TO DEPOSIT ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS.
THROUGH THAT EARLY PREPAYMENT
IF YOU WILL ON ON THE STATE'S
OUTSTANDING. FEDERAL YOU AYE
LOANS- THAT DEPOSIT RESPONSE TO
ABOUT 5% OF THE LOANS WE'VE
TAKEN TODAY. AND THINKING ABOUT
THE MECHANICS OF HOW THE
DEPOSIT WOULD AFFECT EITHER THE
STATE OR EMPLOYERS WITH- THE-
EMPLOYER- PAYROLL TAX REPAYMENT
PLAN THAT THAT MR CORAL JUST
WALKED THROUGH- IF WE PLACE THE
DEPOSIT NOW IS PART OF THE MANY
REVISION. IN A FACT THAT WILL
REDUCE HIGHER EMPLOYER PAYROLL
TAXES THAT THEY WOULD HAVE. IN
OF THE ROAD PERIOD- SO IN THE
CASE OF. WHAT STATES ARE TENURE
FOR. TO FULLY REPAY THE FEDERAL
LOANS- THAT WOULD BE MAY BE
REDUCED TO NINE YEARS OR BY THE
EVIL AND ABOUT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS AND I BRING UP
THIS POINT. ONLY TO CLARIFY
THAT THE DEPOSIT WOULDN'T HAVE
A AN IMMEDIATE FISCAL RELIEF
FOR BUSINESSES AND WORKERS-
HERE AS WE'RE WERE CONTINUING
TO RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC.
THE DEPOSIT WOULD- HOWEVER
SLIGHTLY REDUCE THE STATE'S
INTEREST PAYMENTS GOING FORWARD
AS MR HOLDEN CHEN THIS YEAR'S
INTEREST PAYMENT IN HIS ARE
RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT THIRTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE OF
THE WAIVERS THAT. WERE GRANTED
THROUGH VARIOUS PIECES OF
FEDERAL LEGISLATION- THAT
SUBSEQUENT YEARS INTEREST
PAYMENTS COULD BE AS LARGE AS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR- AND THIS. THE ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
DEPOSIT WILL REDUCE THOSE
SOMEWHAT GOING FORWARD OVER THE
LIFE OF A ALONG THANK YOU. AND
JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UPS RIGHT I
DO IT WITH RESPECT TO THE
INTEREST RATE IS THAT.
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE RATE OF
INFLATION OR MIGHT THAT CHANGE.
IF INFLATION WERE TO RISE.
VETERANS CHANGE ON. THIS IS-
WELL WE'LL OCCURRING. AFTER
SEPTEMBER ONE WAIVER ENDS- AT-
FEDERAL INTEREST RATE OF TWO
POINT 3% SO IT'S YOU KNOW.
HISTORICALLY LOW- IT MAKES
BORROWING TERMS MUCH MORE
FAVORABLE TO THE STATE RIGHT
NOW- BUT THOSE RATESARE TIED
TO- LOOSELY TIED TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDS RATE. AND THEREFORE IF
OVERALL INTEREST RATES WERE TO
INCREASE OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS- THE STATE'S INTEREST
PAYMENTS AS A RESULT- COULD
COULD INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY
ANNA. YEAH ALL THE SUDDEN THE
FAVORABILITY. OF THIS ONE
STRUCTURE LOOKS A LOT DIFFERENT.
THAT'S YOUR HAZARD ANYTHING- TO
MAKING A LARGE CONTRIBUTION NOW
OUT OF- THE PRESENT SURPLUS. I
WOULD DEFERRED THE QUESTION TO
THE ADMINISTRATION- OBVIOUSLY
THE REVISION PROPOSAL IS MORE
THAN ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR DEPOSIT- IT ALSO I
SHOULD ADD INCLUDES A-
STIPULATION THAT ANY LEFTOVER
RESIDUAL A. R. P. ACT. OF FUNDS
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WOULD BE USED THE SAME
PURPOSE WE HONESTLY DON'T KNOW
IF ONES WERE DESPERATELY DO HOW
ARE STILL BE- BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY A QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THIS
TIME- HOW HOW TO USE THESE
THESE. EXTRAORDINARY FEDERAL
RESOURCES. PROJECT THANK YOU
THE MANAGER SENATOR KERR IN.
YEAH I THINK IT ACTUALLY IN THE
LOCAL AND DIRECT THIS QUESTION
TO MR ALL OF THIS BECAUSE I
THINK IT IS IT'S THAT KIND OF
AN ANALYSIS SO- THAT WOULD. BE
REQUIRED- WOOD STRIKING TO ME
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE AT BESIDES
JUST THE MAGNITUDE OF THE DEBT-
IS THE USE OF GENERAL FUND
MONEY- REALLY TO TRY TO TAKE
DOWN SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S
OVER ON THE ASSET LIABILITY
COLUMN YOU KNOW THE STATE'S
BOOKS WHICH- YOU KNOW BOTH IN
MY PRIVATE SECTOR LIFE-
HISTORICALLY ANY MY PUBLIC
SECTOR LIKE I'VE ALWAYS TRIED
TO A BOY- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE.
GENERAL FUND AS WE ALL KNOW IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL- THE
ONGOING PROGRAM SAID TO YOU
KNOW KEEPING THE DOORS OPEN-
KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON- YOU KNOW
TO PUT IT MILDLY RIGHT WE HAVE.
A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS ARE
DEPENDENT ON THE ONGOING MONEY
UP ON THE OTHER HAND WE KNOW BY
TALKING EIGHT CD FOR EXAMPLE
THAT. WE KNOW IDENTIFIED FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND PIECES OF
PROPERTY ON THE BOOKS. ACCESS
LANDS IN THE STATE THAT AT SOME
POINT WILL BE LIQUIDATED IT
WOULD TURN INTO ONE TIME. ONE
ON THE REVENUES- THOSE THOSE
PROPERTIES OR ASSETS JUST LIKE
THIS ALTERNATELY IS UNDER
WRITTEN AS A AS A DECK TO THE
STATE AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE
STATE FUNDED MELLEY. AT THE END
OF THE DAY IS GUARANTEEING-
WHAT'S- WILL MAKE MORE SENSE AT
SOME POINT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
A STRATEGY IN THIS KIND OF GOES
BACK TO. SURNAMES QUESTION TO-
YOU KNOW AMORTIZE. THIS OUT IS
AGGRESSIVELY AS POSSIBLE WITH
WITH ONE TIME FUNDS SO THAT.
WOULD WORK WE'RE KEEPING OUR
ASSETS AND LIABILITIES AWAY
FROM OUR GENERAL FUND- GRANTED
THINGS LIKE. REAL ESTATE ASSETS
OR COULD BE VIEWED AS APPLES TO
ORANGES YOU KNOW RELATIVE TO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS- WHICH IS
HISTORICALLY BEEN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF BUSINESS
CONTRIBUTIONS AND SO FORTH. BUT
YOU KNOW I KNOW- HAVING COME
HERE RECENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
CALL ON MY COLLEAGUES- WITH
THINGS LIKE OPEB AND PENSION
LIABILITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
UNFUNDED LIABILITY AND DEBT. NO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SOONER OR
LATER SOME OF THEM FIGURED OUT
TO DO THE SAME THING LOOK THIS
IS NOW DEAD ON OUR BOOKS YOU
KNOW BASED ON GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES
IT'S ON THE BALLOT SHEET IT'S
NOT OVER ON THE GENERAL FUND
SIDE. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO KEEP
PAYING THIS OFF THE GENERAL
FUND STE- IN. BUT WHAT WE CAN
AFFORD TO DO IS PRE COMMIT- THE
LIQUIDATION OF OTHER ASSETS-
TO- FIRST CALL YOU KNOW TO THIS
DAY THAT IT DOES THAT MAKE ANY
SENSE AT ALL IN THIS CONTEXT
WERE IN MIGHT. BE SWINGING AND
MISSING ON ON. ON SOMETHING
THAT'S AN UNDERLYING PRINCIPLE
HERE. SEVEN ARE. I WOULDN'T SAY
SWINGING AND MISSING NOW- I
THINK HISTORICALLY MAYBE FOR
CONTACTS IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL-
FEDERAL LAW SORT OF. PROVIDES
AS THE DEFAULT MECHANISM FOR
REPAYMENT OF LOANS THE TAX
CREDIT REDUCTION. SYSTEM IF
YOU'RE WELCOME MISTER WORLD
MENTIONED. MOST STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA THE GREAT
RECESSION HAVE AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF THAT SYSTEM AT THE TIME THAT
THE INTEREST RATES WERE
FAVORABLE- AND THE OUTSTANDING
LOAN AMOUNTS WERE AT LEAST IN
THE EYES OF THE STATE'S
MANAGEABLE FEDERAL LAW ALSO
ALLOWS STATES TO ESSENTIALLY
REFINANCE THIS DEBT AND PRIVATE
EQUITY MARKETS- IN SEVERAL
STATES TOOK THAT OPTION DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THEIR MOTIVATIONS ON
OR THE FISCAL DYNAMICS IN THOSE
STATES. IS AN OPTION HERE FOR
THIS FOR THE STATE TO CONSIDER-
OUR OFFICE HASN'T LOOKED INTO
THIS SPECIFIC OPTIONS AS YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT YOUR FIRST CALL
ON ON MAYBE ACCESS PROPERTIES
OR OR SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
OTHER STATES KEPT THE NEXUS
CLOSER TO BUSINESS PAYROLL
TAXES- SO KEPT A LITTLE TIGHTER
WITH THE EXISTING YOU I SYSTEM
I'M GONNA SOMETHING WE'D BE
HAPPY TO LOOK INTO IN MORE
DETAIL- AND GET BACK. TO YOUR
STAFF I'M A REQUEST. YEAH I DID
PRE THAT- WILL UP OCTOBER STAFF
YOU KNOW- OFF. IN IN ASKED THAT
WHATEVER WE COME UP WITH ARE
YOU COME UP WITH IN TERMS OF.
SHARED INFORMATION TO SHARE
WITH. THE REST OF CANADA AS
WELL- ANYONE IS INTERESTED- I
DO THINK. JUST THE MAGNITUDE
OF. THE NUMBER AND AGAIN I
COULD BE OFF- I'M DEALING WITH
A LOT MORE EROS NOW THAN I DID
WHEN I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
BUT- I ALSO KNOWN IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE. THAT'S A
PRETTY BIG NUMBER. IT WILL BE A
PRETTY BIG NUMBER IT WAS THE
GENERAL FUND- DEFICIT FOR
EXAMPLE- PROBABLY WOULD RANK
FIRST OR SECOND IN THE HISTORY
OF STATE. OVERALL SO. IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE ATTACKED REST- GETTING
YOU KNOW MOVED OFF THE STATE'S
BALANCE SHEET. NOTWITHSTANDING
THE FACT THAT- HISTORICALLY
INVITE BY DEFAULT IT REALLY
SHOULD BE. HANDLED BY BUSINESS
CONTRIBUTION SO I WILL FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR RESPONSE. THANK YOU- THANK
YOU SENATOR- I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYONE FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THAT WANTS TO
COMMENT ON THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DANIELLE
BRANDON. A DONE AN ANALYSIS OF
THAT SORT SO I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU OKAY- ALL RIGHT-
IF THERE'S NO OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- THIS WAS A HOLD
OPEN- FOR NOW. SO WE'LL MOVE ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYBODY-
TO ISSUE THREE WHICH IS THE
CLAIMANT SERVICES AND ACCESS.
YES I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
I'M CALEB FOR ALL WITH THE TV-
SO- THIS ISSUE- ALSO CONTAINS
AFFECTIVELY TWO COMPONENTS- THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYOR VISION-
INCLUDES- AS I MENTIONED TWO
MAIN COMPONENTS AROUND
IMPROVING ACCESS TV SERVICES-
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS A
COMPREHENSIVE LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROPOSAL. WHICH REQUEST ELEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND THIRTY NINE POSITIONS
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
NINE POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND THIRTY NINE POSITIONS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
FUNDING WILL COVER A LANGUAGE
ACCESS PORTAL WHICH WILL
SYNTHESIZE WEBSITE CONTENT.
MAKING IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS
TRANSLATED FORMS AND NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM. IT ALSO COVERED
EXPANSION OF EXISTING TELEPHONE
INTERPRETER SERVICES. IT WILL
COVER A NEW- DIRECT GRANT
PROGRAM TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN ORDER PROVIDE
TARGETED- STARTED OUR REGION
EDUCATION SERVICES SUPPORT
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
COMMUNITIES. IT WILL ALSO
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A NEW
MULTI LINGUAL ACCESS
COORDINATOR IN UNIT. IN ORDER
TO IMPLEMENT AND OVERSEE ALL OF
THE L. E. P. INITIATIVES. IT
WILL ALSO SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL
MULTI LINGUAL CLAIMS STAFF IN
THE U. I. PROGRAM TO PROCESS-
NEW PAPER FAX AND PHONE
APPLICATIONS AND MULTI LINGUAL-
LANGUAGES. IT WILL ALSO COVER
ADDITIONAL MARKETING PROMOTION
OF EDIE'S MULTI LINGUAL
SERVICES AND LASTLY WILL COVER
REDESIGNING OF THE EDT MAIN WEB
PAGE AND OTHER YOU AYE WEB
PAGES IN ORDER TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO AVAILABLE RESOURCES. SO THE
SECOND COMPONENT AROUND
IMPROVING ACCESS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISION. IS A REQUEST FOR
ELEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND NINETY TWO
POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ALSO ELEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN NINETY
TWO POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THIS WILL EXPAND
THE PRESENCE OF YOU I TRAIN
STAFF IN THE AMERICA'S JOB
CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA LOCATIONS%
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
REQUESTS AND I'M ALONG WITH
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM HERE
HAPPENING ANSWERING QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISSED HORRELL
MORAL. GROUND WORLD YEAH. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER WORLD- WITH
THE L. A- LIKE TO COMMENT ON
THIS. VETERANS AFFAIRS HAS
ALLEN WITH THE L. A- AGAIN-
BOTH OF THESE PROPOSALS
OBVIOUSLY REPRESENTS STRONG
STEPS TOWARDS ADDRESSING ACCESS
ISSUES THAT WERE REALLY CAME TO
LIGHT DURING THE PANDEMIC ON
WITH NO SPECIFIC COMMENTS I'M
OBVIOUSLY WHAT COLOR. FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AS THESE
PROJECTS- UNFOLD- BUT ASIDE
FROM THAT ARE TOTALLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANY COMMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR DANIELLE BRANDON AGAIN
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
HAVE NOTHING MORE TO ADD AT
THIS TIME BUT HAPPY TO ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS OF. WONDERFUL I
HAVE A QUESTION. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING. ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THESE
ACCESS PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
ONE WE KNOW. THAT THOSE
SERVICES AREN'T GOING AWAY- I
MEAN THE NEEDS ARE NOT GOING
AWAY AND IT. I CAN'T SEE HOW
THE SERVICES WOULD GO AWAY- AND
THEN THERE'S THE U. I.
NAVIGATOR AND SERVICES AT THE
EIGHTY CC BY THE WAY THE A. G.
C. C. IS THAT A STATE- AGENCY
OR DEPARTMENT. SO MANY JOBS AND
PEOPLE. CAN RESTORE- CAN YOU
CONFIRM THAT B. AGENCIES CAESAR
ACT THEY'RE CONSOLIDATING
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHERE- ET IS NOT A PARTNER IN
EVERY AGES YOU SEE IT'S AT A
LOCAL AREA LEVEL- SO YOU HAVE
NOT ONLY LOCAL AREAS- AS
PARTNERS IN A J. C. SEES YOU
COULD I MEAN HE THERE YOU COULD
HAVE OTHER STATE AGENCIES AS
WELL PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING SERVICES. BUT AT THE
STATE STATE AGENCY STATE
DEPARTMENT. STATE PROGRAM. BJCC
IS A LOCATION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT MULTIPLE PARTNERS
ARE INVOLVED IN INCLUDING LOCAL
AREAS AND STATE AGENCIES SO THE
STAFFING WOULD BE OUR STATE
EMPLOYEES WOULD BE STAFFING
THIS. THE SAYS YEAH YOU KNOW
AGENCIES THE LOCATIONS THAT HE
IS A PARTNER IN- IT WOULD BE
PROVIDING YOU AYE TRAIN STAFF
IN IN THOSE LOCATIONS OKAY-
HIGH TRAFFIC LOCATIONS BECAUSE
THE PROPOSALS TO ACTUALLY
EXPAND THE PRESENCE THAT'S
CURRENTLY OUT THERE IS TO
ACTUALLYPROBABLY HAD TWO TO
THREE TO MAYBE EVEN FOUR- YOU I
TRAIN STAFF TO ASSIST PEOPLE
THAT COME IN. WITH YOU I
SPECIFIC ISSUES THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO I'LL JUST HAVE THAT
ONE- IS WHY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THESE LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
DANIELLE BRANDON AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF UNKNOWNS AT THIS
POINT- IN TIME THIS ONE TIME
COMMITMENT BALANCES THIS TO
SPARKLE INVESTMENTS MADE- IN
THE MAY REVISION AND GIVEN THE
CHANGES IN UNEMPLOYMENT AND
JOBS OVERALL. CHANGES IN
FEDERAL FUNDING THE INVESTMENTS
THROUGH ON THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
AND IMPACTS OF OTHER.
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS REIMAGINING
THE BENEFIT SYSTEM
MODERNIZATIONS WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
ARE APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY DOES LA- HAVE ANY. MORE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT. OR
RESPOND NO NO MATTER THANK YOU
OKAY WELL I WOULD JUST SAY- I
FOR ONE DON'T THINK THAT THESE
SERVICES ARE GOING AWAY SO I'D
REALLY. LIKE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE A COMMITMENT I'M NOT
SURE HOW TO DO THAT BUT MAKE A
COMMITMENT- TO THE ONGOING-
SERVICES FOR FINDING IN EVERY
DEPARTMENT WHETHER IT'S
JUDICIAL OR YOU NAME IT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A DECREASE IN THE
NEED FOR- LANGUAGE SERVICES. OF
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN INCREASE IN
THEM SO THAT'S MY ONLY COMMENT
ON THAT. ANYTHING ELSE
COMMITTEE TO SET UP THE
SENATORS NO MR OKAY AGAIN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD
OPEN- THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE FOR. OF
THESE ARE OF. SEVERAL DIFFERENT
ADD PROPOSALS- WHO WANTS TO
MAKE THAT PRESENTATION. I'M
LUCKY YOU IT SAY AGAIN CABLE
FROM THE. EIGHTY TWO- SO AS YOU
MENTIONED- MANAGER AND THERE
ARE A FIVE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
TO THIS ISSUE- THE FIRST OF
WHICH IS A PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS-
OF LEGISLATION UNDER REQUEST
SIX MILLION EIGHTEEN POINT
THREE POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION AND SIX POINT NINE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FUNDED EQUALLY BETWEEN
THE D. I. FUND IN GENERAL FUND
IN ORDER TO ADMINISTER THE
PROVISIONS OF AB FOUR NINETY
NINE. AB FOUR NINE NINE
PROHIBITED ALL STATE AGENCIES
FROM SENDING MAIL TO AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT INCLUDES
INDIVIDUALS FALL SOCIAL UNLESS
OTHERWISE SPECIFIED BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
SECOND COMPONENT OF THIS ISSUE
IS DIRECT DEPOSIT I'M SECRETARY
SU TOUCHED ON THIS ONE IN HER
BROAD OVERVIEW- THIS PROPOSAL
REQUEST FIVE AND A HALF MILLION
GENERAL FUND. AND TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND FIVE AND A HALF MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. IN ORDER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF A DIRECT
DEPOSIT SOLUTION. THE THIRD
COMPONENT- WHICH WAS ALSO
TOUCHED UPON BY THE SECRETARY.
IS THE RE IMAGINING OF THE
BENEFITS SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION
EFFORT- THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS
ELEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IN ORDER TO BEGIN
TO REFOCUS THE B. . M. EFFORT.
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPLEMENT NEW CUSTOMER CENTRIC
PROCESS SEES. LEVERAGE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND CREATE A
MODULAR APPROACH TO FOCUS ON
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE- THE
FOURTH COMPONENT IS OUR
WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT REVISE- THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS AN INCREASE
OF FIVE AND A HALF MILLION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO ALIGN AUTHORITY
WITH FEDERAL ALLOCATIONS AND
ALLOW FOR EXPENDITURE OF
UNSPENT PRIOR YOUR FUNDS.
FUNDING WILL BE LEVERAGED TO
INVEST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW STRATEGIES AND INNOVATIONS
THAT PROMOTE SHORT TERM SKILL
ATTAINMENT IN ADDRESSING JOB
QUALITY INEQUITY WITH A FOCUS
IN SPECIFIC POPULATIONS
INCLUDING THOSE. THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY CO THE NINETEEN.
AND THEN THE LAST TWO
COMPONENTS OF THIS ISSUE IS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS A ONE TIME
TWO MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADDRESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS AT A DEPARTMENT OWN
MANAGE FACILITY IN CHICO
FUNDING WILL GO TOWARDS
REPLACEMENT OF AN OUTDATED H.
FAX SYSTEM FIRE ALARM SYSTEM
ROOF REPLACEMENT AND CARPETING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THESE REQUESTS
AND AGAIN I ALONG WITH SOME MY
COLLEAGUES MEDIA AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU- THE L. A. LIKE TO
COMMENT. WE HAVE NO ISSUES-
WITH THIS GROUP OF RECALLS
THINKING THANK YOU AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RENDON.
YES DANIEL BRANDON'S APARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD AT
THIS TIME BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY SENATORS. I
GUESS MMHM I DO HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING- SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS- SO I SEE THE AMOUNT
THAT'S BEEN REQUESTED HOW
EXACTLY WILL THAT GET SPENT- SO
AS TO SOLVE AT LEAST PARTIALLY
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. ENTER NEED
THE VARIOUS WITH EDT- SO LET
LET ME JUST BACK UP AND JUST
SAY- CURRENTLY WE HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN THE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS OFF SIX OF THE TOP
FORMS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED- BY THE AUDITOR SO
WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY TO
IMPLEMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH AB
FOUR NINETY NINE- I THINK THAT
MOST OF THE- RESOURCES ARE
GOING TO GO TO- ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
COMPLY WITH A DEADLINE OF-
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE- AND
THAT WAY WE'RE NOT TAKING
RESOURCES AWAY FROM OTHER- I.
T. PROJECTS THAT WE NEED TO-
CONTINUE TO WORK ON. TWO WHEN
WE SHOULD USUAL STAFF TO THE
THAT THOSE STAFF WOULD BE I. T.
FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING.
RESOURCES THEY'RE WORKING ON
THE CODE PROBLEM IS THAT
CORRECT AT THAT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING ALTHOUGH NOT I T.
EXPERT. WE NONE OF US ARE AT
THIS POINT RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY I JUST HAVE. ONE
QUESTION- WHAT IS THE NEW
TIMELINE FOR THE BSM- PROJECT.
I CAROL WILLIAMS- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SO IF I COULD JUST
TAKE A JUST A MINUTE JUST TO
MAKE SURE- EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
WORK OUR ATTEMPTING TO MOVE
FORWARD WE'VE DETERMINED THAT
IN ORDER TO APPLY THE LESSONS
LEARNED PRIMARILY FROM THE
PANDEMIC WE NEED A NEW APPROACH
TO BE ASOME- AS SUCH YOUR
WHERE TOP PART OF THE
TECHNOLOGY POTS THE PROJECT
LAST YEAR. AND THE VENDOR
SOLICITATION HAS BEEN CANCELED
WHAT WE REALLY WANT ENSURE THAT
YOU KNOW IS WE ARE NOT STARTING
OVER WE DO NOT NEED TO START
OVER THE LAST TO PROVE PROJECT.
LIFECYCLE STAGE WAS THREE
BEFORE THE PAUSE AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH CD T. TO UPDATE
THE STAGE THREE PROJECT
DOCUMENTS FOR THE SOLUTION TO
MOVE ON THE FINAL STAGE FOR
THIS REQUEST RIGHT HERE IS TO
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE PANDEMIC IN THE MAKE SURE
WITHIN THE U. I. PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE ALL THE
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT IT IS A-
CUSTOMER CENTRIC SOLUTION AND
ARCHITECTURE. MOVING FORWARD IN
SOME OF THAT WAS NOT
NECESSARILY ADDRESSED IN IN THE
PRIOR PROCESSES SO THIS IS
WHERE WE ARE AND THIS IS THE
REQUEST FOR NEXT FOR THIS YEAR
AND IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING WILL
HAVE A REQUEST NEXT YEAR TO
MOVE INTO BDSM PROPER. ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION YES IT DOES OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
WILLIAMS PREFIX. THAT- THANK
GOD THIS IS A IT WILL BE HELD
OPEN. I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS WERE MOVE ON NOW
TO. ISSUE FIVE. AND THESE ARE
VARIOUS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT-
PROGRAMS- WHO'S GOING TO MAKE
THAT PRESENTATION. NOBODY WANTS
TO DO THIS SORRY MADAM CHAIR I
TO RAINY CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD I WAS
FUMBLING AROUND WITH MY LAPTOP
I JUST GOT A MESSAGE IT SAID.
IN ONE HOUR IT'S GOING TO SHUT
DOWN OR RESTART- BUT I THINK
I'LL BE OKAY KIND OF FREAKED ME
OUT- THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE I THOUGHT I
WOULD QUICKLY RUN THROUGH- THE
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
HIGHER CONSTRUCTION CAREERS-
INCREASES IN. INVESTMENTS AND
THEN MAKE IT JUST KIND OF
BROADLY AND GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE DETAIL- AND THEN TRY TO
PASS THE BALL. OFF TO MY
COLLEAGUE RICHARD YEAR ANY T.
P. AND CHENEY WEBER. AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND I WANT
TO SAY. AT THE OUTSET I THINK
SECRETARY TO- AND WAS REAL SLAM
DUNK IN THE OVERVIEW SO I'M
GONNA. TRY TO PICK UP ON THE
THEME. THERE WHICH- I HOPE I
CAN I CAN DO HER JUSTICE. SO
JUST AT IT IN TERMS OF KIND OF
CARRYING OVERVIEW PART HIGHER
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS. I IT'S
KIND OF A TERM OF ART. WE HAVE
TWENTY TWO HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. AROUND THE STATE
DIVERSE SECTORS CURRENTLY-
THERE IN INDUSTRY THEY'RE ALL
INDUSTRY BASED. COLLABORATIONS
MULTIPLE EMPLOYERS ORGANIZED
LABOR. COLLEGES WORKFORCE
BOARDS COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALL FOCUS ON.
WORKERS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OR GROUPS. OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
DISCONNECTED YOUTH. WOMEN
VETERANS LOW INCOME. UNEMPLOYED
UNDER EMPLOYED- AND DEAN. WHAT
WE DO WITH HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AS WE START. WITH
THE BEST JOBS. IN INDUSTRY
SECTORS ARE DRIVING EMPLOYMENT-
AND WE ORGANIZED TYRONE
EMPLOYERS INSIDE THE SECTORS AS
THOSE THAT ARE OFFERING REALLY
GOOD QUALITY JOBS. AND WE LINE
UP WORKFORCE PROGRAMS INCREASE
PATHWAYS TO THOSE JOBS AND THIS
IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING. OVER
THE LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS WITH
HIGHER TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
AND HIGHER CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS- WHAT WE DO. INSTEAD OF
PUSHING PEOPLE INTO LABOR
MARKETS AND HOPE THEY CONNECTED
JOBS RELYING ON MARKETS- WE- WE
SET UP THE CONDITIONS INSIDE
THE SECTORS WITH EMPLOYERS IN
THESE PARTNERSHIPS. THE POLL
PEOPLE INTO GOOD QUALITY JOBS.
SO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THIS APPROACH- AND KIND
OF THE TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE
APPROACH. WHICH PRESENT OBAMA.
LIKE TO CALL. TRAINING PRAY-
WHAT WE'RE TURNING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ON ITS HEAD. BUT
BUILDING ON EXISTING CAPACITY
IN EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS.
AROUND THE STATE- BY THREE FOLK
ON THE A SECTOR SIDE. IN
COMBINING IN JOB WHILE WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS INEXTRICABLY YOU
CAN'T HAVE ONE. WITHOUT THE
OTHER- THE HIGHER CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS IS SIMILAR IN THAT IT
FOCUSES ON EQUITY AND JOB
QUALITY- BUT IT'S SPECIFIC TO
THE CONSTRUCTION SECTOR SO WE
HAVE ELEVEN HIERO CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS PARTNERSHIPS. IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE THESE ARE
REGIONAL- THEY INCLUDE LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS-
TRADES UNIONS IN THEIR
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS- COMMITTEE
COLLEGES COMMITTEE BASE
ORGANIZATIONS WORKFORCE BOARDS-
AND THEY CREATE. PATHWAYS TO
STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
USING WHAT WE CALL THE MULTI
CRAFT- APPROACH DESIGNED BY THE
NATIONAL BUILDING TRADES- AND
NOW IF I JUST REALLY REALLY
QUICKLY. IF IT'S OKAY. MADAM
CHAIR TO RUN THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT WORKFORCE COMPONENTS
VERY VERY QUICKLY YES. SO AS
SIGNATURE SHE POINTED OUT A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS- THE IN A
COMEBACK PLAN THIS IS ADDING A
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS ON TOP
OF THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT
WAS ALREADY APPROVED- THIS WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TARGET
INDUSTRY SECTORS. FROM FIVE TO
TEN. INCLUDING MANUFACTURING
ENERGY AND UTILITIES- AND AS
REQUESTED BY YOU CENTER DRAWS
ON OUR LAST CONVERSATION- IT AT
THE LAST HEARING. WE ADDED
HOSPITALITY AND PROPERTY
SERVICES WHICH WERE HIT EARLY
AND HARDEST- BY THE ECONOMIC
SHOCK OF CODED. THE HOSPITALITY
SECTOR ESPECIALLY IN LARGE
CONVENTION MARKETS LIKE LOS
ANGELES IN THE BAY AREA IS
REALLY AN ECONOMIC DRIVER AND
IT EMPLOYS PREDOMINANTLY
IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE OF COLOR
WOMEN. GROUPS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CODE SO WE ADDED- THAT SECTOR
AND PROPERTY SERVICES WHICH IS
SIMILAR IN TERMS OF THAT. THAT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE WORKERS
IN THAT SECTOR WE ADDED THOSE
TO THAT TO THE LIST OF TARGET
SECTORS. OF THE SECOND PIECE IS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
AND HIRING CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS. IN COLLABORATION WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO A NUMBER
OF OUR CURRENT HR TEEPEES IN
HRC'S HE'S ALREADY INCLUDE
COLLEGES AS PARTNERS- THIS WILL
WORK WILL STRENGTHEN THE
COLLEGES ROLES IN THOSE
EXISTING PROJECTS- AND IT'LL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COLLEGES. ARE INVOLVED IN NEW
PROJECTS- AND ALSO BRING
COLLEGES AND MORE COLLEGES INTO
THE EXISTING PROJECTS AND FOR
THIS IS THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THE STUDENTS IN THE
PARTICIPANTS. WERE PART OF H.
R. T. P.'S NHRC SEIZED UP
BECAUSE WE'RE LEVERAGING THAT
CAPACITY OF THE COLLEGES FOR
LONGER TERM EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES WERE
BRINGING IN- INTEGRATING
COLLEGE CREDIT- CREDIT FOR
PRIOR LEARNING. INDUSTRY VALUED
CREDENTIALS THAT WE CAN AWARD
OUT TO THIS PARTICIPANTS
INSTANCE THAT ARE PORTABLE- AND
CONTEXTUALIZE BASIC SKILLS ESL-
AND MATH AS YOU WELL KNOW ITS-
IT REQUIRES COLLEGE LEVEL MATH
OFTEN TO GET INTO. STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS- SO WE NEED TO HAVE
THESE BASIC SKILLS AVAILABLE-
AT COLLEGE OF MASS IS NOT A
BASIC SKILL- BUT WE NEED TO
HAVE THOSE AVAILABLE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND COLLEGES ARE
PERFECTLY SITUATED TO PROVIDE
THOSE- SO GONNA DO WORKING ON
THE- THAT ALIGNMENT THE THIRD
PIECE IS. A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL EQUITY AND
RECOVERY PARTNERSHIPS. AND THIS
IS FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO
REGIONALLY ORGANIZED LOCAL
WORKFORCE BOARDS WE'VE DONE
THIS FOR SOMETIME NOW AROUND
WILL BE CALLED REGIONAL
PLANNING UNITS THAT WE
IDENTIFIED. IN THE STATE. IN
WITH REGIONAL COMMITTEE COLLEGE
CAN- SO AS I SAID WE'RE
BUILDING ON REQUIRED WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY ACT
PLANNING IT'S IN THE FEDERAL
LAW WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
FIVE YEARS. AND IS ALSO
BUILDING A STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM A COLLABORATION
REGIONAL ORGANIZING OF COLLEGES
AROUND FOR TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
SO WE'RE BUILDING ON EXISTING-WORK- BUT THIS IS FOCUSED ON
DEEPENING NETWORK. CONNECTING
COLLEGES WORKFORCE BOARDS AFTER
ALIGNMENT TO INDUSTRY SECTORS
ARE DRIVING REGIONAL EMPLOYMENT
AND THEN WITH THAT FOCUS ON
HIGH ROAD TO HIGHER ELEMENTS OF
QUALITY JBS. IN EQUITY- AND
THERE IS ONE MORE PIECE. ON THE
TRAINING SITE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HOUSING WORKFORCE
APPRENTICESHIPS. THIS IS
BUILDING ON OUR HIRING
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS
PARTNERSHIPS. AS I SAID IN EACH
REGION OF THE STATE IS CREATING
PATHWAYS IN THE STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP. AS THE STATE
INVEST IN BUILDING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO THIS IS
A DRESSING BOTH POTENTIAL
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES- WELL
CREATING PATHWAYS TO GOOD
QUALITY JOBS IN THE TRADES FOR
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS. ARE AND
THEN FINALLY- AND I COULD ASK
HEADED OVER TO- MY COLLEAGUE
ACTUALLY WEBER THE CHANCES OF
SHE WANTS ANYTHING TO THIS
BODY. FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SHARE DATA INFRASTRUCTURE- IT
WOULDN'T WHICH IS COORDINATION
OF COLLECTING PARTICIPANT DATA-
BECAUSE PARTICIPANTS ARE OFTEN
THE SAME ACROSS. THESE PROGRAMS
ARE AT THIS AT THE WITHIN THE
LABOR AGENCY AT THE COLLEGE SO
WE NEED TO COLLECT THE SAME
DATA IN THE SAME WAY. TO BETTER
MEASURE AND ANALYZE OUTCOMES
FOR A PROGRAMS AND SO WE CAN.
PUT TOGETHER GOOD REPORTS THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'RE MAKING- THIS WILL
ALSO ALLOW COLLEGES WORK FOR
SPORTS WE HOPE- THIS IS OUR
INTENT TO SHARE DATA IN REAL
TIME. AS TOO OFTEN JOB SEEKERS.
ARE HAVING TO START OVER EVERY
TIME THEY WALK INTO THE DOOR OF
A NEW PROGRAM SO FOR SHARING
DATA ACROSS AS PROGRAMS WE CAN
SAVE A LOT OF TIME- AND
HEADACHE. FOR WORKERS LOOKING
FOR JOBS WHO DON'T HAVE- WE
DON'T HAVE THAT TIME YOU DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY OF TIME- SO
THOSE ARE THE FIVE COMPONENTS
AND I. IF IT'S OKAY I'D LIKE TO
HAND IT OVER TO REYES HOBBY
HERE TO TALK ABOUT EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL IN JANUARY
BURKE. TO ADD ANYTHING ON THE
COLLEGE. PARK THAT PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER RAINY. YES I
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
THIS AFTERNOON- AND THANK YOU
TIM FOR PASSING UP ALL OVER TO
ME- AT FIRST- IN THIS BUDGET
AFTER TWO PROPOSALS COMING
FROM- THAT WILL BE DELIVERED TO
ETPB. I EIGHTY P. IS AN
EMPLOYER AS THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING FIND AND-
WE TYPICALLY SERVE- OVER FOUR
THOUSAND BUSINESSES EVERY YEAR
TRAINING MANY DIFFERENT WORKERS
IN THE TO BUDGET OFFICE IN THE
TWO PROPOSALS THAT YOU. SEE
BEFORE YOU- WE'RE PROPOSING A
TRAINED- SOMEWHERE AROUND
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND WORKERS-
THE FIRST OF BUDGET OUT THE
FIRST PROPOSAL REALLY ROUGH IT
REALLY IS. TO EXPAND. THE WORK
THAT EACH OF YOU HAS BEEN DOING
WITH. BUSINESSES AND ALL ALLOW
US TO- SIR NON- BUSINESS OR
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT WOULD
THEIR TYPICALLY DON'T ACCESS
EGP FINES AND- AND SHE GOT OUR
SERVICES SUCH AS HEALTHCARE IT-
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND
PUBLIC SECTOR. EMPLOYMENT WHICH
ARE ALL BY THE WAY ARE. GOOD
QUALITY PAYING JOBS- THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS TO EXPAND OUR WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CONTRACT EDUCATION UNITS- AND-
THE REAL INTENT BEHIND THAT
PROPOSAL IS TO. INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
WE SERVE OUR AS WE ALL KNOW
THERE'S SMALL BUSINESSES WERE
PARTICULARLY. HARD HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC- AND DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE FOUND THAT WE WERE
SERVING A GREAT DEAL OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT NEEDED THESE
BUSINESS SUPPORTS AND TRAINING
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES TO REACT TO
THAT. AFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC
AND WE BELIEVE THAT. BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THOSE TYPES OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS IN
TRAINING TO THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES WELL ARE ALSO NOT
JUST SUPPORT THEM COMING OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO
ACCELERATE THEIR GROWTH PROCESS
SEES. THEREBY CREATING A MORE
OPPORTUNITIES AND MORE-
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE ECONOMY- WE ALSO LOOKED
SEEKING TO INCREASE THE ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE TRULY IN
NEED AND ARE. SORT OF LEFT
BEHIND BY THIS ECONOMY- AND
THEN ALSO WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- WE'RE
LOOKING WE'RE SEEKING TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CERTIFICATES AND CREDENTIALS
THAT ARE ARE ACHIEVED THROUGH
THESE TRAINING PROGRAMS. AND
THEN LASTLY AND- I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUE SHINNY WEBER WILL
SPEAK TO THIS A LITTLE BIT IS
ONE OF OUR CRITICAL INTENSIVES
TO DEEP IN THE BUSINESS
ENGAGEMENT PROCESSES AND
RELATIONSHIPS. THAT THE
COMMUNITY HOW I HAS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE WITH
LOCAL BUSINESSES. IN EACH OF
THE GEOGRAPHIC REGION. SO WHAT
THE I'D LIKE TURN IT OFF TO
MICHAEL SHOULD WEBER TO SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE COMMUNITY.
SIDE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIR AND- I AM I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- TIM AND BATCH HAVE A
VERY ELOQUENTLY SAID A LOT OF
THE THINGS AND I DON'T I DON'T
WANT TO BE REPETITIVE. BUT D. I
WANT TO I DO WANT TO STRESS THE
INTEGRATION AND COLLABORATION
OF WORK BETWEEN THE TWO
AGENCIES. ARE VERY CRITICAL TO
THE WORK THAT WE DO GAME REALLY
FOCUSED. ON INCREASING STUDENT
LEARNING OUTCOMES. AND ALSO
PRIMARILY LOOKING AT ODD JOBS.
AND EMPLOYMENT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. AND OUR TO BE ABLE TO
DO. INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS WHICH IS
REALLY THE PRIMARY FOCUS THAT
WE HAVE WE REALLY NEED TO
INCREASE AND DO EMPLOYER
ENGAGEMENT VERY DIFFERENTLY.
WHICH IS WHERE THIS PARTNERSHIP
BECOMES VERY CRITICAL AND THEN
ALSO EXPANDING THE WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES WHERE
EMPLOYER PARTNERSHIPS ARE
REALLY. CRITICAL AS WELL AND SO
I DON'T REALLY WANT TO- REPEAT
ANYTHING. READ HAPPY TO ANSWER.
ON THE- OTHER THINGS THAT I
WANT TO JUST MENTION VERY
QUICKLY IS. THAT YOU KNOW WE
TEND TO TAG TEAM ON THIS AND-
MY COLLEAGUE LIZ THAT NEVER
READ BY CHANCE OR OF- COLLEGE
FINANCING FACILITIES. GENERALLY
IS THE LEAD ON THESE BUDGET
HEARINGS AND I'M GOING TO.
INVITE HER TO. PROVIDE HER
COMMENTS AS WELL REPRESENTING
THAT CHANCES OFFICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER THAT ALSO
STILL BLASTING OUT I JUST TO
BUILD ON THIS IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY. IS THAT THEY MAY
REVISION PRESENTS REALLY AS THE
STATED THAT DEEP AND PROFOUND
OPPORTUNITY TO DEEPEN OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WHY IS THIS CROSS
AGENCY COLLABORATION NECESSARY
THE REALITY IS THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS. OR UNDEREMPLOYED AS A
RESULT OF THIS PANDEMIC DON'T
SEE AGENCY LINES THEY JUST KNOW
THAT THEY NEED ASSISTANCE IN
FINDING NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND SOCIAL MOBILITY
SO WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S
INCUMBENT ON US AS A CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES LABOR AGENCY IN
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. TO
COLLABORATE AND STREAMLINE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES AND TO MAKE
THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED US THE
LAST PIECE ALL ADDED IT WE DO
RESPECTFULLY URGE FOR
CONSIDERATION OF GREATER
CHANCES OFFICE CUT CAPACITY BY
WAY OF THIS POSITIONS. TO
SUPPORT THESE IMPORTANT NEW AND
EXPANDED INITIATIVES THE
CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES ARE THE
LARGEST SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY
SERVING TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS AND A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN COLLEGES. WE HAVE FEWER
THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE THIS
CRITICAL WORK POSSIBLE STAFFING
CAPACITY WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL AND
ULTIMATELY MEET THE NEEDS OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
COUNTING ON US FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU- CENTER AND QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS NO THANK YOU I'M IF
I CAN'T- SENATOR CRITICIZING.
NO THAK YOU THANK YOU- I DO-
MAYBE IF MAYBE THIS IS DIRECTED
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT
ANYONE COULD COULD ANSWER MY
QUESTION IS HOW TO HOLD UP THE
EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE TO ANY
JOB COMMITMENTS OR THE QUALITY
OF THE JOB COMMITMENTS OR- IF
THEY'RE DOING TRAINING THAT THE
QUALITY OF THE TRAINING THE
REACHING OUT TO OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT HISTORICALLY- LIVED OUT IN
THE REASON. I ASK ABOUT THAT IS
BECAUSE- AND ACCESS I MENTIONED
TO US SECRETARY SUE OF PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION IF
IT'S PUT OUT THERE AS A
COMMITMENT THEN OUR PUBLIC
ACCESS AND THE REASON I RAISE
THIS IS BECAUSE FOR TWO YEARS I
HAD A ON. MOST TRYING TO GET
LEGISLATION THROUGH THAT WAS
PRETTY SIMPLE IT BASICALLY SAID
THAT IF YOU'RE THE RECIPIENT OF
PUBLIC FUNDS WHO PROMISED TO
CREATE JOBS IN EXCHANGE FOR OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT YOU
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
THEY SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT TO
THE PUBLIC YOU KNOW GETTING
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER OF
JOBS THE TYPE OF JOBS THEY
CREATED. WELL BASICALLY WHAT
DID THEY PROMISE IN RETURN FOR
OF THESE PUBLIC DOLLARS- AND MY
BILL WAS I HAVE THE LETTER WAS
OPPOSED OF BY COMPANIES WHO
SAID THAT IF THEY WERE REQUIRED
INCLUDING APPLYING FOR- THE ETP
FINDING THAT IF THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO BE- TRANSPARENT
WITH THIS INFORMATION THAT THEY
WOULD NOT PARTICIPATE. ALL
WHICH WAS QUITE SURPRISING TO
ME SO MY QUESTION IS AND THAT
WAS A VERY SIMPLE PROPOSAL
THERE- MY QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
HOLD- EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE. TO
THESE COMMITMENTS AND HOW ARE
WE ASSURE OUR TAXPAYER THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION. SO WHO WANTS TO
ENSURE DANIELLE BRANDON- THANK
I DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL AM
I DON'T HAVE A RESPONSE HANDY
FOR THAT AND BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO TURN IT TO ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES- ATP OR THE BOARD
IF. THEY HAVE A RESPONSE FOR
YOU. THANK YOU. YES SIR MADAM
CHAIR RESTAURANT HERE WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL- FOR
EGP OUR PANEL ACTUALLY DOES-
HOLDER- BUSINESSES- THAT WE
WORK WITH ACCOUNTABLE TO. A
HIGHER STANDARD SO THEY SET
THRESHOLDS FOR FINDING- THAT
THEY REQUIRE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF-
SALARY- REQUIREMENTS OR CERTAIN
DIVERSIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO I
FEEL LIKE- THROUGH THESE
INVESTMENTS WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO. ENSURE THAT- WERE
CONTRIBUTING TO IT- THE
CREATION OF GOOD QUALITY JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA AS A MATTER OF
FACT DURING THE PANDEMIC- EACH
OF THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL PUT IN PLACE- A PROGRAM.
CALLED THE CODED PILOT PROGRAM
WHICH WAS WHICH ACTED REALLY IS
AN INCENTIVE FOR EMPLOYERS TO
HIRE AND TRAIN WORKERS A
LIVABLE WAGE JOBS AND- BLIGHTED
BY THE END OF THIS PROGRAM
YOU'RE WILL HAVE PUT OUT MORE
THAN TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
NOT FIND CREATING MORE THAN
TWELVE THOUSAND JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIA. THAT ARE GOOD
PAYING QUALITY JOBS SO I FEEL
LIKE- YOU KNOW. THE RESOURCES
THAT WE BE USING UTILIZING TO
THESE PROGRAMS WOULD. HOLD
BUSINESSES ACCOUNTABLE. THANK
YOU- MISTER. THANK YOU TRAVIS
ALLEN- FROM THE L'ANNO. ON I
THINK WE'LL START- WITH SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS ABOUT THE
OVERALL NAY REVISION WORK FIRST
PROPOSALS AND THEN TURN TO
OTHER SPECIFIC ITEMS HERE IN
THIS ISSUE- THANK. FIRST WHAT
WE AGREED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS CLEARLY LAID BARE
LONGSTANDING ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES IN THE STATE'S LABOR
MARKETS AND ALSO GREETED
MINISTRATION AND NOW IS THE
TIME TO. TO THINK ABOUT. STATE
POLICIES AND STRUCTURES GOING
FORWARD ON. SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SPENT THE
WEEKEND ASSEMBLING. A LIST OF
THE WORKFORCE RELATED PROPOSALS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION THIS YEAR I'M AND WE
MUST ADDRESS EARLIER THIS WEEK
AND HAND OUT FORM. ON ACROSS
ALL OF STATE GOVERNMENT THERE
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE WORKFORCE
RELATED PROPOSALS THAT ARE NEW
IN THE MAY REVISION IN TOTAL
MORE THAN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
I'M SORRY YOUR HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS REGARDING THROUGH THE
BROAD PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS. ON
WE FIND THAT SOME OF THE NEW
PROPOSALS- WARRANT THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION AND
PRINCIPALLY THESE ARE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE EXPANSIONS OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE SHOWN
PROMISE. IN WHICH THE STATE HAS
CAPACITY TO BUILD ON. BUT MANY
OF THE PROPOSALS HAVE SERIOUS
SHORTCOMINGS OUR- FIRST MANY OF
THEM ARE BRAND NEW AND LACKS
KEY INFORMATION. FOR EXAMPLE-
THE ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS ­S
SECRETARY SUE LAID OUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS AGENDA. IS
DETAILED IN A SINGLE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT WE
RECEIVED AND THEY'RE PRICED
RELATIVELY LITTLE INFORMATION
ABOUT THESE. COMPONENTS WE
DON'T KNOW VERY MUCH THIS. ON
OTHER ARE RELATED ISSUES- SO X.
OUR GRANT PROGRAM AT AN ENTITY
WELL BEYOND THEIR EXISTING
MANAGEMENT CAPACITY WHETHER OR
NOT THEY CAN GET THOSE GRANTS
OUT IN A TIMELY MANNER I TO
AFFECT THE PANDEMIC CONDITIONS
WE ALSO RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT-
DUPLICATION OF EXISTING STATE
PROGRAMS AND OTHER ENTITIES-
AND ECHO YOUR CONCERNS MADAM
CHAIR ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY ON
SO SPECIFIC TO THE PROPOSAL'S
HERE THESE ARE THE COMPONENTS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S SO CALLED
JOBS PACKAGE ON IT OR NOT LEAVE
THE LARGEST OF THAT ECONOMIC
RESILIENCY FONG WAS WILL HEAR
NEXT. AND I THINK YOU'RE VERY
SORT OF TWO GROUPS THERE ARE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
ACROSS OUR WORKFORCE FOR AN E.
OR EXPANSION OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND THIS FALLS IN THAT
FIRST GROUP OF- COMMENTS WE
MADE THESE EXPANSIONS TOP
WARRANT SERIOUS LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION OTHER LIKELY
WITHIN THE CAPACITY OF THESE
ENTITIES TO MANAGE A TIMELY
FASHION ON IN THE STATE HAVE
SOME FAMILIARITY BECAUSE THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE SHOWN PROMISE ON
A LARGE COMPONENT OF THAT IS A
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION
TO THE HIGH ROPES TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP WHICH IS QUICKLY
BECOMING THE STATE'S FLAGSHIP
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
AT THE BORDER. ON THE
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
OTHER PROPOSALS ARE RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE BOARD AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RAISES MORE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ON OFFICE ON
THE FIRST COMPONENT IS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS I TO ESTABLISH
FUTURE T. P.'S THAT ALIGN WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PATHWAYS ON
THIS SEEMS LIKE IT MIGHT BE
DUPLICATIVE WITH THE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE WHICH IS A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING. OUR ONGOING FUNDED
PROGRAM AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- TO FORM
APPRENTICESHIPS IN
NONTRADITIONAL INDUSTRY SECTORS
THAT PROGRAMS CURRENTLY- UNDER
UTILISED AS WE'RE NOT SURE. TO
WHAT DEGREE THESE MIGHT BE
DUPLICATIVE THE SECOND BOZELL'S
MILLION OF THE AGAIN FOR. TO
READ FOR HOT. SO EQUITY
PARTNERS WITH THE CA HOW. ON
NRF. BRIEF REVIEW OF WHAT THE
FOR IS AVAILABLE THIS LIKE IT
MIGHT BE RELATIVE DEEPLY OF
STATE'S A- STRONG WORK FOR
PROGRAM THE COMMUTER COLLEGES.
THAT PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS AFTER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO.
COLLABORATE WITH REGIONAL
PARTNERS- TO IMPROVE-
EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS AND THE
SUPPORT INDUSTRY SPECIFIC
ACCREDITATION SO IT'S NOT CLEAR
TO US WHAT THE NEW FUNDING
WOULD DO- THAT THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO DO TODAY. ADDITIONALLY
THERE'S FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH E. P. R. TO
EXPAND OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS
THROUGH CONTRACT EDUCATION AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AGAIN
THIS SEEMS POTENTIALLY.
DUPLICATIVE AND POTENTIALLY ON
NEEDED ON THIS STATE. CURRENTLY
FUNDS ON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR ABOUT ONE POINT ONE MILLION
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS-
BUT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DON'T HAVE THAT MANY STUDENTS
RIGHT HOUSE WITH THEIR OWN USED
SEATS. THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE CURRENT EXISTING STATE
FUNDING THAT THEY COULD USE TO
SUPPORT A COHORT- FOR A
TRAINING PROGRAM. SIMILAR TO
THOSE PROPOSING EIGHTY P. BUT
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING- THE DGPS IS
PROPOSED TO RECEIVE HERE AND
FINALLY THAT THE DATE
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE THAT
MISTER RANEY MENTIONED- WE'RE
UNCLEAR HOW THIS DIFFERS OR
WOULD BE- WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE JANUARY PROPOSAL PUT
FORTH BY THE GOVERNOR- SO
CALLED CRADLE TO CAREERS- DATA.
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WHICH WOULD.
CORRELATE DATA ACROSS VARIOUS
STATE ENTITIES INCLUDING THOSE.
IN THIS PACKAGE ON. SO FORGIVE
THE LENGTHY WALK THROUGH THESE
PER. ON AGAIN WORK IT'S UNCLEAR
I WOULD THINK THE LETTER. IN AT
BIT IN A DIFFICULT POSITION
WITH THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
AVAILABLE CURRENTLY- TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ABOUT THESE
PROPOSALS THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISS BRANDON DO YOU
HAVE YOUR HAND UP. I DO THINK
US SENATOR ISA AND DANIEL
GRANTED AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
JUST I WANTED TO SAY THAT THE
FINANCE DOESN'T SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS THEY ALEJO THE
PROGRAMS IN THESE LABOR
PROPOSALS BUILD UPON EXISTING
PROGRAMS AS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
SECRETARY AND BY THE L. A. L.
INCLUDING THE HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
AND THE HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS MODEL. AND THE EXISTING
WORK OF THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL I'M AT THE STATE LEVEL AS
WELL AS THE WORK FORCE FOR
COORDINATION AND THEN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS
PART OF THE REGIONAL PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION OCCURRING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THIS H. R. T. T.
THE HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
IN THE HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS ARE INDUSTRY BASED IN
EMPLOYER DEMAND DRIVEN THEY
HAVE AND CONTINUE TO HAVE.
PLAYERS WORKERS AND LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES FURTHER M. S.
ONE HEIGHT THE NEWS PROPOSED-
TARGET CAN PREVIOUSLY BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALEJO I
INCLUDING ALIGNMENT OF THE
LABOR AGENCY IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. COMMUNITY COLLEGE H.
R. T. P. PROGRAMS HYBRID
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS
CURRICULUM AND DEVELOPING A
SHARED DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND THAT THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES FIFTEEN
MILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD FOR
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PLAN AS WELL AS FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE AT ONE TIME TO THE
LABOR AGENCY TO COORDINATE AND
DEVELOP POLICY. AS WELL AS A
MULTI YEAR ENCUMBRANCE
EXPENDITURES SURE PERIOD FOR
THIS PROPOSAL SO WE THINK
THERE'S ADEQUATE TIME TO SPEND
THESE FUNDS FINALLY THERE ARE
CAR ABOUT. LANGUAGE I SHOULD
SAY ALLOWING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THESE
PROPOSALS ACROSS ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS AND SO I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- MISTER
RANEY OR- ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
RESPOND TO THE L. A. O.'S
CONCERNS- YEAH THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR OF REAL QUICKLY FIRST TO
SAY I HAVE A LOTTERY FOR THE L.
AND WE HAD A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
OF THEM- POINTING OUT WHERE WE
NEED TO PROVIDE MORE CLEAR.
AND- I APPRECIATE THAT. MR AL
STAFF HAD TO WORK- OVER THE
WEEKEND- THE STUFF CAME TO.
PRETTY FAST AND WE WERE ALL
SPENT A LOT OF WEEK WORK- IT
JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS FIRST
OF ALL I THINK GROUP EVERYTHING-
BRANDON SAY- AT THE- PARTNER
FINANCE. THAT ON THE CRIME RATE
WITH THE COLLEGE. MR ALUM
APPOINTED I ALLEY UP OUT UP
EARLIER IN THE STATE THAT THEY
IS THERE A OF PRO ACROSS THE-
THAT HAD ARE GETTING. I. THE IS
BEEN A CASE THAT WE BEEN A
CHECK IT WOULD BE TRYING TO
SELL FOR SOMETIME. IN FACT WE
PROPOSE A NEW TO- A WAY WITHIN
THE LABOR- TO TOGETHER MORE.
WORKFORCE PER INTO DEPART FIFTY
AT READ. THAT FRANK. ACROSS THE-
I. THAT WERE WITH THE KERR. IN
THE WAY WE THAT WE ARE- IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO REDUCING THAT
FRAGMENT. SO NOT IN. THE A-
THAT'S CROSS AGE PART- THAT
WE'RE COMMITTED TO- I ALSO JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THESE
ARE NEW PROGRAMS- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE SAID. THE FOR MILLION
IN IN A CHURCH P. MY- I NHRC
FUNDING. IN CLASS. WITH
COLLEGES BUILDING ON THAT MODEL
OF H. TWO DE IN A- HE'S WHERE
WE HAVE A OF CAPACITY. THE
OPPORTUNE HERE IS A- TO HELP
BRITISH JOBS. HAVE THOSE EXTRA.
THE EXTRA VALUE ADD. THAT THE
COLLEGE COLLEGE PROVIDING- FOR.
CREDIT WHEN YOU GET THE TRAIN
PROGRAM THAT'LL- YOU. LONGER
TERM INTER OF YOUR- YOUR- AND
ALSO FURTHER EDUCATIONAL. SO
WORKS ABOUT THE PARTNERSHIP BUT
IT DOES. ON CURRENT PROGRAM
WORK JUST LIKE OUR H. R. T.
PETER- THE- OTHER IS THE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS FOR THE- EQUITY
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT IS ALSO
BUILDING ON. CURRENT WORK SO
WE'VE BEEN. VERY BUSY WITH.
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARD OR
REGIONALLY PLANNING INPUT. THAT
AROUND INDUSTRIES. AND COURTNEY
WITH THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM. STRONG WORK FORCE IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON INTERNAL
COLLEGE UP A CAPACITY AND WORK
AROUND. FOR TECHNICAL
EDUCATION- PREDOMINANTLY IT'S A
BIG INVESTMENT- IT'S IN
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE. THAT
PROVIDE CERTIFICATES
CREDENTIALS FOR STUDENTS AND
WORKERS WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THROUGH THE STRONG WORK FIRST
PROGRAM TO ATTACH THOSE
CREDENTIALS. THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN REGIONAL LBOR
MARKET SO THEY HAVE REAL
INDUSTRY VALUE. SO THIS WORK
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING. WILL
INCREASE ADELINE. HI AND- WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
IT HOPE THAT- RABAL TO CONTINUE
THAT WORK. OKAY- ANYMORE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SAYING
NOT MADAM CHAIR IF I COULD JUST
ADD TO- SORRY WHO CAN'T THANK
IS JENNY WEBER WITH CHANCES
OFFICE- IF I COULD JUST ADD TO
CAR I RECALL THE EACH R. T. P.
PROJECT- THE HAVE THE H. I. T.
P. ARE REALLY OF MY AS AS
SOMEONE SAID- EARLIER- IN-
EMPLOY. PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
STATE ANY LIKE OF AND THERE'S A
LOT OF UP AND FOR ONLINE THERE
WHICH WERE ON AND THIS IS A
PACKAGE ALLOW US TO DO THAT IN
THE TO- ALSO LOOKING AT TRAIN.
B- CAL PRINT SHIPPING. ARCH
STOP HR T. P. WHICH I THAT'LL
GO TO BE VERY IN THE LAW TERM
AND THAT IS THE ONE OF THE
WHOLE YOU KNOW GOOD REALLY
AREN'T BIG WE WERE TO SEE OF
THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP. MARCHERS
THE TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM
TRAINING THESE ARE VERY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING WILL
THAT'S OF SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND SO THE FUNDING
IS GOING TO BE VERY CRITICAL IN
HELPING. SMALL BUSINESSES
RECOVER. S. AS THE ECONOMY
RECOVERS ON YOUR ROAD TO
RECOVERY WE ALL KNOW SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE. JOB CREATORS IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND THIS IS GOING
TO BE A VERY CRUCIAL SUPPORT
FOR THEM IN THAT PROCESS. OKAY
THANK YOU- I JUST WANT TO- SORT
OF. SORRY REPEAT OF THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE AND THIS GOES BOTH
TO LABOR AGENCY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND- AND
TO L. A. O. IS. THAT WE- I WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC THAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS. INFORMATION THAT WHEN
THERE'S A COMMITMENT MADE TO
JOBS AND CERTAIN KINDS OF JOBS
THAT WE HAVE ABSOLUTE
CONFIDENCE THAT- IS NOT GOING
TO BE- THE SYSTEM THAT WILL
BLOCK US FROM GETTING ACCESS TO
THAT INFORMATION AND I SAY THAT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF MY
UNFORTUNATE- EXPERIENCE IN- AND
SEEN THE POSITION OF THE- FOR
EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THAT ABSOLUTELY
REFUSED AND SAID IT WAS NOT- IT
WAS NOT AND- SOMETHING THAT
THEY WOULD AGREE TO DO SO- I
CAN APPRECIATE MR- HOW DID YOUR
EXPLANATION ABOUT THE SUCCESS
OF THE TRAINING. BUT UP I WANT
US TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A THE
PUBLIC NOT JUST MAYOR YOU'RE
NOT A ONE OFF HERE AND THERE
ARE WANT ABSOLUTE- TRANSPARENCY
TO THE PUBLIC FOR ALL THESE-
WHAT REALLY OURS THE BILL
PROBABLY BE A HISTORIC
INVESTMENT. IN WORKFORCE-
TRAINING AND I HAVE AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF RESPECT FOR THE HIGH
ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS- AND
THEY'RE JUST THERE REALLY ARE A
MODEL THAT'S GOTTEN BETTER
BETTER THROUGH THE YEARS- BUT-
THE REST OF THESE FUNDS THE
REST OF THESE PROGRAMS. I DON'T
HAVE THE SAME EXPERIENCE OR A
BAD EXPERIENCE AS FAR AS WHEN
IT COMES TO TRANSPARENCY SO I'D
REALLY URGE EVERYONE. TO MAKE
THAT- CRYSTAL CLEAR- IN THIS
BUDGET THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY IN YOUR
HARD WORK EVERY DAY. LET'S SEE
WE'RE GOING ON TO THAT WAS HELD
OPEN SIX MARIN THE RIGHT YOU'RE
CORRECT I'M ON. NOW ON SIX OKAY
ISSUE SIX COMMUNITY ECONOMIC.
RESILIENCE ON. BUT AFTER
EVERYONE- THIS IS ZERO- NINE.
I'M A SENIOR ADVISER BRIDGE IN
THE- IN THE GUY OFFICE OF THE
PLAN RESEARCH I TO THANK YOU
INVITING ME TO SHARE OF THE-
THINKING AROUND THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE FUNDS- SO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS- I
THINK THAT SECRETARY SU LAID
OUT THE VISION PRETTY CLEARLY
WHAT I HOPE TO DO HERE IS TO
SORT OF LAY OUT PRETTY BROADLY
THE THINKING BEHIND THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
FINE. WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH IT THE POINT OF IT AND
THEN- GOING TO SOME DETAILS-
AND THEN AFTER THAT WE'RE
PREPARED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS WHICH I NOW- LA- AND
OTHERS HAVE FORWARDED TO US SO
WE CAN GET INTO THE DETAILS ON
THAT AS WELL- SO I JUST WANTED
TO RE EMPHASIZE THE POINT OF
THE FUNDING GIVEN THE
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD IT I
THINK THIS. WILL TIED TO THAT
VERY MUCH SO THAT. WE CARE
ABOUT TRANSFERRED WITH. ABOUT
JOB CALL. BUT HAVE TO. THOSE
JOBS RIGHT H. R. TV IS DO NOT
CREATE JOBS WE HAVE TO MAKE THE
JOB TO CONNECT PEOPLE TO. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS FUND DOES. SO
THE COMMUNITY CAN RELATE FUNDS
AIMS TO BUILD WRIT LARGE THIS
IS A TRANSITION TO A NEW
ECONOMY THIS IS A MORE
SUSTAINABLE A MORE RESILIENT A
MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY. AND THE
FUND IS DESIGNED TO DEPLOY THIS
ONCE IN A GENERATION SURPLUS.
TO ADDRESS TO ESSENTIAL
CHALLENGES RIGHT SO THE FIRST
ONE- AS SECRETARY SU SAID IS
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM A
PANDEMIC. THAT WE KNOW IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA'S REGIONS AND
POPULATIONS AND INDUSTRIES VERY
DIFFERENTLY- AND WE KNOW ALSO
AS WE'VE SAID- YOU HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THROUGHOUT- THAT
THIS IS- REVEALED THAT THAT. WE
DON'T EVEN INEQUALITY IN THE
PRE PANDEMIC ECONOMY WAS ALSO
FOR NOTABLE BUT IT DOESN'T
OTHER THING IN ADDITION TO
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE RECOVER.
HE THINKS ABOUT HOW WE- FORWARD.
HOW DO WE MAKE A TREND. TO A
HIGHER ECONOMY HOW DO WE MAKE A
TRANSITION SPECIFICALLY TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY- AND SO THIS
IS PART IN PARCEL RECOVERY I
DON'T WANT TO SAY THIS IN A WAY
THAT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE TRYING
TO SORT OF. DO GOOD BY DOING
CLIMATE WORK BUT THAT'S GOING
TO AFFECT EVERY SINGLE INDUSTRY
INOCULATION IN CALIFORNIA. IS
IMPACTED BY OR WILL IMPACT.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ALSO
BECAUSE- CARBON NEUTRALITY IS
RIGHT NOW. A A DRIVER OF THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY. SO IF
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO RETAIN ITS
COMPETITIVENESS. AND COMPETE
AND INNOVATION AND ITS RECORD
AS A STATE ECONOMY THAT TO PLAY
IN THE SPACE IS EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT SO NOT JUST FOR SORT
OF- CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN WATER.
AND LOWER CARBON EMISSIONS BUT
ALSO PROVIDE ECONOMIC AND
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE IT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT AND I
ALSO SAY THAT. JUST SO WE DON'T
THINK WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT.
CARBON NEUTRALITY THE
TRANSITION IS ALSO A CHANCE FOR
US TO GET IN THIS FUND HELPS US
GET IN FRONT OF HELP EVERY
REGION GET IN FRONT OF THE
MACROECONOMIC CHANGES THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE EVERY. DAY AUTUMN
IS A ASIAN. GLOBAL IS- THE
KINDS OF- THE KINDS OF IN THAT
ARE. A READ AND IF JOB AND ENDS
THERE SO THIS A WAY UP. ALL OF
THAT- IN A WAY OF. ALLOWS READ
TO DO. A FUTURE CALL. THAT IS-
OF THE STATE OF. SO LET ME SAY
NOW THAT THE- CREEK THING ABOUT
THIS FAR IS THAT IT IS A REGION.
OFF WE HER YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
WE THE LEAD. LEAD ON THIS WE
HAVE HEARD YOU READ. YOUR
BECAUSE- THAT IS THE STATE JOB
SWOOP IN DECIDE WHAT HAPPENS IN
REGIONAL ECONOMIES. RIGHT BUT
THE IDEA IS THAT- THE STATE
REALLY CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT
DETERMINE. THE DESTINY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC REGIONS
WE SEE OUR ROLE IN THIS IS THE
ROLES IS WHEN WE DESIGNED THE
FUN LIKE THIS- BUILT AS I WILL
MENTION- VERY MUCH OF SOME
STRUCTURES THAT WE- ADMIRED AND
FOLLOWED. FROM YOUR LEAD
INCLUDING THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS IS. AB ONE OF SIX BUT
MORE ON THAT LATER WHAT WE SEE
OUR ROLE ESSENTIALLY IS
PROVIDING. RESOURCES FOR THE
REGION TO SHE THEIR TRAY.
BECAUSE WHAT MAKES SENSE. IN A
FOR A CAN. IN THE C. THAT IS.
WITH WHILE FIRE. WITH AND A
COLLAPSE. IN IN THE NEED TO
STAY UP BY. FEEDS IN- AND- WHAT
PRODUCT. IS DIFFERENT THAN.
HAPPENING IN THE VALLEY.
MANAGING GROUND- REDUCTION
BECAUSE OF. IN AGRA TRADE. OR
REALLY IN THE CURRENT WHICH BY
THE WAY INCREDIBLY NOT REALLY
GAS IN THIS. GOING HUNDRED TRY.
IN LA SO WHAT LOTS OF THINGS BY.
AND BY AND SO WANT TO GIVE
THOSE REGIONS THE CHAIN TO
DECIDE WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR OWN. THE OTHER THING THAT.
WE WANT TO DO TO OUR SUPPORT
THE IN SO. AND INCLUDES TAPE.
RIGHT WHERE LOCALS. COME TO DO
TO. AS I SAID THERE. FUTURE.
BUT WE DON'T WE DON'T. WHAT TO
DO BUT WE DO PUT SOME
GUARDRAILS ON THE MONEY SO WE
DO A COUPLE THINGS WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A SAY. IN WHO IS AT THE
TABLE WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A PLACE FOR LABOR SO
THAT WORKERS HAVE A SAY. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S A
PLACE FOR COMMUNITY VOICES
ESPECIALLY. BLACK INDIGENOUS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR- THAT HAVE
TOO OFTEN BEEN LEFT OUT OF
DECISION MAKING- AS WELL AS-
BUSINESSES. GOVERNMENT THE LAND
TO BE EDUCATION THE WORKFORCE
SYSTEM THE SOCIAL SERVICE
SYSTEM SO IT IS A BIG TABLE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY A PLACE AT THE TABLE
FOR THE PEOPLE WHOSE VOICES
HAVE NOT FULLY BEEN HURT. SO
THAT'S ONE THING WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO SEND A HIGH ROAD
AGENDA. THERE WILL BE METRICS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THERE WILL
BE I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THAT
THERE WILL BE NO DOLLAR THAT
GOES OUT THE DOOR WITHOUT AN
EVALUATION. PLAN AND I'VE BEEN
A METRICS PLANT BUT- REALLY
LARGE THE METRICS ARE GOING TO
BE AROUND THE HIGH ROAD WHAT WE
MEAN BY THAT AS SECRETARY SU
EXPLAINED AS- SUSTAINABILITY.
SO HOW DOES ANY OF THIS
INVESTMENT ALIGNS THE STATE'S
CLIMATE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
THERE WILL BE EQUITY METRICS.
HOW IS THIS ADVANCE INCLUSIVITY
HOUSES LIFT UP ALL CALIFORNIANS
SO THAT EVERYONE BENEFITS IN
THE TRANSITION- HOW DOES THIS
ADDRESS JOB QUALITY. WHICH AS
DIRECTOR RAINY DESCRIBED SO
ELOQUENTLY WE CANNOT DELIVER
EQUITY WITHOUT JOB QUALITY SO
HOW ARE WE GOING TO CREATE
THOSE GOOD JOBS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO TRACK THAT THEY'RE
PRETTY GOOD JOBS. ALL OF THESE
THINGS IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
EXPECT FROM THE INVESTMENTS.
I'M THE KIND OF THING THAT
SUPPORTS. REALLY ROBUST
ECONOMIC GROWTH. THAT BENEFITS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THIS IS I
SAID LOOK VERY DIFFERENT. IN
EVERY REGION BUT IN EVERY
SINGLE REGION IT WILL LIFT UP
FAMILIES. AND WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES AND BUSINESSES AND-
ALSO CRITICALLY THE TAX BASE.
RIGHT MANY REASONS WHICH DEPEND
ON PARTICULAR INDUSTRIES ARE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR TAX BASE OR
SEE THAT DECLINE OR HAVE SEEN A
DECLINE. AND SO. HOW WE BUILD
THE QUALITY OF LIFE. IN EACH
REGION THAT CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE AND RESPECT SO THAT'S
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THIS
INVESTMENT THAT HAS TO. LIFT UP
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. AND THEN.
DISTRIBUTION I WILL SAY IS ALSO
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. WE WANT TO
GUARANTEE THAT THERE IS
INVESTMENT IN REGIONS. WHICH
HAVE BEEN HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC. WHICH HAVE. BORNE THE-
GREATEST BROWN OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ENVIRONMENTAL CHAU.
AND THOSE INLAND REGIONS THAT
HAVE OFTEN BEEN LEFT OUT OF
CALIFORNIA'S STORIED ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY RIGHT SO THAT'S WHAT
WE REALLY COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT WITH THIS MYSELF THIS
MONEY IS COMPETITIVE BUT IS
ALSO GUARANTEED TO GO TO EVERY
REGION. AND THE LAST THING I
WILL SAY BEFORE WE GO INTO MORE
DETAILS IS THAT THIS IS PART
OF. AND I THINK BOTH HIM AND-
SECRETARY SUE EMPHASIZED THIS
IS PART OF A COHERENT COME BACK
VISION IT IS NOT FRAGMENTED IN
FACT. THIS WILL CONNECT TO ALL
INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE BUDGET
NOT ONLY TO THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS AND HRT PIECE THAT
WE CAN TALK ABOUT HOW THAT
WORKS- BUT IT CONNECTS TO.
COMMUNITY CAPACITY INVESTMENTS
WHICH WERE LIFTED UP AND
PRIORITIZED BY THE LEGISLATURE
SO THAT TEN SEVENTY TWO
INVESTMENTS. WE HAVE WRITTEN IN
ON. THE FACT THAT WE CANNOT DO
THIS WORK UNLESS WE BUILD
CAPACITY IN COMMUNITY GROUPS TO
JOIN IN THE WORK AND THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO THERE'S
A SEPARATE FUNDING FOR THAT THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE. AND
OTHER PLACES THAT WE ARE
DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO THAT SO
THAT'S NOT IN SORT OF NAME ONLY
THIS BIG TASK- WE ARE.
CONNECTED DIRECTLY TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. INVEST THERE
HAVE BECAUSE- THE BUDGET IN.
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION IN
ENERGY- AND BECAUSE THESE WILL
ALSO TAKE PLACE IN REGIONS AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE ARE PART OF THIS ECONOMIC
PLAN- AND WE ARE MAKING SURE
THAT- THESE ARE ALL. THESE ARE
ALL ISSUES WITHIN THEIR OWN
DISTINCT. AND CRITICAL PIECES
OF- OF THE RECOVERY IN OF THE
TRANSITION AND WE THINK NONE OF
THEM ARE EXTRANEOUS AND WE
REALLY ARE STRUGGLING NOT
STRUGGLING BUT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO COMBINING ALL THE THINGS
TOGETHER ACROSS THE BUDGET SO
TRANSIT NO IS YOU AND- YOUR
COLLEAGUES LOOK AT THIS OVER
THE WEEKENDS WE ALSO HAVE
STRUGGLED TO PULL THESE THINGS
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A SINGLE COHERENT STORY
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S THE WAY.
TO CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE AND THIS
IS A LOT OF MONEY TO INVEST AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT LIFTS
UP ALL CALIFORNIANS SO THAT'S
THE THINKING BEHIND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER- THE SPECIFICS ON THE
STRUCTURE AND INVESTMENTS- AND
I CAN ALSO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE SENT TO US.
IN ADVANCE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PURSUE THOSE- AND- MY
COLLEAGUE- I CALLED THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCING LIKELY TO
RAINY IS ALSO HERE- TO HELP US
TALK ABOUT THE WAY THAT THIS
INTERSECTS- WITH THE H. R. P.
P. IS WAS COMPLETELY. DISTINCT
FUNDING STREAM. THANK YOU MISS
WHITE- DOES THE L. A. O. WANT
TO COMMENT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JAZZ ALAMO AGAIN FROM THE
L. L. ON THE OTHER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
SHE ECONOMIC RESILIENCY FUND-
WOULD IT. FIRST I SHOULD SAY
ARE THERE THERE'S VERY LITTLE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
ABOUT THE PROPOSED FUND AT THIS
TIME- IT IS INCLUDED IN THE
OMNIBUS JOBS PACKAGE B. C. P.
AND THAT THE TRAILER BILL IS
RATHER SHORT ON SO WE'RE STILL
LEARNING ABOUT THE FUN ONE
THING I WOULD POINT OUT THOUGH.
IS THAT THE PHONE PROPOSES TO
USE. SORT OF GRANT FUNDING IN
TWO STAGES FIRST WITH. OUR
PLANNING GRANTS TO THE REGION'S
A SMALLER AMOUNT IS THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOLLOWED BY
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS FOR THE
BULK OF THE FUNDING. ON IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO US AT THIS TIME
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
APPROVE THE ENTIRE BUDGETED
AMOUNT. RIGHT NOW- ONE OPTION
WOULD BE TO GO FOR WITH ANY
GRANTS LOANS ON EVERY IS THIS
QUESTION PART BECAUSE- THE
ADMINISTRATION ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT. THROUGH THE SEATS
THINKING WORK FOR THE FUND
ITSELF. RESIDES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. JUST
TRANSITION ROAD MAP WHICH IS A
REPORT WILL BE RELEASED LATER
THIS YEAR- AND BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE HASN'T CHANCE. ON
GIVEN THAT HASN'T BEEN RELEASED
YET TO WEIGH IN WILL PROVIDE
COMMENTS OR FEEDBACK JUST
CONSIDER THE REPORT IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFICULT AT THIS POINT
TO MOVE FORWARD. I WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. ON HOW
TO ANSWER ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS- ON ICE OUR OFFICE
CHAIRS WITH BROAD GOALS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS. UP WITH THE
PANDEMIC RECOVERY- BUT IT'S A
MATTER OF OUT. OF LEGISLATIVE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW KEY
DETAILS ON ONE OF THE KEY
DETAILS THAT WE WOULD RAISE
YOUR ATTENTION HAS TO DO WITH
GOVERNANCE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP EARLIER.
THE FUND IS PROPOSED TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY. JOINTLY BY OPR
LABOR AGENCY AND COPIOUS BUT
THE GRANT WOULD BE IN
IMPLEMENTED OUR OR DISTRIBUTED
BY THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. I'M SO THIS IS FOR
ENTITIES OBVIOUSLY RELATED BUT
FOR DISTINCT ENTITIES THAT
WOULD GOVERN AND ADMINISTER THE
FUND. IT'S NOT CLEAR WHO THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD GO TO- FOR
PURPOSES OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO
DETERMINE HOW WELL THE FUNDS
WORKING. ON OTHER PROJECTS ARE
GOING FORWARD OR TO SUGGEST TO
DEMAND CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM-
IN FUTURE YEARS ALSO THIS IS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WE.
WE LEGISLATURE- THERE IS MORE I
DETAIL ABOUT THE MOVING THANK.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEPART OF FINE. WHO IS THE
MISTER. YES MA'AM HI DANIELLE
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I DON'T
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO
I DIDN'T- MY COLLEAGUES FLIGHTS
THAT TESTIMONY BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
FOR FINANCE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I JUST HAVE
HOPEFULLY ONE SHORT- QUESTION
AND THAT IS SINCE THIS IS-
THESE ARE FEDERAL DOLLARS RIGHT
THAT WILL BE USED. FOR THIS
FUND- ARE THERE ANY.
RESTRICTIONS OR LIMITATIONS-
EIGHT IF THERE ARE- IN THAT
SHORT ANSWER GIVE IT TO US
TODAY IF IT TAKES MORE
EXPLANATION WE CAN WE CAN GET
IT FROM YOU BUT ARE THERE ANY
RULES OF. FEDERAL RULES OR
RESTRICTIONS OR LIMITATIONS ON
HOW THE FUNDING IS USED. MISTER
WHO CAN ANSWER THAT. I CAN YOUR
FRIEND WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO THINK THAT THIS
IS AN ALLOWABLE USE OF THESE
FUNDS- AND I WOULD DEFER TO ADD
ANYBODY ELSE SAID- ON ME TEAM
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
BUT WE BELIEVE THIS IS
INELIGIBLE USE. AND WONDERING-
MANAGER BY IF YOU BARK FURTHER
COMMENTS I COULD RESPONSE TO
THE OF THE QUESTIONS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE L. A. O. SO.
SURE WE CAN KEEP YOUR ANSWERS
SHORT THANK AND SALUTE- THERE'S
A LOT TO SAY I WILL KEEP THIS
SHORT I WANT TO SAY FIRST OF
ALL THE- I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THERE IS. THIS IS DESIGNED
TO HAVE A CABINET LEVEL INTER
AGENCY WORK GROUP OF THE THREE
AGENCIES BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
PRIMARILY A WORKFORCE- FUNCTION
AS PRIMARILY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FUNCTION IS TIED
CLOSELY TO JOBS AND WORKFORCE
SO. THE IDEA IS THAT THERE IS A
FREE MARKET GUIDELINES THE
DECISIONS THE VALUATION METRICS
IS ALL ABOUT TAKING CARE OF A
CABINET DEPUTY LEVEL- SENIOR.
WE ARE HAPPY I WAS VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT WAS PROPOSED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS WE ARE
HAPPY TO SET UP A SCHEDULED TO
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON THAT. THE IDEA WAS A NIMBLE
FUND- THAT WE COULD STREAMLINE
THE STATE'S ROLE UP FRONT TO
GET THE MONEY OUT TO THE
REGION'S AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
IT WILL BE ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE LABOR
AGENCY YES BUT THE DECISION
MAKING. ARE THE ACCOUNTABILITY
WE ALL THE HEALTH- AT THAT
CABIN A LITTLE. US SO WE FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THAT IS A
WORKABLE- SOLUTION- AND
ACCOUNTABLE SOLUTION. THE THING
I WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE JUST
TRANSITION ROADMAP IS THAT. WE
HAD THIS ONCE IN A- LIFETIME
RIGHT OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST
THIS FUND IT WOULD BE CRAZY TO
COME UP WITH THE ROADMAP AND
THEN SAY THERE'S NO MONEY TO DO
ANYTHING RIGHT. AND THIS IS
ALSO I THINK THE IDEA OF STAGED
INVESTMENTS IS ACTUALLY
INTRIGUING BUT- I WOULD SAY
THAT- YOU KNOW. I FEEL LIKE
FOLKS HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF THE
PLANNING AND WE NEED TO PLAN
BEFORE WE INVEST THE MONEY BUT
THERE NEEDS TO BE. INVESTMENT
LIFTED UP BEHIND IT WE ALSO
SCHEDULED IN HERE. TO LET SOME
OF THE MONEY GO EARLY BECAUSE
FOLKS HAVE ALREADY BEEN DOING A
LOT OF THIS PLANNING IN THE
REGION- SO SOME OF THAT COULD
BE- PILOTED. THE ROADMAP LET ME
SAY SB THREE MORE AND WHAT IT
SAYS IS THAT. REGIONS HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER TO DO INDUSTRIAL
PLANNING TO DO WORKFORCE
PLANNING AS YOU ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION THE H. R. TWO
BEES TO THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PEACE. AND THAT THE
RESILIENCE FUNDS DOES THE
INDUSTRIAL PLANNING AND
ECONOMIC DIVERSIFICATION THAT'S
WHAT THE ROADMAP SAYS IT'S
REALLY THAT SIMPLE IT'S A
FRAMEWORK- THAT CALLS FOR THAT
AND CLOSE KNIT LIVED UP I MEAN
THIS IS WHAT WE WERE PROPOSING-
AND IT JUST SO HAPPENS THAT.
THAT WE'RE GOING HERE BUDGET
PROCESS RIGHT NOW SO JUST TO
CLARIFY THAT I UNDERSTAND-
SINCE YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHAT'S IN
IT- WE THINK THIS ALIGNS WELL
WITH IT BUT THERE'S NOT A SORT
OF SECRET AGENDA IN THAT- SO.
WANTED TO SAY THAT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE FUNDING AND
LEADERSHIP ABOR AGENCY AS
WELL. WE ARE CONVINCED THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH CAPACITY- GREAT
THANK YOU MISS WHITE- WE SEEN
MORE OF COURSE. ARE CALM. WE
YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION WE'RE HOLDING THIS
OPEN. AND WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SEVEN. WHICH IS NOW ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TANK THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE. THANK YOU
SECRETARY SOOOO AND EVERYONE-
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO. EVERY
SINGLE DAY PRESHEAF YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY WE AREN'T ISSUE
SEVEN A CALTRANS OF BUDGET
SUMMARY. WHO WANTS TO MAKE THAT
PRESENTATION WHO'S HERE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE YEAH MY NAME IS
THE STEPHEN CARE ACT I'M THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER OF
CALTRANS AND I'LL BE PRESENTING
ON BUT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER TO BE
OUR NORMAL OR REGULAR- MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS IN THIS ITEM.
AND THEN IN THE NEXT I'LL TAKE
UP THE LARGER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- TRANSPORTATION
PROPOSAL. SO FOR OUR
TRADITIONAL MAY REVISE FINANCE
LETTERS WE HAVE A FOR A TOTAL
FINANCE OTHERS NO I'LL BE BRIEF
IN GOING THROUGH THEM. THE
FIRST IS A- IS A TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM REQUEST FOR THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
FOURTEEN POSITIONS FOR- IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY FOR
LEGAL SERVICES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE DONE
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND WILL
YOU PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES IN
THE AREA OF- REAL PROPERTY
ACQUISITION AND- MANAGEMENT AS
WELL- SO THESE RESOURCES WILL
BE USED- FIRING PROPERTIES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY MADERA TO
CHAPTER STATEMENT AND THERE'S
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED- PARCELS
REMAINING. IN THAT AREA. THE
NEXT FINANCE LETTER THAT WE
HAVE. IS A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM REQUEST FOR TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWENTY POSITIONS. DO ESTABLISH
IN CAN'T MAKE ORDINATORS TO
MITIGATE SAFETY RISK I THINK
THE PAYMENTS ON STATE PROPERTY-
THESE- POSITIONS WELL PRIMARILY
LIAISE WITH THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCIAL
COUNSEL. AND FOR- WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS TO CONNECT THESE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO SERVICES AND TO
HOUSING. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
IS A- QUITE A NECESSARY STEP IN
DEVELOPING A MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTION FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESS. DOESN'T
DO US ANY GOOD TO JUST MOVE THE
PROBLEM FROM ARE RIGHT AWAY TO
SOMEBODY ELSE'S WE NEED TO- TO-
HELP COORDINATE- SERVICES FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
THE NEXT ITEM IS A PERMANENT
INCREASE OF TEN POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN OPERATING
EXPENSE- TO IMPLEMENT A
REPLACEMENT STRATEGY FOR THE
MOST CRITICAL END OF LIFE IT
ELEMENTS ARE IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. THIS IS
BORN OF A RECOMMENDATION- THEY
CAME OUT OF THE RECENTLY
PUBLISHED IN IN JULY TWENTY
TWENTY APPLICATION ROADMAP
STUDY. THAT WAS A STUDY THAT
WAS FUNDED EMPIRE BUDGET ACT TO
HAVE US LOOK AT WHAT WE REALLY
NEEDED TO DO- TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR IT SYSTEMS.
THIS IS BEYOND WHAT YOU MIGHT
THINK OF AS AN ID SYSTEM IN IN
THE NORMAL POWER PLANTS THIS
IS- THESE ARE INCLUDE SYSTEMS
THAT CONTROL- FREEWAY TRAFFIC
ARE RAMPS AROUND METRES LIGHTS
AND LANES- AND EVEN-
CONTRIBUTES TO THE MAINTENANCE
OF OUR HIGHWAYS AND BRIDGES. IN
THE FINAL OF THE FOR
TRADITIONAL MAY REVISE FINANCE
LETTERS IS A REQUEST FOR A FIVE
POINT. FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TEN POSITIONS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING- IN COSTS RELATED
TO THE CURRENT PHASE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM NETWORK.
DATA SAFETY DATA SYSTEM-
REPLACE OUR PROJECT. THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM NETWORK
IS A SAFETY DATA SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES VALUABLE DATA- AND
ANALYSIS AND HELPS US A
CALTRANS ACHIEVE OUR GOALS IN
REDUCING THE NUMBER AND
SEVERITY OF TRAFFIC COLLISIONS.
THE CURRENT AS TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM NETWORK DATA SYSTEM
COVERS LESS THAN 10% OF THE
ROADWAY NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA.
AND FEDERAL MANDATES REQUIRED
STATES HAVE A SEAT IT SYSTEM TO
PERFORMANCE YES IN ALICE'S
SUPPORTING BOTH THE STRATEGIC
HIGHWAY SAFETY PLAN. IN THE
HIGHWAY SAFETY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM- SO WE KNEW UPDATED AT
TRANSPORTATION SIFT SYSTEM
NETWORKS ET DATA SYSTEM- WITH
ALL THE REQUIRED CAPABILITIES
WILL PROVIDE A SUPPORT I'M
SORRY WILL PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
ADVANCE STATE DENOUNCES. AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND
IMPROVE ROADWAY SAFETY. THOSE
ARE THE FOUR TRADITIONAL ITEMS
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- BEFORE MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT- ISSUE IN YOUR TENTH.
OKAY WE HAVE A ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE ALEJO. I'M GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THANK MINUTES WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THE PROPOSALS UNDER- THIS ISSUE
ITEM RAISE NO CONCERNS FOR
OFFICE. THANK YOU. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. JAMES
MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF%
FINANCE- I HAVE NOTHING TO ADD
AT THIS TIME BUT HAVE TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY WE ON- WE
WANT TO SENATORS MY COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER SENATOR NEWMAN. I GUESS
YOU JUST ONE REAL QUICK
QUESTION HOPEFULLY FOR MISTER
TECH. I'M ON THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM NETWORK REPLACEMENT. TO
THE EXTENT THIS IS A NEW ITEM
IS PART OF THE REVISED- IS
THERE A REASON WHY WOULD HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE ORIGINAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL. ALL RIGHT HEY
YES ACTUALLY SO WE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON THIS ISSUE AND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO LOOK AT
FUNDING THIS FIRST STEP IN IN
REPLACEMENT OF THE- THE ITEM.
BUT WE HAD- ATTEMPTED TO GO
DOWN ANOTHER PATH FOR THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR- IT KIND OF
FELL THROUGH AND SO WE CAME AND
WORKED OUT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO BRING IT FORWARD
TO LEGISLATURE IS PART OF- AS
PART OF THIS- US. PRESIDENT
THANK THANK YOU. OKAY NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS SENATE QUARTERS EIGHT
NO COMMENTS QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF MR
CHARACTER ON THIS ISSUE SEVEN
WE MOVE ON HOLDING AN OPEN
ISSUE EIGHT S. TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE. THAT
YOU MISTER TECH AND YES I WILL
START OFF GIVING A SLIGHTLY
MORE LENGTHY OVERVIEW OF THIS
PACKAGE AND THEN OF COURSE-
THERE ARE SEVERAL PEOPLE ONLINE
READY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS FOR
THIS ONE. SO THE MAIN REBEL TO
THE TRANSPORTATION BUDGET
PROPOSES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN NEW
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OF COURSE- OF ON
MAINTENANCE OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'RE PROPOSING
OVER ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
STATE INVESTMENT IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TO PROPEL
IT EQUITABLE RECOVERY AND
POSITION THE STATE TO PURSUE
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL FEDERAL
FUNDING AS WELL. THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL CREATE QUALITY
JOBS AND ACCELERATE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS SUPPORT
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AND PROVIDE BETTER CONNECTIVITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. CALTRANS
CONTINUES TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG OF MAINTENANCE AND
HIGHWAY REPAIRS ON THE SYSTEM
ARE USING THE VERY SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN TRANSPORTATION
REVENUES PROVIDED THROUGH SB 1%
BUT WANT. ALTHOUGH REDUCE
TRAVEL DURING THE CODE PERIOD
HAS MARGINALLY AFFECTED TO
FORECASTED REVENUE OBVIOUSLY IN
A DOWNWARD TREND- WE'VE SEEN-
REDUCE TRAFFIC ON ROADWAYS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND AN
ANTICIPATED BID SAVINGS THAT
HAVE ALLOWED US TO ACCELERATE
PROJECTS AND WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS USING AVAILABLE. USING
USING ALREADY AVAILABLE FUNDING.
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO MAKING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS YEAR THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WILL
RELEASE THE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO KNOWN AS
CAPTAIN. THIS ACTION PLAN IS
THE PRODUCT OF A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT THAT INCLUDED A ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
AND IS MEANT TO BE A UNIVERSAL
FRAMEWORK FOR ALIGNING STATE
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS WITH
CLINICAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN. FRAMEWORK INCLUDES
GUIDING PRINCIPLES AND
STRATEGIES TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA TOWARDS A MORE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION. I'M
MORE SPECIFIC TO THE MAY REVISE
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND
RELATED ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
ACTIVITIES AND I'LL TRY TO WALK
THROUGH EACH OF THOSE ARE IN
AND IN TURN. THE FIRST IS A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT TO DELIVER CRITICAL
PROJECTS IN TIME FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC GAMES THE
LOS ANGELES AREA. THESE FUNDS
WILL ALLOW- I'M SORRY THESE
FUNDS WILL FLOW THROUGH THE-
CURRENTLY EXISTING TRANSIT
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION EIGHT. THE NEXT
INVESTMENT IS A ONE BILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT
FOR HIGH PRIORITY TRANSIT AND
RAIL PROJECTS STATEWIDE THIS IS
SEPARATE FROM THOSE I JUST
MENTIONED THAT WOULD IMPROVE
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN STATE AND
REGIONAL LOCAL SERVICE THESE
TIMES BUT ALSO FLOW THROUGH THE
TRANSIT INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM. THE NEXT INVESTMENT IS
A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT FOR
PROJECTS- THROUGH THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM INCLUDES PROJECTS THAT
INCREASE WALKING AND BIKING
THAT INCREASES SAFETY AND
MOBILITY OF NON MOTORIZED%
USERS. AND THAT ADVANCE
GREENHOUSE. REGIONAL GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS. THESE
PROJECTS ALSO ENHANCE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BENEFIT MANY TYPES
OF USERS ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THESE FUNDS ARE ANTICIPATED TO
BE USED FOR PROJECTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY. BEEN THROUGH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS- AND THEN
JUST AS BEEN ENOUGH TO KEEP UP
MAY. AND THIS WILL SOME OF THE
PROJECTS TO RECEIVE SOME HIGH
SCORE. THE NEXT IN. IN FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR IN GENERAL FUND
TO- CRITICAL STATE IMPROVEMENTS
AT. GREAT IN THIS IS A C. WHERE
YOU HAVE A- A RAIL OR LIGHT
RAIL CROSSING A HIGHWAY OR
STREET AT THE SAME LEVEL. THESE
ARE VERY DANGEROUS SITUATIONS
THAT WE TRY TO MITIGATE
WHATEVER WE CAN'T- BY
SEPARATING THEM TO TWO
DIFFERENT LEVELS- THIS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR- M.
INVESTMENT WILL HELP TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE MORE CRITICAL ONES
ACROSS THE STATE. THE NEXT
ISSUE IS A FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
PROPOSITION ONE A BOND FUNDS TO
COMPLETE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
CONSTRUCTION AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. ADVANCE WORK FOR
SERVICE BETWEEN HER SAID IN
BAKERSFIELD. AND ADVANCED
PLANNING AND PROJECT DESIGN FOR
THE ENTIRE PROJECT. THIS
INVESTMENT WILL ALSO LEVERAGE
POTENTIAL FUTURE FEDERAL. THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT STAFF NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE EXPANDED WORKLOAD
AS WELL. THE NEXT ITEM IS A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
THAT'S ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR IN DOLLARS AND SPECIAL
TIMES AND AT NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS
TO SUPPORT THE ADVANCEMENT OF
PRIORITY STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS PROTECTION PROGRAM
PROJECTS THOSE ARE OUR BREAD
AND BUTTER MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION PROJECTS. AND
ALSO INTER REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS. AS WELL AS LOCAL ROAD
AND BRIDGE INVESTMENTS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE NEXT
INVESTMENT IS A FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN ZERO EMISSION
RAIL AND TRANSIT EQUIPMENT
PURCHASES INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS
FUNDING IS A HUNDRED MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND AND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT FUNDING
AND TWENTY SEVEN MILLION FROM
FEDERAL. THESE FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO DEMONSTRATE AND
PURCHASE OR LEASE STATE OF THE
ART CLEAN BUS AND RAIL
EQUIPMENT AND TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL HELP
ELIMINATE FOSSIL FUEL EMISSIONS
AND INCREASE THE FREQUENCY OF
INTERCITY RAIL AND INTERCITY
BUS SERVICE. AND FINALLY- THESE
INVESTMENTS THERE'S ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENTS
IN ZERO EMISSION USING ZERO
EMISSION BUSES AND TRUCKS THIS
IS ONE POINT THREE BILLION IN
GENERAL FUND- AND EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION IN AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL. THIS MONEY WILL BE
USED TO DEMONSTRATE AND
PURCHASE OR LEASE GREEN BUSES
AND TRUCKS AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THESE FUNDS ARE NOT
BUDGETED AS PART OF
TRANSPORTATION. IS ACTUALLY
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PROPOSALS FOR CALLIE
P. A. IN ENERGY COMMISSION. BUT
I WANTED TO BRING IT UP HERE
BECAUSE THERE IS OF COURSE A
VERY CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE TRANSPORTATION. SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY VERY BRIEF SUMMARY
OF THE MAY REVISION A TO
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL- THERE
ARE REPRESENTATIVES HERE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY AND OF
COURSE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CORRECT- WELL THE L. A.
O. ONE TWO. IS THAT MR MENACE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ON
UNITS GROW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- THERE THE
PROPOSED THAT TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN TRANSPORTATION
SPENDING AND MOST OF THE
FUNDING CONSISTS OF ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS- AND THE CHANT
AND INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM AN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND
VARIOUS OTHER AT THE AND LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS- AND
GENERALLY. WE THINK THE KEY
QUESTION A REVIEWING THIS
PACKAGE IS WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE THINGS TO INCREASE
FUNDING ALINES THAT THE
BROADER BUDGETARY PRIORITIES
EITHER WITHIN TRANSPORTATION OR
OTHER PARTS OF THE BUDGET. AND
FOR EXAMPLE YOU WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER IT'S
DEDICATING A BILLION DOLLARS TO
PROJECTS ACCORDING TO LA
OLYMPICS ARE HAPPEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION ALLIANCE WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. AND
THAT CONCLUDES. OUR COMMENTS
RAPID THINK ANY QUESTIONS. YES
WE WANT MONEY FOR THE OLYMPICS.
SORRY COULDN'T RESIST. OKAY
DOES ANYONE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WANT TO COMMENT. AND
POLITICS PARTNER FINANCES WOULD
JUST NOTE THE IMPORTANCE WITH
THIS PROPOSAL THAT IT WILL
CREATE JOBS- EXCEL OR
TRANSPORTATION CONNECTIVITY
ACROSS THE STATE HELPS THE
STATE ACHIEVE CLIMATE GOALS AND
HELP THE STATE OF LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES CENTER
NEWMAN THANK YOU MEASURE AND
QUICK QUESTION FOR MR CORRECT A
REGARDING THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING- I KNOW
THERE WAS THERE WERE
CONVERSATIONS IN A ACTUALLY THE
PAST TO SEE TO SEE MEETINGS
ABOUT INCREASING THE
INCREMENTAL VARIABLE FOR THE
EIGHTY P. PROJECTS AND SO IT
APPEARS THAT THE FIREMEN THAT
THERE'S BEEN NO CHANGE- IS THAT
CORRECT. I'M NOT CHANGING IN IN
WHAT EXACTLY I'M SORRY I I'M
SORRY SHOULD BE CLEARED SO THAT
THERE WAS A RECOMMENDATION MADE
BY. I THINK THROUGH THE CDC TO
ASK FOR TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
YES INSTEAD OF THE I THINK THE
REASON PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED SO
THIS FIVE HUNDRED IS NOT AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED IT'S
THE ORIGINAL FIVE HUNDRED
CORRECT- SO IF I CAN SENATOR
THIS THE- PROPOSAL WAS MADE
AFTER. THE C. D. C. INITIALLY
PROPOSED A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO THE PROGRAM- SO
IT. IT'S NOT AND IT. ADDITIONAL
DOLLAR AMOUNT IT'S THIS IS A
NEW PROPOSAL- THE CURRENT SIZE
OF THE PROGRAM IS TWO HUNDRED
AND I WANT TO SAY AROUND TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SO THIS IS- TWO
YEARS WORTH OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. IN IN ONE AT ONE TIME
FUNDING- WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
THAT WILL HELP. OF THE VERY
HIGHEST SCORING PROJECTS THAT
JUST WEREN'T ABLE TO RECEIVE
FUNDING IN THIS LAST ROUND. AT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IS AN AWFUL
LOT OF MONEY- IN FACT AT THE
MOMENT THERE ARE THERE ARE- I
THINK THE TOTAL APPLICATIONS
FOR. THE LAST ROUND OF ATP
WEREN'T EVEN THAT HOT. NO I
APPRECIATE THAT I JUST TRYING
MY FEDERAL W. ON WHERE WE WELL
UP IT WHERE ONE OF SO I THINK
YOU MADE IT CLEAR SO IT SHOWED
THIS IS. THIS IS MORE THAN
ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED WHEN THE
BUDGET PROCESS STARTED. BUT
IT'S BUT IT'S IT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN WAS
PROPOSED BY THE CDC SO THAT
THAT'S THE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED
RIGHT. YES I COOK I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR-
SENATE QUARTERS THE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. NO THE
ONLY ONE I HAD WAS THE ONE THAT
WAS JUST SO AS WE CENTER NEWMAN
THANK YOU. GREAT I'M I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. ONE IS
HOW. HOW CAN WE BE SURE WOULD
WHAT KIND OF. GUARANTEES ARE
THERE IN ALL OF THIS- IT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
THE PURPOSE OF IT
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE EFFORTS-
I AGREE WITH THIS KIND OF
INVESTMENT THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT. HOWEVER I'M ASKING IS
WHAT ARE THE WORK FORCE
STANDARDS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET OUT OF. ANY YOU KNOW
PROPOSED- ARE JOB CREATION-
THAT ANYONE MIGHT BE COMMITTED.
TO SO I MIGHT AS YOU HAVE
ANYONE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS A BETTER CALCULATION
THE NIGHT BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING WHEN WE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT- THESE KINDS OF CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS. WE ARE TALKING AT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND JOBS CREATED
FOR EACH BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTED AT THAT'S FOR HIGHWAYS
WHICH OF COURSE IS WHAT I'M
MOST FAMILIAR WITH- THERE MAY
BE DIFFERENT NUMBERS- RELATED
TO RAIL AND TRANSIT- BUT THESE
ARE SIGNIFICANT- JOB CREATIONS
AND THOSE ARE DIRECT NUMBERS IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE SOMETIMES
YOU'LL HEAR FOLKS MIGHT TALK
ABOUT JOB CREATIONS. ABOUT THIS
TRICKLE DOWN OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT- OF DIFFERENT LEVELS
BUT- IT'S THIRTEEN THOUSAND IS
THE JET THE GENERALLY ACCEPTED
NUMBER THAT WE USE FOR HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION. I MIGHT MIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ANSWER- I WOULD TAKE IT I'M
ASKING TO GO A STEP FURTHER
WHICH IS NOT ONLY THE NUMBER OF
JOBS. BUT THE ACTUAL WORKFORCE
STANDARDS THE QUALITY OF THE
JOBS- AND- IN THE FIRST STEP IS
THE NUMBER BUT THE SECOND STEP
IS WHAT CAN WE EXPECT AS FAR AS
REQUIRING. ALL WORKFORCE
STANDARDS AND- IF WE DON'T
WATCH OUT FOR THAT I GUARANTEE
YOU THERE WILL BE MANY MANY OF
THOSE JOBS MANY THOUSANDS OF
THOSE JOBS WILL BE
SUBCONTRACTED OUT. AND WILL END
UP- YOU KNOW LOW WAGE LOW PAID
SOMETIMES EVEN WAGE THEFT JOBS
SO THAT'S MY THAT'S WHY I ASKED
THE QUESTION WHAT ARE THE WORK
FORCE STANDARDS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE ANY THEN I REALLY-
JUST WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THIS IS. AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY SO BILL THE
STANDARDS THE WORKFORCE
STANDARDS QUALITY OF THE JOBS-
ALSO. REACHING OUT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES- THAT USUALLY DON'T
GET THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS IN
THE WAY THAT THEY SHOULD OF
COMMITTEES OF COLOR WOMEN. LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES- THAT'S THE
SECOND ISSUE- AND- JUST TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE BUT IT- VERY
SPECIFIC- SORT OF THING THAT- I
HOPE THAT WE COULD ADDRESS. AND
THAT IS- AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES THERE ARE MANY GRADES
TRUCK DRIVERS WERE
MISCLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. THEY HAVE TO
SHOULDER THE COST OF
ELECTRIFICATION SO HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THIS FUNDING.
ENSURES THAT THOSE
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS ARE NOT
BEARING THE FULL COST OF THE
ELECTRIFICATION SO THAT'S A
SPECIFIC QUESTION BUT IT'S AN
EXAMPLE AT THE SAME TIME. OF
WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF WE ARE NOT
INTENTIONAL DELIBERATE AND
EXPLICIT WHAT WE EXPECT TO COME
OUT OF. SUCH AN A GREAT- MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. I
THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION SENATOR I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF- ANYONE AT THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT GIVEN YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT THE-
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THANK YOU.
YES MATT I'M SURE THIS IS CHAD
ADDISON FROM CALLOUSED YANG I
FOCUS A LOT ON THE RAIL AND
TRANSIT PROGRAMS AND
SPECIFICALLY IN THE TRANSIT
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM.
I'M ART THE SELECTION CRITERIA
FOR MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS BUT A
PRIORITY ON THE TYPES OF THAT
CONCERNS THAT YOU JUST RAISED.
SO WE HAVE BOTH DONE SELECTION
CRITERIA THAT FOCUSED ON
AGENCIES THAT APPLY BRINGING IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY WORKFORCE
AGREEMENTS AS WELL AS THE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS. AS%
SOMETHING TO HIGHLIGHT AND THEY
ALSO GIVE PRIORITY TO. A
WORKFORCE WORKFORCE STAFF FOCUS
ON ON THE PRIORITY POPULATIONS
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT THE
SELECTION PROCESS FOR ORDERED
PROJECTS INCLUDES ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THOSE DETAILS BUT WE
DEFINITELY. I TAKE TO HEART
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. OKAY. OKAY I JUST WANNA
INVITE- SERINA A STORY OF WHAT
WE WERE ABLE TO DO IN LOS
ANGELES- A FEW YEARS AGO. WHEN
THERE WAS FUNDING THAT WE
CREATED THROUGH AN INCREASE
OFFER A PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AN INCREASE IN OUR SALES TAX
AND THE BECAUSE WE INSISTED ON.
VERY SPECIFIC LEE LOOKING AT
HOW ARE WE GOING TO CREATE JOBS
IN THE AREA AND THAT WE ENDED
UP BECAUSE OF THE DELIBERATE
NATURE OF OUR EXPECTATIONS A WE
ENDED UP WITH ONE BRAND NEW
FACTORY. ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
FACTORY OFFER THE TRAINS AND
THEN ELECTRIC- BUS FACTORY WAS
ALSO BUILT AND BETWEEN THE TWO
OF THEM HAVE I DON'T KNOW OVER
A THOUSAND PLUS WORKERS SO I
THINK THIS IS THE THIS IS WHAT
I'M- YOU KNOW I HAVE IN MY
MIND. THAT WE CAN DO A LOT MORE
WITH THIS ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAN WHAT WE
TRADITIONALLY HAVE DONE SO.
CHECK THANK YOU EVERYONE-
THAT'S A- HOLDEN OPEN
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK THANK
YOU EVERYBODY WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NINE THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA
PACKAGE. THIS ITEM- I'D LIKE TO
HAND OUT TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE HEART ALSO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU STEVE AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ON
THE HEART WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION. I
AM EXTREMELY PLEASED AND
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA
PROPOSAL WITH YOU ALL. TO MAKE
THE PROPOSAL A REALITY HOW
TRAINS ARE FIVE THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM GENERAL FUND
INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. WHICH INCLUDES
RESOURCES FOR FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE POSITION. FOR THREE
YEARS TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM.
I MANY OF YOU ARE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR FOR YOUR CALTRANS HAS
CONTINUED TO INCREASE. OUR
INVESTMENT IN TRASH REDUCTION
ON THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
AND MEANWHILE OUR LEVEL OF
SERVICE HAS CONTINUED TO
DECREASE DECREASE ESPECIALLY IN
RECENT YEARS. WHILE CALTRANS
AND ALL OF THE PARTNERS THAT WE
WORK IN CONTACT WITH I THINK
YOU NEED TO INVEST SIGNIFICANT
TIME AND RESOURCES. IN THE
BAFFERT. AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
CURRENT PRODUCTION OF TRASH
THAT'S ENTERING THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM AND FRANKLY OUR
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE. IF
IT'S COMING IN AS A LATE AT ANY
RATE THAT WERE UNABLE. TO MEET
WITH EXISTING RESOURCES. THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOUR SO HIM THAT
THAT NOT THEM ASK FOR.
RESOURCES YOU CONTINUE TO PICK
UP TRASH FROM ROADSIDE NOT
CERTAINLY ONE PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL. BUT WHAT THE PROPOSAL
SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH IS REALLY A
RADICAL SHIFT IN THE WAY THAT
CALTRANS. OUR PARTNERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND TAKE CARE OF THE
PUBLIC SPACES ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M ON THE STATE AND THE LOCAL
SYSTEM THAT PROPOSAL WILL MAKE
LASTING IMPROVEMENTS THAT
EXTEND FAR BEYOND. THE THREE
YEARS OF THIS PROGRAM I'M A
HUGE COMPONENT OF THIS PROGRAM
THAT PROGRAM THAT SEEKS TO TAKE
EXISTING FACE. AND MAKE IT A
PART OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WILL BE CRUCIAL IN
THIS EFFORT. THROUGHOUT THIS
PROPOSAL THERE ARE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NOT JUST
LETTER ABATEMENT AND TRASH YOUR
EDUCATION. BUT ALSO
IMPROVEMENTS BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECTS THAT INCORPORATE ART
INSTALLATION. I THAT WILL BE A
IN IT HOPEFULLY INCORPORATED BY
ARTISTS FROM THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE. WHAT
WE FOUND IS PEOPLE DON'T TAKE
CARE OF THE PUBLIC FACES THAT
WE HAVE A LONGER FREEWAYS
ROADWAYS. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
SEE THEM AND THEY'RE OUT. I'M
THROUGH THE PROPOSAL WE REALLY
SPEAK TO DEVELOP. AND A NEW WAY
OF A CALIFORNIANS. LOOKING AT.
THE PAPER THAT THEY- AND THE
ROAD AND FREEWAYS THAT U. AND
FOR THE PROPOSAL WE THAT OUR-
IS. I STARTED NEED. I PUBLIC.
ARE THEIR OWN. YOUR POINT THIS
FOR. ALSO WILL DELIVER.
THOUSAND YOU AND HELP ACROSS
THE STATE. INCLUDING IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE
HUGE PART OF THE PROPOSAL IS
INCREASING CALTRANS EXISTING
PARTNERSHIP. WITH EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES. IMPORTANT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES ARE REALLY
INCREDIBLE IN THEIR MISSION TO
HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE OVERCOMING
BARRIERS TO WORK. INCLUDING
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. VETERANS ARE AT
RISK YOUTH. I CALTRAIN WORKED
THESE GROUPS BUT WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HOPEFULLY INCREASE OUR REACH.
AND DEVELOP REALLY AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
HAVE TO WEAR A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES. I CANNOT POINT
WE HAVE ANOTHER ASPECT OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT CREATE WELFARE
YOUR MEAT AND- COMPLICATION JOB
WITHIN CALTRANS. THAT ARE NOT A
JOB THAT REALLY CAREERS- WE
HAVE HAD PEOPLE WHO HAVE
STARTED IN THE JOB WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT FOR NOW EXECUTIVES
THAT CALTRANS. RIGHT THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GROWTH AND MOBILITY AND THROUGH
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS. THERE WOULD ALSO BE
SCHOLARSHIPS AVAILABLE TO ALL
THESE FOLKS AND YOU CHIU AND.
FOUR YEAR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. ANOTHER ON OF THE
PROPOSED IS THE IMPACT THAT IT
WILL HAVE ON OUR LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS. ON TRIBAL LANDS AND
TRANSIT CENTERS AND THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM THROUGH THAT THAT
INVESTMENT. NEARLY ONE THIRD OF
THE DOLLARS WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
LOCAL. AND THAT'LL BE FOR
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECT LETTER
ABATEMENT I'M ON LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
ON TRIBAL LANDS. AND AGAIN
WITHOUT CONCEPT OF. NOT JUST
CONTINUING TO PICK UP TRASH
ONCE IT'S ON THE ROADWAY BUT
REALLY COMING TOGETHER OUT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
YOU TO STOP TRUMP'S BEFORE IT
GETS THERE IN TO GET EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN IN TRANSFORMING OUR
PUBLIC SPACES. INTO PLACES THAT
WE CAN ALL TAKE PRIDE IN. AND
THAT WE ARE TREATED BETTER. I
FINALLY I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT AND WE WOULD ALSO
HAVE A COMPONENT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO BE A PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN. WHERE WE
WORK WITH STUDENTS AND PULLED
ACROSS THE STATE AND ALSO JUST
WORKED. AND I CAN KIND OF
CHANGE THE TONE IN TURN IN
TERMS OF THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT
OUR SYSTEM IN OUR STATE. I'LL
REITERATE THAT I OFTEN HEAR
THAT IT SEEMS THAT THE CALTRANS
IS NOT. I'M YOU KNOW COLLECTING
TRASH FROM ROADWAYS AND
CERTAINLY THE PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW US TO COLLECT TRASH FROM
ROADWAYS. ESPECIALLY AND URBAN
AREAS BUT ALSO ON EVERY STATE
ROUTE FRANKLY IN THE STATE. I
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO COLLECT
MORE TRASH AT A GREATER
FREQUENCY. I CAN TELL YOU I'VE
BEEN OUT WITH OUR MAINTENANCE
CREWS ON REQUESTED TRASH FROM
ROADWAYS. AND OFTENTIMES AND
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE IT'S SO
BAD THAT OUR CREWS ARE GETTING
HIT WITH TRASH I'M LOOKING IT
UP. AND WE HAVE PLENTY OF
PHOTOS THAT DEMONSTRATE AND
OFTENTIMES SEVENTY TWO HOURS
AFTER WE COMPLETELY CLEAN THE
LOCATION. TRANSACTION THREE
ACCUMULATED AND NOT LOCATION
AND IT LOOKED AS IF CALTRANS
WAS NEVER THERE. SO THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL IT'S REALLY THE
IDEA OF BRINGING OUR COMMUNITY
TOGETHER. INCREASING OUR
CALTRAIN FORCES INCREASING OUR
PARTNERSHIP. AND WHICH IS WITH
THE ORGANIZATION TO. PROVIDE
JOBS AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY
OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO WORK.
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO BREAK INTO
THE NEXT CHAPTER OF THEIR
LIVES. AND THEN AGAIN WORKING
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS. THE LOCAL
SYSTEM. THANK YOU THERE WITH
FACT. ARE IF THEY'RE ANY FOR.
THANK YOU MAY HART. THE I AM
VERY ABOUT THIS- OF PROGRAMMING
I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION BUT
WILL- START WITH THE- L. A. O.
ANY COMMENTS. YES FRANK JIMENEZ
AGAIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE WAY THIS
PROPOSAL AGAINST ITS OTHER
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES. ARE
GIVEN THE INCREASE IN TRASH ON
STATE HIGHWAYS AND LOCAL ROADS
WE FIND IT REASONABLE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING. FOR STATE AND
LOCAL- BUT OUR BASEMENT
EFFORTS. IN LOOKING AT THIS
PROPOSAL WE THINK THE KEY
QUESTION IS WHETHER
BEAUTIFICATION ARE PROJECTS ON
HIGHWAYS AND ROADS. ARE PART OF
THE LEGISLATURE ISM PRIORITIES.
OR AND WHETHER THERE ARE HIGHER
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES I'M
ALSO WITHIN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND JUST IN TERMS OF
GENERAL FUND SPENDING UNTIL.
THANK YOU MISTER JIMENEZ-
ANYONE FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
JAMES MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- JUST LIKE THATTHAT
WE CAN KERR WITH THE PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL ALLOW CALTRANS TO
INCREASE ITS LITTER ABATEMENT
EFFORTS AND ALSO ESTABLISHED
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WILL. REDUCE
LITTERING THE FUTURE AS WELL AS
WAS MENTIONED PROVIDE RESOURCES
FOR BEAUTIFICATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ENHANCEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU-
I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION. OUR
PROBLEM IS HEART. IS HOW WILL
THE MONEY BE DIVIDED SINCE WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS- ENORMOUS
NEED- ALL OVER THE STATE- RIGHT
I'VE HEARD THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
EITHER DONE BY POPULATION- LANE
MILES BUT HOW ABOUT. COURAGE OF
TRASH- NOT BE A CONSIDERATION
IN- DECIDING WHERE THE
RESOURCES ARE SPENT. ABSOLUTELY
ON OUR STATE THAT TIME WE
CERTAINLY LOOK AT ART WHAT WE
COLOR SIGNIFICANT TRASH
GENERATING AREA. THAT WE WOULD
BE INCREASING RHETORIC THE
REVOCATION DEFINITELY IN THE
AREAS WHERE WE PUT THAT WE
IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT CASH
GENERATING AREAS. SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY JUST EQUAL BUT THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE A FOCUS ON
THE STATE BANKFOR THE LITTER
ABATEMENT PROPHETICALLY. ADD
FOR THE BEAUTIFICATION PROJECTS
AND I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE BEAUTIFICATION PROJECT WE
EXPECT THOSE TO BE FUNCTIONAL
AS WELL I'M NOT JEFF AND GREAT
TO LOOK AT BUT ALSO TO SERVE A
PURPOSE IN TERMS OF. A WOMEN
NEEDING A LEGAL ABOUT PAYING
FOR PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM IRAN
FROM TRASHING. THERE'S CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE STATE AND LOCAL
SYSTEM WERE TRASHED IT TENDS TO
COLLECT. THAT WE INTEND EVERY
AFTER EVERY BEAUTIFICATION AND
EVEN A LOT OF OUR PATIENTS TO
HAVE A FUNCTIONAL COMPONENT AS
WELL. ON THE LOCAL SYSTEM IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE DOLLARS WILL
GO I DON'T CERTAINLY BE A FOCUS
ON UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
CALTRANS DEVELOPING A LOCAL
LOCAL PROGRAM AND REALLY. TRY
TO GET A LOCAL MATCH PROGRAM
THAT WILL BE DETERMINED BETWEEN
ZERO AND 50% MATCH- BASED ON
THE COPY OF THE COMMUNITY. TO
LEVERAGE LOCAL CAPITAL. THANK
YOU. OF I JUST STEP I JUST
WANNA TAKE UP TO TELL YOU THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY INSPIRED EVEN IF
THIS HASN'T BEEN APPROVED YOU
ALREADY INSPIRED A NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES IN THE AREA PART OF
MY DISTRICT- HOLLYWOOD A
DISTRICT BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
COMMITTED TO PARTNERING UP AND
PUTTING THEIR OWN RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO EVEN MORE-
ALONG THESE LINES SO APPRECIATE
THE- THE WORK YOU PUT INTO
THIS- ANYBODY WOULD HAVE.
SENATOR CORTESE ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS YOU KNOW THANKS.
THANKS MADAM CHAIR WORST YOU'RE
STILL ON THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA
PACKAGE RIGHT YES. C. O. C.
BASIS HERE- SO MS HIS HEART BUT
ANYWAY I. TO THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT- YOU KNOW I'M I'M
INTERESTED- A LITTLE MORE
INTERESTED IN THE DETAILS OF
HOW THINGS ARE YOUR PLAN ROLL
OUT SPECIAL INTERESTS LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS AND- I HAPPEN TO
BE. CHATTING WITH THE DIRECTOR
RECENTLY IN FRONT OF ME SOME
FORESHADOWING OF WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN BUT- WE'VE WE'VE HAD IN
MY HOME DISTRICTS ARE COUNTY
SOME. GOOD SUCCESS IN THE PAST
PUTTING TOGETHER PARTNERSHIPS-
YOU KNOW THAT INVOLVES
CONSERVATION CORPS FOR EXAMPLE
THE COUNTY THE CITY AND IN
CALTRANS YOU KNOW ON AN AMMO
YOU AND- SURE IT WAS A HUGE.
RELIEF TO LOCAL CONSTITUENTS TO
HEAR THAT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR. YOU
KNOW THAT'S SOMEONE ELSE'S
PROBLEM OR THAT'S YOU KNOW
DON'T DON'T CALL THE COUNTY OR
DON'T CALL NOW THEY DON'T WANT
TO HEAR FROM US DON'T CALL US
CALL WOULD BE GREAT SO.
BASICALLY PEOPLE JUST SEE IT AS
GOVERNMENT'S ISSUE IT WE DON'T
REALLY CARE. WHO HAS TO DEAL
WITH THAT SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
DEAL WITH IT SO I I'D LIKE THE
IDEA OF THE PARTNERSHIPS ALSO
LIKE THE IDEA OF A RICH
BECAUSE- ASSUMING IT DOESN'T
GET. YOU KNOW INTO A BIG ISSUE
IN TERMS OF. WORKFORCE
COOPERATION- YOU'RE CERTAINLY
WE'VE BEEN AWARE IN IN BIGGER
MECHANICS AND- SEVENS AND
PERSISTENCE OF THE MAINTENANCE
CREWS ARE JUST SPREAD VERY VERY
THIN. RELATIVE TO THE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT'S OUT THERE. IN THE
PANDEMIC'S EXACERBATED THAT
BECAUSE- OF- YOU KNOW RESTORE
LOCAL RESTRICTIONS ON- ON ON
HOW MUCH- CAN BE DONE IN TERMS
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION. OF
MOVING PEOPLE AROUND DURING
PANDEMIC SO FOR SO IT'S ALL
BECOME KIND OF THE PERFECT
STORM- BUT I'M JUST LOOKING FOR
MAYBE SOME OFFLINE NO I DON'T
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME IT'S
BEEN A LONG MEETING AND ON- SB
CANDID- YOU COULD PROBABLY GIVE
US A VERY GOOD BUT LATELY YOU
KNOW EXPLANATION OF HOW SOME
THAT MIGHT WORK BUT IF WE COULD
NOT GET TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND TO OUR OFFICE IS
JUST A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
OUTLINED IN TERMS OF. HOW
THINGS ARE RIGHT THE ROLL OUT-
COUNTY BY COUNTY. CONFORMANCE
TO BE MISS UNITED. YOU GET SOME
TO GET THIS MONEY S. ESSENCE
PUSH DOWN TO GET GEOGRAPHIC
EQUITY OR POPULATION EQUITY OR
WHATEVER'S GOING TO HAPPEN
INTERCHANGEABLE B. I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU'RE GONNA WORK ALL THAT
OUT BUT I THINK WE ALL HAVE A
LOT OF CURIOSITY ABOUT THAT AND
I THINK. WHEN WE GET DOWN TO
WORK OUR DISTRICT OPERATIONS
THE NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS
AND OTHER FOLKS THAT FRANKLY
CARE MORE ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN A
LOT OF CASES MEDIA ABOUT THE
BIG ISSUES LIKE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CLIMATE AND- IN PRISON
REFORM I MEAN THEY JUST WANT TO
KNOW HOW'S THIS GONNA GET
CLEANED UP SO AGAIN I'M ALL FOR
IT- IT WOULD LOVE TO GET SOME
MORE DETAIL- SOONER YOU KNOW
SINCE WE CAN'T. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING PROVIDED. MORE DETAIL IN
WRITING I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WHAT YOU'VE
SHARED AT THE DOCKET APPEARED
AT THE PROPOSED BALL I'M REALLY
TRYING TO BREAK DOWN
BUREAUCRACY. BRING TOGETHER
PARTNERSHIPS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHAT STATE GOVERNMENT MAKE
THINGS A LOT EASIER FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE. I'M AND DOWN TOGETHER
AND TRYING TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
MORE BEAUTIFUL PLACE- AND THE
PARTNERSHIP GO ALL THE WAY
FROM. CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE TO
THE STATE CONSERVATION CORPS
THAN ALL OF THE FOLKS THAT WE
WORK. WITH I WILL CERTAINLY GET
YOU IN MORE DETAIL. THANK YOU
KNOW THAT WOULD JUST SAY I'M
SORRY THE BILL. BUT- I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES AGREE WITH ME ON
THIS- THE SOONER WE HAVE AN
IDEA OF WHAT'S BEING OFFERED
ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S ANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MATCHES THAT MIGHT.
ENTICED TO THIS- THE OONER THE
BETTER BECAUSE AS THEY'RE ON
THE SAME CYCLE IS US IN A I
THINK I KNOW I WOULD- I'M
GUESSING MIKE TO CALL CENTER
HERE TODAY ON THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD ALSO DO THE SAME THING.
IS A WORD FOR LOCALS TO BE NOT
ONLY AWARE OF THIS BUT TO START
THINKING ABOUT FACTORY DIçN-
SOME SOME SOME KIND OF A
COLLABORATIVE MATTRESS SOME
KIND OF MONEY IN THEIR BUDGETS
TO BE PREPARED. NOT TO LEVERAGE
WELL WHAT YOU'RE OFFERING HERE-
IF THEY GET THERE THE SAME AS
US IF THEY WAIT TOO LONG TO GET
BE ON JULY FIRST- THEY'RE KIND
OF- IT'S LIKE FREEZE TAG YOU
HAVE TO WAIT A YEAR. YOU KNOW
TO PARTICIPATE IN MANY CASES
SO- SO WE WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO GET THAT INFORMATION
OUT TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IN OUR COUNTY AND- TO THE
EXTENT YOU CAN ENCOURAGE THE
OTHER WEBSITE OF OFFICES TO DO
THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE WOULD
BE SMART. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER COURTESY- THIS IS A WILL
HOLDING THIS ITEM OPEN- AND WE
MOVE ON TO WE HAVE TO MORE
ITEMS- I JUST WANT TO. LET
EVERYONE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
UNTIL SIX PM AND THE- WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT YET TO DO SO-
NEXUS ISSUE TEN- OF PROPOSITION.
ONE A. AUTHORITY. CLOSED GONNA
HAVE. YEAH MADAM AND- MY BY AND
I'M THE CHIEF. OFFICER AT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. I'M
GOING TO PRESENT THE MAY
REVISION REQUEST TO APPROPRIATE
PROPOSITION ONE A BOND FUNDS
FOR THE PROJECT. THE AUTHORITY
IS FOLLOWING THE PROCESS
SPECIFIED IN THE VOTER APPROVED
PROPOSITION ONE A BOND ACT FOR
APPROPRIATIONS. WHICH INCLUDE
SUBMITTING A FUNDING PLAN TO
THE LEGISLATURE NINETY DAYS
PRIOR TO FORMALLY REQUESTING
THE APPROPRIATIONS. THE FUNDING
PLAN WAS SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH
AND NOW THE MAY REVISION
FORMALLY REQUEST THE
APPROPRIATIONS. BASED ON THE
FUNDING PLAN SUBMITTED IN
FEBRUARY THIS SUBCOMMITTEE AND
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
HELD A JOINT HEARING ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH THERE REVIEW THE
FUNDING PLAN. THE MAY REVISION
BUDGET REQUEST IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WAS OUTLINED OF THE
FUNDING PLAN. AND AT THE MARCH
HEARING. THE AUTHORITY IS
SPECIFICALLY REQUESTING FOUR
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND
PROPOSITION ONE DAY FUNDS TO
COMPLETE WORK ON THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT FROM MADERA TO POPLAR
AVENUE WHICH IS NORTH OF
BAKERSFIELD. THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PROP ONE A. FUNDING WARM SIR
ENSURE SUFFICIENT CASH FOR THE
PROJECT AS REMAINING FEDERAL
FUNDS CANNOT BE EXPANDED YET
AND CAP AND TRADE FUNDS WILL BE
RECEIVED OVERTIME. THIS
APPROPRIATION IS NEEDED IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BECAUSE
WITHOUT T WE PROJECT WE WILL
RUN OUT OF MONEY IN EARLY
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. IF CASH FLOW FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORK IS
INSUFFICIENT WORK WOULD HAVE TO
BE SLOWED AND WORKERS LAID OFF.
AT THE MARCH HEARING THE
AUTHORITY OUTLINED PROGRESS ON
CENTRAL VALLEY CONSTRUCTION.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS THE
NUMBER OF STRUCTURES COMPLETED
OR UNDER CONSTRUCTION HAS
TRIPLED FROM NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. AND WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO MILES OF
GUIDE WAY. UNDER A COMPLETE OR
UNDER CONSTRUCTION NOW. WITH
THE PROPOSITION ONE A BOND
FUNDS REQUESTED HERE WE CAN
COMPLETE THAT WORK. SECOND THE
AUTHORITY IS REQUESTING ONE
HUNDRED MILLION IN PROPOSITION
ONE A BOND FUNDS TO SUPPORT
PLANNING PROJECT DEVELOPMENT
AND ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. FOR
THE PHASE ONE SYSTEM THE SAN
FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES
ANAHEIM SEGMENT. FINALIZING
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK ON PHASE ONE
SEGMENTS WILL OCCUR OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. WISSAM
COMPLETING THIS CALENDAR YEAR
OTHERS AND TWENTY TWO AND-
EARLY TWENTY THREE. A THIRD THE
AUTHORITY IS REQUESTING TEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN STATE
OPERATIONS AUGMENTATIONS IN
FIFTY SIX POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THIS WORK. SINCE THE JOINT
HEARING IN MARCH THE BOARD
ADOPTED AND SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE FINAL TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. THAT PLAN
OUTLINES NEXT STEPS TO GET HIGH
SPEED RAIL PASSENGER SERVICE UP
AND RUNNING BETWEEN MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD BY THE END OF THE
DECADE AS THE FIRST BUILDING
BLOCK OF THE STATEWIDE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM. I WITH THE
MAY REVISION. OF THE
AUTHORITIES PROPOSITION ONE A
APPROPRIATION IS PART NOW OF
THE LARGER TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE WHICH MISTER CAPTAIN
OTHER SPOKE UP. FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN IN THESE OTHER
TRANSPORTATION AREAS WE THINK
THESE STATE MONIES WERE
POSITION CALIFORNIA TO BE WE
HOPE FIRST IN LINE. FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
ARE NOW BEING DISCUSSED BY THE
BY DEMONSTRATION AND ALSO THE
U. S. CONGRESS. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. WE'RE
GOOD THANK YOU MISTER LEWIS.
FROM THE L. A. O. ANY COMMENTS.
UNDERESTIMATE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SO OUR HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS
ARE VERY SIMILAR TO THE ONES
THAT WE DISCUSSED WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN MARCH SO COVER
THEM PRETTY QUICKLY IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I KNOW OF THE
HOUR IS LATE. IN SUMMARY WE
THINK THESE PROPOSALS REPRESENT
A KEY DECISION POINT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WITH REGARD TO THIS
PROJECT WE SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER TWO MAIN
THINGS AS IT MAKES DECISIONS ON
THESE PROPOSALS. IS ITS LEVEL
OF CONFIDENCE THAT THE
AVAILABLE FUNDING WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT THE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT.
THE AUTHORITY EXPECTED EXISTING
FUNDING WILL BE ROUGHLY
SUFFICIENT THAT WE KNOW THAT
THE PROJECT HAS HAD A HISTORY
OF INCREASES IN COSTS. SECOND
WE SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ITS COMMITMENT TO
FULLY FUNDING THE PROJECT. THE
LEVEL OF COMMITMENT TO MEETING
A FUNDING GAP OF ANY THAT COULD
EMERGE YOU CONSTRUCTING THE
PERCENTAGE BAKERSFIELD THANK
MIGHT AS WELL AS ITS COMMITMENT
TO FINDING FUTURE SEGMENTS. IF
THE LEGISLATURE IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
EVEN IF THE FUNDING GAP EMERGES
AND IS ALSO COMMITTED TO
FINDING FUTURE PROJECT SEGMENTS
THEN WE THINK THE AUTHORITIES
GENERAL APPROACH IS REASONABLE.
HOWEVER IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
NOT PREPARED TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO FUNDING WERE SAID
TO BAKERSFIELD AND FUTURE
STATEMENTS AT THIS TIME. IT
COULD PROVIDE SPECIFIC
ALTERNATIVE DIRECTION SUCH AS
THREE BUDGET OR TRAILER BILLING
LANGUAGE. AND OR DELAY ACTION
ON SOME OR ALL OF THE
APPROPRIATION REQUEST TO LATER
IN THE SUMMER OR EVEN TOLD THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR. WE NOTE THAT
DELAYING ACTION COULD PROVIDE
MORE TIME FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION ESPECIALLY GIVEN
ALL THE OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE-
IN FOR THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
NOW. AND ALSO PRESERVE AND
NATURAL LEGISLATIVE DECISION
MAKING POINT. TO BE NOTED THAT
IN ADDITION TO THESE BIG
PICTURE CONSIDERATIONS WE JUST
OUTLINED OUT WE DO HAVE SOME
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THEY WERE
STILL WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORITY ON ON THAT PARTICULAR
FREE SUPPORT. PROPOSAL AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THEM ON THIS ON THIS QUESTION.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CHRISTY- THE L. A. O.
ANY COME. I DON'T KNOW SORRY
THE SLATE OKAY WITH OF DOES
THE- DETERMINE FINANCE SORRY.
READ ACCOUNTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROPOSAL
AND WOULD KNOW THAT IT IS A
CONSISTENT WITH THE BUSINESS
PLAN THEN A FUNDING PLAN. AS
RENDON INSTEAD INDICATED WAS
RELEASED BACK FEBRUARY- WE DO
BELIEVE THE SONS OF THESE
PATIENTS IN ORDER TO COMPLETE
THEIR CENTRAL VALLEY STUDY FROM
GEORGE. THANK YOU. OKAY. SENATE
CRITICIZING ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NO THANK YOU MANAGER.
OKAY I THINK THAT DOES IT THEN-
WE'RE LEAVING THIS OPEN AND
MOVING ON THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED- ISSUE ELEVEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS TIME AND THE CLOSING
POSITION WITH ALL OF YOU- I AM
KATHLEEN WHAT CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT
F MOTOR VEHICLES THE TV
CONTINUES TO TRANSFORM INTO AN
EFFICIENT MOBILE AND CUSTOMER
CENTRIC OR ORGANIZATION IN
EFFORT TO BRING OUR SERVICES TO
EVERYONE ANYWHERE. WE HAVE
ACTUALLY INCREASED OUR ONLINE
SERVICE OFFERINGS BECOME MORE
EFFICIENT OUR OFFICE JUST FOR
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS AND
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT AS WE PROCESS
MILLIONS OF TRANSACTIONS EVERY
WEEK EVERY WEEK FOR ALL OF OUR
CHANNELS WE CAN TEAM TO COLLECT
REVENUE FOR THE STATE REDUCE
TRAVEL ON TRANSFER MILES AND
SAVE TONS OF PAPER. EFFORTS
HAVE INCLUDED EXPANDED KIOSK
DEPLOYMENT LAUNCHING A
REDESIGNED RESPONSIVE WEBSITE
ADDING THE ABILITY TO ACCEPT
CREDIT CARDS IN OUR FIELD
OFFICES AND EMPLOYING-
IMPROVING UP WEIGHT TRAINING TO
FOCUS ON CUSTOMER SERVICE. THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES PROPOSALS
TO CONTINUE THESE IMPROVEMENTS
AND IT'S CHANGING CONDITIONS
INCLUDING THE ONGOING PANDEMIC
AND THE CHANGING FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS THE MAY REVISION
ALSO INCLUDES RESOURCES FOR A
NEW MOBILE IDENTITY PROGRAM I
WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO LEAST
THOUGHT PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW. OF
OUR BUDGET REQUESTS. YES A GOOD
SHARON AND COMMITTEE OF SO
THANK YOU FOR THE UP. TO YOU
THIS. I'M IN. ANY AGENDA WELL
SOME OF. THE POINTS I WANT TO
MAKERS ABOUT EIGHT ITEMS THAT
WILL GO THROUGH ALL ALL TRY TO
KEEP THE HIGH LEVEL AS I KNOW
THAT WE'RE AT THE END OF THE
DAY. ARE THE FIRST ONE ON
DRESSES THE RELY THE
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS- THIS
THIS PROPOSAL IS BASICALLY THE
SAME FROM WHEN WE SUBMIT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ARE WE JUST
WANTED ANOTHER WE'RE GONNA
PROPOSED TO SHIFT FOUR HUNDRED
NINE MILLION OVER FOR FISCAL
YEARS BEGINNING A BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. FROM
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT TO
THE GENERAL FUND. HI THIS IS
GOING TO PROVIDE US WITH SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO ADJUST OUR
WORKFORCE EXPENDITURES. LOOK AT
OUR CHANGES TO PASSED THE REAL
ID. I'LL BE STILL EXPECT TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
TRY TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE THAT
TRANSACTION EASIER WHETHER YOU
CAN DO IT FROM HOME WHEN YOU'RE
UPLOADING YOUR DOCUMENTS FIRST-
GETTING A PRE APPROVED SO THAT
WHEN YOU CAN- GET A
CONFIRMATION TO SHOW THAT YOU
ARE BUILDING. A READY TO GO
INTO A FIELD OFFICE. WITH AN
APPOINTMENT- WE HAVE ALSO. TO
PROVIDE ABOUT POINT MILLION.
UNIQUE REAL ID SO FAR WE NEED
TO PROD. ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION OVER THE NEXT THREE
FOUR TO FIVE YEARS. WE HAVE
REDUCES TRANSACTION TIMES AND
HEALTH- USED TO BE ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES NOW WE'RE ABOUT TO TEN.
WE CONTINUE TO ROLL OUT AN
AGGRESSIVE MARKETING PLAN
STARTING IN BUDGET HERE- AND AS
WE OP THAT WE WILL SHOW OUR-
CUSTOMERS AS WELL. THAT THEY
DON'T NEED TO NECESSARY
PROVIDER SO SECURITY CARD.
ANYMORE THEY CAN JUST PROVIDE
THE NUMBER AND WE WILL CHECK IT
FOR YOU. AS THE- THIS PROPOSAL-
IT IS PRETTY MUCH THE SAME
WE'RE JUST GONNA LET YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING OVER
TO THE GENERAL FUND. BUT THE
NEXT PROPOSAL THAT WILL TALK
ABOUT AS THE DIGITAL
ACCELERATION FACILITIES AND
TALENT ACQUISITION- GIVE HE
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE SERVICE
SERVICES TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF CUSTOMERS. THIS IS
BEING ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENTS AND NEW
OFFERINGS OF WEB AND MOBILE
OPTIONS. ARE WE WORK CONTINUED
OPENING UP OUR CHANNELS THE
DIFFERENCE SERVICE CHANNELS
MORE WAYS TO GO DIGITAL. MY
NAME MORE DATA AND GETTING MORE
DIGITAL FORM- IN THIS PROPOSAL
AS- WAS CAPPING WEBER HAS
STATED. THERE IS A TEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S GOING TO BE
GOING TOWARDS THE MOBILE
IDENTITY- DRIVER'S LICENSE. A
THREE MILLION WILL BE A PROTECT
IMPLEMENTATION ANOTHER THREE
MILLION FOR BUSINESS PROCESS
ENGINEERING FOR ANOTHER FOUR
MILLION FOR A PILOT SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT. WILL WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT CTS TO ROLL OUT A
PILOT PROGRAM- FOR THE NEXT
PROPOSAL THAT WE WILL WORK ON
IS THE DIGITAL EXPERIENCE
PLATFORM PROJECT BOB THIS IS A
MAJOR PROJECT HERE AND CAN BE
AS WE MOVE AWAY FROM A
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS BUILT IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. IT'S
THE REQUESTED FOR FIFTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO- IT'S ABOUT A FIVE TO SIX
YEAR PROJECT. WHERE WE WILL
FIRST START THE FIRST PHASE
WILL BE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
WILL BEGIN THAT AND- AND BUDGET
YEAR. AS WELL AS STARTING IN
OUR VEHICLE REGISTRATION. AND
THEN WE WILL FINANCE THE CAR
DRIVER'S LICENSE SO WILL BE
BROKEN DOWN INTO THREE PHASES.
I WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
C. T. I. THIS. WAS KIND OF BORN
OUT OF THE C. T. INCOME UP
STRIKE TEAM- ANALYSIS WHERE
THEY'RE SHOWINGSPECIFIC
PROBLEMS WITH THE ABUSE COURT
LIKE SEE SYSTEM- YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO AVOID ANY SYSTEM
LIMITATIONS- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ACCOMMODATE
ANY CHANGES IN THE FUTURE. ANY
FUTURE ALLEGE BILLS THAT COME
IN- ANY PARTNERS WITH OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT WANT TO
PARTNER WITH US AS WE HAVE A
LONG REACH. THAT WE CAN.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
KEEP COSTS LOWER. THE FOURTH.
PROPOSAL THAT I WILL DISCUSS IN
STATE TO STATE. IDEA BECAUSE
REQUESTING FUNDING OR RESOURCES
ABOUT NINE POINT SIX MILLION.
INCLUDING ABOUT ELEVEN TEN HELD
POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ZERO. INCLUDING FUNNY ALSO FOR
A HUNDRED ELEVEN TEN POLE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- I. STATE TO STATE IS
BASICALLY WHAT THE REAL IDEA
ACTORS REQUIRING US TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. AND WHAT WE
WILL CHECK WITH ALL OTHER
STATES TO DETERMINE IF THE
APPLICANT CURRENTLY HOLDS A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR REAL ID
CARD ANOTHER STATE. SO IT'S
BEEN PRETTY HIGH LEVEL THE IDEA
IS THAT. IF I GO TO FLORIDA AND
I TRY TO APPLY FOR A REAL ID.
OF FLORIDA WOULD THEN
COMMUNICATE WITH CALIFORNIA AND
TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
RELY TO USE UP THEIR- ARM. AT
THE STATE OF RECEIVE THAT
CONFIRMATION- IN ANOTHER STATE
OR POSSESSES A REAL ID CARD IN
ANOTHER STATE. OF THE RECEIVING
STATE MUST TAKE MEASURES TO
CONFIRM THAT THE PERSON HAS
TERMINATED OR IS TERMINATING
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE OR- ID
CARD. ISSUED PRIOR TO PRIOR
STATE SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE SHOWING WHO IS NOW
THE HOME STATE. HI THIS IS
REQUIRED BY THE FENCE- AND I
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PROPOSAL. WE HAVE AN S. B. TWO
TEN. OUT OF THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FINAL OVER WORK WITH
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THIS IS FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE INSPECTION
AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. UBS
REQUESTING ONE TIME
IMPLEMENTATION RESOURCES FROM
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FINE
TO CONTINUE IMPLEMENTATION THAT
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH SB
TWO CHAD. LEGISLATION IS
REQUIRING- THAT THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A
BANK REGULATION FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE INSPECTION MAINTENANCE.
FOR NON GASOLINE MOTOR VEHICLES
WITH A GROSS WEIGHT RATING. OF
MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND
POUNDS. THIS FOR BILL BASICALLY
REQUIRES DMB TO WITHHOLD
REGISTRATION FROM THOSE
VEHICLES WHO FAILED. TO
ESTABLISH EMISSION COMPLIANCE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A NEXT WE ALSO
HAVE AB EIGHTY FIVE WERE WE
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AT CD
TFA- THEY CURRENTLY HAVE A
PROPOSAL. INDIA VS IS GOING TO
REQUEST INCREASES REIMBURSABLE
ACCORDING TO EXPLAIN IT
PROJECT- AUTOMATE THE
COLLECTION OF SALES TAX FROM
USED CARS AND REQUIRED BY ABA
TO FIVE ANY ZERO. AND WE ALSO
HAVE A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROPOSAL. IS REQUESTING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FROM
FROM VARIOUS SPEECH BACK AND
REPLACEMENT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. OTHERS
FUNDING WILL PRESERVE THE
CONDITION EXTEND THE USEFUL
LIFE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
ABOUT SEVEN POINT FIVE NINE AS
THROUGH THE H. FACT DESIGN AND
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS AND
ANOTHER TWO POINT FIVE ABOUT
REPLACEMENTS. WE ALSO HAVE IT'S
NOT ON THE AGENDA BUT WE ALSO
SIX PROPOSALS THAT ARE RELATED
TO CAL POLY PROJECTS AS WELL.
THE OVERALL THEME- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT MOVING FORWARD JUST
TO CONTINUE TO GO DIGITAL
COMPUTER REDUCE PAPER. WE ALSO
HAVE SOME STATUTORY CHANGES AND
WELL THAT THAT THAT BASICALLY
RUNS PARALLEL WITH THAT THEME.
AND WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE I
KNOW THAT WAS KIND OF FAST AT
THE END OF THE DAY OUT OF IT
YOU STILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I
MISS KATHLEEN ABOUT BUYING HER
ANSWER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER SCRAP. OF DO WE HAVE
THE- L. A. O. ANY COMMENTS. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR UNITS
DROVE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE THREE QUITE
COOPER COMMONS REGARDS CARE THE
DMV PROPOSAL FIRST- WITH REGARD
TO THE REAL ID PROPOSAL WE NOTE
THAT THE INTERNATIONAL REQUEST
IN JANUARY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS EXTENDED THE
REAL ID DEADLINE FROM OCTOBER
TWENTY WINES HERE. MAY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE NOW THERE IS ALL
THE DEPARTMENT DID NOT- REVISED
A LEVEL FUNDING BUT PROPOSES TO
EXTEND ENCUMBRANCE CARRIED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR FIND UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO MEET
CUSTOMER DEMAND. HOWEVER
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT REMAIN THAT
MAY IMPACT THE LEVEL OF
TEMPORARY STAFF NEED INFIELD
OFFICE SAYS- AND BASED ON THE
WORKLOAD AND GUARANTEES HE
RECOMMENDS THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE BUDGET YOUR
FUNDING REQUEST FOR A REAL ID
SUPPORT. AND REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT BACK NEXT
YEAR WITH THE REVISED
PROJECTION OF CUSTOMER DEMAND
AND ADJUSTED I FUNDING REQUEST
AND CONSISTENT WITH OUR JANUARY
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT LEGISLATURE
APPROVES THAT PORTION OF THE
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENT. AND
SECOND WITH REGARD TO DIGITAL
ACCELERATION FACILITIES AND
TALENT ACQUISITION PROPOSAL- WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET REQUEST
THAT'S NOT INCLUDING THE KEY
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO GET SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION. AND CONTINUED TO
REVIEW SUCH INFORMATION AT THE
PARTNER PROVIDES THEM. HOWEVER
WE DO FIND THAT THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE LESS LIKELY TO
BE IMMEDIATE PRIORITY SO IT'S
AN INTERESTING DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE PROPOSAL
BY THE TIME YOU HAVE TO PASS A
BUDGET WE RECOMMEND THE
REJECTION OF THIS REQUEST- AND
FINALLY ANSWERED IT WITH
REGARDS TO DIGITAL- EXPERIENCE
PLATFORM PROJECT- AND WE JUST
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED BY YOUR FUNDING ONLY
TO ENSURE GREATER LEGISLATIVE.
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROJECT GIVEN
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS I. D.
PROJECT IN THE PAST AND THIRDS
OF THE DEPARTMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF PREVIOUS I.
T. PROJECT- AND THAT CONCLUDES
OUR COMMENT. THANK YOU ZERO-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCEPLEASE. MADAM CHAIR MATTHEW
WITH THE OF- JUST TO COMMENT.
THE REAL ID REQUEST- YES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MOVED THE
DEADLINE OUT TO MAY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- HOWEVER WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT- THE
DEMAND OF THE TOTAL ADOPTION
RATE OR DEMAND OF. ALL
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUES TO BE
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION IT'S
JUST A QUESTION OF WHEN THEY
COMMAND- PROVIDING ALL THE
FUNDING- NOW- ALLOWS WITH WITH
THE VISUAL LANGUAGE ALLOWING
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO ADJUST YEAR
BY YEAR- WILL ALLOW US TO
PROCESS ALL OF THOSE- REAL
ID'S- INREGARD TO THE DIGITAL
ACCELERATION REQUEST- WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE L.
A. ON PROVIDING THE-
INFORMATION- IT'S REQUESTING- I.
SAY THESE PROJECTS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT PROPOSAL-
REALLY HELP BRING DMV INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- AND KIND
OF CREATE THAT VISION OF THE
DMV OF THE FUTURE- THAT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS- AND THIRDLY- FOR THE
DIGITAL EXPERIENCE PROJECT-
DALY IS RECOMMENDING- ONE YEAR
FUNDING WE'RE RECOMMENDING
APPROVING THREE YEARS BECAUSE-
THE PROJECT IS COMMENCING IN
PHASES AND WE WANTED TO FIND-
THE FIRST TWO PHASES SENSE- THE
SECOND PHASE IS SCHEDULED TO
BEGIN- IN JANUARY THIS COMING
JANUARY AND SO. IF YOU HAVE ONE
YEAR FUNDING- YOU MIGHT RISK-
ACOSTA INCREASES DUE TO. THE M.
VISA ABILITY TO- TELL POTENTIAL
CONTRACTORS THAT- FUNDING IS IN
PLACE BUT I CAN LET DMV EXPAND
ON THAT IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU
MISTER. SEVEN- SENATOR CORTEZ
THE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
NONE THANK YOU MANAGER OKAY
WELL AGAIN THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH WE'VE REACHED THE END OF
OUR ISSUES APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
WORK THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR
NINE SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN. TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. GERMANUS A TWO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY TODAY I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT
KEEP YOUR REMARKS TWO WITHIN A
MAXIMUM OF ONE MINUTE NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. THEME NONE
OF WILL MOVE INTO. LAW ON TO
WITH WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE- MISS
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FORTY IN Q. WE'LL START
WITH WIND THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. ONE THREE TWO.
SHARE AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
HOUSE ALANINE I'M A PROGRAM
COORDINATOR CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
AND I'M A PRISONER ADVOCATE I'M
CALLING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
YOU PROVIDE REPARATIONS TO THE
VICTIM LIVES SURVIVORS OF
FORCED STERILIZATION
CALIFORNIANS BURDEN I'M ALSO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE MANY
CURRENTLY AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED VICTIMS SURVIVORS
WHOSE VOICES YOU'VE NEVER
HEARD. WE ALL THANK ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WENDY CARILLO AND- YEAH
IN NAME OUT THERE ARE GO FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS THE
SEVEN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND
FIND ONTO THIS IMPORTANT THAT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE AGAIN
GIVING. PEOPLE HOPE WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN NONE. GIVEN THE
LARGEST. NOW BEST TIME FOR CAL.
TO CONFRONT THIS SHAMEFUL
HISTORY AND TAKE A DEFINITIVE
STAND AGAINST RACIST. SEXIST
AND ABLEIST PRACTICES WITHIN
OUR PENAL SYSTEM. FILE IN ITS
COMPLEXITY. ESTABLISHING A FOR
A MEASURE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL DISCOURAGE AN ADDRESS
MEDICAL PRACTICES THAT SERVE
ONLY TO PERPETUATE EXISTING
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES IN OUR STATE BY
PROVIDING REPARATIONS FOR THE
EGREGIOUS FORMS OF REPRODUCTIVE
OPPRESSION CALIFORNIA CAN BE
AMONG THOSE STATES LEADING THE
NATION AND- ADVOCATING THESE
LINGERING VESTIGES OF EUGENICS.
HIDING THIS HUMBLE CONVICT.
WOULD REPRESENT A MOST
IMPRESSIVE DEMONSTRATION OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE I URGE YOU
TO INCLUDE THIS. SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MOST
COURAGEOUS CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE POLICE TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS UNDER A MINUTE SO
WE CAN MAKE SURE EVERYBODY GETS
IN. NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. OKAY WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS EILEEN BURKE- AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE TRUTH AND
RECONCILIATION COMMITTEE OF
NEIGHBORHOOD UNITARIAN
UNIVERSALIST CHURCH IN PASADENA
AND I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL FOR REPARATIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF INVOLUNTARY
STERILIZATION- CALIFORNIA WAS
IN THE FOREFRONT OF.
CELEBRATION ALL THROUGH THE
COUNTRY AND IT'S TIME THAT WE
DO SOMETHING ABOUT PAYING OUR
DEBT THOSE WHO WERE HARMED SO
MUCH- AND WE BETTER DO IT NOW
TO BE FORTY TWO RIGHT AND THERE
ARE STILL WHILE THERE ARE NO
VICTIMS YOU CAN BE HELPED IT'S
TIME FOR ALL OF US ET AL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO WAIT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS BUT I THINK
HE THAT WOULD KEEP YOU PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF MERISTEM
IN REGARDS TO AGENDA EIGHT PART
B. ISSUE FIVE UNDER THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
SCHLERETH DONOVAN STRONG
SUPPORT FIVE MILLION ALLOCATION
TO PROGRAMS TARGETING
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM.
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
COMMITMENT TO CREATING AN
EMPLOYER CULTURE THAT IS
INCLUDING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABILITIES SHE- SACRAMENTO
BASED EDUCATIONAL. OF STATEWIDE
PROGRAMMING THAT IS DEDICATED
TO PREPARING YOUNG ADULTS ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM FOR A LIFE
AND GREATER INDEPENDENCE AND
FULFILLMENT. FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL HELP KERRY FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL BREAKING BARRIERS
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES TRAINING
TO EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH BEST PRACTICES ON
RECRUITING INTERVIEWING HIRING
TRAINING. AND RETAINING
INDIVIDUAL DOCTORS IN THE
INTEGRATED JOB PUTTING GOOD
COMMANDS RETAIN THEIR NON
ARCHITECTURE HE HEARD YOU TO
SUPPORT THE FUNDING IN
SUBSEQUENT TRAILER BILL TO
ENSURE THIS WORKING SCANTRAXX.
STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WANT THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SPARKY HARLAN AND I AM CEO BILL
WILSON CENTER AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND WE THIRD
OVER NINE HUNDRED HOMELESS
YOUTH AND FAMILY MEMBERS EVERY
NIGHT. I AM IN SUPPORT OF PART
EIGHT ISSUED TO BACK THE ONLY A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR VOCAL PLANS
THAT WE'RE LOSING SOME OF THE
FANS AND ALSO A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND HOUSING PROGRAM
AND HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES. PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD EXPAND UP TO TWENTY MORE
COUNTY IF THEY'RE WELCOME
CENTER LOSSES ONE TIME FUNDING
WE WOULD LOSE OVER 75% OF OUR
HOMELESS YOUTH SERVICES AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WE NEED THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING AGAIN TO
CONTINUE OUR WORK THAT WE DO
FOR HOMELESS YOUTH IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
THREE GO AHEAD. HELLO- OKAY MY
NAME IS ERIC SALEM STATE
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SAID GET TO
TECHNICIANS AND I REPRESENTS
LIKE TAX WORKING FOR THE STATE
IN OUR STATE MENTAL HOSPITALS
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
CORRECTIONS FIVE TAX HAVE
WORKED THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
RISKING THEIR HEALTH THEIR
LIVES AS WELL AS THE HEALTH AND
LIVES OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND THROUGHOUT THAT TIME THEY
DONE SO WITH A 10% PAY CUT- AND
ALSO THEIR REYES IS BEING
WITHHELD- WE OBJECT TO ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE NUMBER ELEVEN-
IN THE REDUCTION OF TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN
POSITION THAT C. H. YES
STOCKTON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. THANK
YOU I WON FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. NINE ONE FIVE ZERO.
RIGHT ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING DANIEL
SANCHEZ I'M THE OPPOSITE SHE
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA REGARDING A UNDER
JUDICIAL BRANCH COMMISSION
CHIEF SUPPORT THE GOLD OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
TO FOCUS ON SAFETY FAIRNESS
EQUITY AND EFFECTIVENESS FOR
JUSTICE. INTEREST IN THE BALD
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR COMMUNITY WE
SEE THE EXPANSION OF THE
EXISTING JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE
TRIAL PROGRAM TO MAKE IT A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM AS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE GOAL
FOLLOWING THE HUMPHREY DECISION
COURTS WILL BE IMPLEMENTING
PREACH TRIAL DECISION WITHOUT
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING A HUNDRED
PERCENT. TO ENCOURAGE THE
RELEASES REPORT TO RETURN TO
COURT IN EXPAND OPTION AT LEAST
RESTRICTIVE OPTIONS AVAILABLE
THE LEGISLATURE HAD ME CLEAR
THE CONCERN REGARDING JUSTICE
BY GEOGRAPHY AND WITHOUT A
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK AT CREEK
THE END OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATA AND OTHER FACTORS THERE IS
LIKELY TO BE A DIFFERENT
APPLICATION IN THE PRE TRIAL.
EXTENSION OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED AND
OPERATED BY THE COURT DIRECTLY
MITIGATE THAT CONCERN ON
DESPERATELY IMPLEMENTATION AND
BUILD ON EFFORTS ALREADY UNDER
WAY TO ESTABLISH A UNIFIED
APPROACH TO THE PARENT
MINISTRATION OBJECTIVE THANK.
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT THANK YOU. NEXT THANK
YOU I'M FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
PLEASE ON BEHALF OF S. C. I.
CALIFORNIA WANTING TO START
WITH A FEW ITEMS ON- TOP AGENDA
A THAT WERE ACTUALLY LAUGHED
OUT OF THE NAME REVISED AS IT
RELATES TO THE COURT BUDGET WE
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR A
MODEST TRANSCRIPT RATE INCREASE
FOR COURT REPORTERS. ALL
AMOUNTS OF FUNDING FOR A
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FIND.
I'M ON AUGMENTATION TO ENSURE
THAT CORE OPERATIONS THAT NEED
TO BE- ATTRACTING THE COURT
BACKLOG AND THE ANTICIPATED
INFLUX OF INCREASED WORKLOAD AS
IT RELATES TO THE ADDICTION
MORATORIUM. BE AN AUGMENTATION
TO THE BUDGET AND SPECIALTY
COURT. WE ADDITIONALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE WORLD SHOULD HAVE OF THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED FOR LEGAL AID. WHAT
DRAFT THE NEEDS OF THE RUN
FIRST BASE AN AFFECTION WE
BELIEVE ITS POTENTIALLY
INSUFFICIENT WE ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT. FOR
THE. FUNDING ALLOCATION FOR.
THE TRIAL THAT TO MAKE SURE IT
EXPAND TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT-
ARKANSAS THAT THE- IS BUT AN
PROFESSIONAL TO ACHIEVE THE
STATED GOAL. ONLY ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SORRY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. THANK YOU RUN ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BACKROOM FOREIGN NUMBERS WHEN I
THINK ABOUT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LOOKING AT THE
REPRODUCTIVE TACTIC AND WHEN
YOU'RE ACCUSED THE COURT OF THE
SEVEN AND A HALF MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUEST TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO DRIVERS ARE
THOROUGHLY PATIENT IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS AND
HOSPITALS. BETWEEN NINETEEN OH
NINE AND NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
CALIFORNIA LED THE COUNTRY'S
ECONOMIC MOVEMENT TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE A LOT OF THE
ABILITY TO DECIDE OVER THEIR
OWN BODIES I THINK PANELS
NINETEEN BACKING UNFIT. TO
REPRODUCE AND CLIENT. GIVEN ALL
EXCEPT A YOU TO THE- BECAUSE
AND BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WON SIX FOUR
PLEASE CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON
CORBEAU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION COMMENTING
ON THE ISSUE FIVE WELL WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE FUNDS TO GO
TOWARD EXPANDING TRAINING FOR
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
INCLUDING THE LAUNCH OF THE
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR REGISTERED
DENTAL ASSISTANT. THE DEMO
FACTOR WHICH WAS UNDERSTAFFED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC IS STILL
DOWN ABOUT TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
LOCAL JOBS COMPARED TO CREATE
AND THEN A GLOBAL. EDUCATIONAL
THE STATIC THE SHOW THAT DOWN
OFFICES ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING
AT 85% I THINK I THINK THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM OFFER A
PATHWAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING THOSE WITHOUT A
COLLEGE DEGREE INTO AN
ATTRACTIVE CAREER AND I THINK
WORKING ENVIRONMENT. THIS
TRAINING PROGRAM WILL LEAD TO
NEW JOBS DURING THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT THANK YOU ARE YOU TWENTY
GO AHEAD. I GET AFTERNOON IF AT
ALL THEY EVERYTHING THAT AND
POWER NOW THE CHARACTERS
CALIFORNIA. I'LL BE GOING OVER
THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS COALITIONS
IN PRE TRIAL ACT BRITAIN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO EXPAND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PROBATION LIKE
RECALL PILOTS AND AFFECT THE
BODY REJECTED FUNDING IN EFFECT
PROVIDE COUNTY FOR FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED PRE TRIAL
SERVICES. LOS ANGELES IS ONE OF
THE COUNTY FOR THE PILOT IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN THE RESULT
FROM THE GROUND UP INTO
STARTING EITHER COUNTY
LEADERSHIP NOW THE PUBLIC IN
THE PD SOMETHING TO DATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PILOTS
MONITOR FOR RACIAL AND GENDER
BIAS. SO WE GET A P. ALL RIGHT
AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT. 97%
OF THOSE ON SUPERVISED RELEASE.
FINALLY FOR PLAY ON ALEX. BONTA
OF THOSE CHARGED WITH. SEVENTY
EIGHT. WERE IN CUSTODY BLACK
CHARGE WITH FELONY FOR A MAN.
HI RATE- ARE TO LOWER. AND WHY
WOMEN. IT'S RESPONSIBLE BIG FAN.
THAT LACK OF PROVEN FOR RECORD
AT THE FACT. QUALITY REVIEW AND
LONGER TERM BENEFITS WHAT DOES
NOT PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS. OUR COMMUNITY BAKERY
TRUCK SERVICE MODELS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO AND SANTA CLARA.
COUNTIES WILL BE MISSING
CORRECTION WITH OUR BOARD THE
DOCKET CARE FIRST YEAH LAST
ROAD MAP. ALONG COUNTY THE
ECONOMY EMPLOYMENT INNOVATIVE.
COMMUNITY BASED GREENHOUSE
SERVICE MODEL THAT APPLE THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE I LOOK
AT JUST THE BY THE L. A. L.
WHAT INCREASE THANK. YOU JEFF
OPULENCE REDUCTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. NEXT THANK YOU
BYEONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD TO WORK ACT AND
SALAS FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF POSTAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION BUDGET REQUEST TO
PROVIDE REPARATIONS TO
SURVIVORS OF FORCED
STERILIZATION UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S EUGENIC LAW AND I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS BY
THE OTHERS SPEAKERS WHO SPOKE
ON THE PREVIOUS PLAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU RUN
ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRAIN MEMBERS
MEANING THAT THERE TONIGHT AT
THE FILLING YOUR NUMBER
RESIDENTS OF SOUTHEAST DOWNEY
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION BUDGET
REQUEST DISCOVERS THE FOURTH
GENERATION COMPENSATION
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR MURDERED ANOTHER VESSEL
THREE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT REQUEST AND BLACK
INDIGENOUS LET THE NEXT
INCARCERATED PEOPLE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND POOR PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN PRIMARILY CARRIED
INTEREST IN THE NATION. AT THE
SAME POPULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
INTERESSIERTE MICHAEL THE
NINETEEN AND HAVE BORNE THE
BRUNT OF CALIFORNIANS LIKE
LEGACY JENNINGS NOW THE TIME
FOR ALL TO HEAL PLEASE ENSURE
THAT SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
BUDGET REQUEST AND IS INCLUDED
IN THE FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONCE THREE
PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK THE PROPOSAL PROVIDING WE
CALL AT THE OF ACT TECHNIQUE.
BURKE I WOULD LIKE THAT I THINK
SENATOR NEWMAN AND CHAIRED OVER
CALLING IT AND TO ISSUE FIVE ON
THE AGENDA NUMBER ELEVEN. YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL THE PROPOSAL BEING
VERY WELL COMMITTEE AT THE ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED SIX THANK YOU
AFTER THAT THANK YOU AFTER
TECHNICIAN POSITION. AT EPA OR
B. YEAH BOSTON. HE HAD SO MUCH
WORK FOR THE BANK AFTER
TECHNICIAN THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
FORCING OUR MEMBERS WORKING
MANDATORY OVERTIME BEYOND THE
LIMITATIONS FILLED OUT IN OUR
CONTRACT. ON TOP OF IT ALL.
OKAY NURSES HAVE BEEN THE
TEMPER PAY CUT HAD RAISED THAT
WERE- SO THAT IN THE COUNTRY
THE FOR. HAVE PRE NO ILL
INMATES WITH KOBE AND I THINK.
IT WHILE DOING THEIR- NOW THE
DEPARTMENT STAYING NEARLY HALF
OF THOSE DENTAL WORKERS ARE NOT
NEEDED MY QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. OR THE SAME TWO
HUNDRED AND SIX THANK YOU AFTER
TECHNICIAN. NOT NEEDED FOUR
MONTHS AGO DURING THE PEAK OF
THE PANDEMIC WHILE THEY WERE
WORKING. A MANDATORY. SHIFTS A
MONTH WORKING BACK TO BACK TO
BACK SIXTEEN HOUR DAY. WE HEARD
IN THE GARDEN STATE THAT THESE
POSITIONS WOULD BE TRANSFERRED
TO OTHER PRISONS. BUT THAT
SEEMS HIGHLY ILLOGICAL
CONSIDERING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE KEY
POSITIONS AT OTHER. PROGRAMS
THANK YOUNG AGE GROUP THERE ARE
MARKETABLE I APPRECIATE. IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING.
THANK YOU RUN ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU.
THAT THE- GOOD EVENING EMPOWER
NOW YOUR LAST NAME. FIRST ROUND
REJECTED PROP TWENTY FIVE BUT
THE BIG REASON ONE OF THOSE
REASONS WHAT THE DEEP LEGACY OF
HARM IN CORRUPTION AND ABUSE AT
THE HANDS OF PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE IDEA THAT WE SHOULD EXPAND
PILOT PROGRAMS THAT WERE PUT
FORTH UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THE
PROP TWENTY FIVE A PATH TO
PROVIDE EARLY IMPLEMENTATION.
IS FRANKLY BAD GOVERNANCE AND
WE DO NOT NEED ANY MORE BAD
GOVERNANCE IT'S GOING TO CAUSE
HARM IN THE BUTTE. WHEN THE
DIRECTION. WE GOT THE PRE TRIAL
SERVICES IS ONE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WELLNESS AND LYFT CUT
SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENGAGING IN WHAT IS ALREADY A
DIFFICULT PROCESS WITH THE
COURT SYSTEM WE CANNOT GIVE
MORE MONEY TO PILOT PROGRAMS
THAT WERE REJECTED BY WELL OVER
HALF OF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHO VOTED IN
NOVEMBER BECAUSE WE DO NOT WANT
PROBATION CONTINUE TO ENCROACH
ON THE LIVES OF OUR PEOPLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. THANK YOU I WON
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JUDY HYMAN
WITH THE JUSTICE TO JOBS AND
CHARACTERS CALIFORNIA COALITION
I URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE
AND EXPAND PROBATION LEAD PRE
TRIAL SERVICES PROGRAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHY YOU WOULD
AGREE TO EXPAND AND
EXPERIMENTAL PILOT PROGRAM
BEFORE HAVING DATA TO EVALUATE
WHETHER IT'S HELPFUL OR HARMFUL
OR HAD NO IMPACT. PARTICULAR
GIVEN YOUR CONCERNS FROM THE
START ABOUT BIASES TO SPECIALLY
TROUBLING THAT THE GOVERNOR
WANTS TO EXPAND AND FINANCES
PROGRAM IN PLACE WITHOUT
COMPLETING RACIAL IMPACT
ANALYSIS. VERY LIMITED
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
VOLUNTARILY FROM THESE PROGRAMS
AS YOU HEARD EARLIER WE HAVE
SOME INFORMATION COLLECTED TO
PROBE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST IT SUGGESTED THESE.
PROBATION RUN PROGRAMS MIGHT BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. ENDING UP
INCREASING MASS INCARCERATION
BY CONTRAST WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
THAT PRE TRIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS RUN BY NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES BY PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY GROUPS HAVE ACTUALLY
SHOWN POSITIVE RESULTS. LIKE
LONELY ARRESTS IN HIGH COURT
APPEARANCE RATES AT MUCH LOWER
COST WHILE STILL ENSURING
PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING IN SICK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE THREE
SIX. BY TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. THANK YOU FOR.
YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS TO CLARIFY KEY I'M A
POLICY ASSOCIATE AT THE JUSTICE
GROUP AS THE JUSTICE GROUP IS A
LEADING POWERFUL ORGANIZATION A
WOMEN'S BOBSLED OPEN BEEN
INCARCERATED I ASKED THE BODY
TO THE JACK THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
TO INFUSE A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS- I'M SPENDING
ON PROBATION LEAD PRE TRIAL
PROGRAM WE'RE EXPANDING THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL COULD HELP
PILOT PROGRAM IS ANTITHETICAL.
TO A WELL A CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
OUR PROGRAM AS MY COMMENT PARTY
WITH IT. CONCERNING DISPARITIES
REGULARLY FOR WOMEN IN LOCKING
HOW BOARD BEACHWOOD OF THE
CLAIM OF THE PROGRAMS WITHOUT
REALLY IN. THAT COME OUT OF MY-
INSTEAD WE ARE VERY OF WHAT ARE
ALONG AREN'T FIRST COMMENT.
THAT WE CONFUSED. AT THE- INTO
CLEAR BASED GOOD HOW ARE
AGENCIES AND PROGRAMS INSTEAD
OF. APPROACH THANK YOU THE
PILOT PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME'S CYNTHIA
CHANDLER I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
I'M SPENT MUCH OF THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS WORKING WITH
PEOPLE IN PRISON TO DOCUMENT
AND EXPOSE MODERN FORCING
CRYSTALLIZATION ABUSING
CALIFORNIA PRISON AND I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE TEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUEST TO ESTABLISH THE
POOREST YOUR REALIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM. I GUESS
WHAT I CAN REALLY SAY IS IT'S
TIME. AS SOMEONE WHO- HAD THE
MISFORTUNE OF HAVING TO INFORM
PEOPLE THAT THEY WERE
STERILIZED WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE I'VE SEEN THE
HORRIFIC IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
KIND OF POLICY IT WAS REALLY
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF HISTORICAL
INTEREST ENDING OF THE HORRORS
OF THE HISTORY OF EUGENICS.
THAT THAT MODERN ABUSES ABLE TO
REOCCUR I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
BE PART OF THE MOVEMENT OF
CHAMPION THAT WILL PERMANENTLY
AND THE RESET AND CLASSES
PRACTICE OF EUGENICS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE. OF THEM GO AHEAD. NOT
J. POCKMARKED WITH DIGNITY AND
POWER NOW IN THE CHARACTERS-
CALIFORNIA COALITION- ACTIVE
BODY TO REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
HUNDRED FORTY BILLION DOLLAR-
SPENDING OBLIGATION THAT PRE
TRIAL PROGRAM PROGRAMS FRIENDLY
THE SAME THING ONE MOMENT
YOU'RE WELCOME OPPOITION
TWENTY FIVE WHICH WAS ROUNDLY
REJECTED BY CALIFORNIA VOTERS
IN FACT COUNTY THAT ALREADY HAD
OF PRETRIAL PROBATION AND
PRETRIAL POLLUTED REJECTED PROP
TWENTY FIVE I COUNTED THIRTEEN
THAT LEE. WAS NO MEANINGFUL
DATA COLLECTED ASSESSMENT
REVIEW LEASE PROGRAM THAT WOULD
WARRANT ANY FUNDING LET ALONE
EXPANSION ARTS TO GIVE THEM ANY
MONEY WOULD BE WIRED OF THE
RESPONSIBLE EXACTLY LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE EFFECT BROUGHT UP
EARLIER HE DID A GOOD INTERNET
COMMISSION ACTED QUICKLY FOUND
OUT THEY WERE ACTUALLY VERY
HARMFUL TO OUR COMMUNITY- WE
WILL BEGIN OUR THAT THAT. WHAT
HAD BEEN SUCCESSFUL COMMUNITY
BASED PRE TRIAL SERVICE MODEL
MIKE ONE FACTOR CONTROLLING
CHINA CLARA- IT WAS THE. FOR TO
MOVE TOWARDS THAT- THANK YOU.
THIRTY AFTER REJECTING. THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU LINE SEVEN
SEVEN CALL. YEAH I JUST WANT TO
OUR- WORD AND NOT A MINUTE-
EVERYONE HAS ONE THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. ONE WONDERFUL DAY YOU HI
COURTNEY HANDS ON THE OF THE
CAL CALL FOR A FOR. AND FOUNDER
OF THE CAR STRAIGHT TALK BUT
PROBLEM OF THE FOR. ABSOLUTELY
YES PLEASE FIND NOTIFICATION
AND COMPENSATION FOR SURVIVORS
OF FORCED STERILIZATION AND I'M
ALSO CALLING TO URGE YOU. TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR IS A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE TRIAL
PROBATION LEAD PILOT PROGRAM.
TO THE TUNE OF NOT JUST ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
NOW BUT SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING ANNUALLY WE DESPERATELY
NEED THE MONEY FOR ROBUST
COMMUNITY BASED. PRE TRIAL
SERVICES THEY'RE PROVEN TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE AND LESS COSTLY
MANDATE A REPORT FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL NOTE THAT THE
QUALITY OF THE DATA THEY
RECEIVE. FROM COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN HORRIBLE. GOVERNOR STAFF
SO THERE'S NO FUNDING FOR RACE
OR GENDER. EQUITY ANALYSIS TO
FIGURE OUT IF THESE ARE WORKING
OR NOT THERE'S NO DATA
TRANSPARENCY OR CLEAR SIGNS
THAT THEY'RE WORKING IN FACT
WE'VE SEEN IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THAT PROBATION PILOT. EXPAND
THE NET CREW CAN DECRIMINALIZE
SURVEILLED AND INCARCERATED
THANK YOU JOHN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR CALLING I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK BYE ONE
FIVE PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALEX STERN AND I'M A
CALLER ACTIVISTS WHO STUDIED
THE LONG AND TRAGIC HISTORY OF
COURSE DELEGATION IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY LOOKING AT THE
HISTORICAL SURVIVORS THE TIME
IS NOW PASSED THE COMPENSATION
BILL AND HUNDRED AND FUNDED AT
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. EVERY YEAR WE ESTIMATE
DYING AND SO THE TIME IS THAT
YOUR TO ADDRESS THIS IS NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR HAD. YOU CAN
HEAR ME YES YOU GO HASN'T. BY I
AM CALLING- AND THE PERSON
WHO'S IN THE MOVABLE MIDDLE IF
YOU WILL AND I AM HERE TO CALL
THE TO CALL OUT TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S ONE HUNDRED FORTY
BILLION DOLLAR PRE TRIAL
PROGRAM WE KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW
INTEREST IN LOOKING AT THE CHIU
JUDICIAL COUNCIL REPORTS THAT
THEY'RE JUST COMPLETE PLOT-
THEY'RE NOT. TAKING IT FOR
SOMETHING THE EFFORT INVESTMENT
OF SEVENTY MILLION AND AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION NEXT YEAR AND THEN
SEVENTY MILLION THERE AFTER WE
REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
WHERE THAT MONEY'S GOING THIS
IS JUST BAD GOVERNANCE TO BE
THREE FILLING UP A PROGRAM THAT
SIMPLY A PILOT PROGRAM WITHOUT
KNOWING ITS GOAL- NEGATIVE AND
POSITIVE CONSEQUENCES. AND MAKE
NO MISTAKE BUT THIS INVESTMENT
IS TRULY AN INVESTMENT IN MASS
INCARCERATION OR RATHER MATH RE
INCARCERATION WE NEED WE NEED
TO BE CLEAR THAT WHEN THIS
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
GO TO THE COUNTY IT'S GOING TO
BE SPENT IF WE LOOK AT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
85% OF IT IS GOING TO GO TO
STAFF AND THE VAST MAJORITY IS
GOING TO BE GOING TO LAW ARMED
A PROBATION OFFICER THANK YOU
FOR CALLING THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONCE NINE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ELENA SANTA MARIA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ITEM ONE THE OFFICE
OF EQUITY AND LEAST THOSE
PROGRAMS SENATOR ALSO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
QUESTIONS OF WHAT OTHER
AGENCIES ARE DOING ON EQUITY
AND HOW THE OFFICE OF EQUITY
WITHIN- YES WILL WORK IN
COORDINATION WITH THE BROADER
GOAL OF ADDRESSING SYSTEMIC
RACISM WITHIN GOVERNMENT.
ADDRESSING EQUITY WILL TAKE
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL WORK-
LIKE THE PRACTICES OF HIRING IN
ENSURING AGENCIES WHO WANT
HISTORIC WHO SUPPORT WHO WANT
TO SUPPORT HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. LIKE
THE LEAST DOES PROGRAM WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTORS OF-
YESS COMMENTS EITHER RELATES TO
EQUITY WORKING ENCOURAGED HIM
TO LOOK AT THE HIRING PRACTICES
WITHIN- YES. OTHER TWENTY
TWENTY PROGRAM MANAGERS ONE
STAFF- YES ARE 73% WHITE AND
83% MALE THE PROGRAM THREE
MANAGERS ARE 1100% WHITE. THE
SENIOR EMERGENCY SERVICE
COORDINATORS ARE 60% WHITE AND
THE EMERGENCE SERVICE SPEED
MANAGEMENT COORDINATORS AND
INSTRUCTORS ARE 65% WHITE AND
73% MALE. WE HOPE AS IT RELATES
ACTUALLY THE EQUITY OFFICE
BUDGET REQUESTS CREATE RACIAL
EQUITY ACTION PLAN. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. THANK YOU BYE ONE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS I'M CALLING FROM LIKE
IN ST SERVICE I THINK THIS GOES
LARGEST NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
SERVICES DON'T NEED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS I'M
CALLING ON IN REGARDS TO PARK A
ISSUE Q. AND I'M AT THE CORNER
OF THE ENGAGE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT MAY REVISE TO BACK
FILL. THE LAW A FEDERAL BROKEN
HAND. I'M ALSO CALLING FOR.
HUNDRED YOU'LL ONE GENERAL FUND
REQUIRE FOR- WE ASK TO CONTINUE
THE HOME YOUTH ARGUE THESE
SERVICES AND HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND THE HOMELESS YOUTH
EMERGENCY SERVICES HI THE
PROGRAM. AND LET ME SEE THAT
EXPANDED- TO AT LEAST TWENTY
MORE COUNTY. AT LARKIN STREET
THIS PROGRAM FUND. CRITICAL
SERVICE. INTENDED MEALS
THOUSAND OF COUNSELING SESSIONS
SHELTER BED NIGHT TABLES ASIAN
PLANTS FOR YOU IT WAS A
CRITICAL PART OF MAKING SURE
THAT MY COUNTRY TO KEEP OUR
DOORS OPEN WITHOUT INTERRUPTION
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC PLEASE
ENSURE THAT THESE BONDS ARE
RESTORED ON BEHALF OF YOU TO
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
SAN FRANCISCO AND ACROSS THE
STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SONYA GOOD JOB A LOT
WITH- EACH UNIT REPRODUCTIVE
AND GENDER EQUITY CALLING ON
THE VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST TO
COMPETITION I READ THE FIRST
EDITION THAT WERE HARMED OVER
THE PERIOD OF MORE THAN SEVENTY
YEARS OF RACIST SEXIST AND
ABLEIST EUGENIC LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA WAS THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE STERILIZER IN
THE COUNTRY STERILIZING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND TO SIXTY
THOUSAND RECORDED NATIONWIDE-
WE LIKE ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND JOIN
THEM IN AFRICA CALIFORNIA TO
CONFRONT THE SHAMEFUL HISTORY-
AND FINALLY TO COMPATIBILITY
POLITICALLY JUST TORN UP AT THE
BACK TO THE QUESTION I URGE YOU
TO INCLUDE THE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
IN THE FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING.
THANK YOU I KNOW TWO PER GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THE MANY MANY
HERE WITHIN ON ASSOCIATION WE
NEED TO FOCUS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGING SHOULD
DO TO HELP YOUR MORE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS AS A TRANSFORMATIVE
OPPORTUNITY- THROUGH THE AIR
QUALITY AND MAHOUT THIS IS ARE-MOST. INFLUENCED AND IMPACTED
COMMITTEE ON THIS OCCASION
SUPPORTS TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGES FOCUSED ON TRANSIT AND
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION TO REDUCE
HARMFUL POLLUTANTS IN THE
IDYLLWILD TRAVEL FURTHER ARE
CLEANER AND I'M STANDARDS WE
SUPPORT INCREASED ATTENTION TO
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM THE DELEGATION SHOULD
BE INCREASED TO ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO BE PROGRAM THE MAN.
WHO SUPPORT THE FOUR HUNDRED
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT THE DRONE MISSION
RAIL TRANSIT VEHICLES IN THE
PRODUCTION AND EXPAND INTERCITY
RAIL RAIL. AND TRANSIT SERVICE.
THE PROPOSED ONE. SEVENTY
MILLION AND THE EMTS OF
ATTENTION AT THE CAN HAVE A
DUTY. MA CHECKER. INCARNATION
OF THE CHARACTER EVERYTHING
BOARD AND G. H. I THINK YOU CAN
ONE OF THE MOST IMPACT CLEAN.
PROGRAMS THE BILL AND YOU COUNT.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION ON
OUR COUPLE THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M ALL SIX PLEASE
CALL AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARTY
REGAN AND I REPRESENT LARKIN
STREET YOUTH SERVICES THE SAN
FRANCISCO. I'M CALLING TO GIVE
COMMENT IMPART A ISSUE TO AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN TO BE
REVISED TO BACK THE LAWS THE
FEDERAL VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT
SACRAMENTO FUNDING. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND REQUEST
OR- YES TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
HOMELESS YOU CAN LEARN
EVERYTHING HOUSING PROGRAM AND
A HOMELESS PERSON JERRY I WOULD
PROGRAM EXPAND THESE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS HAVE TO TWENTY MORE.
COUNTIES THANK YOU FOR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
NOT FURTHER DISCONNECTED A LOT
THE CALIFORNIA BE BUILT AT THE
PANDEMIC. QUITE FUNNY PRODUCED
THE CONCRETE AND IT RESULT FOR
YOU FOR ANYTHING HOMELESSNESS
IN DANGER CITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IN CRITICAL FIND
HELP DIVERT YOU FROM MORE
EXPENSIVE INFORMATIK OUTCOMES
INCLUDING HOSPITAL EIGHT PRISON
TIME AND LANGUISHING ON THE
STREET. YOU HAVE A
TRANSFORMATIVE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
PHOTOVOLTAIC AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION TO INCLUDE EXPAND
THE CALLOW YET Y. E. N. H. BY
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NINETY SEVEN GO OUT.
BY. NINE SEVEN. NEXT BY NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHOOT
HELLO BY NINETY FIVE BUT MY
NAME IS VERY MUCH ON A I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH BEND THE ARC
JEWISH ACTS THAT ACTION
COMMENTING ON ISSUE FOR ITEM
THREE I CALLED THE COMMITTEE TO
TAKE THIS MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS PARTICULAR PRE TRIAL
PILOT NISHIDA PREPARATION FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TEN
WHICH DID NOT HAPPEN AND THAT'S
LOGICALLY CALLED WITH THE PILOT
SHOULD BE AND- THE PILOT
DEPLOYMENT HAITIAN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE GROUND
HAS SHIFTED. STUDY OUT OF
HARVARD AND MIT HAVE SHOWN THE
INHERENT RACIAL BIAS THE RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOL NOT ONLY DO
RISK ASSESSMENT UNDERMINE THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEY ROBBED THE
ACCUSED OF THEIR RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS IN THE PAST YEAR WE
HAVE WITNESSED THE CALLED FOR
DIVESTING FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND FOR INVESTING IN COMMUNITY
BASED WEB SERVICES UTILIZING
PROBATION IN THIS PILOT AN ARM
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS DOES THE OPPOSITE
BY INCREASING THE RESOURCES AND
POWER OF THE CARCERAL SYSTEM.
THE VISION OF A TRANSFORMED
PRETRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
INSPECTOR BY ENDING ITS OUT OF
DATE PILOTS AND SUPPORTING REAL
PRE TRIAL SERVICES THAT DUE
PROCESS THAT WILL PROTECT THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND
THE RIGHT TO PRE TRIAL RELEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I WON
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THURMOND PERRIN MEMBERS
CHRISTENDOM BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- WANT TO
SPEAK HERE WAS MORNING PART A
ISSUE NUMBER TWO ON THE
COMPRENDE I. FUNDING WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO THE FUNCTIONAL
CRIME FIBER PROGRAM. HOWEVER WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE A FULL THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FINAL BUDGET YOU PROVIDE. A
GREATER. I AM NOT. YOU DID BACK
SO I DO BELIEVE THAT CAN THAT
ARE NEEDED IT WAS FUNDING WILL
MORE THAN THAT THEN WE WOULD
ALSO URGE YOU TO REJECT ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ANY DOLLARS
NOT NEEDED FOR BACK WILL BE
REVERTED THE STATE BUDGET.
VICTIM SERVICE PROGRAMS ARE
UNDER AGAIN FOR SERVICES LIKE
THEY'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE ON.
ANY ADDITIONAL HONEY IS
PROVIDED THROUGH THE BUDGET
WILL BE A WELFARE AND WELL
UTILIZED BY BOTH OF THEM THANK
YOU PREVENTING CUT SHOULD BE
OUR MINIMUM BY AUGMENTATION
AND- WELCOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATE CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW. MANY MORE COLORS WE HAVE.
THANK YOU I THOUGHT THIRTY AND-
OKAY- AGAIN I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY IF YOU CAN KEEP IT
UNDER ONE MINUTE OR ELSE WE MAY
HAVE TO CUT OFF PEOPLE. WHO
WERE AT THE IN ON THE LIST SO
PLEASE KEEP IT AS SHORT AS YOU
CAN THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU RUN ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN KIRBY TYLER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OUR KING
STREET EAST SERVICES CALLING ON
PART A ISSUE Q. NINE THE CARD
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN
THE REVISED TO BACKFILL THE
LOSSES FEDERAL FOCUS ON.
EARNING A HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME. GENERAL FUND REQUESTS
FOR- YES TO CONTINUE TO
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND HOMELESS YOUTH. SERVICE
PILOT PROGRAM AND YOU EXPAND
THE PROGRAM CHAPTER TWENTY MORE
COUNTY. AT LARKIN STREET THE
FUNDING APART POWERFUL IMPACT.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC WE DID IT IN A MATTER
OF DAYS INCREMENTAL BENNETT
CRITICAL TO THAT YOU HAD I'M
INTERESTED ACCESS TO WARM MEALS
AND A SAFE PLACE INSIDE. THE
CONNECTOR CRITICAL RESOURCES
SUCH AS TRAINED COUNSELORS THE
INTERNAL CONNECTION. THE
FUNDING ALSO PROVIDED EMERGENCY
HOUSING VOUCHERS WHEN THEY SAY
SOCCER HAD TO CLOSE. LET ME BE
CLEAR LARKIN STREET VIçT
PROGRAM ENSURED THAT WE MET THE
IMMEDIATE NEED. FOR MORE THAN A
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. THE
WHITE PROGRAM FUNDING TO
SUBSTANTIALLY AND NECESSARILY
MOVE THE NEEDLE PREVENT READY
AND HARM YOU COMMONSENSE. THE
PROVIDE YOUR SUPPORT THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM AND
ULTIMATELY CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING SERVICES. FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE THANK YOU. PLEASE PLEASE
KEEP YOUR OF RIMMER WHAT WILL
HAVE START ASKING PEOPLE.
CALLERS TO. JUST SAY YOU'RE
NAME AND WHAT ISSUE YOU'RE
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING. BUT
KEEP IT AS SHORT OR ELSE WE'LL
HAVE TO DO THAT THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I WON SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAUREN
KLEIN WITH THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEY JUST SPEAK INTO PORT PART
A ISSUE FOR NUMBER FIVE LEGAL
AID FOR RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS.
WELL WE APPRECIATE THIS
INVESTMENT FUNDING AT THIS
LEVEL IS EQUAL TO OUR LAST DAM
FUNDING ALLOCATED IN THE YEARS
IMMEDIATELY PRECEDING THE KIND
THAT MAKE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR FALLS FAR
SHORT OF WHAT WILL BE REQUIRED
TO MEET THE DRAMATICALLY
GROWING STATE. WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
FUNDING BE ALLOCATED TO THE
EQUAL ACCESS FUND WHICH FUNDS
ALL OF THE LEGAL CORRECT SUCH
AS IMMIGRATION AND DB SERVICES
AS WELL AS MANY OTHERS THAT ARE
CRITICALLY NEEDED AND NOT
COVERED BY THE FUNDING. I ALSO
LIKE TO ECHO THE EARLIER
COMMENTS BY LIBBY SANCHEZ OF AS
THE ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OF
FUNDING FOR COURT REPORTERS IN
THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
FUNDING ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT
OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE. AND
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF PART EIGHT ISSUE TO
THE BOCA. I THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU BRING FOR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I KEEP WHAT
FROM UNCOMMON LAW ADDRESSING
ISSUE FIVE NUMBER TWELVE AT
LEAST SIX TIMES OVER THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS THE PAROLE BOARD
DECIDED- HEARING BACKLOG OF THE
REASON THEY NEED TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY PROCESS HEARINGS.
THE BACKLOG IS A DRECT RESULT
OF THEIR REFUSAL TO GRANT
PAROLE IF THEY'VE DONE NOTHING
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER TO
INCREASE THE PROGRAM RATE I GOT
FIVE QUICK RECOMMENDATIONS ONE
STOP THEM FROM USING
SUBJECTIVE. FACTORS LIKE INSIDE
THAT THEIR OWN EXPERTS ADMIT
DON'T SHOW VIOLENCE RISK TO
PRODUCE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ON
COMMISSIONERS AND PEARL
APPLICANTS FOR EVERY PAROLE
HEARING THREE RESUME IN PERSON
PAROLE HEARINGS FOR EVERY PRO
APPLICANT WHO WANTS ONE. FOR
PROVIDE AUTOMATIC JUDICIAL
REVIEW FOR YOUTH AND ELDERLY
PAROLE HEARINGS THAT DON'T
RESULT IN PAROLE GRANTS IN FIVE
AUTHORIZED THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE RACIAL DISPARITIES
AND UNLAWFUL PAROLE. GRANT
RATES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I WON SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
WORKABLE AND I'M AN ORGANIZER
WITH MY DEFENSE THAT AND THE
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA COALITION
AND MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID PROBATION IS UNEQUIVOCALLY
A LOT AN ARM OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE ELECTRONIC MONITORING
INFORMATION IS A PROTECTING OUR
PEOPLE TO OPEN THEIR PRESENTS.
WE'VE BEEN UP LISTENING THAT
THE GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET ON
PROBATION. LEAD PRE TRIAL
PROGRAMS IN A WAY THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY REPREHENSIBLE WE
CANNOT IGNORE THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS WHO REJECTED ACT YOU CAN
BE AT THAT PROPERTY FIVE RACK
REFERENDUM WHICH FAILED IN THE
STATE THE GOVERNOR AND STATE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE CAN
COULD YOU REDUCING THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
LOOKING BINDING AND REACH AND
INSTEAD FIND COMMUNITY BASED
PRE TRIAL SERVICES. THAT YOU
HAVE ENCOURAGED AND. DEMANDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT THING
YOU I WON EIGHTY NINE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS A BALLOT I THE
CALABRESE. READ THE GENDER I.
CALL ON THE BOARD EIGHT FIVE
THREE THREE- FOR REFEREE FOR
THEIR LIVES BORTHWICK THEIR
LIVES- STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS THANK YOU
CAN I CHERISH AND SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO SENATOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
BYE ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
ADDED. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MIKE CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY- I'M
CALLING THIS EVENING TO- FIRST
OF ALL- I WANT TO THANK MY
THOUGHTS WITH A COMMENT BY
BOTH- A. B. SANCHEZ AND LAUREN
KLEIN. ABOUT THE NEED. ORDERS
IN THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
FUND. WE ALSO AVOID OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL IN
THE BUDGET AND THIS IS- PARTY
ITEM TWO AND UNDER THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH FOR THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- POOR ON A NEW
TRAFFIC CAMS THE PROGRAM. WE
FEEL LIKE WE'VE SEEN IN OUR
FAMILY THE WE NEED TO REDUCE
THE FEES AND FRANKLY THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD ABOUT
ELIMINATING BACK. ON
COLLECTIBLE DAT IS A RIGHT WAY
TO GO AND THAT'S WHAT WE OUGHT
TO DO THIS YEAR JEFF WADE THIS
DEATH AND THEN LAST WEEK WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR-
REPARATIONS FOR FORCED. THEIR
OWN THING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M MORE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE FLAG. AND TURN MEMBERS
ERRANI MONITORS ANY TO GET
CONSOLIDATION- THE PROVIDING
CALVET AGAIN THAT EIGHT ISSUE
SEVEN ITEM ONE. MARK THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THE
REQUEST HUNDRED FOURTEEN
MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM TO ADDRESS A
BACKLOG AND THEN FINALLY
REQUEST THE MOBILE OF THE
PRIORITY PATIENT IF YOU CLICK.
OFF GRANTEES THANK YOU THANK
YOU I LOVE IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIVE ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS AUTHORS THAT OF ALL THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS SENIOR
MANAGER FOR THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M JUST CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST PROVIDE REPARATIONS FOR
SURVIVORS OF FORCED
STERILIZATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING COOLEY RANDOLPH
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL FOR YOUR MISSION
BUT THERE'S BEEN WE AGREED WITH
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT BOND
SHOULD BE AUGMENTED BUT WE
THINK AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. ART SHOULD BE
AUGMENTED FOR TOTAL OF ONE
BILLION DOLLARS YOU TO HIGH
DEMAND THESE AMERICANS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACTION PLAN FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE OR CAPPING I
WOULD BE GOING THROUGH A VERY
LENGTHY PUBLIC PROCESS IS A LOT
OF ACT WITH ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES ARE TO SUPPORT BECAUSE
ADDED ACTUALLY CLIMB AIR
POLLUTION AND HEALTH PRIMARY
CARE TRANSPORTATION THANK
MAKING FOR THE DEPARTMENT. OF
MOTOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT A ONE PLEASE
CALL. I IS CAROLINE ADAM
BOOKMARKING STREET YOUTH
SERVICES I JUST LIKE TO SPEAK
ON PART A ISSUE TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH PREVIOUS COMMENT
BROWN ALSO LED BY THE REAGAN
AND KATHLEEN WOULD LIKE IT'S A
PART OF BOCA FIND AND IT'S A
PART OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME ONLY AT
NINE OR- TEN PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING. HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE INTO ALL TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS KATIE
WATER SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION WE
MUST PROTECT AND STRENGTHEN
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE IN THE
JUNE BUDGET WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THE PAY RATE WILL GO
DOWN AT THE END OF THIS YEAR WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO GO BACKWARDS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M TO ATTEND PLEASE GO OUT. HI
MY NAME IS SEAN YOUNG CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE FINANCIAL
JUSTICE PROJECT IN THE OFFICE
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO TREASURER
AND I'M CALLING TO COMMENT ON
THE FIND AT THE END OF THE
PROGRAM PROPOSED IN PART ASIAN
OR- I DECIDED I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO AND DAD-
USED AT THE START OPPORTUNITY
TO ABOLISH AND FORGET GAP FROM
THE FIND PETE OUT RIGHT I'M
INSTEAD OF CREATING AN AMNESTY
PROGRAM WHICH HAS- A
QUESTIONABLE TRACK RECORD IN
CALIFORNIA AND INSTEAD BRING
SYSTEMIC REFORMS WERE STATE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ.
OP ED IN THE LA TIMES I'M CALL
TO TRY TO PICK UP ON HOW TO
DESCRIBE THE NEED- PROVIDING P.
REFORM. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ELEVEN PLEASE GOING. HI
MY NAME IS TIFFANY MEYER WITH
BUYERS COMMITTEE PERSONAL RIGHT
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND
I REPRESENT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED AND TARGET BY THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM I'M
COMMENTING TO HOSE THE PROPOSAL
TO ALLOCATE FUNDS. TO PROBATION
APARTMENT THE RUN PRE TRIAL
INITIATIVE THE PROPOSAL PLACE A
VALUABLE AND LIMITED RESOURCES
INTO AN AGENCY THAT CANNOT
PROTECT PEOPLE WHO ARE AT RISK
OF HARM IN THE PRE TRIAL CAN
FIND THEM WE'VE SEEN ACTIVATION
APARTMENT LEAGUE BASKETBALL.
EMISSION CONTROL BY CREMATION
APARTMENT ARE NECESSARILY
PUNITIVE THEY RESTRICT MOVEMENT
ASSOCIATION. RIGHT OFTEN FAIL
TO ADEQUATELY CONSIDER OR
COMEDY DISABILITIES SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK. YOU FOR
CALLING PRETTY SHADE IT. THANK
YOU I'M TO THIRTEEN GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARJORIE CALLING
TO CHECK GO COLOR MAN ON THANK
YOU THIS I'M CALLING IT THE
MORE OF EIGHT ISSUE YOU. BUT
THAT IS THAT IN THE VERIFY TO
BACK FILL THE LOS OF FEDERAL
FOCUS ON WHERE SUPPORTING A ONE
HUNDRED LONG ONE JOURNAL AND
REQUIRE FOR- EMO DEFY. SESSION
OF DOCUMENT WOULD HELP EIGHT
DAY AND OFTEN AND CROWN
HOMELESSNESS. ALL IN. BY WAY OF
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND POVERTY. THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING KILL.
THANK YOU FOR PLEASE GO OUT.
THAT COULD BE MAINTAINED
REPRESENT THE COMPANY COLLISION
CALLING ON FRIDAY ISSUED HERE I
AM WITH THE BUT THAT BACK ON
THE BLOCK ABOUT CONFINED AND
BUT A HUNDRED MILLION ONE
HUNDRED OFTEN- YES REQUEST YOU
KNOW THAT MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY YOUTH OF
COLOR IN OUT WIDE ENOUGH I HAD
CALLED THE PPO. AND WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
ON. THIS ISSUE YEAH THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. THANK YOU RYAN
FORTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MODERATOR MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
KNOCKING ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL THANK YOU- THANK
THE CHAIR AND HER STAFF WORK ON
ISSUE COR NUMBER NINE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REGARDING LIKE THEY'LL ALSO
HERE REPORTER THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY. I REQUEST FOR
THE PROP ONE EIGHT DOLLARS
ISSUE CAN FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION AND FINALLY ISSUE FIVE
YEAH HI LO TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
EXPANSION. IN THE YOU CAN BE
EXPANSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE YOU. ONE NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ARE
DOING BIG PROJECTS INCLUDE
DREADED USED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR WORK ACTION FUND
WE URGE THE SENATE SUPPORT AND
THE COMPOSED COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FONG UNDER THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. THE ONE TIME ALLOCATION
OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION EDERAL DOLLARS WOULD
SUPPORT REGIONAL LOCAL P. COLOR
COLLABORATIVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RANGERS SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD. I
ABSOLUTELY MY NAME IS NIKKI AND
I MIGHT THAT AFFECT NO- AND HOW
MUCH ARE YOU NEEDING COMMITTEE
IS WELL AS THE CHARACTER IN
FACTORED IN ON JUST CALLING TO
APPROACH- YOU KNOW AT GROUNDING
THAT THESE PRE TRIAL PROGRAM IN
PROBATION THE FUNDING- THAT
WILL YOU KNOW. YOU DEFINITELY
THAT. FOR COMMUNITY BASED AND
PUBLIC DEFENDER BASED PROGRAMS
REALLY- EXELON THIS WORK AND
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING HOW MANY
COMMUNITY EVENTS. THIS KIND OF
LAUNCH A LINE FOR MEN- RESPOND-
IS THE SAME FEELS LIKE IT'S IN
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
RANGERS SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS RIO WITH THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS TO THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA FIRST WE OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS PRE TRIAL PILOT
PROPOSAL INSTEAD WE SHOULD BE
MOVING TOWARD NONPROFITS
PRETRIAL SERVICES SECOND WE
OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL RELATED TO
RELIEVING TRAFFIC AND NON
TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS NOT THE
RIGHT APPROACH TO THAT YOU
DON'T NEED ANOTHER AMNESTY
PROGRAM WE NEED REPEAL OF
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
ELIMINATION OF HALF THAT. OUR
ORGANIZATION. IN THE PAST AND
THAT THE PLAN THEY WERE MAJORLY
UNSUCCESSFUL ELIMINATE OUT THAT
REPEAL CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST
WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY SIX MINUTES
LEFT WHOEVER DOES NOT SPEAK UP
WILL ASK YOU TO SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS IN IN WRITING SO THAT
MEANS EVERYBODY ELSE PLEASE
KEEP IT JUST. YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION THE ISSUE AND WHAT
YOU SUPPORT OR WHAT YOU OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD MOTOR.
THANK YOU VERY TWENTY TWO
PLEASED AHEAD. YES GO AHEAD. IT
WENT ON WITH THE PERFECT AMOUNT
OF PROBLEM NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND
CAREFIRST COALITION I ALSO HAVE
AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER
CURRENTLY ON PROBATION AND A
HALF OF BODY THERE EXACTLY
GOVERNOR HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR COMPOSED SPENDING ON
PROBATION AND PRETRIAL
PROGRAMS- EXTENDING THAT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE TRIAL
PROGRAM IS ANTITHETICAL TO THE
WELL OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
VOTERS- 81% OF VOTERS WHO HAD A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PROGRAM
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY. WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
TWENTY EIGHT GOING. KILEY MYERS
AT THE BILL YOU WRITE BUDGET OF
THE PENTAGON CALLING FOR THE
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUESTED PROBABLY
SUPPORT DELEGATION COMPENSATION
PROGRAM THE TIME IS NOW TO
COMPETE PROVIDERS THE STATE
BANK REPORT EARLY NATION WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY DISABLED BLACK
LATINA AND IMMIGRANT WOMEN I
JUST WANTED TO. CLEAR THAT
YOU'RE REQUESTING A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS IT'LL
COMPENSATION AMOUNT OF WITH
EVENLY DIVIDED AMONGST THE
VERIFIED PRIVATE COMING FORWARD
THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY LET'S NOT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. NEXT. HEARING TO ALL
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DENISE HIM A LIKE K. ANIME
OF THE U. EIGHTEEN I WORK AT
THE YES STOCKTON THIS IS
REGARDING THE CDC OUR AGENDA IF
YOU NUMBER FIVE NUMBER ELEVEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AND OR OBJECT TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
SIX PT POSITIONS AT THE APM DR.
I BELIEVE HE'S ARE A VITAL PART
OF MAKING HELP MULTI
DISCIPLINARY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR CALL. NEXT
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME OF
MY THINKING ABOUT I'M A
RESIDENT IN PASADENA CALIFORNIA
AND I AM VOICING MY SUPPORT.
FOR THE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET TO
REQUIRED- AND PROVIDE
REPARATIONS TO SURVIVORS OF
FORCED STERILIZATION UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S EUGENIC LAWS.
BETWEEN NINETEEN OR NINETEEN
NINETY NINE AFTER BY. GERALD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR CALL THE NEXT. THANK YOU
RANGERS THIRTY PLEASE CONTACT.
HI MY NAME IS AN ASSISTANT
MANAGER AND I'M A REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ADVOCATE IN GLENDALE
CALIFORNIA CALLING TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION BUDGET REQUEST TO
ACCOMPLISH THE COMPENSATION FOR
SURVIVORS OF FORCED OR
INVOLUNTARY STERILIZATION
PROGRAM AND I JUST WANTED TO
THINK ASSEMBLY WHEN YOU GOT A
DEAL AND SENATOR- GOOD ACTORS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND THE
SEVEN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. THAT
SIGNED ON TO THE TEMPERATURE
REQUIRED. THE YES. THANK YOU
BRING TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BY HERO
WHY- I'M A PART OF DIGNITY AND
POWER NOW AND I'M HERE- A POST
MEANS THE GARDEN THERE IS ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION PRE
CHILD KILEY PROPOSAL- OKAY MORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING. THANK YOU BRING TO
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LARA HUMANISM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA MIGHT BE
ENOUGH TO REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF THE L.
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST- ONE TIME REQUEST FOR
REPARATIONS TO SURVIVORS OF
FORCED STERILIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA- IT IS LONG PAST
TRYING TO MAKE THIS RIGHT AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ERIKA COHN AND I AM
THE FILMMAKER WHO HELPED EXPOSE
MODERN STERILIZATION ABUSE IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS AS
CHRONICLED IN THE FILM BELLY
THE BEAST WHICH WAS JUST GREEN
FOR LEGISLATORS WITH A
BIPARTISAN PANEL BRINGING
TOGETHER SOUTHERN REPUBLICANS
IN CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS. ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THE STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUEST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THE FILM
WE REALLY APPRECIATED. NEXT
THANK YOU ARE INTO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME. IS
AND I'M CALLING FROM CALIFORNIA
TWENTY SEVEN DISTRICT AND I'M
CALLING AT THE PORT OF THE
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUEST FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF MY NINA WAS THEIR
LIVES L. A. C. G. H. U. S. B.
AS A YOUNG TEENAGER. I DO BEING
ANYTHING DEMOCRAT YOUR HELP BY
THOSE IN CHARGE AND THE
SIXTIES. FAILURE OF THE ABILITY
TO CHANGE HOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE. YOUR CALLING.
NEXT THANK YOU RANGE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROCHELLE MARTIN AND I'M CALLING
FROM WHAT YOU'RE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU TO THE
TO- THE COURT AB ONE ZERO ZERO
SEVEN THE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
TO ESTABLISH THE FOR
STERILIZATION PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MERRY
MALCOMSON I'M A PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN AT A CA YEAH
STOCKTON AND I JUST STOPPED BY
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY BUSINESS BY TAXES
THIS IS YOUR FIVE NUMBER
ELEVEN. JUST WANTED TO JUST
BRING ABOUT THAT WE- THANK YOU
AMONG OTHER THINGS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING. THEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK THAT
YOU DO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD WE
HAVE ONE MORE MINUTE SO WHOEVER
JUMPS ON. PLEASE KEEP IT SHORT.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. FORTY TWO.
FIND CHIU FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES QUICKLY PLEASE THANK YOU.
YEAH YEAH I THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JAMES NELSON I WORK WITH THE
DEEPLY AND THEY MAKE THEIR
POWER NOW ON THE CONTRARY SB
TWENTY NINE YEARS INCARCERATED
AND IT ALL STARTED OFF WHEN I
WAS A JUVENILE CANNOT BE AND
INCARCERATED AGAIN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT LET'S YOU
KNOW LITTLE. OLD AS WELL THANK
YOU SIR APPRECIATE. YOUR
CALLING THEM THANK YOU. BANK
YOU ONE EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU ALL HEAR
ME. OKAY HELLO I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY WE- WE'RE GETTING A CUT
OFF HERE SO I HAVE TO AND THAT
THAT WAS OUR LAST CALL- THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY WE APPRECIATE
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU THANK
YOU FOR WAITING TO. BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE CALL IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU ALL.
HAVE A BLESSED EVENING AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
ALL. WE'RE SORRY YOUR
CONFERENCE IS ENDING NOW PLEASE
HANG UP.